do you know that around 53 percent of
website traffic comes from organic
search which makes search engine
optimization a top priority for
businesses online the more you rank high
in search engines the more you have the
possibility to gain traffic to your
website which indirectly results in
conversions thereby boosting your
business moreover the market is flooded
with SEO jobs a few of them includes SEO
Associates SEO analysts SEO Executives
SEO managers SEO experts with salaries
going as high as hundred thousand
dollars which makes it a lucrative
career so here we present you our SEO
full course that will cover every
aspects needed to get a job in this
field before we move ahead consider
subscribing to our Channel and hit the
Bell icon to never miss any updates from
Simply learn in this SEO full course we
will be recovering all the major and
minor concepts related to SEO we have
smartly divided this course from
beginners to advanced level so that
anyone can become an SEO expert with
this all in one course we will start off
with a small introduction to SEO and an
understanding of what SEO exactly is
moving ahead we will understand the
significance of SEO and why one should
optimize a web content for SEO we will
understand the types of SEO covering
on-page SEO and off-page SEO techniques
we will put detail light on how keyword
research is done as it is the most
important part of any SEO technique
followed by our Pro tips to rank on
Google and YouTube by the end of this
course you will be able to gain
expertise in various SEO tools like
Google search console and Google
analytics and will be able to understand
and the market of SEO in terms of jobs
and salaries finally we will end this
video with the top SEO interview
questions that will help you to Ace your
interview and grab the job opportunity
so without any further Ado let's begin
with this complete learning package for
SEO
Rachel is a baker who runs her own
Bakery
to expand her business she decided to
create an online presence by first
setting up a Blog she began posting on
her blog regularly however even after
regularly posting on the blog there were
barely any visitors showing up deciding
not to give up Rachel began searching
for a solution on the internet that's
when she came across SEO or search
engine optimization a term she's never
heard before
so let's take a journey together and
help her learn about SEO search engine
optimization is a method that could
improve the quality and quantity of the
audience coming to Rachel's website from
search engines it could increase brand
awareness attract local customers and
build credibility and trust and all of
this is possible without having to spend
a single penny to bring visitors to our
website Rachel would have to take
advantage of the two types of SEO
on-page and off-page SEO Rachel first
decides to tackle on-page SEO and get
that sorted on-page SEO involved Rachel
optimizing her website both in terms of
content and the technical aspects
including the HTML source code schema
meta Tags and More she started off by
using tools like Google AdWords allref
and semrush to identify popular Search
terms associated with the recipes she
planned to publish on her blog she began
to look for Search terms related to the
broader area of baking cooking and
related topics once she found these
Search terms she began to incorporate
them into her recipes
she started off by providing an
introduction to the recipe with this she
could provide an engaging beginning to
her story like how the dish reminded her
of her childhood and enabled her to
naturally include the Search terms into
the blog she also included these
keywords in the actual recipe as well
additionally she added pictures videos
time lapses and more to increase
credibility and engagement for her
content and subsequently persuading
search engines to show her content to
more people after this she moved to the
website metacontent that search engines
display when her blog appears in search
results
she optimized The Meta tax alt tags
header Tags and More this completed the
on-page aspect of SEO thanks to this she
saw a significant increase in the number
of visitors coming to her page having
done all she could on her webpage she
now decides to explore what could be
done off page to improve her Page's
visibility on search engines off-page
SEO involved Rachel doing things outside
her site page to help increase its
search engine rankings making
optimizations outside the site would
improve the site's popularity relevance
trustworthiness and Authority this is
possible with the help of reputable
websites vouching for your content with
backlinks social media marketing guest
blogging linked unlinked brand mentions
influencer marketing and much more
Rachel also understood that for her
content to reach people she would have
to promote it on social media platforms
like Facebook Twitter and Instagram as
well as Niche platforms like quora
Reddit and medium these could help her
achieve greater reach for her website by
sending stronger social signals to
search engines
leading to the page being shown as
highly relevant for related searches and
audiences and even after understanding
and implementing all of this Rachel had
just scratched the surface of what was
possible with SEO
before we find out what she did next
let's have a look at a quiz which of the
following is the most effective way to
improve off-page SEO one creating plenty
of web pages of a Content 2. getting
backlinks from relevant and
authoritative sites three acquiring
backlinks through link Buy
4. none of the above let us know your
answer in the comments section below for
a chance to win an Amazon voucher now
let's go back to Rachel Rachel decided
to take up simplylearn's digital
marketing certification with classes
covering just about everything she
needed to know about SEO it was only a
matter of time before Rachel began to
implement her learnings on her website
and see a massive uptick in the number
of viewers coming to her website in time
she could even earn money off the site
by setting up an online shop and with
that we've covered an introduction to
the concepts of SEO and the
possibilities it can open for you either
as a marketer or a business owner so
we're going to use a basic example and
let's just say you have a Blog you're a
food blogger you're passionate about
food and your Niche is ice cream and
let's just say you have a lot of ice
cream recipes you want to get traffic to
your blog you want people to read your
blog and you're curious why am I not
ranking for my blog why when people type
in ice cream recipes and say Google my
blog posts don't appear at the top of
organic rankings and there's a number of
reasons why you wouldn't be ranked for
your blog post or your ice cream recipes
and the main reason would be your
competitors so there could be somebody
else out there who is also passionate
about ice cream and has been blogging
along longer than you and they have more
content and more blog posts and more
pages for Google to rank so that's
usually the number one reason the other
reason is improper usage of keywords and
we're going to talk a little bit or it's
actually a lot more about you know
keyword usage in your content so what
kind of keywords do you want to rank for
that's really what we're talking about
when we talk about usage of keywords
what keywords do you want to rank for
and how do we work those keywords into
the content another reason is poor link
building practices and really that means
our other blog posts or other websites
linking to you also are you linking to
other pages on your website and so it's
all about link building and with link
building it's internal linking so are we
linking from one blog post to another
and it's external linking our other
websites of high quality linking to us
and so that's what we talk about when we
talk about link building and then
another reason is web page load time so
you could be running your blog post on
say WordPress for example and your blog
post isn't loading fast enough well if
you look at it this way think about it
if you're Google would you really want
to rank a website or blog post in this
example number one on Google rankings if
that particular page loaded very slow no
you wouldn't because when somebody
clicked on that link in organic search
and went to your website they're going
to have a bad experience because the
page is going to load slow so Google
doesn't want their users to have a bad
experience you don't want your users to
have a bad experience and so that's why
web page load time is a critical factor
for ranking so we need to make sure that
our web pages load fast and then your
user experience is not good enough so
Google again based on my example about
the web page load time Google wants
people to have a good experience when
they go from their search engine to your
website and there's a lot at play there
specifically web page load time but also
you know Google doesn't want any spam
content Google doesn't want any pop-ups
or overbearing ads on the web page they
want people to are searching for
something in particular let's just say
ice cream recipes and they want to find
a relevant website that has ice cream
recipes they want to be able to click on
that link and read some good content
about ice cream recipes it's that simple
and that's really what Google's trying
to create in their environment and
that's you as an end user as a website
owner you want your users to have a good
experience and then why last but not
least your website is the indexed by
mistake and really what we mean is the
indexed is Google needs to be able to
index all the pages on your website so
if you have a Blog with a hundred
recipes you want Google to have access
to all 100 recipes so we're going to
talk a little bit later about how to get
your pages ranked or indexed on Google
organic search so let's move on to what
is SEO so sticking with our ice cream
Blog theme really SEO search engine
optimization really is the practice of
increasing your pages that Google has
indexed up the rankings so the end
result is we want all our pages to be
ranked number one for particular
keywords so if you want to be ranked for
ice cream recipes well there's certain
things you need to do so that's
generally how it works we need to apply
search engine optimization to increase a
page for keyword we want to be found for
so let me give you an example so let's
just say there's a hundred students that
participated in an essay competition and
so the competition in this particular
case is evaluated on the basis of is the
content relevant are they using suitable
titles for their essay do they have
structure when they're participating in
this essay or talking about the essay
and do they have a suitable synopsis and
is the content neat and readable these
seem all logical for an essay
competition well guess what they seem
logical for SEO because that's exactly
how SEO works it's exactly all those
points I just made mentioned about
structure logic readability organization
title all those things are what's
important in SEO and so we need relevant
content we need titles for our Pages
Google needs to be able to see structure
we need to have synopsis of what the
page is about and that's called The Meta
description and then again the the
content needs to be readable and that's
important and so in order to be readable
again we're going to talk more about
site speed because site speed is
important okay and when we talk about
responsive design when I say respond to
design that means your site your page
needs a load both on desktop and also on
mobile and so all these things are
important just like an essay competition
Google is the judge and they need to be
able to determine what page is best to
rank number one number two number three
Etc on Google Search and then link
building remember I mentioned link
building a moment ago well link building
internally and externally also plays a
vital role and so we're going to talk
about that a little bit later in the
class when we talk about off-page SEO
how does Google rank website and
basically Google follows three basic
steps to rank a website they need to
crawl your website they need to take
what they crawl back to their servers
and when they take it back to their
servers your web pages they need to you
know have them available for indexing so
when somebody actually types in a
keyword into google.com it'll be
available to be found on organic search
so that's what indexing is all about and
then Google's job when somebody does
type in a search query is to basically
rank those pages that they've indexed
from number one to Infinity depending on
how many pages are relevant to that
search query so really it's about
crawling indexing and ranking so
crawling is simply a process done by
which Google has Bots and what these
Bots do is they go to your web server
and they're going to crawl every page
that they can find and how do they find
these Pages well they basically follow
links you might have heard the term
spidering but that's what they call
search engine spidering so basically
what Google's doing is they're building
a web so to speak all the links that
they're following and so when they can
follow all these links on your website
they're going to be able to crawl them
and when they crawl them basically they
going to take that content and store it
on their servers so it's available in
their index So based on this method
Google finds out which websites have
relevant content and which ones don't
based on certain keywords that are typed
into Google because if they can't crawl
your website you're not going to be
found and if you can't be found then
you're not going to show up for Relevant
keywords so we need to make sure your
site's available to be crawled and we'll
talk about that a little bit later okay
but let's show you an example so let's
just go to Google Search and if I type
in the keyword simply learn okay I could
see I have one way in 10 000 results
okay and that's how many results are
showing up for simply learn okay now
they may not all be simply learn pages
but nonetheless simply learned is ranked
number one here organically and there
are 1 million 10 000 Pages related to
the keyword simply learn now when it
comes to organic search we don't want to
get it confused with paid search so
anytime time you see paid search you're
going to see something that says add
next to it okay so we could see that
there are paid ads here but when it
comes to organic search those are
generally below paid ads and so that's
where Google counts the 1 million 10 000
results and so that's the whole idea
behind crawling and indexing Google's
able to cross simply learns website and
based on all the pages that they gather
they're going to make those pages
available in organic search so if you
type in a keyword and your web page is
not available for indexing then you're
never going to show up for that keyword
so that's why it's important to make
sure your website is available for
crawling and indexing and so when a user
types a query on search Google search
the most relevant websites that are in
Google's index are going to pair in the
search results so in the example I gave
was simply learn well simply learn is
the brand name of the company simply
learned so there's a a lot of relevancy
there so that's why you see simply learn
show up here organically number one like
we mentioned about what is SEO and why
SEO we talked about that user experience
so there's a lot of factors that go into
ranking relevancy being one of them so
in the simply learned example simply
learn is relevant to a lot of the simply
learned Pages because that's who they
are simply learn however simply learn
also needs to make sure that you know
for their Pages the page load time is
fast meaning these Pages load very fast
for the end user and Google also takes
into account other factors like how long
someone is staying on a website or are
they bouncing meaning are they going to
one page that they land on and then
leaving the website okay and so the user
experience is very very important there
are other factors also like language and
location and so for example location if
you do a search say in India the results
are going to be a little bit different
than say the results in the United
States why because Google is indexing as
many web pages as they can find so if
somebody's doing a search in India their
results may be a little bit different
than the results show up in the U.S
because Google has different Bots and
these Bots are crawling different pages
at different times and so Google's index
is updating continuously but it's not
real time syncing so if you do a search
in India you may not see exactly the
same thing because both search engines
the Google in India and the Google and
the US are may not be exactly synced up
so an example would be you know if
you're looking for Cafe so if you search
a cafe in say San Francisco you're going
to see different results now if you do a
search for cafes in Mumbai you're going
to see different results there's going
to be local search here at the top there
may be some paid search but again you
may see different results because one
location but two Google search engines
in India and United States google.com
aren't exactly synced up exactly at the
same exact time you do that search so
location is important language is
important and relevancy is important
along with user experience so all those
are important factors in how Google
ranks websites okay so we're going to
talk about the types of SEO now so if we
want to rank for a particular keyword on
Google we're going to have to apply
search engine optimization and so
there's two strategies to search engine
optimization on-page SEO and off-page
SEO so first we're going to talk about
on-page SEO so on page SEO is nothing
more than optimizing your own website
and so when we say optimizing your own
website there's certain elements on your
website and on your web pages that we
need to take into account and so some of
those elements are headers meta
descriptions title tags linking so all
of those elements are something we can
control as an end user who wants to rank
our web page and our website on Google
and before we do anything with our
website the first thing we need to do is
understand what keywords we want to rank
for in order to understand what keywords
we want to rank for we need to do
keyword research and if you do anything
in SEO keyword research is the most
important activity that's the most
important thing you can do for SEO and
why do I say it's the most important
because you need to understand if you
choose a keyword that you want to rank
for you need to understand how much
traffic you're going to get from that
keyword if you're ranked organically say
number one on Google so how much traffic
will you get if you're ranked number one
on Google so you need to understand what
the volume is and the number 2 we need
to understand what the competition is
for that keyword that you want to rank
for so if you choose a keyword and
there's not much competition for it then
chances are you can rank for that
keyword for a web page on your website
quicker than say a keyword that has a
lot of competition so we need to
understand those two basic factors
volume and competition before we choose
a keyword and it's it's simply the
practice of going through the motions of
getting your volume and getting your
competition data so you can choose the
keywords you want and then once you
choose the keyword you want then you can
go and apply on page SEO you can change
the title tag The Meta descriptions the
headers all those elements can be
changed but first you need to choose
your keywords and so again the primary
components we're looking for are how
much traffic you can get or the search
volume how much competition there is for
that keyword and of course relevancy
okay you need to be able to choose a key
keyword that's relevant to the web page
you're trying to rank for and so let me
show you example how to go through this
so the first thing we want to do is we
want to use a tool and the tool I would
recommend is Google Keyword Planner and
why do I choose Google Keyword Planner
because if we're trying to rank on
google.com or Google search engine we
want to be able to get the data right
from the source so Google's going to be
able to give us information about how
much volume a keyword has and how much
competition it has so let me show you an
example so if I want to use Google's
Keyword Planner and I want to rank for
the keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist then I'm going to
type that keyword into Google's Keyword
Planner and what Google's going to do is
they're going to give me some Trends
about how much volume this particular
keyword gets over the course of a year
and so for that particular keyword I can
see that there are trends that that
appear for both desktop and mobile so
mobile is important because people start
their search process a lot of times on
their mobile device so we want to be
able to get data from mobile as well as
desktop and so we could see a trend here
that for each particular month over the
last 12 months we can see how much
volume this particular keyword how to
become a digital marketing specialist
gets per month and so on average on
average over the past 12 months I could
see how to become a digital marketing
specialist is averages 30 searches a
month and this is on google.com and so
Google gives us the volume what they
also give us is the competition and so
here I can see Google says for that
particular keyword the competition is
medium and so in the Google's Keyword
Planner what they also do is give me
other relevant keywords that I might
think about optimizing for because you
don't want to optimize for just one key
word so how to become a digital
marketing specialist they're going to
also offer up other types of keywords
that are relevant so just digital
marketing Specialists social media
marketing specialist so for those
keywords I can see the volume so for
example digital marketing specialist I
can see the average volume is one
thousand per month on average of the
last 12 months I can also see the
competition is medium but for some other
keywords I can see the search volume
being high like digital marketing course
at 2900 per month but also the
competition is high and so what I would
recommend is a best practice is to
collect all your relevant keywords okay
and put all your relevant keywords in a
spreadsheet and when you put all these
relevant keywords in a spreadsheet you
want to get the data on those keywords
and the data I'm referring to is the
volume and competition so in this case
we have volume from Google planner
Google's Keyword Planner and I have
competition from Google's Keyword
Planner and so if I go into a spread
shade and I put all that information in
here I'm going to be able to see the
volume and competition and so that's
important however one thing to note here
is that Google's Keyword Planner if I go
back just gives us low medium and high
and if I want to compare numbers to
numbers maybe I want to be able to get
exactly the competition number for the
keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist what I can do is go
into Google and I can type in that
keyword so if I type in the keyword how
to become a digital marketing specialist
I can see there's 76 Million results so
I could see 76 Million results 76.1
actually and for the keyword how to
become a digital marketing specialist
now that's a whole lot of results for
this particular keyword especially when
the volume is only 30 per month on
average and so what I want to do is get
a more clear picture of the competition
and so what you can could actually do is
type in the syntax all in title and then
colon and then your keyword how to
become a digital marketing specialist
and when I do that I get a different
result here I can see only
136 listings for how to become a digital
marketing specialist but that's not just
136 that's 136 with that particular
keyword that we want to rank for in the
title tag okay so the title tag is what
you see when you type in a keyword or
search query in Google search and the
title tag is what you see at the top of
every search result and so now I can see
I typed in how to become a digital
marketing specialist with the all
entitled syntax and now I can see every
listing every one of these 136 results
have that particular keyword in it so I
could see every one of them how to
become a digital marketing specialist
and why is that important because now
that tells me I only need to climb over
136 listings to rank for that keyword
how to become a digital marketing
specialist and so the idea here is you
want to get your volume from Google's
Keyword Planner but you want to get your
competition from Google search and again
that's simply typing in the syntax all
in title and then your keyword in this
example how to become a digital
marketing specialist once you get those
two numbers you're going to plug them in
to your spreadsheet and then once you do
that for number of different keyword
queries and these keyword queries again
have to be relevant once you do that
then you can go in and pick the keywords
you want to optimize for and that's
important because again if you're not
sure about a keyword then you want to do
the keyword research so you can be sure
of how much traffic you can get and how
much competition there is those are two
important three important factors in
starting the process for on-page SEO so
again you want to
create content for say a keyword like
digital marketing
but digital marketing may seem a little
bit broad so you want to probably stay
away from broader keywords because
broader keywords tend to have a lot of
volume which is great but they may also
tend to have a lot of competition but
that's the whole point of doing the
keyword research maybe it doesn't maybe
there's more volume than competition
that's what you need to find out when
you do the keyword research you need to
find those keywords that are relevant to
your content that have a lot of volume
and low competition and then once we
identify those keywords then we are free
to go in and start optimizing our web
pages for those keywords and the first
place we want to start is the title tag
so if you remember my example going back
here to our search how to become a
digital marketing specialist we saw that
every one of these listings had that
keyword in the title tag and the title
tag is important because that's what
users who use Google search see first
when they talk type in a query and get
results so they're going to see the
title tag so the title tag is the most
important element for on-page SEO it's
the most important factor because that's
what people see and so ideally when we
choose our keyword we want to make sure
that keyword is in the title tag because
that's what shows up in Google search
and that's what makes that particular
web page relevant for that keyword query
so the idea behind a title tag it's
between 50 and 60 characters and so we
want to make sure we stay within that
limit no more than 60 characters because
what happens if it's beyond that then
Google will truncate the title tag so if
I go back to my search you can see here
on this particular title tag Google
trunk handed it meaning they added the
ellipses after the title tag because it
exceeded the 60 character limit so you
want to stay within those character
counts and so the title tag is the first
place you should start when optimizing
your website because we have the right
keyword in the title tag and somebody
types in that keyword then chances are
it's going to be relevant they're going
to see it and they're going to click
through to your website and that's the
whole idea behind ranking we want to get
clicks so that's how the title tag
appears so when you optimize it you're
going to update the title tag and this
is how it shows up it's going to show up
at the top of your listing okay and it's
going to be bigger and Bolder than
anything else Google displays so the
second thing you want to optimize is the
meta description and The Meta
description is simply just a brief
description up to 155 I would say about
155 to 60 160 characters but probably no
more than that and so the meta
description is nothing more than a
summary of the web page itself so if I
go back to my Google search results I
see my title tag and I see the page that
this particular listing belongs to and
underneath that is where I can see my
meta description so in this particular
keyword query how to become a digital
marketing specialist I see the meta
description an ultimate guide on how to
build a career in digital marketing and
the skills required to become a digital
marketing specialist note that it's a
well-written meta description within 155
characters and it includes the keyword
digital marketing specialist so we're
trying to rank for how to become a
digital marketing specialist and here
you can see become a digital marketing
specialist so there's a lot of relevancy
between not only the title tag and the
keyword but the meta description and the
keyword so when you're optimizing a
keyword you want to start with the title
tag but you also want to update the meta
description because if you don't update
the meta description and you leave The
Meta description blank then you're
leaving it to Google to add in copy that
they deem relevant and so for on-page
SEO we want to take control of the copy
and we want to optimize it for the
keywords we want to be found for so the
meta description is a powerful tool at
our disposal it gives us more characters
to work with it gives us more to talk
about so for that particular page and so
if the title tag is only 60 characters
maximum it's not a lot of information to
try and get somebody to click so the
meta description helps us in identifying
what that page is about in order to get
the click so the two working in tandem
will hopefully increase your
click-through rates so when you're found
organically we want to get the click and
then the third element that's important
is the URL and URL stands for uniform
resource locator and why is the URL so
important because that's what people see
so if I go back to my search result how
to become a digital marketing specialist
notice that the URL also includes how to
become a digital marketing specialist
article okay so it's very relevant the
URL is very relevant one we can see it
in the search results but two you know
it's is relevant to the keyword query
and that's important for the end user
and Google Google wants to know hey is
this the page that's relevant to the
user's query and if it is then this user
is likely going to have a good X user
experience after they click on the
listing so the URL is an element that
helps not only with the click-through
rate but with ranking and having a poor
URL structure doesn't help at all
because not only does Google not
recognize the URL as being relevant but
the end user may not want to click on
that page given the the way the URL
looks so you want to try and avoid a
poor URL structure so the rule of thumb
is this if you don't understand what the
URL is then Google is likely not going
to understand what the URL is and so we
want to try and keep our URL structures
clean and when I say clean ideally you
want to make sure that whatever keyword
you're trying to optimize that's the key
word that's in included in the URL
nothing included that is not
understandable so again going back to
our example how to become a digital
marketing specialist it's very clean the
title tag is the keyword The Meta
description is cleanly written has the
keyword and then the URL is the other
element that the end user can see and
that URL includes the keyword in it so
after we've done those three elements
the title tag The Meta description and
the URL then we want to start optimizing
the page itself so ideally when we say
optimize the page itself the page
remember needs to be structured and when
we say structured it needs to be
structured in terms of you know headers
and subheaders and organized in a manner
in which the end user can read the
article read the content clearly and
concisely without being confused and so
that's the job of headers they add they
add basically an organization relational
structure to the content and with
headers there's a hierarchy so you have
anywhere from H1 which is the top of the
hierarchy to an H6 and so you're free to
use any one of those headers when
building on a page in order to organize
the content but ideally you probably
want to stick with an H1 or an H2
because those are at the top of the
hierarchy and what those do is they
actually stress to Google that hey this
header with this particular keyword in
it is important so if you use an H6 with
the keyword in it it's telling Google
hey this is an H6 but it's not as
important so an H1 and an H2 tag show
importance and so let's look at an
example of what that is so here you
could see an H1 is going to be at the
top of the hierarchy so that means it's
going to be bigger and Bolder then you
have an H2 which is going to be bigger
and Bolder than an H3 but not as big and
bold as an H2 so with headers not only
are you organizing the content 10
accordingly but you're also signaling to
Google how important that particular
header is and of course the header needs
to include the keyword we're trying to
rank for so let's take a look again at
that example so if we go to how to
become a digital marketing specialist if
I click on that page I can look at the
content and I can see that there are
headers in here so the headers are there
to organize the content and that's what
we want we want to be able to organize
the content and if you look at the other
example I'm showing here how to become a
digital marketing specialist a learning
path Explorer you can see that's an H1
but below it's a subheader the growing
digital marketing job market so that's
an H2 and so we're not stressing to
Google that that's more important than
nh1 but nonetheless we're stressing at
Google that it's important nonetheless
so we want to be able to use headers we
want to be able to use keywords in our
headers in order to stress to Google
what's important and also to organize
the content because Google likes content
organized okay the next element we want
to focus on is internal linking and so
internal link you never remember earlier
in the presentation it's basically links
from one page on your website to another
and so here we can see on this
particular article how to become a
digital marketing specialist there's
also links to other pages on simply
learns website and so for this
particular content it also links to SEO
specialist PPC specialist social media
marketing Specialists and digital
marketing specialist so the whole idea
behind internal linking is to link from
one page to another where it's relevant
and in this case it's relevant because
we're talking about how to become a
digital marketing specialist that's what
the whole content is about and so what
simply learns doing here is offering up
other pages on their web website that
are relevant to becoming a digital
marketing specialist and so this is a
best practice when you're optimizing a
web page so you want to be able to have
internal linking on your site and the
whole idea behind internal linking is it
also allows users to navigate through
the site naturally so when I say
naturally they don't always have to
refer back to the top navigation they
can naturally and seamlessly go from one
relevant article or page to another and
so that's the whole idea behind link
building and internal link building it
allows Google to identify you know pages
that they want to crawl and index
because they're linked to one another
but it also helps the end user because
it allows the end user to go from one
page to another and it's signaling to
Google hey this particular page is
linked to this page so we're going to
also index that page and so that's the
whole important part of internal linking
it's about the end you user experience
and it's about allowing Google to find
the pages on your website so they can
crawl them and index them so you can be
ranked for them and so also in addition
to internal linking we want to be able
to use natural language and so what do I
mean by natural language or natural
language processing so what Google does
is in terms of natural language
processing they're looking for the
content and the keyword it needs to be
relevant so when your website is about
digital marketing you don't necessarily
want to rank or try to rank for the
keyword digital marketing one it's too
broad two there might be some
competition but three you're probably
not going to write something as broad
like digital marketing so ideally what
you want to do is you want to choose
other relevant related keywords that's
going to be more natural and so that's
what we mean on natural language
processing we want to choose keywords
that are more natural to the content
you're writing so instead of the key or
digital marketing maybe we want to talk
about the types of digital marketing or
digital marketing examples or what is a
digital marketing strategy or how to
become a digital marketing specialist so
those are all relevant keywords to
digital marketing and more relevant to
the content because if you try to rank
for the keyword digital marketing again
it's probably going to be a little bit
broad probably more competition and not
as relevant to your content and as a
result probably not a good user
experience so think about some other
keywords that you could optimize and
rank for and that goes back to the
keyword research that's why the keyword
research is so important because it
allows us to identify other keywords and
the natural language process what
keywords are more relevant for the
content and then another element to
on-page SEO is the sitemap and so with a
site map it's basically a list of all
the pages on your website and the whole
idea of listing all the pages on your
website in one document is it helps both
users and search engines understand the
structure of your website so there are
two types of sitemaps one's an HTML
sitemap and that's designed for humans
so if you have a website with a lot of
content at the footer or the bottom of
your web page you probably want to have
a link to sitemap so if somebody clicks
on that side map they're going to be
able to see all the pages on your
website structured in an organized
manner well an XML sitemap and XML is
just a different format it's designed
for crawlers and so the whole idea
remember is Google likes to crawl
content when they crawl content they
bring it back to their servers and index
it and so we want to be able to create a
sitemap for Google or other search
engine crawlers and so XML is the format
so let me show you example of how that
looks so if I go to simplylearn.com and
simply type in say sitemap.xml just as
an example I'm going to get this
particular page in this particular page
displays two XML sitemaps so these site
maps are there for Google to go ahead
and crawl and nothing more than a list
of all the pages on your website and so
this is a quick and easy way for Google
to get a hold of all those pages so that
they can index them and that's the whole
idea behind SEO you want to be able to
have Google index all the content you
want to be found for for the keyword you
want to be found for so it all starts
with the sitemap so let's go from
on-page SEO which in recap is basically
optimizing certain elements on your
website so that you are relevant for a
particular keyword and that meant
updating the title tag The Meta
description the URL the headers choosing
the right keywords to put into the
content having internal linking chain
and also updating the sitemap well those
are elements that you can do on your
website so we're going to switch gears
and talk about a different strategy
off-page SEO because without on page or
off page you can't have a page ranking
so the two work together so you can do
as much as you want on on page but you
still need off-page SEO and you could do
all the off-page SEO you want but you
still need on page so both of these
strategies have to be in full effect in
order for you to rank so let's now
switch gears to off-page SEO and so
off-page SEO is simply the process of
linking or promoting your website using
link building and so if you remember I
talked about this earlier on there's two
types of links internal and external
linking and so for on-page SEO we used
internal linking for off-page SEO we're
going to talk about external linking and
external linking allows us to improve
our website sites recognition or
relevancy or credibility and why do we
want to improve our relevancy and
credibility and trustworthiness and
Authority because we want Google to know
that our web page is trustworthy it is
recognized by other websites and it is
relevant for a particular keyword and so
if we can do that using off-page SEO
methods then Google's going to rank our
web page for the keyword we want to be
found for so it's really off-page SEO is
synonymous with link building and
there's plenty of opportunities to do
link building it just comes down to
creating a strategy so again some of the
benefits to off page well we talked
about you know being credible and
trustworthiness and relevant we need to
do that in order to rank but there's
some other benefits there so if we're
have a link on another credible website
then it's likely going to increase the
traffic to our own website it also
creates high domain Authority and so
what I mean by high domain Authority is
if we have basically links to other web
pages pointing back to us then basically
our domain Authority is going to improve
and when our domain Authority improves
other websites are going to want to link
to us so the higher authoritative we are
for our website than other web pages are
going to want to link to us and so the
more external linking we have the higher
the domain Authority so it all starts
with linking to other high domain
Authority websites so linking to a high
domain Authority website for example
having a link on Wikipedia that points
back to our web page creates high domain
Authority for us and it helps Drive
traffic so some of the other benefits of
off-page SEO are in credibility so if
we're linking from Wikipedia to our web
page it does create credibility for us
it also helps us increase our page rank
so remember that external linking helps
build domain Authority helps build
credibility
trustworthiness and it's going to in
turn help us rank for that particular
page and then certainly not last having
a good off-page SEO link building
strategy increases our brand awareness
because if we're on other high Authority
websites Wikipedia or say a social
platform it's going to increase our
brand awareness and increasing our brand
awareness increases our trustworthiness
and so if somebody is looking to say
become a digital marketing specialist
then likely instead of typing in digital
marketing specialist on Google they
might type in our brand name in this
case simply learn and so these are all
the benefits to off-page SEO so it's
nothing more than having links on other
websites that are pointing back to ours
and again there's lots of benefits its
drives helps Drive traffic and increases
our Authority so those are things that
we want to take advantage of when we
want want to rank and the key behind
off-page SEO or link building is always
going to be content so from an on-page
SEO perspective having quality content
allows that content to be optimized for
Relevant keyword and ranked but also
from an off-page SEO strategy having
high quality content allows us to have
other sites and it doesn't necessarily
have to be a website it could be a
social platform or it can be another
blogging platform or blogging website
link back to ours why because the
content is original it's natural it's
well structured it reads well and so
that's the whole idea behind off page
you can't have links on other websites
if you don't have quality content so one
of the ideas behind off-page SEO is not
only do you want to create good content
but you probably want to spend a lot of
time or a bit of time on others websites
so remember the example I used earlier
in this presentation about having an ice
cream blog and ice cream recipes well it
probably wouldn't be a bad idea to say
spend some time on other blogs related
to desserts related to cakes related to
food in general related to vegetables or
other items that people could link from
so the whole idea is understanding who
else is out there who has relevant
content that you could share so you
could share your content with them they
can share their content with you and
generally that's how it works naturally
anyway in the web sphere if somebody
likes your content they're going to link
to it they don't necessarily have to
wait for you to ask them but it might
not be a bad idea to understand who else
is out there that has content somewhat
of yours so that you can you know get a
link on that particular website or blog
post and so some other ideas behind
having external links pointing back to
your website is social media so social
media is not just Facebook or Twitter
but it expands beyond that there's
there's core there's media there's all
sorts of content generated websites like
Reddit so the list goes on and on you
just need to find what's relevant for
your content if it's relevant for your
content then it's worth putting or
trying to get the external link on that
social media platform and then again
going back to my ice cream blog recipes
blog post yeah if you find a particular
blog that you want to have an external
link on there's nothing wrong with
reaching out to that particular blogger
you know in some cases very flattering
but in other cases if the content is
relevant then why not it's only going to
help your end user experience if you add
somebody who has a say a Blog about
cakes having their link on your blog
post so there's nothing wrong with it
because it also adds to the user
experience and if you're going to ask
somebody to put an external link on
theirs you might want to be open-minded
and make sure that you're are able and
willing to put an external link on your
blog post or website pointing to their
content that's how the web Works
especially if the contents of quality
relevant and of good nature okay so
let's move on and finish up with the
do's and don'ts of SEO so we talked a
lot about why SEO what is SEO how do we
rank for SEO what is on page SEO what is
off-page SEO and so let's just wrap up
with some of the things you again want
to do to rank your page for a particular
keyword and some of the things you don't
want to do so the first thing on the
list is optimize for white hat
techniques and what I mean for opting in
for white hat techniques is basically
everything I just mentioned today you
want to do keyword research you want to
choose a natural language processing
form format so you could choose keywords
that are going to be relevant natural to
the content and you don't want to opt
for black cat techniques and blad hat
techniques are probably not even worth
going into detail but one example is
choosing a keyword arbitrarily like say
digital marketing and just stuffing that
keyword into the content so that's
probably not something you want to do
because again it's not going to be good
for the end user so stay away from black
hat and focus on some of the techniques
we talked about in today's presentation
the other do we want to do is get
backlinks from relevant sites so that's
off page SEO again it's what I mentioned
earlier it's about linking your quality
content to another person's website that
also has quality content we don't want
to have a backlink from an irrelevant
site why because it's not going to be
relevant and it's also going to hurt our
Authority because if it's on a site
that's not of good quality then Google's
going to look at us and say well this
site is linking to your site but it's
not relevant so therefore you know we're
not going to look at you in this same
way as if you were on a quality website
we do want to use our keywords naturally
because title tags are what people see
first on organic search but you don't
want to use the same title tag on every
page of your website so we want to stay
away from doing that so you want to have
a unique title tag for every web page on
your website and ideally what does that
mean that means using our keyword
research to choose one of two keywords
per page and optimizing your web page
for those one to two keywords so you
ideally what you want to do is have one
or two different keywords for every page
on your website we definitely definitely
definitely want to write engaging
content so the content should be
engaging remember user experience we
want users to stay on our website we
want them to enjoy the content that
they're reading and we want them to go
from one page to another naturally we
definitely don't want to leverage or
plagiarize or just copy content from
others websites because it's not one
probably going to be relevant to what
you're writing about two it's duplicate
content and it's somebody else's so
that's a black cat Technique we want to
stay away from I can't emphasize this
enough we need to do keyword research
first before you do anything else you
need to find relevant keywords and not
only that you need to understand the
volume and the competition for each of
those keywords okay you don't want to
choose a key word that has low volume
High competition you want to choose a
keyword that has high volume low
competition but above all you want to
choose keywords that are relevant to
your content we want to avoid keyword
stuffing so don't take a keyword and
just stuff it everywhere on the page
it's not going to be natural and
Google's going to be able to pick up on
that so we want to maintain some level
of quality with our content and quality
with the keyword that we choose so
reminder when you have quality content
it's always going to link internally to
another page on your website with
quality content but it's got to be
natural and don't just build site-wide
backlinks meaning don't just have an
internal link to the home page or don't
have every page on your website linking
to just one page so internal linking
should be natural naturally linking from
one page to another not only does it
help Google understand and crawl all the
web pages on your website but it's good
for the end User it's good user
experience and certainly last but
something I didn't talk about does take
time to rank your content so remember
the process you're going to write your
content you're going to choose keywords
you're going to change the elements on
that page for those keywords and all the
while you're going to make sure Google
can crawl that content and when they
crawl they're going to index it the
process to takes time especially if you
choose a keyword that's competitive so
just be patient if you have quality
content and you've optimized for on-page
SEO and off-page SEO then you will rank
for that keyword and then make sure your
website's user friendly and mobile
friendly so we talked about responsive
content earlier so remember most users
today start the process of search on
mobile so we want to make sure your
websites are mobile friendly on-page
optimization as the name suggests is the
practice of optimizing web pages to rank
higher and get relevant traffic from the
search engine
on-page optimization includes both
content and HTML source code
optimization search engine optimization
can be very complex so when you're
trying to understand it for the first
time I find it very easy just to break
it up into general concepts that you
might already have an understanding of
when you look at the hundreds of signals
that go into SEO they can be broken up
into either relevancy or because
sometimes it's both popularity so
relevancy and popularity out of all
these signals they fit into one of these
two things we're going to break all the
signals we have into these two areas in
this section we're going to talk about
the on-page factors that's because these
are the factors that you have direct
impact upon and you can make a small
tweak and have a big impact with Organic
traffic with your on-page relevancy
factors the primary on-page relevancy
factors that I'll cover in this lesson
are title tags and meta description
header tags which are used for headlines
and subheadings website URLs and URL
structure image alt text internal links
keyword usage and sitemaps
let's start with one of my favorites and
that is the title tag this is also
called a page title the page title is
not shown on the page now rather it is
displayed on the browser Tab and this is
what makes it highly important is that
in addition to being displayed on the
browser tab it is also the title tag or
the page title that is shown on the text
in the Google search results as the link
to the page
the page title influences both the
click-through rates and people's first
impressions of our website
next up we have the meta description
Now The Meta description can be a bit
confusing
The Meta description is in the code and
it does not influence rankings
but it does influence clicks
people will see your snippet or your
page information in the search engine
results
that gray text is the meta description
if you don't have a meta description
then it may pull information from the
page
you can affect this and improve the
chances of your meta description
appearing if you write a short
descriptive phrase of the content or the
purpose of the page
and just because we edit these elements
does not guarantee that they will show
up
I often say that we affect the change
but we cannot control it
this is because the search engine May
override your changes and show different
content in these areas
sometimes it may help and it might be a
better description but many times it's
not
now let's go to the next element the
header tags these are also referred to
as the heading and subheading
and this is how HTML was built when the
web was first created
it enables a logical hierarchy of
content
so starting with the headline then
displaying a subheading and then
subheadings after that
the idea here is that you're
establishing a hierarchy of information
so you start with the H1 like a
newspaper there's only one main headline
per page
it describes the main purpose of the
page
then a subheading the H2 this is how you
break the sub content into subcategories
obviously you'll want to use a keyword
in there as well
you see by describing the purpose of the
page in the headline and then again in a
subheading you're naturally going to use
your primary and secondary keywords
because you're going to associate them
with the product or the purpose and the
benefit
the key is to keep it short
you see after the headline are the
subcategories the H2S and then your H3
is typically used as a paragraph heading
now putting the keyword in these
headings alone does not make your page
optimized
remember the purpose is to provide a
quick reference for people to find the
content they need within seconds
so short explanatory heading and
subheadings paragraph headings are very
effective
and naturally you'll be using keywords
to help people locate the information
that is most important to them
now if we go back to the search engine
results page the serp there is another
element in that listing the page title
is the large Blue text The Meta
description is the gray text now the
green text is the URL of the page that
is listed this is the address of the
page just like the address for your home
the internet knows that the URL is the
address for that page this is extremely
important for SEO for a variety of
reasons the most important though is
your keyword usage I like to make sure
that I have at least one Relevant Word
in the URL now also here keep it short
one of the worst things you can do is
have a URL full of keywords or even
worse hyphenate them all remember people
use these urls
they provide context for the page people
also copy and paste URLs into Mobile
messages emails and Social Links so it
is extremely important to keep these
short succinct and I like to say
readable
now I've just briefly touched about the
importance of the URL and now let's look
at the URL structure
first let's start with the primary core
of the URL the domain name
in the example with the URL I have here
example.com that's the domain name so
this is the first thing that people see
with your online business
now be on the internet this is going to
be what's in all of your ads emails
brochures business cards and online your
social profiles all of your marketing
efforts are going to drive people to
this domain there's a lot of advice
about buying or using domains that have
your keywords in them and unfortunately
domains have been being sold for decades
so there's less chance of finding a
domain with the keywords you want now
the search engines don't make the
keyword used in the domain a primary
ranking signal so that's good however
the domain is your business it needs to
be memorable if you have a very I call
it a spammy looking domain name with
multiple words and hyphens or one that's
hard to spell or confusing people are
going to make an initial impression off
of that so make sure you have something
that's going to make a great first
impression here's the rule for a domain
name something that's easy to spell and
easy to pronounce ideally sure it's
something you can type and share some
something you're going to be able to put
on a business card and be proud of not
something that you bought primarily
because you want it for SEO reasons and
you think with that you're going to
succeed as an example just think about
Amazon their domain name says nothing
about books and yet it grew to be one of
the largest e-commerce companies in the
world the same with Alibaba or Google
their domain names were not the keyword
but their marketing and branding built
their company now everything after the
domain is a subdirectory this is based
on your website organization as an
example if you have a website selling
shoes then the subdirectory can be
called shoes it's easy right the sub
directory is the folder that contains
the relevant files or Pages for that
group think of a file folder with
documents inside the file folder is
usually based on a major category of
content or products now inside the
folder are individual documents or Pages
these files or Pages usually come after
the subdirectory in this example you see
the file.html the next step in
optimizing the URL is to name the page
in a way that explains the content of
the page to use our eCommerce shoe
website a page name would usually be a
specific product name this way you would
end up with domain name forward slash
shoes as the category forward slash
brand name running shoe insert that here
if you've ever looked at the HTML that
make up the instructions of the page
you'll understand a bit more of how
search engines get the information from
the page the text on the page and the
markup such as the headings provide
instructions as to where the text is
located the importance and prominence of
the text in addition to the arrangement
of the overall page HTML is a set of
instructions for a browser to assemble
the page and the search engines use that
as well now the search engines spiders
cannot see images as the internet
developed many attributes were added to
provide for accessibility and additional
features users that are site impaired
cannot see images
and the alternative text tag describes
the image
further there are many times when our
bandwidth isn't strong and not all of
the images will load in that case we
need the alt text description to provide
the context of the image and its purpose
search engines use this alt text
description to gain additional context
about the page the content of the image
and its purpose now we have an entire
section on links but at this point I
just want to cover internal links an
internal link is a link from one page on
your website to another page of your own
website now this is important from a
relevancy perspective
you'll see internal links in your main
navigation
you'll likely have a link that says home
one that says contact us or about our
company
what you're showing to search engines
and to humans is that this section if
you click on this link is about our
company or this is where you find our
contact information
you see these links are not votes like
external links however they provide
relevance and context to the information
on your own website
let's dive in a little more on keywords
when a search engine crawls and
processes your website it doesn't simply
look for the instances of specific
keywords
it's a lot more complex than that
it's using a technology called natural
language processing
natural language processing uses
algorithms to try to understand the
meaning of text
you see search engine processing is
attempting to be human
this is the same way that people see and
hear the words and we're using the words
to find the meaning expressed in the
words
similarly when a search engine goes to
your website it may see keywords but
it's looking for the context of those
words
you may say football but just having the
word football repeated throughout your
website isn't going to help you rank
specifically for football
what you need to do and what is more
common in actual human conversation
happens very naturally
when we talk about football we use
naturally additional words such as goal
and referee and World Cup you see Google
and the other search engines are going
to take these into account
by usage of other synonyms and other
common words you present the context of
a bigger broader idea for your website
the next site signal that we have is
site Maps now there are two kinds of
site Maps there's the site map that is
for humans and there is the site map
that are for search engine robots
crawlers or spiders
the one that is for human is called an
HTML sitemap you've probably seen these
before the link is generally in the
footer of a website if you click on it
it shows you the major sections of the
website provide some search
functionality but looking at it as a
human it shows you the hierarchy of the
website and where to find important
information
it shows how everything fits together
now there's something else that exists
called an XML sitemap
it's not linked from any page of your
website but exists as an independent
file on your server
now this is something you can see but it
is formatted for search engine spiders
using a programming language called XML
it shows the hierarchy and the priority
of each of the URLs of the website every
page every document every image and it
also shows the date that each page was
last updated or changed
so at this point we've covered a lot of
things that are important and things
that you should be doing when optimizing
your on-page content
now let's go a different direction and
cover things that you should not be
doing keyword stuffing hidden text
repetitive anchor text and cloaking the
first one is keyword stuffing now back
in the early days of search engine
optimization people used to increase the
instances of words on the page now this
is well before natural language
processing at that time search engines
were looking for occurrences of specific
words well search engines they're very
smart about this
what may have worked 20 years ago or 10
years ago keyword stuffing does not work
you're not going to rank better for any
given phrase by including it a dozen or
more times on the page in fact you might
get an over optimization penalty by
constantly repeating the same word over
and over focus on writing content that
engages with your visitors and uses
language naturally now the next one is
hidden text unfortunately I still see
this this is when you write content that
is solely for search engines and not for
people now typically it is attempted by
writing a lot of repetitive keywords as
text coloring it white and placing it
against a white background as you see
this was developed as another way to add
more keyword stuff text without the user
seeing the overuse of keywords now it
didn't work too well in the past and it
definitely does not work today
this tactic backfires in two ways first
search engines can tell when it's white
text on a white background it's easy to
tell from a computer science point of
view search engines read the HTML and in
the HTML are the instructions for colors
when you hide text modern search engines
are smart enough to figure it out
probably better than a human now
secondly it's done to hide repetitive
keyword stuff text which is the second
thing against you these outdated
unprofessional tactics will most likely
get a website penalized by the search
engines the next one is repetitive
anchor text
you may have followed a link to a page
when looking for a business or
information and instead of the
information you want you get a page that
doesn't feel like it was written for
people
every sentence is redundant repetitive
and almost every keyword is linked even
when there doesn't need to be a link it
confuses the flow of the information on
the page now again this used to be a
tactic that sometimes would work but
it's no longer helpful
search engines and their natural
language processing algorithms have
advanced significantly they can tell
when something's not readable when
something is probably intended for
machines and rankings but not for people
search engines will figure it out please
don't waste time on redundant links
trying to inflate the relevance of your
links and Pages the last thing to cover
here is cloaking cloaking is the idea of
showing one thing to the search engines
and something entirely different to
humans now this is related to the rest
of the tactics I just covered it's
something that used to work but it was
expressly against the search engine
guidelines while it may have worked if
the search engine is discovered it on
your website you could have been
penalized or dropped from the search
engine results entirely now we've
covered all of the most important
on-page optimization factors let's take
a look at what the theoretically
perfectly optimized page would look like
in this example we can see many of these
elements being used together you can
also see that the base key phrase
digital camera is being repeated but
always included with a specific contact
next first at the top of the page is the
URL which has digital cameras in the
address
the page title follows using the context
of the information and adding the word
reviews you can also see at the top of
the page that the main navigation and
secondary navigation also called the
breadcrumb navigation provides context
of the Page's location within the entire
website and natural keyword usage
the H1 headline is the key phrase but
also happens to simply be the best title
for the content of the page
subsequent subheadings provide
additional information such as ratings
recommendations and features
the links provide relevant ways to
access additional content the image
utilizes alt text there are also clear
calls to action which provide relevant
offers to visitors
as you can see the context of all of the
content is very strong and sends a clear
relevancy signal to both search engines
and readers
to conclude this section I'd like to
cover the top influencing factors now
sometimes you may find these as lists
but I found it a bit more practical to
separate them into categories
typically every year you'll find these
collections of lists from surveys
experts or speculation
some are from testing but honestly you
can't ever truly test a search engine as
they change a little bit with every
algorithm
so the best thing is to take from these
lists these factors that are the tried
and true factors over the years that
have worked consistently
also those tactics that not only make
your website more effective with users
they tend to do well with search engines
so if a tactic serves that Dual Purpose
it's a good tactic
so these are not exclusive and have to
lists for every situation but guides and
indicators for you to use the top
on-page factors from surveys opinions
and data are these
a relevant page title page headings
anchor text links a keyword-based URL
a keyword or contextual file name such
as page name image name or PDF file name
alt text and images and finally what you
do with the content on a page to make it
more readable lists bullet points and
bolded text
the top factors for off-page linking
tend to contain these items
the total number of domains linking to
you
the number of Highly influential domains
linking to you
the number of unique domain IP addresses
the total backlinks without no follow
limits
the total relevant anchor text in links
to you
and finally the types and context of
keywords in Anchor text links
the domain also contributes factors to
your overall rankings such as the age of
the domain which would include ownership
information such as the length of time
owned and operated by a company
the real business information tied to
that domain such as the business address
being the same as the business
registration address for the domain
in addition the signals from social
accounts driving visits to the domain
functionally the search engines also
utilize some attribution based on the
quality of programming of the website
for instance taking care of the basic
search engine Protocols of the
robots.txt file XML sitemap and https
protocol
websites that Implement these features
have shown that they are familiar with
search engine guidelines and protocol
now one of the changes over the past few
years has been the implementation of
page speed as an increasing ranking
Factor
slow loading pages with a lot of
extraneous code that slow the delivery
of the page will be penalized as they
take away from the user experience
optimizing the page code speeding up the
load time of the page can directly
impact your rankings and this is closely
related to the mobile friendliness of
your website
if your website is not mobile friendly
it will be limited in visibility as
Google's primary index is focused on
mobile devices and mobile delivery
behavioral factors are the newest
factors and with the Advent of
artificial intelligence it is making
determining the intent and the is making
determinings easier
for a search engine to derive a judgment
of relevancy based on interaction
while the extent of these signals is not
fully known it is suspected that they
are minor but growing in importance
these include the amount of users that
search for a brand name business's name
and go to that result showing brand
awareness
also the amount of direct visits
bypassing search
time on page pages per session which is
also called the depth of visit
and lastly the behavior of a Searcher
from the results page how many results
are clicked how many times do they
return to the results
this evaluation is looking to judge if
the results presented were satisfactory
or deficient for that query so let's
start with the why we would do keyword
research so Jesse is planning to publish
a Blog of pizza recipes so she was doing
pizza recipes step by step piece of
recipes with sausage homemade pizza
toppings pizza dough recipes thin crust
pizzas she's doing a lot of different
topics on pizza recipes well what Jesse
needs to do is understand what's going
to drive traffic to these blog posts if
she's writing about you know different
topics around pizza recipes so she's
Unsure how these blogs are going to
drive traffic so she really needs to
understand that hey you need to choose
the right keywords to drive traffic so
the question is if you're writing a blog
post about recipes with sausages is
pizza recipes with sausages or recipes
for free the best keyword to use maybe
maybe not so you need to take uh care
and shoes in the queue words to align
with your content so that's really the
idea of why we would do keyword research
because some of the issues with keywords
that are poorly chosen are they could
have slow search volume for example you
may choose a keyword that just a lot of
people aren't using to search for or
they can be highly competitive so if you
choose a keyword that's very broad or
popular it can be very competitive and
take you a long time to be found for
that keyword or you could just make the
mistake of choosing a keyword that is in
aligned with your content or you can
choose keywords but use them incorrectly
with your content so these are some of
the issues that you can encounter if you
just go about choosing keywords randomly
without due diligence without the proper
research so low search volume will lead
to less traffic High competition session
you may not even rank at all okay if
somebody finds you for a keyword that's
not relevant to the topic they're just
going to leave the page and if you're
not using the right keywords and or if
you are using the right keywords and not
using them correctly in the content then
your pages may not even be found in
organic search so you really have to
take care and choosing the keywords to
me that's the most important step with
SEO is keyword research so we're going
to talk about the types of keyword
research then so we have short tail
keywords and we have long tail keywords
so if you write a blog post about pizza
recipes well what are you going to
choose a short tail or long tail so
let's talk about short tail keywords
first so short tail keywords are
keywords that are usually three keywords
in a phrase or shorter in some cases it
may be two keywords in a phrase or
shorter so short tip keywords usually
have high search volume which means
likely means higher competition but what
it all also means it could be lower
conversions because short sale keywords
like for example pizza recipes could be
considered a short choke heat word but
maybe somebody's looking for homemade
pizza recipes or pizza recipes from
their favorite Italian restaurant so
short taking words may not be as
relevant so if we compare it with long
tail keywords chances are you're going
to have lower competition that's one of
the benefits but you're also going to
have lower search volume but with longer
tail keywords the key word is probably
going to be more relevant with the
content you're writing about so
therefore the conversion rates likely
going to be higher so that's really the
difference between short-term keywords
and long tail keywords if you want to
look at simplistically short tail
keywords are Broad in nature it's going
to capture a lot of eyeballs but those
eyeballs may look at your content as not
relevant versus long tail keywords that
may be very relevant but not as many
eyeballs on them so short tail keywords
the characteristics they're not as
specific usually they're less than three
words they have high search volume and
high competition so if you just choose
pizza recipes could take you a while to
rank for that keyword but when you rank
you're going to get the traffic but
again it may not convert because the key
word is Broad in nature so pizza recipes
is a short tail keyword that may not be
exactly what you're writing about in
your blog post so it may draw a lot of
traffic but the traffic may not do
anything so the longer tail keywords are
very specific they consist of more than
three words in the search query they
have relatively low search volume
competition so the chance of you ranking
higher faster for that long take word is
probably going to be greater because not
many other websites are trying to rank
for that same keyword and so the benefit
of that is if you have let's just say
homemade pizza recipes with mushrooms
that's a long tail key word but if
somebody's looking for that type of
pizza recipe then you know know you're
going to track the right traffic and
chances are that traffic's going to
engage or convert based on the type of
conversion you have in place so example
would be homemade pizza dough recipes
that'd be another example more than
thick keywords in the phrase very
specific we're talking about homemade
pizza dough recipe so we're not talking
about just pizza recipes so it's a
little bit more uh specific in nature
longer tail so these keywords are used
for targeted Pages including blog posts
if you're writing a blog post
specifically about pizza recipes with
homemade dough then this is the key word
you likely would want to use versus just
pizza recipes so let's look at an
example between a short tail keyword and
a long tail keyword and to accentuate
the differences we're going to use
Google's Keyword Planner tool so
Google's keyboard Planner tool is
located in Google ads the Google ads
platform and when you're in the Google
ads platform you can simply click click
on tools and then Keyword Planner and so
what Keyword Planner allows us to do is
get a sense of the type of volume that a
particular keyword has so what Google's
Keyword Planner does is they show you
the average monthly searches this is the
average monthly search volume of a
keyword over the past 12 months and so
in this example we're going to choose
pizza recipes and homemade pizza dough
recipes so one short tail and one long
tail so we enter those keywords in we're
going to click get results and what
Google's going to do is it's going to
show us the volume of those keywords so
for pizza recipe we could see the
average monthly search volume is 33 100
for pizza recipe so note that pizza
recipe and pizza recipes are closely
related keywords and so what Google does
is they consider that a close variance
so meaning if somebody ties a piece of
recipe then they're also in Google's
eyes looking for pizza recipes so it's a
close variance and so for the keyword
pizza recipe which is short tail we
could see on average over the past 12
months this keyword received 33 100
queries and so if we hover over the
graph we could see basically the volume
the average volume per month so here I
could see for this particular keyword
here the volume per month is 33 1000 and
then I could see the actual volume over
the past 12 months and then for the long
tail keyword I can see homemade pizza
dough recipe again close variants
homemade pizza dough recipes I can see
over the past 12 months with the search
volume is for this on average is 2400
but I could see here in December the
volume went up to 3600 but for example
in May it was 1900. so it's gonna
fluctuate a bit over the past 12 months
but on average it's about 2400 so
shorter tail a lot more volume longer
tail not as much volume but nonetheless
there is volume here and so these are
the difference between a short tail and
a longer tail and so well Google's
Keyword Planner also does is allow us to
get a sense of what the competition is
and so here I can see the competition is
low for both of these keywords fair
enough so we now know that if we want to
optimize or choose the keyword homemade
pizza dough recipe for our blog post we
know for ranked on page one of Google
even in the top spot we can expect about
2400 search queries for that keyword now
whether you get all 2400 clicks for that
keyword remains to be seen chances are
you're not going to get all 2400 you're
going to get a Lion's Share of those
clicks but you're going to at least get
some volume on it so even the longer
tick keywords have a lot of Promise
because there is some search volume here
for this keyword how to do a proper
keyword research so we looked at
Google's Keyword Planner tool in Google
ads and we typed in two keywords and we
were able to get a sense of what the
average volume is so we definitely want
to choose keywords based on the
following factors we want to choose it
based on search volume search volume is
a good indicator of the potential
traffic we can obtain so again for the
keyword homemade pizza dough recipe we
know that it averages 2400 a month in
search volume again we may not get all
2400 but we're going to get a line share
of that we also need to look at
competition and so Google's Keyword
Planner gives us a high medium or low in
terms of the competition but if you're
somebody who wants to get a better sense
of what the competition is and you
should because competition is a key
component in choosing keywords and so
what I want to do is get a sense of how
many people are actually optimizing for
that keyword so Google's Keyword Planner
tool is going to give me a low medium
high really what I want to do is get a
better sense of that numerically so what
I can do is go into Google search and I
can type in pizza recipes and I could
see there's about 1 billion results
that's a lot of results however that
means that every potential web page out
there on the internet that mentions
pizza recipes is going to be included in
this number here and so I want to get a
better sense of who's optimizing for
pizza recipes so I'm going to put in the
all in title syntax and so what that is
going to ask Google to do is tell me all
the websites that have pizza recipes the
keyword pizza recipes in the title tag
so if I do all entitle colon space then
pizza recipes my result drops down to
336 000. so what that tells me is that
there are 336
000 results with the keyword pizza
recipes in the title tag now if I want
to focus in on my other keyword if I
choose my other keyword was a longer
tail keyword homemade pizza dough recipe
so if I type that keyword in the
homemade pizza dough recipe or recipes
remember close variance and I just click
enter or type the keyword in hit my
Enter key I'm going to get 35 Million
results but again is that really an
indicator of the type of competition I
have no because every listing that
mentions homemade pizza dough recipes is
going to be included in the search
results so I'm going to type in my all
in title colon space and then I'm going
to get a better sense of how many
websites have the keyword homemade pizza
dough recipes in the title tag and I get
2160 different results so here I can see
the first result in the title tag
homemade pizza dough recipe second one
homemade pizza dough recipe so these are
are sites or web pages that have that
keyword in the title tag so now I have a
numerical number to work with and so the
thing you have to understand about SEO
specifically about keyword research is
you need to do research on a few
different keywords not just one or two
so what we want to do is have a
spreadsheet the spreadsheet is going to
contain keywords that we can potentially
want to optimize for choose as keywords
to optimize for SEO and so my
recommendation is you come up with a
theme first so the theme for us in this
exercise is pizza recipes and so that's
our theme so we chose the keyword pizza
recipes so the close variance here is
pizza recipe what was the volume well we
know the volume was 33 100 for pizza
recipe so what are we going to do we're
going to put that number in in our
volume column what was the competition
well if we go back and type in pizza
recipes it was 680 three thousand so I'm
going to type in 683
000. what was our next keyword well it
was pizza or homemade pizza dough
recipes so if I go back for this
particular keyword is 2400 so I'm going
to put 2400 in under my volume column
and then what was my competition well my
competition was I typed that keyword
back in
2160. so I'm gonna put two thousand one
hundred and sixty so now I have an idea
of what kind of volume and what kind of
competition I have now you want to do
this for a number of different keywords
and when you do it for a number of
keywords what you do want to do is
obviously choose a relevant keyword that
has high volume and low competition so
another way of saying it is the volume
or ratio of volume to competition and so
basically what we could do is take
volume divided by competition if I make
that a percentage I can see it's point
three five percent is the ratio between
volume the competition if I do the same
for my longer tail keyword 2400 divided
by 2160 I can see that 111 so this just
kind of proves the point that yeah I'm
still going to get some volume but I
have a better chance of ranking for this
longer tier keyword homemade pizza dough
recipes so you want to be able to do
that for a number of keywords and
examine the volume the competition and
the ratio between volume and competition
for your themed keywords in this case
pizza recipes so relevancy you want to
choose keywords that are very relevant
to the content that you're writing and
then again commercial intent what
keywords are going to drive more
conversions and revenue for the business
so when we talk about commercial intent
we're talking about you know are you
choosing keywords that are going to get
somebody to do what you want them to do
so we could say You Know download pizza
dough recipes so somebody's typing in
the keyword download pizza dough recipes
then chances are they're going to find
you come to your side and take action by
downloading that pizza dough recipe so
you want to be able to also think about
the intent of the key word is it going
to help you drive conversions and
revenue if you're an e-commerce site so
search volume is the average monthly
search volume made for a particular
keyword and phrase so we can get that
number using Google's Keyword Planner
tool in the Google ads platform we want
to Target keywords with high search
volume that will help bring traffic to
the website we want volume but we want
to take into account seasonality as well
so that's where the Google's Keyword
Planner tool comes in place because if
we go back again we can just hover over
we can get a sense of any particular
Trend going on or season out so for
example if I saw a large growth in the
winter months and not much volume growth
in the summer months then that might
indicate to me that this keyword is more
popular during the wintertime time so
pay attention to the grass that you know
the Keyword Planner tool gives you use
them to your advantage to take into
account seasonality so a good example
would be funny Halloween costumes well
we know that for Halloween you're going
to have a spike probably towards the end
of September all the way through October
and then it's going to drop after
October 31st which is Halloween so
that's an example but in the case of
pizza recipes you know you may find that
more people are choosing to search for
pizza recipes during maybe the summer
months versus the winter months so pay
attention to seasonality it will affect
search volume so competition based on
our example it's one of the most
important key metrics you don't want to
choose a key word that's highly
competitive because if it's competitive
then it's going to be harder to rank
number one or even on page one of Google
depending on competitive it is so high
search for I Am low competition in other
words is the ratio between the two is
the ideal combination so going back to
the spreadsheet recommend you have that
spreadsheet handy put your theme in
place okay theme pizza recipes we use
Google's Keyword Planner tool to find
the volume we use the all entitled
syntax to find the competition so we
entered both of those numbers in and we
get our ratio and so when you have these
numbers for a number of different
keywords you want to be able to choose
that ratio of high volume low
competition but always relevancy always
trumps ratio so always go with a key
word that is going to be relevant to
your content don't choose a keyword
that's not relevant if you choose a
keyword that's not relevant it's not
going to bode well for user engagement
so the difficulty of a keyword ranges
from 0 to 100 in Google's keyword tool
so it's going to be easy it's going to
be medium it's going to be hard but my
recommendation is also to get the new
numerical factor and that's the all in
title syntax and again relevancy is what
drives the traffic to your website and
keep the traffic there on your website
and also not only will keep the traffic
on your website but hopefully get that
traffic to engage and convert so that's
the key about relevancy you always want
to choose keywords that are relevant to
your content even if it's sacrificing
volume relevancy again trumps volume and
competition so always choose relevant
keywords first so when you do that
you're always almost guaranteeing that
at some point somebody's going to find
your content because somebody out there
might be looking for it and if they do
you're going to get found and then the
engagement is going to be better so
understand your business find keywords
that are relevant to your business and
then focus on those keywords that'll
help you with getting the right traffic
to your site always keep in mind the
commercial intent so these keywords are
more specific and result in conver
version rate for example buying is a
good commercial intent keyword so if you
really want somebody to come to your
website and buy then focus on those
types of keywords in the case of the
pizza recipes maybe it's download could
be our commercial intent keyword again
there may be low search volume but those
are the type of keywords you want to
focus on because that's the type of
traffic you want to drive to your site
so some other examples a commercial
intent keywords or discount deal your
coupon shipping you know don't be afraid
to use some of these keywords as part of
your longer tail keyword phrase again
the volume may not be high but the
traffic quality is probably going to be
better so keyword research is the
foundation for SEO so if you have chosen
your keywords properly then if you do
get ranked for those keywords then it's
going to lead to better engagement with
some conversions and so when we talk
about keywords we also want to talk
about our primary and secondary keywords
so every page should have at least a
primary keyword and then a second carry
keyword to work with so primary keywords
are really defining the nature of your
content the secondary keywords are
relevant to the primary keyword so why
do we choose a primary and secondary
keyword because you may choose a keyword
as a primary keyword that is relevant to
the content but may not necessarily rank
very high or have a lot of volume that's
secondary keyword is also relevant to
the primary keyword but also relevant to
content and you may rank for that
secondary keyword so you always want to
go with two keywords versus just one
keyword you want to give your yourself a
chance to rank for at least two
different types of keywords of relevant
nature so for web page there can be
several secondary keywords but only one
primary keyword so your primary keyword
is always going to be relevant to your
content secondary keywords can be
relevant to the keyword but and you may
have multiple secondary keywords but
it's also going to be related to the
content and it gives you a better
opportunity to be found between both the
primary and secondary and search Okay so
let's take a look at another example of
how to use primary keywords and
secondary keywords when choosing
keywords so if our primary keyword is
healthy diet plan remember healthy diet
plan is directly related to the content
so that's what we're talking about but
these secondary keywords are also
related to content and play off the
primary keyword and so what we want to
do is go to cool Google's Keyword
Planner tool and get an idea of the
volume for healthy diet plan and then
also the volume and competition for some
of these secondary keywords like healthy
diet for weight loss healthy diet food
low carb diet healthy meal plans and
diet plan weight loss so if I go in to
Google's Keyword Planner and type those
keywords in I'm going to choose get
results and now here I can see healthy
diet plan keyword I'm focusing on is my
primary keyword has an average monthly
search volume of 9900 and then some of
my secondary keywords healthy diet foods
diet plan weight loss low carb diet you
know Google will give me a number of
different keywords to work with so I'm
going to look at the search volume of
those as well and so ideally what I want
to do is be able to then look at the
volume and then look at the competition
so healthy diet plan to go into my
keyword analysis here that's my theme so
that's my keyword what's my volume for
healthy diet plan nine thousand nine
hundred what's my competition so my
competition is seventy four thousand
seven hundred and that's going to give
me a ratio of volume to competition of
13 so that's what my content's about
that's a considered a short tail keyword
because it has a lot of competition and
so my ratio is 13 and what I want to do
is I want to be able to put these other
secondary keywords it's in here as well
maybe even go to a little longer tail
because I want to be able to find two
key release two keywords I want to be
able to find my primary keyword that's
relevant to my content and then I want
to be able to find my secondary keyword
which is again related to the primary
keyword which is also related to the
content and so I want to be able to
choose two keywords basically and I want
to choose two keywords that are relevant
that have good ratio between volume and
competition so that's the whole idea
again I'm how to do keyword research you
want to be able to find your keywords
use the tools available to you and get a
sense of what the volume is what the
competition is look at the ratio between
the volume and competition and then
based on the content choose that primary
keyword and then again based on the
keyword you chose choose some secondary
keywords as well because you want to be
found for not just one keyword but
multiple keywords okay let's look at
some alternative suggestions to key
keyword research so for doing keyword
research we want to take into account
LSI keywords we could take into account
other platforms that host a lot of
content like quora or Reddit we can use
Google suggestions in the keyword search
bar we can use popular platforms like
Wikipedia and we can use social media
bookmarking like Reddit so there are
lots of suggestions that we can obtain
from various sources so let's start with
LSI keywords and LSI stands for latent
semantic insect indexing and so
basically what it is it's just keywords
that I'll link to your primary keyword
and so when you're choosing keywords you
always want to choose that primary
keyword and then secondary keywords that
are similar to the primary keyword and
usually those are LSI or latent semantic
indexing type keywords so they're used
to drive relevant traffic to your page
so if you're focus in on one keyword we
want to to have other keywords that are
similar to increase our visibility on
the search engine result pages so we
could find latent semantic indexing
right in search so if we use the term
healthy diet if we go to Google search
for example if I type in healthy diet
and Google search all I need to do is
scroll to the bottom of the page and I
can see searches related to healthy diet
so healthy diet menu healthy diet essay
what does a healthy diet look like
notice at the top Google's also given me
some other suggestions here so they're
saying low-fat diet veganism gluten-free
diet so there's lots of different
suggestions right in Google search bar
so all of these are LSI related keywords
so if you're optimizing a page for a
healthy diet then you could choose
low-fat diet as a secondary keyword you
can use gluten-free diet as a secondary
keyword it really depends on what the
content is but you always want to
support your content with as much LSI
keywords as possible so you can be found
for as many different keywords as
possible in Google search so it's
important because if you have a Blog
that you know talks about python so how
do the search engines know if the
website python is about the programming
language or the snake so Google for
example uses LSI keywords to understand
what the page is specifically focusing
on so if you're just focusing on Python
and your content you want to support
that with LSI keywords and so that will
allow your web page to better
communicate with Google also to have the
visibility to show up on search so they
can certainly improve your search
positioning and featured Snippets as
well so if you have a keyword that
answers a question you could certainly
found for feature snippet for example
maybe you know healthy diet recipes if I
type that in you can see here there's a
featured snippet so if I'm talking about
recipes that's a key word I may want to
use and if I use that then Google has an
opportunity to see what my content's
about and place my information at the
top in this featured snippet you can
also again see what some of the
questions are being asked what mails are
good for weight loss what is a good
healthy diet plan all of these can be
keyword phrases that you can use so the
answers are right here in Google so Cora
is a great platform because core is a
platform that people go and ask
questions in a community responds with
answers or responses to that particular
question or topic and so the great thing
about core is it's a good eye is a good
place for you to go to get some ideas
about a specific topic so if we're
talking about healthy dieting so we can
find keywords with high search volume
writing quora so the whole idea is you
can look at you know the top five
questions for specific topic like
healthy dieting and find relevant
keywords to healthy dieting so if you
just type in that particular keyword in
quora you're going to probably get some
responses to questions or responses to
somebody else's question and so if we
take a look at core for example so if I
just type in healthy dieting what I'm
going to do is I'm going to get some
responses to the the topic healthy
dieting so what's the best diet for
Healthy Living what are the top five
tips for a healthy diet habit so all of
these could be keyword phrases that you
could take away with for your own
content and so the benefit here is
you're getting kind of an idea of what's
trending what people are talking about
and if you use tips for a healthy diet
habit for example and you optimize for
that well again that could turn around
and bode well for you because you could
be featured in Google as a featured
snippet at the top here you can also
turn around and use LSI related keywords
for healthy diet habits and you can
simply just look for those LSI keywords
right in Google remember at the bottom
or at the top up if I scroll down I
could see some related LSI keywords at
the bottom so writing Google as well you
could see in the Google search bar that
Google provides some LSI related
keywords to your query so if I go back
here and type in healthy diet recipes I
can see here Google's suggesting some
other related keywords healthy diet menu
healthy diet for men healthy diet foods
healthy diet for women so these are all
LSI related keywords that you can use to
support your primary keyword and the
content you're writing about so we've
talked about LSI keywords where to find
them so they're found right here they
can be found at the top of Google and
they can be found at the bottom you can
also then go to core as well and get
some ideas for the types of questions
that are being asked so if you ask a
question and use that as your keyword
phrase then again you have an
opportunity of showing up for a featured
snippet in Google just by doing some
additional research within Google itself
or on quora so according to Google the
autocomplete predictions are
automatically generated by Google's
algorithm without any human intervention
it's based on a number of factors but
the primary factor is how often past
users have searched for terms so Google
collects all the keyword queries that
somebody types in and they're suggesting
some of the most popular terms that
people have typed in so if I go back to
Google again if I start to type in
recipes I could see some of the other
queries that somebody else has typed in
or some of the most popular queries
related to that topic so if you enter
the keyword healthy diet Google's going
to suggest multiple keyword suggestions
that users have asked in the past and
you could certainly get the search
volume of those keywords just by looking
in Google itself I can see for healthy
diet recipes billions of pages related
to healthy diet recipes I can also get
the search volume by going into Google's
Keyword Planner so if I type in healthy
diet I'm gonna to be able to see what my
search volume is for that keyword and in
addition I can see the seasonality of
that particular keyword and in addition
to that Google's going to provide some
other related keywords to my search
query so if I'm looking for healthy diet
Google's going to suggest hey maybe you
should choose healthy food or healthy
eating or how to lose weight so those
are LSI related keywords that Google
provides in the keyword plan which is
built into the Google ads platform
another option for you is Wikipedia so
Wikipedia is a vast platform of content
so we could turn Wikipedia into our own
assets and use it to our own Advantage
by finding relevant keywords in an easy
fashion so with Wikipedia we can
identify a list of keywords in The Meta
description itself we could choose
keywords from the first paragraph of
Wikipedia that has many relevant
keywords or we could take a look at
keywords from the Wikipedia content
section so we can also see additional
Pages like the see also section that
gives relevant keywords that you're
looking for we can also look at the
references section as they contain
relevant keywords so go to Wikipedia as
an example and I type in healthy diet
into Wikipedia here I can get just in
the first paragraph alone I can see some
additional keywords that I might choose
to use like micronutrients I never knew
that micronutrients was related to
healthy diet but Wikipedia is providing
some information about what
micronutrients is and maybe I can use
that as a keyword an LSI related keyword
to my content so if I scroll down I get
to see also section so it might give me
some information food information
consumers for example dietary guidelines
I can look at categories like dietetics
and diets I can also look at the
references section so I can also see
what what information was provided like
health effects of overweight and obesity
I can look at diet and physical activity
so all of these are related to my main
keyword healthy diet so the answers are
right in here on the platform they're
just all over the page so Wikipedia has
an abundance of information you just
need to know where to look so again with
Wikipedia you can look no further in the
first paragraph you look no further than
the C also section the references
section category section there's lots of
information right on the page itself to
help you get ideas for keywords so if
you Google your keyword with Wikipedia
term in the search query and get
relevant keywords from the title tags on
the serp so you can also do that as well
so if I type in healthy diet Wikipedia
and search I can also get some
information here as well so people also
search for healthy food advantages or
healthy food habits essay or information
about healthy food all of these are
related to my keyword healthy diet so
again another bit of information for you
to choose or look to choose some
additional keywords for so Reddit it's a
popular Community where people post
content and discuss a variety of topics
so that's what Reddit is so with the
help of subreddits an individual can
find relevant keywords with with high
search volume so in Reddit there's an
easy way to find out keywords they have
a keyword tool called keyword it so the
keyword it gives the average monthly
searches for a particular keyword so if
we type a Word in key Reddit and choose
keywords from the auto generated list
this tool will extract the keywords and
give us those relevant terms with search
volume so if we go to the keyword it and
Show an example of that for example
healthy food if I get keywords I can see
what keywords are relevant in the search
volume of that keyword so if I just type
in healthy food keyword it tool is going
to tell me some relevant keywords in
which the volume is so if you don't have
the Keyword Planner tool in Google ads
available to you this is a good
alternative solution to finding keywords
so it's free you just need to go to
keyword.com type in your keyword click
get keywords and what it's going to do
is give you some relevant keywords
related to your primary keyword with the
search volume let's talk about keyword
clustering now so the whole idea about
keyword clustering is to really take
advantage of the keywords that we're
optimizing for to gain higher rankings
so if we can cluster keywords together
in a theme and that theme of keywords is
relevant to a specific page of a website
then we have a better opportunity to
rank so in other words why do we have to
Target just one keyword when we can
Target many so keep in mind you know LSI
keywords we want to group a bunch of
keywords together that are similar for
Content so for example after some
keyword research search you can
thematically group keywords into a core
topic so for example we can cluster
these group of keywords together like
for example what is SEO how does SEO
work intro to SEO what are the basics of
SEO all of those are related to The Core
theme what is SEO another cluster of
keywords for example could be SEO
techniques SEO best practices tips and
tricks website optimization on-page SEO
techniques Etc so those are clusters of
keywords okay that we can group together
in themes and if we group keywords
together in themes we can apply that to
a particular content on our website so
the whole idea behind clustering
keywords it's going to provide more
diversity more of an opportunity for us
to be found so that's the whole idea
behind clustering so some additional
steps remember stay up to date on
industry news to brainstorm your ideas
first and identify by a list of keywords
like ethema keywords that you can
cluster together and then you could
determine the keywords that your
competitors are already ranking for so
for example if we want to rank for the
keyword SEO best practices for example
we can use a tool called keyword Moz if
I go to keyword the keyword Explorer
tool and Moz and just type in SEO best
practices what it's going to do is it's
going to give me some volume related to
that particular keyword but more
importantly what it's also going to do
is going to show me what pages are
already ranked for that particular
keyword so therefore I can get a sense
of who is already ranking for that
keyword so here I can see Moz Moz
medium.com alexa.com so I can get a
sense of what web pages are ranked for a
particular keyword or group of keywords
I want to write for myself so if we look
at tools for keyword research look no
further than Moz that's the mods of the
tool I would just use but you could also
use Google's Keyword Planner which we
used in the example so for example if I
go back to the Google ads Keyword
Planner if you're in Google ads you
click on tools you click on Cleveland
planner and what Keyword Planner does is
it provides you for a particular keyword
the average monthly search volume of the
past 12 months it provides you
information on seasonality so if I hover
my mouse over a graph I'm going to be
able to see the volume per month over
the last 12 months what the keyboard
planner also does is it provides me some
additional ideas for my particular
keyword and in addition to that it's
going to provide me some sense of how
competitive that keyword is by telling
me whether it's low medium or high in
terms of competition so there's sem Raj
there's also other additional keywords
tools out there like word stream or href
or the Reddit tool keyword it and then
Moz is is another tool I particularly
you so if I go to Moz again here I can
just type in a keyword that I'm
interested in it's going to give me the
search volume of that keyword it's going
to give me the level of difficulty so 50
out of 100 so it's halfway between
difficulty and easy and then it's going
to give me some additional metrics like
for example what my expected organic
click-through rate would be if I were to
rank for this keyword but more
importantly what I like about this is we
could see exactly what other sites are
linked to this particular keyword we're
interested in so here I can look at the
top 10 list so this is mozz's keyword
Explorer tool so that's what this tool
is and it's part of moz.com so there's a
lot of tools at your disposal I
particularly use Moz I particularly use
Google's Keyword Planner and those are
the tools I use but there are lots of
tools out there so if we order review
everything we talked about with keyword
research we started with why keyword
research so we want to always take a
look at what keywords have a good ratio
of volume and competition so we always
want high volume and low competition we
always want relevancy for our keyword
and we always want to choose a primary
keyword and secondary keywords so that's
things to look for when we talk about
you know doing keyword research we want
to look for high volume low competition
relevancy and also commercial intent are
we selling a product and do we want to
use keywords like the word by in our
keyword phrase that's going to get
somebody to purchase that product if
they type in a similar keyword with Buy
in it as an example so that's why and
how to do keyword research we talked
about the types of different keywords
that we can focus in on we specifically
talked about short tail keywords and
long tail keywords so short tail
keywords are going to be three words or
less in the keyword phrase they're
always going to have high volume but
most likely they're going to also have
high competition so it might take you
longer to rank for that short tail
keyword because there's a lot of other
websites who also want to rank for that
keyword so my recommendation again is
stay away from short tail keywords
because it's going to take you longer to
rank now you can focus on longer tail
keywords now these keywords are more
specific they're more than three words
in the keyword phrase they're likely
going to have lower search volume but
it's going to be more specific and it's
probably going to bring more quality
traffic to your site so an example of a
long tail keyword would be homemade
pizza dough recipes that's what we
looked at earlier so you can always pick
keywords that are longer tail but also
relevant to your content and again the
benefits quality traffic and probably
higher engagement then we looked at
alternative suggestions to doing keyword
research we talked about LSI keywords so
LSI keywords or latent semantic indexing
so we want to take a look at keyword
words that are relevant or related to
your primary keyword we looked at other
platforms where you can go and find
other relevant keywords we talked about
quora we talked about Google suggestions
in terms of their search engine and
their toolbar talked about Wikipedia
going to Wikipedia and using the
categories or references section we
talked about Reddit with the keyword
tool that allows you to see you know
keywords in the search volume there and
again that's a free tool to use so you
have lots of suggestions lots of tools
at your disposal like Moz sem rush so
there's no shortage of places you can go
to to find keywords the key takeaways
really is find keywords that are
relevant stick with longer tail you know
find supporting LSI related keywords
choose your keywords wisely in terms of
commercial intent and then stay away
from keywords that are highly
competitive because the more competition
for keyword the longer it is going to
take you to be found for that keyword
work we then finished up with keyword
clustering so group your keywords
together in a theme so remember if we
cluster keywords together in a Content
theme then likely it's going to be more
relevant for the content it's going to
give us a better opportunity found for a
variety of keywords definitely use the
tools to your advantage some are free
some are not my suggestion on using
different tools is to try them out see
how the user interface works for you see
what kind of data that these different
tools provide are they easy to use and
does it provide all the different
information you're looking for like
competition or who else is ranking for a
particular keyword or the volume and
some of the other metrics that you may
need to do your keyword research so try
your own tools out and see what you like
you don't necessarily have to go with
our suggestions but certainly the likes
of Moz or sem rush or Google's Keyword
Planner are always popular amongst
people who do SEO in the section on on
page optimization we talked about fact
factors that centered on relevancy in
this section we're going to go in a
different direction we're going to talk
about the signals that focus on
popularity so what does popularity mean
in this context well it's actually quite
simple popularity always relates to
links to hyperlinks on the web so you
have seen these when you see the
typically blue text that is underlined
what this is is a tool it's a ahref
technically in HTML that is pointing
from one web document to a different one
this is a pretty simple concept I
imagine you already know this
so what does this mean from an SEO
perspective well it turns out that this
gigantic group of signals the ones
related to hyperlinks are and are and
historically have been the Lion's Share
of signals that the search engines
process when trying to rank pages
now there's one big problem with these
from an SEO perspective is that they are
historically and today very difficult to
influence this is because they do not
take place on your website they take
place elsewhere it's other people who
are linking to you generally speaking
and this makes them very very difficult
to have an influence on so this is a
good thing and a bad thing it's a good
thing because it it turns out to be a
great metric for ranking web documents
it's a bad thing because it's hard for
us to make an impact on day-to-day level
hands down the most time consuming and
difficult part of SEO is link building
now there's a lot of reasons for this
primarily because it's constantly
changing and because of all the elements
that are involved with this but the big
the bigger takeaway here is that there's
no one-size-fits-all solution for link
building you have to take the context of
your business of your website and you
have to apply general principles to that
so in this video we're going to cover
these general principles so you can
figure out how to apply those to your
business
these principles are and I think these
are the most clever and the most
important ones are creating link worthy
content
proactively participate in an off-site
engagement and utilizing offline
relationships the tried and true method
for building links is creating content
that's optimized for humans so let me
explain what this means the currency of
the internet if you will is the content
itself that's why people go on they want
to read the newest article or they want
to see the newest video whatever it may
be that is what has been true since the
beginning and I have no doubt will be
true going forward so as an SEO or as an
online marketer in general you can use
this to your advantage creating the
content that people are going to want to
share with their friends whether they're
going to want to cite in any kind of
paper or whatever they're working on
that is a tried and true way of getting
links this is what we call the power of
content you can do all kinds of bells
and whistles you can go do these newest
tactics you can try all these different
things out but at the end of the day
what's really important is the content
itself so this is what I focus on this
is where 80 of my time goes on when I'm
working on link building it's on the
content itself can I create something
that is just truly that is so truly
great that someone essentially has to
link to it this is what I focus on
trying to answer and while there is no
simple answer to that go and ask that
question always sets you in the right
direction
the next strategy that I want to talk
about is actually very counter-intuitive
so if you're trying to build links to
your own website I found one of the most
effective ways and this is consistently
true is to engage off your own site now
this doesn't make any sense right why
would you work on other people's
websites if you're trying to promote
your yourself well think about human
beings human beings are much more likely
to link and give back to people to human
beings that they know well so a lot of
the time I spend when I'm doing link
building is spent off-site engaging with
others so sometimes this is through
social media so I'll use whatever the
latest social network is and I'll chat
with people there who have similar
interests or have similar interests to
what I'm trying to promote be it a
different topic or be it a new industry
altogether I'll spend a lot of time
promoting others and a lot of times
chatting with other people building up
genuine real relationships with human
beings so that when it comes time for
them to write an article or when it's
when they're ready to link out to other
people I'm the first person they think
too and they link back to my website one
of the reasons that link building is so
hard is because the internet moves so
fast asked what worked yesterday might
not work tomorrow
so one of the most clever and easy ways
to avoid this problem is to just simply
go offline utilize some of the
relationships that you have off of the
internet in order to benefit on the
internet this is something I try to do
all the time because it consistently
works by far the easiest favors to cash
in on are the ones that you're already
owed so these might be from your friends
who you work with it might be from
friends who from childhood these are
people who you actually know in the real
world who are much more likely to help
you when you're trying to promote new
content online
so what I'm trying to do link building
one of the things I focus on is people
that I know in the real world
so this can be lots of things this can
be personal friends who happen to have
websites and blogs this can be friendly
competition you have or friendly allies
you have in your space just saying hey
we're looking for these kind of things
can you help us out and maybe I'll help
you out somewhere else it's utilizing
these relationships that Exist Elsewhere
so that you can start gaining these
links yourself
if that doesn't work if maybe you don't
have any friends in these Arenas you can
always go to local businesses and local
agencies so sometimes this is a
government-owned thing sometimes this is
just third parties all together
there's lots of things that they need
help with that you as a business owner
or you as trying to promote some client
may be able to help them with and if you
can help them offline they're more much
more likely to help you online well link
building it's very important to
understand that not all links are are
created equally a link coming from the
home page of CNN is going to provide a
lot of what we call link Equity it's
gonna have a lot of popularity metrics
tied to it and so it's going to be more
valuable to you and help you rank higher
whereas a link also coming from the home
page but let's say Joe's spam blog that
is not going to be particularly helpful
for you and it actually in some cases
could hurt you so when you're going out
and doing link building make sure that
you can stand behind the source of the
link that is coming at you this could be
in a good example from like a government
website where it's trusted and a bad
example this could be from a website
that you would not normally go to even
on your own
in addition to that there's different
kinds of links depending on the
direction that they're going so if a
link is coming towards you towards your
website that's called an inbound link
these are the ones that are very helpful
for popularity metrics that we've talked
about
there's also outbound links these are
links that you linking to other people
now generally there's a big
misconception about this that you'd
think you would not want to link out to
other people but if you just follow the
natural Channel events and you look at
people who are writing blogs without SEO
in mind you'll see that they are linking
out naturally and it's these natural
patterns that search engines are looking
for so there's absolutely no problem in
linking out just as long as it's two
sources that you actually do trust so
there's inbound links there's outbound
links there's links that have a lot of
popularity value so like from an
established Government website or from
something popular like CNN there's also
links that are inbound that are not
going to have as much value for you that
you probably don't want to spend your
time building now regardless of where
your links are coming from it's
important to look out for one particular
attribute it's called Rel nofollow Rel
no follow was a tool that was originally
developed to combat comment spam like on
blogs you'd have lots of people who are
leaving
completely irrelevant comments so they
can link back to their own website and
get credit for that that does not work
at all today one of the primary reasons
for that is the search engine introduced
something called Rel nofollow where they
said here's a link that's going out for
my website but I do not stand behind it
and it does not pass any credit a lot of
times when you're doing leak building
you'll get a link which you're very
proud of coming from somewhere very
popular but then realize that it has
this attribute attached to it no follow
and which means you will not get any
credit for it so make sure that when
you're doing your leak building the link
coming at you that you've earned does
not have this attribute associated with
it otherwise you will get no credit for
it now that you understand what nofollow
is let's let's talk about the biggest
use case for this social media most of
the links that we see in social media
are valueless this is because they're
either hidden from search engines
entirely this mostly happens on Facebook
or they're visible to search engines but
they use this row this Rel nofollow
attribute which means that they're
useless so while social media does have
many many benefits SEO and particularly
link value from SEO is not one of the
direct benefits of participating in
social media now that we've covered some
of the link building dues let's talk
about some of the link building don'ts
so these are things that you should not
do because you'll be wasting your time
and possibly more importantly your money
the first one is Spam so we have all
seen this online when you go somewhere
and you see just a bunch of spammy links
links that are clearly written only for
machines only for search engines a lot
of times these will have the name of
pharmaceutical drugs on them a lot of
times they'll have um just can be
completely irrelevant to the content
while these have worked in some
instances they are certainly not a best
practice and they are certainly not a
long-term strategy so I never recommend
trying to invest in spammy links this
way because it's not going to ultimately
help you in fact in many ways it'll
probably hurt you so do not go out of
your way to try to get spammy links
the next one is buying links this is
these are toes closely tied together now
buying links is when you go out and try
to buy sometimes relevant sometimes
irrelevant links and again this is
something that had it worked sometimes
historically not always my biggest
problem with this is not so much the
ethical problem although there is one
there the search engines have clearly
said not to ever do this my biggest
problem with it is that you could not
calculate an accurate Roi on this so if
you spend a dollar on this you don't
know if you're gonna make a dollar or
two dollars back you have no idea
there's no way to accurately measure
this so you have no idea if this if this
is valuable to you or not
where as opposed to if you're creating
valuable content you can measure that
and you can directly tie it to Sales so
your your money dollar for dollar is
spent much much more effectively on
content than it is on buying links so I
highly recommend do not spend your time
or your money buying links
the last one is acquiring reciprocal
links so reciprocal links as you can
imagine are links that go in a circle
you link to somebody and they link
directly back to you now in the natural
web when no marketing is taking new
place into this there's no kind of
manipulation trying to go on that
happens that happens all the time so
don't go out of your way and be afraid
of this happening so one new site will
very regularly link to another news
article and that article might link back
to them somewhere else that happens so
don't stress about this too much but
don't go out of your way to try to build
all of your links in a reciprocal way
we're overthinking this by trying to
link to somebody else who links to a
third party that third party links to
you don't waste your time this is just
not a factor that you should worry about
reciprocal links are not generally as
good as one-way links but it happens so
often that is not is not worthy of your
time or any kind of investment trying to
avoid this
the concept of linking is foundational
to good rankings and understanding the
internet at Large
it starts with the premise that good
content will be cited by others
recommending it to other people
how we cite and recommend information
online is by linking to it
we link to information that we find
valuable
based on that the search engines assess
content by how websites link to one
another
so we are going to cover the definition
and purpose of links and the different
functions that links serve
we'll also look at how links mirror
human judgment
we'll look at how search engines
evaluate links by mirroring human
judgment
and how that affects what's called Block
Level analysis
and how where the location of different
links and how they are used will greatly
affect their relevance
we're going to look at how visitors from
different link sources will behave
differently based on where they came
from
and also how you can measure the
effectiveness of links and finally we're
going to look at both good and bad
linking practices now links serve a
number of purposes
from a functional standpoint they
usually are our primary means of
navigation online we click on links we
go to different pages and from those
pages we find links to other pages
links are also a method of citing other
content
when we quote somebody when we use
information that we have found somewhere
else we cite that information to give
credit to the original author typically
online we do that with a link so that if
someone wants to see the original Source
document it's available to them that
also helps to provide credibility to you
credibility to the author of the
original source as well as assigning
importance to the knowledge that came
from that original source and the
authority of the original source
links also provide us with a clear
structure of how our websites are built
how the pages relate to one another and
how organized the information can be
so let's break down the functional part
of a link
this is important if you're going to be
developing anchor text and linking to
understand the structure
the ahref equals is the start of the
link tag
what you are doing is developing the
reference of where the document is
contained that's the href reference is
what it is short for
what comes next within the quotes is the
location of the document now this can be
a full URL or you may just be linking to
a document that's on the main root level
of your server
this is the full location where you can
access the document
and so you're putting the name of the
document the extension so that it will
be linked
the next part is what I have in caps
you'll notice off to the left I have
something in all blue text and
underlined which most people will
recognize as a link
you see when it is in between the
document location
and the closing of the link tag the text
you have in there is what's called
anchor text
you see instead of publishing the
document location and the full URL of
the document
we can put the link within text and
create anchor text so all someone has to
do is click on the link and the document
loads for them
this anchor text is vitally important to
understanding how we can add additional
relevance to linking content
then we see the closure of the link tag
this is what makes the internet the
internet is millions of pages connected
together by Links
so when we look at the functional side
of links and we look at this example
here as you can see the title of this
article is not the URL address of the
article
it's a title and the title is the link
that is the anchor text of the link
and so from a search engine standpoint
search engines look to see what words
are being used in the link and how
relevant those words are to the document
that is being linked
it also looks to see where is the link
is it in the editorial information in
the article
is it part of the navigation
is it in a sidebar or is it an ad
and then also search engines are looking
to see if this is a text link or an
image link
how long has that link been there
what type of link is it does it go
somewhere within your website does it go
to another website or is it a reciprocal
link which I will explain more later
they also look to see the text in the
link and the context to the page with
the link directs you to
we utilize links a little differently
you see from a human standpoint whenever
we refer information to another person
when we provide reference material to
another person or even if someone asks
us for a recommendation we provide this
information
you see offline we mirror the same
behavior as we do online when we link
people ask us for information and we
provide it
we just mirror that online by making a
link
offline we recommend we refer we provide
information to each other in much the
same way the way I want you to think
about it from a human standpoint is that
if you asked another person for advice
or directions or a referral
are there certain people that you would
trust more than others
I'm sure the answer to that is yes and
maybe you have some people in mind that
you are thinking about
you see we run across the same issue
with search
the search engines know that there are
some websites that are much more
trustworthy than others
just like if you were to ask someone for
information I'm sure you would ask the
right person
for the information you would ask the
most knowledgeable trustworthy person
you knew
who had Authority in that subject area
the search engines are trying to do the
same thing with the links that we
publish on our websites they're trying
to determine who is the most trustworthy
and relevant based on the
recommendations referrals and citations
of other websites to other websites
who are the websites that are trusted
that are authorities
the search engines are trying to do from
a technical algorithmic standpoint what
we do naturally from a human standpoint
now from The Human Side as I had said
before we need to think of links as
information that we receive from other
people
Word of Mouth advice information
directions recommendations this is where
we need to think about links not from
the standpoint of building false
relevance for a search engine but being
a helpful resource for our readers how
can we help them how can we provide
information and how can we be a credible
source of information
how can we develop our Authority within
the industry and so that people who have
questions about this content will see
our websites as authoritative and
credible resources
the best way to develop links as you'll
see is good content when people like
what they read when they like what they
see when they are willing to recommend
it to others it's because you have
created something of value
and they'll link to you when they feel
that you are credible
and that you are authoritative with this
information
only then will they share it with other
people
because you have earned that right for
them to share it with others by
providing content that is informative
educational
entertaining and you've provided that
service only then will people then want
to recommend it to others by linking to
it
now links serve a number of benefits
When I look at some of the incoming
links to my site one of the things I
notice is that if I get a link in
certain places that can drive a lot of
brand exposure I can have thousands of
people coming to the site looking to see
an article and that provides a lot of
exposure to a lot of people
however also getting a link from a
certain website especially if it's a
high relevant authoritative website I
can see my rankings increase because of
that
but then also a good link is going to
drive people that will convert and drive
sales or leads those who become
customers
so those are the three aspects of a good
link a good link will drive traffic to
your site a good link will assist your
rankings
and a good link will bring in business
if you can get a link to do all three of
those at the same time that's what I
call the golden link because it has all
three benefits
usually however you're going to find
that different links will provide
different types of benefits one of these
three or maybe two out of these three
one of the things I'm usually very
focused on is the link that drives sales
or generates leads that's getting links
in the right place that will benefit me
tangibly rather than just getting
thousands of people to see it
why it benefits me financially if I can
get a link in the right place
so from here let's break down the
different types of links we have
navigational links we see these in our
navigation our primary navigation maybe
the footer of our web pages where we
have links to typical information such
as about us or contact us
we also have sidebar links this might be
related information or offers or calls
to action
and then also I would break it down into
outbound or inbound type of navigation
outbound are links going to other
websites inbound links are links that
come from other websites and that also I
might send to other pages on my own site
now I've used the term editorial an
editorial link is a link that is found
within the content of the website
and by that I mean through an article
so if I am writing an article and I link
to someone else and cite them or
reference them
that is what's called an editorial link
it means that it's part of the content
a great example of this is that the
navigation on your web pages is not part
of the content
it serves a function as navigation
but it doesn't have anything to do with
supporting information with citing and
Authority
so information and links that you put
within the content and presented content
of your site are considered editorial
now there's also a call to action links
where you're bringing someone to a
landing page or a registration page or a
sale page
then also we have Social Links now these
can provide a variety of means but
typically a social link will go to a
profile
maybe it's a username that takes you
somewhere else or comment or maybe just
an image or something that goes to a
social site or that you have placed on
your own site as well
either way it's all contained within
that social network even though the
links are going on and off your site
they tend to be controlled in that
social environment
now I've used the term reciprocal link
now this is
something very specific
a reciprocal link is one where you would
go to somebody else and you would make a
trade such as if you link to me I'll
link to you
and maybe you put those links on the
home page or maybe you create a page
just for that link
you see sometimes it just doesn't make
sense and so the search engines will see
that you've linked to each other but if
there's no contextual relevance if
there's no contextual relevance
most likely you won't get any benefit
because you've agreed to link to each
other for the primary purpose of
boosting rankings now this is not to say
that two websites can't link to each
other because there is some relevance
we'll look at some examples of that
later on in this module
also then we have advertising links
these can be ads banners anything on the
page that is an advertising link that if
you were to click on it you would go to
that advertisers page
those links are typically through an ad
server and they take place in entirely
different ecosystem
but they are links and we need to know
what kind of links are advertising and
which kind of links are functional to
our websites
now when I broke down the different
types of links so we have our navigation
links we have links in our sidebar and
in our footer with Block Level analysis
does is that the search engines look at
the code of the page
they break down the page because it's
very easy to figure out which part of
the code has to do with your navigation
which part of the code has to do with
your sidebar and your footer and which
part of the code is calling ads from an
ad server what this leaves is the
editorial content your article and the
ability of search engines then to break
down your page into these different
elements the reason why they do it is
that the links contained in the
editorial space are considered to be
more relevant in terms of linking to
other websites than any of the other
types of links on your web page search
engines don't consider all parts of the
page to be equally relevant which is
okay because neither do humans we look
at the navigation as utilization pure
utility because it's just helping me
navigate among the different pages of
your website I'm not expecting to learn
anything I'm using it as a functional
means of navigating your site now your
sidebar might have some calls to action
it might have links to other pages but
it's not an article it's what you've
developed and so it might be a little
more important than your navigation but
it's not as important as what you may
have written within content your footer
navigation is basically the same you
control that it's the same on every page
and so what the search engines are
looking for are the unique content the
unique article or information that
you've published and if there is a link
within the editorial content that is
highly relevant because it has to do
with content it has to do with
information that you are sharing and so
the links there are going to be more
highly relevant and are going to be more
important for the search engines to see
you see it's the same way with humans
we're not going to look at navigation to
learn something it's functional the same
thing with the footer and as humans
we're reading the content that you have
in your article and if you link to
another source well you've provided us
with utility but it's contextual utility
because you're citing where you found
information or you're citing an
additional Source or you are linking to
an example and it enables me as a human
to see that understand it and if I need
that additional information I can click
on it and go to it
so I'm going to look at the information
on the page in that article very
differently that I'm going to look at
the headings the navigation the sidebars
or the footer because the article is
what is informing me and so the links in
the article I'm going to look at very
differently and hold them in a higher
level of relevance
now over time search engines have had to
refine the algorithm about links
you see in the early days of search
engine algorithms they used to Simply
count the amount of links than if one
site had more links than another that
made it more credible
however once people started to figure
that out people started accumulating
links by really any means necessary
and they were just looking for the sheer
volume of links because they knew if
they got the most amount of links it
would affect their rankings
and so over the years the search engines
have had to change and adjust and add
more relevance to their algorithm
refine it in order to look at different
aspects of links
in order to properly determine relevance
so over time it wasn't just having a
link it was then also looking at how
many people cite this site as an
authority so looking at the source of
the link and the types of pages
then also looking at the text of the
link and matching it with the text of
the page
does it match is it contextual
and then looking at the type of Link
doing the Block Level analysis
and then also the context the relevancy
of your site compared to the linking
site compared to the link and the
information that's being shared there
also some of the ways that they can look
at it are the age of the link how long
has that link been there
humans do the same thing when we look to
see how long someone has been in
business we're looking at credibility
and then of course there are many many
other ongoing refinements that are going
into the search engines evaluations of
links sometimes the age of the link
isn't as relevant especially when you're
looking for something that has happened
very recently
an Old Link could mean that it's old
news or that something has changed since
then
so search engines are in a constant
battle to ensure that people are not
gaming the system
by falsely creating relevance through
linking
the link relevancy and the algorithm is
all about trying to determine who is the
most relevant and credible within this
area
and that is the focus of most search
engine algorithm refinements over the
past few years and it will be into the
future
now this is where I'm going to start
bringing in some screenshots from a link
Management program
as a search engine Optimizer a link
Management program is probably going to
be one of your best friends as you move
along in this industry
in this example this program link Decks
that I'm using will track the incoming
links to my website and it'll also
provide a breakdown as to what type of
website those links are coming from so I
can see how many links I have from blogs
how many links I have from news sites
how many links from wikis how many links
from directories forums social media
public relations sites articles or
additional resources
then I can also add my competitors and I
can compare where I stand in terms of
the amount of links from each source and
where my competitors stand
in this way I can be sure that we all
have a similar link profile you see if
my linking profile looks vastly
different than all my competitors the
search engines are going to see that as
well and know that something might be
different with me good or bad and that's
going to raise a red flag
so I want to look at the linking profile
because every industry and
almost every business is linking profile
is going to be a little different but
especially among Industries we see that
linking profiles that is the amount of
links from different sources it's going
to be slightly different for every
different type of industry or business
so this helps me understand where my
links are coming from which is vitally
important because from a business
standpoint one thing that I've tracked
consistently in analytics is that people
will act differently and also I can
predict which source is going to send me
the best customers
you see just because someone comes from
a link doesn't mean they're going to buy
or become a customer or really become a
lead
many times they're going to come look at
your information and leave
and based on how they come to your site
whether it's through a Blog a directory
a forum or a new site has a lot to do
with how they view your website
and it's all about the context
you see this is what I've learned over
the years is that people will behave
differently based on how they find the
website
what I found is that people from blogs
news sites and articles they tend to
stay longer do more and have a higher
chance of conversion of becoming a
customer or a lead
the main reason is because blogs and
articles they have a lot of context it's
an article someone has taken the time to
write some information out and then link
to my site which means there is a highly
contextual reason for someone to click
that link
also what it means is that there's a lot
less competition for that link when my
link is in that article
compare that with social news or any
type of social site
you see when you're on a social site and
you're looking at your social stream of
information there's a lot of different
people competing for your attention a
lot of different things and it's not
just in one subject area it's usually
from multiple subject areas and so the
context is very low because there's a
lot of different types of information
and the competition for your attention
is very high
because of that people from social sites
or applications
tend to visit more often but they only
tend to view one page and leave
immediately
because they're looking to see what was
interesting and then they move on to the
next subject
that's the difference between how people
react based on where they come from
and so when I'm measuring links I'm
looking to see which links do I have
what's the source and then how do those
sources behave differently from one
another
and why
you see if I find that I'm getting links
from sources that people are staying
longer doing more and converting at a
higher rate then I'm going to continue
to focus on building links in those
areas because it directly affects how I
monetize my website
so here's a strategy in building links
one of the things I'm looking at is the
source of links like I said if I can
find a link Source that's providing
visitors that will stay look at my
content engage with the content and
eventually convert and convert at a
higher rate than other sources of
content or visitors
then I'm going to focus on that source
and so I'm going to look at some high
Authority websites whether they're
industry Publications news sites
education sites those are what are
considered high Authority
blogs articles news sites
that's what I'm looking to do I want to
find the most authoritative website
and sometimes it happens naturally if
people that work at those websites or
manage those sites if they find you and
they like your content they'll link to
it and that way you can get more
credibility more relevancy
certain people certain organizations
certain websites have more Authority
influence than others it goes back to
the question that I asked you early in
this module that how do you know if
someone is more authoritative than
somebody else
we also have mid Authority websites
which you can get some links on and low
Authority websites which are very easy
to get links but here's what I've
learned when it comes to link building
one link from one high quality website
can be worth hundreds or thousands of
mid to low quality links
ultimately it's about quality not
quantity
one of the things that I will do
utilizing my link software is look at
the context of the link
I want to see how relevant this is so as
I said if I want to find a high relevant
website what I'm looking for in terms of
this is I want to see the influence of
the domain as well as the relevance of
the domain those are two factors that
we're going to look at when we're
evaluating the quality of a domain now
as I'm looking at this report here what
influence means is that it is a high
quality website that within the linking
algorithm these sites have a lot of
authority however they may not be
relevant
so for example they may have a lot of
sites attributing authority to them
but they may not be relevant to my
industry which is why we have the next
column of keyword relevance
you see when I'm evaluating my links I'm
looking for the sources that are both
influential and relevant
that means that I've got a link from a
site that fits the two standards of high
Authority it's authoritative and
relevant now it's good to have links
from authoritative sites that might not
be relevant
it's still authoritative
however to get the full benefit I want
it to be influential and relevant but
not to say that I'm not looking for
links from these other sources this is
just a means of measuring what you have
as well as comparing it to your
competitors and other websites
now here's some best practices when I'm
optimizing anchor text I want to
maintain contextual relevance so I want
to use text in the text link and I want
to explain to people what they're
linking to what they're going to find
when they click on that link if I use an
image as a link I'm going to use an ALT
attribute because if that image doesn't
show up that ultrabute
is necessary to let people know where to
go
but also I do get a little tiny bit of
benefit by using that alt attribute
within the image link
I also want to look at the relevance of
the source page that I'm linking to and
make sure contextually the link the link
text and the content of the page is
contextually relevant to the destination
page
I also want to be sure that I don't
overuse the keywords that I don't make
multiple links to the same destination
that I don't use the same anchor text
over and over
I can be downgraded or even penalized by
the search engine algorithm if that is
found on my pages
so as an example instead of using click
here
for a how-to article
I might use the exact phrase of how to
fix whatever it is and use that as the
link to the page that has the content
that's a simple way of looking at anchor
text am I directing someone to
additional information if I am then how
can I present it to them so they know
exactly what they're going to find and
Link it appropriately
I look at it as developing the next step
for your readers where do you want them
to go what do you want them to do what
resources do you have available to them
how can you structure them so that
they're easily understood and you're
explaining the Final Destination
like I said if you overuse anchor text
you can be downgraded or penalized by
the search engines
so what I will tell you to do is number
one avoid overstuffing anchor content
that means needlessly repeating keywords
in the anchor text don't do that
avoid being redundant meaning don't have
four or five or six links with the same
anchor text going to the same page
that's a clear way of letting search
engines know that you're going overboard
don't just randomly Place links
throughout your text just to get the
link
ask yourself are you really helping the
reader find the information they need
and do it once
and then also avoid extremely overly
promotional words within the linked text
such as best expert cheap number one
those types of things
so a couple examples we can say for
travel advice click here but I would say
here is my travel advice and Link travel
advice rewrite it be creative
if it were easy everyone would be doing
it
but this is where you can write things
in a better way to get the attention of
the reader and position it as a resource
also utilizing your url as the link or
as the anchor text as well for the link
in order to get that click
as I've got it here I would not
recommend that you use that I would
recommend that you avoid that
also the third line the check out the
best website for iPhones and iPhone
accessories utilizing overly promotional
words is one of those ways that you can
easily get caught by the search engines
now for future considerations when it
comes to Links realize that the majority
of algorithm changes are link based
evaluation refinements because people
are constantly attempting to fool the
search engines and develop a false link
profile
you should work to create high quality
links with high quality content
I wouldn't chase after Poor or low
quality links
now as I've mentioned before there are a
number of tools available for you to
manage and measure your backlinks tools
such as link decks Moz Raven Advanced
Link manager Majestic SEO and then also
you can use your Google analytics as
well however Google analytics only shows
you the visitors that have come from
links and what they've done the basic
functions of Link management software
and there are many other types other
than what are listed here
but the first thing that it does is just
provide a catalog of incoming links from
other domains to your site and your
competitor sites they offer tools for
comparison to see which domains are
linking to you what type of link it is
and on which Pages those links are
listed they'll also report newly
acquired links in the past 30 60 90 days
or something similar to that the purpose
of Link management software is to help
you assess high quality domains versus
low quality domains in terms of
importance and relevance
like I said the first job of a link
management tool is to collect all of
your backlinks you add your domain and
the tools will usually spider the domain
they'll go out into search engines and
go out into many other formats in order
to find and retrace who is linking to
you what page that link is contained
sometimes what text is on that page and
what text is being used in the link they
will catalog all of your incoming links
organize them format them and report
back to you most of these link programs
provide additional filters and
management tools so that you can get
more insights about who is linking to
you how they are linking to you and the
type of site
personally I use Link decks in order to
Monitor and report on my backlinking so
the first report here that I'm showing
out of Link decks is that I see the
total amount of incoming links to my
domain this says I have over 2 000 links
and those 2 000 links are on about 1 000
domains on average it looks like I have
about two links from every domain that
is linking to me so this is one way that
you start to look at your links number
one the total amount of domains that are
linking to you and then the total amount
of links available this way you can
isolate domains that are linking to you
consistently and also find those that
may not be the best domains or that are
sending a lot of links that are just not
relevant
the next thing I do in analyzing My
Links is to look at the type of Link
meaning the type of site that it's
coming from
this report breaks down the amount of
links coming from blogs news sites
directories forums social sites articles
or resources now it doesn't usually get
all of those links but it does get
enough to give you an idea of how well
you're doing in each channel one of the
things that I do like about this report
is it also has a timeline so I can look
and see when new links have been
acquired and maybe when some links have
been just disappeared that's called
churn and it's normal it's normal
because many times a link is published
on social media and it kind of just goes
away or it's not tracked anymore by your
link management software it can't find
it anymore and so linking is always
Dynamic you are always gaining new links
and losing old links there's going to be
a normal amount of churn
the next report shows me all of the
domains that are linking to me it also
shows me in the next column how many of
those domains are also linking to at
least one competitor and it will list as
many competitors as I have listed in
here if they list to multiple
competitors
it would let me know the influence of
that site or the authority that site is
seen because of the amount of websites
and credibility that Authority has for
that domain it'll also let me know the
keyword relevance how relevant that
website is overall contextually to my
domain and the content that I have
it will also let me know how many pages
on that domain have links to my website
so I can also go through and I can
filter this list by the type of site I
can filter by those domains that are
using anchor text to see how much anchor
text is being used and what type of
anchor text there are many different
ways that you can filter through all of
the domains that are linking to you in
order to get an idea of what's happening
on your domain what are competitors
doing and also the relevance of those
links to your site
now when I say that I can add
competitors this is another type of
report very similar to the one I showed
earlier where I look at my own standing
in the different types of sources of
links such as blogs directories forums
and so on I can also when I add my
competitors look to see how they are
performing in those different areas as
well and so I can compare my link
profile to my competitors
different Industries are going to have
different backlink profiles they might
be more heavily weighted towards blogs
or they might be more heavily weighted
towards forums or social sites in this
way I can look to see if my competitors
are actively link building and how
they're going about it I can see where
maybe they are excelling in one area
that the rest of the competitors are not
so I can compare different strategies I
can also compare different timelines to
see if I am acquiring Links at a faster
rate than my competitors this is very
important if you are a newer business or
a newer website trying to compete
now specifically what I can do is look
at an individual domain in this case
this domain has three pages linking to
me and that domain also links to two of
my competitors I can look at the
specific pages and what I'm looking at
here are Snippets this should be
familiar to you because what it's
showing is the URL of the page that's
linking to my page it shows me the page
title of that page and then in this
report it lets me know if there are any
keywords being used in the link in the
anchor text as well as the number of
links from that page now what this tells
me is that this is most likely a
directory something that is listing all
the different places that where you can
buy products because it's most likely
the linking to the domain name seeing
that there are no keywords being used in
Anchor text and also that there are 16
out about links from that page that
means that it must be a list of some
sort and they are linking not only to me
but most likely to competitors as well
so I can track my Links at the Domain
level and at the page level I can look
to see which Pages might have more
influence or relevance to my content I
can also see the link URL the page title
if any keywords are being used in the
anchor text and also within the context
of how many additional links are leaving
from that page if there are a high
amount of outgoing links on that page
then a link from that page might not be
as valuable since there are so many
links the less links there are coming
out from that page the more it will
benefit my site because I'm getting more
benefit from less links
now also what I'm going to do is compare
the link reports to my analytics I'm
going to go to my analytics because
linking software does not show traffic
it doesn't show how many people are
clicking on the link it only shows who's
linking to you but it does not show
visitor activity analytics will show you
visitor activity to see which domains
are most effective in sending visitors
to your site if you'll go back to the
primary benefits of linking visitors
branding and business analytics show me
visitors and business it shows me which
domains are sending me visitors and
which of those visitors are becoming
customers
so what I can do is go to Google
analytics look at all the domains that
are referring traffic to my site I can
also click on the domain and see the
destination page that they are linking
to I can see how many visitors are
coming either monthly or annually how
often they're coming back whether
they're new users or repeat users how
long they stay how many pages they View
and how many conversions as a result of
those visits this is a great way to get
a 360 degree view of your linking
because not only do you want links that
will help you rank better you also want
links that will send business and
customers to you as well
building links can take many forms
ideally it is through networks
relationships and marketing that other
websites and users learn about you like
you and recommend you to others
unfortunately there is a lot of bad
outdated and untrustworthy advice to be
found about building links to your
website
in this section I'll present the best
practices as accepted by the omcp
standard
the objectives for this module that
you'll be able to develop a link
building strategy
that you'll understand the value of
different link types
finally you'll be able to find inbound
link opportunities
first step in building links is to
evaluate what you have
now there are many tools available that
you can utilize to do this for you there
are automated tools that you can get
that will catalog all of the incoming
links to your website
some of them are link decks Moz Raven or
Advanced Link manager there are many
that can do that you may also want to
utilize your analytics as well in order
to find websites that link to you
the first step is evaluating where you
are right now
your incoming links have a significant
impact on your rankings
and you can do a lot of on-page
optimization and see some results
however a lot of Google's algorithm
takes into account links from other high
quality websites
now when you evaluate what you have in
this example I'm showing you a
screenshot from link decks
link decks catalogs the incoming links
to my website and it groups them into
different areas
the first way it groups them is by high
value or high influence domains
those are websites that link to me that
have a lot of influence not necessarily
in my industry but High influence based
on the amount of people that link to
them as an authority on many different
subjects
the next way that it groups that is
based on relevance
now this is when it looks at the match
of my content versus the content of the
other website
in the first example we can see the
National Library of Medicine
it is a high influence website because
it is a government website with a lot of
information that is cited frequently
because of the amount of other websites
linking to that site it has a high
amount of influence
now based on the website that I am
measuring
there is a lot of keyword relevance
meaning that that National Library of
Medicine site with the government has a
lot of content that's very similar to my
site a lot of the same keywords are
being used
so not only is this website of high
influence it also has a lot of relevance
and that's key when evaluating my
backlinks
I want to look at which websites are
also referring traffic
so while I may have a link from the
National Library of Medicine I want to
look at my analytics and look to see is
it also providing visitors our visitors
following that link to my site and I
also want to look at the quality of
traffic that it produces
do these visitors stay longer than
average
do they convert more than average I want
to look at the quality of traffic based
on the source
next I want to look at the incoming
links from those other websites number
one I want to make sure that the
incoming link from the other site is
both accurate and relevant meaning the
text that is used in the link is it
accurate to the content that will appear
on the page when the visitor clicks that
link
is the content relevant this is
especially relevant if I have updated my
website changed the content or moved
things around
I want to be sure that that incoming
link sends visitors to the appropriate
page and the appropriate information
I also want to ensure that that link is
worded correctly that it uses the right
words that is sending visitors and
setting expectations of the content that
they will see
I may need to contact the website
manager or owner and maybe ask for a
better linked text or a more accurate
page destination
now this requires some interaction with
the owner or manager of another website
and you always want to be respectful of
their time and not demanding that they
make any changes
in some cases the organization may be so
big you may never find the right person
in order to optimize the text or the
destination of that link
you always want to look for accuracy in
cases where your company or website name
is utilized in the link
but also if there is any contact
information such as address phone number
a description of your business and any
content
make sure it's accurate and it all
points to the right place
another way to look for links is to
Simply go to a search engine and start
doing searches
search for your company your business
your company name and look for websites
that may mention you but do not have a
live link to your website
many times your company will be
mentioned or cited but there will not be
a live link you can only find these
through doing searches and seeing which
websites mention you without linking to
you
now this could be an opportunity to get
an Easy Link especially if you can find
some contact information and finding the
right person that could add a link to
your company information
again you'll need to be polite ask for
their help and it will help it if you
can develop the link along with the link
text and send that over
giving them just a quick and easy edit
to be able to add the information
so make it as easy as possible
as an example I've provided a sample
request format
again you want to be polite you want to
be inviting and respectful of their time
and their management
sometimes like I said you may find the
right person that can help you
however the larger the company the more
difficult it will be to make this happen
this just requires your patience
and again being polite and not expecting
the company to do what you are asking
many times this is just a formality and
sometimes companies will act on it so be
sure to approach this with the right
expectations
the next thing I want to look at are
business listings these are the easy
ways to establish links and ensure that
links are where they should be and also
opportunities
look for business directories especially
if your company has a local presence
you can utilize Chamber of Commerce
lists Association lists or local
listings
if they are on websites see if they
offer links that can go to your website
rather than just the list of businesses
that are in the area
even on a larger level you can look for
associations directories or listings
where you can add your business or
double check if your business is there
and always ensure that your business
name address phone number and URL are
correct complete and consistent with
other listings
the next level will require some active
marketing and that's where you search
for opportunities
you can go out and look for other
resource lists within your industry or
directories of businesses within your
industry and you can get a link many
times through membership or submitting
your business as a resource
however you may want to step up your
marketing you can do that by
interviewing your clients seeing if they
might be willing to provide a
testimonial and a link to your website
you may also want to go out and find
other communities online maybe some
social communities that are relevant to
your industry
get involved with those communities fill
out a profile and get involved by
contributing information
by sharing information you'll find that
people like getting information and
they'll respond by linking to your site
another option is to utilize the tool
that you had for indexing your links
from the first step you can also add
your competitors and you can look at
their backlinks
you can look and see which websites and
which domains are linking to your
competitors but you always need to go
and see why what are those other sites
linking to and what is the nature of
that link
sometimes it may exclude you from being
able to approach competitors backlinks
and ask them for links
however if they're being linked to by
companies that are simply stating here
are vendors in this space and they are
linking your competitors and you're not
there
then it might make a lot of sense for
you to approach and ask if you can be
listed as well
however be sure that the links to your
competitors are not from a consumer or
customer relationship
in that case it might be out of line for
you to ask for a link
make sure if you approach anyone who's
linking to a competitor and asking for a
link to your site
make sure the context is right and that
it makes sense for them
and that's the ultimate judge of value
does it benefit somebody else to link to
your site
we all know that it will benefit you but
when you present your link request you
need to offer value and the benefit for
others to link to you
so be sure that you present it in a way
that is beneficial
and good for those people that will be
adding the link they're the ones that
have to take the work to do it and
they're also the ones that are adding a
recommendation for you and your business
so as always you need to be considerate
and patient
now the best way to build links is by
creating something that people like and
sharing it
you see the best way to build links is
by creating value through content or
information or entertainment
you see when people like things they
link to it
if they find a study or a white paper or
research that you performed they link to
it
if you post a infographic that explains
something
and it's attractive people link to it
you see that's what's most amazing about
linking I find that when we put most of
our effort into creating content that
people like
that's what builds the most valuable and
the most relevant links
and so what type of content well you can
create infographics videos top 10 lists
or articles articles with advice or
analysis of Market data or even research
that type of content people love it and
so when you publish it out you utilize
social media to extend the reach and the
visibility of that type of content
and when someone likes it they'll link
to it and recommend it to others
now people also like depending upon your
industry or your business they also like
some personality maybe some humor
people always like expert information
they like the cute this is why pictures
of cats tend to be liked and linked to
more than almost anything else
and also the unexpected
if you can inject any of that into your
content that just makes it more valuable
more personable and again more shareable
by other people and every time someone
shares it it builds a link to your site
you see the best linking is when people
like something
when you create something that people
like and share you might be surprised at
the many opportunities there are
to get links based on your content
I've seen many many blogs based on
cooking fashion Arts Sports music
and when people specialize within a
specific topic they always find an
audience and so anything they publish
builds links
even on certain social media sites such
as Pinterest
people upload pictures on articles and
infographics especially about
landscaping flowers food cars you name
it there is a special interest for
anything and you can develop links from
those social sites to your site
and it can generate traffic
even with a Blog developing articles
that talk about upcoming events new
music Sports whatever it is when you
create content that people like
it takes the longest amount of time to
build content for building links when
you develop your own content that's the
biggest investment you'll make in time
and research and writing and
presentation
however
the result is that when you develop that
content
you will receive the best and highest
quality links and the most valuable
links
are going to be to that content
as I mentioned before one high quality
link can be worth more than hundreds or
thousands of low quality links so my
best advice is to create content that
people like that they link to
and that will be high value links that
you'll generate to your site focus in on
so let's talk then now about how the
Google algorithms work so we'll shift
gears here and we'll talk about how
these algorithms work on Google so
Google uses advanced concepts retrieve
data so what they do is they're
spidering they're spidering they're
collecting web pages and they're taking
all these web pages back to their server
and anytime somebody does a query
they're delivering those web pages
within milliseconds they're delivering
results based on your query so that's in
general how it works so it uses a
combination of different algorithms to
deliver the best results they want the
best results and so some of the most
popular algorithms below are Google
Panda Google penguin and Google rank
brain so these are all things that
Google has done and to make sure that
they're constantly tweaking their search
engine is to deliver the best results so
let's talk about some of these these
popular algorithms and before we talk
about these popular algorithms let's
just make one thing clear that Google's
always tweaking their algorithms on
their search engine and so if you want
to get an idea how often they do it well
they do it every day they're constantly
tweaking it but what they do is they
release major changes to their algorithm
a few times a year so if you want to get
a sense of what those changes look like
well you could go to moz.com and you can
go to Google Dash algorithm Dash change
and you can see here that hey Google
changes the search algorithm around 500
to 600 times while most of these are
minor Google again rolls out major
changes like Panda like penguin that
affects search results in significant
ways so you can go here and you can go
all the way back to 2000 and see some of
the algorithm of them changes that have
occurred over the last few years and you
can see here the last major one was done
in August of 2018 that was the medic
core update so they're constantly making
changes to their search engine to
deliver a more concise more better
ecosystem for the end user so if it's a
better search engine for the end user
end users are going to come back so the
whole idea is continuing to tweak the
system that the algorithms to better
show more accurate results and so let's
take a look at some of the the major
algorithm changes that they've done in
the past so the first is we'll talk
about Google Panda and Panda was an
algorithm released back in 2011. so here
we are in 2019 is a few years ago but
still significant in that really this
algorithm emphasized high quality
content because before Panda there was a
there's just a lot of content out there
on the internet and there was a lot of
spam content there are a lot of
duplicate content and so really the idea
behind panda is for Google to really
deliver in their search engine results
Pages high quality content so what it
did was it removed web pages that had
low quality or duplicate content so that
was the whole idea behind you know the
algorithm nickname Panda it removed low
quality and duplicate content and that
kind of cleaned things up a bit where if
you did a search query now you'd
actually see better better results and
one thing about panda is because there's
so much quality because Google's
indexing so much there on the internet
that it's constantly being updated it's
updated regularly so the next one we're
going to talk about is Google penguin so
penguin was released after Panda and
with that focused in on was low quality
links so remember we talked about link
building we talk about quality links
over quantity so naturally you're going
to have links naturally from all
websites whether that be high quality or
low quality the whole idea behind this
algorithm is to sever the links that are
low quality and so the idea behind that
was they focused on two areas so they
focused in on Links games and keyword
stuffing so that's what penguin focused
on was link schemes were basically link
almost link farming where you produced
Mass amounts of backlinks and not all of
them were good quality they weren't
natural links links should be natural
from one high quality site or blog to
another high quality cider blog and by
creating lengths games you've created an
ecosystem where links just went to
irrelevant low quality spam related
pages and so Google's Penguins algorithm
update focused in on that effort to
remove or combat pages that had poor
links from being indexed in their search
engine results and then they also
combated keyword stuffing keyword
stuffing is nothing more than taking
your targeted keyword and stuffing it
into the content of your page or title
tag your meta description so any sites
that were caught up doing that basically
suffer the consequences because what
penguin did was take care of sites that
basically were accused of keyword
stuffing or had characteristics of
keyword stuffing and they removed sites
that had a lot of links pointing to it
from poor quality sites and vice versa
sites that really had a lot of external
links pointing to other poor quality
sites so that's what penguin did they
took a look at those two areas and so we
talk about link schemes again penguin's
aim was to decrease the ranking of web
pages that created artificially by using
black hat techniques and basically what
I mean by black hat techniques that
artificially creating length that just
didn't make sense just for the sake of
getting the backlink just for the sake
of passing link juice and so that's what
a link scheme is or was and so Google
basically tweaked their algorithm to
combat those poor link schemes and so
keyword stuffing as I mentioned a minute
ago it's just repetitive usage of the
same keyword and that just basically
suffers the content is the thing that
suffers here and when the content
suffers the end users suffer so Google
is all about quality content and when
you have quality content and that
quality contents indexed and users find
what they're looking for chances are
they're going to go back to the search
engine to continue to find what they're
looking for with the end result being
presented with quality content so
keyword stuffing really dilutes the
quality of the content and then let's
talk about the third algorithm which is
rank brain so rank brain is a processing
algorithm that uses is machine learning
and what that does that machine learning
interprets search queries that users
search on Google so for example if
rankbrain sees a word or phrase it isn't
familiar with basically the machine can
make a guess as to what words or phrases
might have a similar meaning and filter
the result accordingly so basically take
these search engine queries and present
them in a way that's logical so that the
end result can be something that's
relevant to what you're looking for and
so for example if you're searching for
online marketing you will get results
related for digital marketing on search
engine real Pages why because rankbrain
will interpret that particular keyword
and they're trying to basically match
based on all the data they collected
what words or phrases might have a
similar meaning so online marketing
digital marketing have similar meanings
have you ever wondered what will happen
if the pages of your website are not
visible in the search engines
definitely this can be the most scary
thought you ever had
but due to lack of technical knowledge
this is happening in the real world with
the newbies in the SEO industry
well for these beginners this video is
the opportunity and the solution to your
problems
to get your Pages search and appear in
Google search results
it is important that these pages
are indexed in Google
and to get the web pages indexed Google
search console
or search console is the One-Stop
solution
Google search console formerly known as
Google webmaster tool is a web service
provided by Google Developers
Google search console is mainly
responsible for optimizing a website for
its visibility
indexing website detecting crawl errors
Etc
after understanding what is Google
search console
now we need to focus on why search
console is an important part of search
engine optimization
a website's technicalities are directly
or indirectly related to search control
consider you have created a website for
your business
but from past few weeks your website is
not visible in search result Pages here
search console comes into action
there is a possibility that searched
engine crawlers are not able to crawl
your website thus it is not visible in
the search result pages
to make crawlers crawl your website you
will need to optimize your website using
search console
some other technical aspects of search
console includes
fixing indexing problems
sending the updated content or Pages for
indexing
generating search traffic reports
generating alerts
if there are any issues related to
indexing or any other issue gets the
list of sites linking to your website
keep the track of mobile usability
amp pages
and more
so now it is the right time to
understand how search console works
but before we begin this topic
have a look at the range of courses of
digital marketing and search engine
optimization from skill up by simply
learn you can get the link in the
description box below so now I have a
question for you
what will you do at first
if your web page fails to appear in
search result pages
well let me know your thoughts in the
comment section below stay tuned with
this video Even though if you don't have
the answer right now by the end of this
video you will surely able to answer
this question so let's get started by
knowing how search console works
to understand the working of search
console it is necessary to have a
detailed knowledge about how search
engine works search engines mainly Works
in three steps crawling indexing and
ranking let's have a look at each step
one by one
so first let's start with crawling
search engines are hungry for content
and so they send Web spiders or web
crawlers also known as robots or search
engine Bots to discover new content or
any updated content
content can be an image a web page a
video or anything else present on the
web this process is known as crawling
now let's know about indexing
as soon as the crawler discovered the
updated content or new content
these web crawlers start storing the
URLs of the content into the search
index or web Index this process is known
as indexing once the content is indexed
it starts appearing in the search result
pages
when a user enters a search query the
most relevant results are taken from the
index
and displayed in the form of most
relevant to least relevant in the search
result Pages this process is known as
ranking now that we have gained
knowledge about how search engine works
here I have a question for you
choose the correct option with respect
to working of search engines
you need to choose the option for all
the steps of how search engines work
option A indexing crawling ranking
option b ranking indexing crawling
option C crawling indexing ranking and
option D crawling ranking and indexing
let us know your answer in the comment
section below
now let's get started by learning how
search console actually works
search console is a primary source of
information that helps search engine
Bots to crawl index and rank the pages
of your website
thereby allowing the website owners to
monitor the health of your website
all you need to do is integrate search
console with your website and get the
ownership
allow the search engine Bots to crawl
your website and index the pages also
don't forget to submit your website
sitemap to search engines submitting
sitemaps helps the crawler to discover
more pages of your website
thereby understanding your site's
architecture
we will know how it is done in the
upcoming part of the video
also you need to keep an eye on the
errors suggested by search console and
solve them else it may harm the ranking
of your website
now let me remind you that all the
reports that are generated in search
console are based on the activity of the
web Crawlers on your website now let's
understand various parameters and
terminologies from search console to get
a complete understanding of this
webmaster tool
so without any further delay let's start
understanding the basic terminologies of
Google search console and how they work
and improve your website's Health
the first one we have is performance
reports
Google search console provides two types
of performance report search reports and
discover reports
let's first understand about search
reports
search reports help to analyze the
search performance of your website
search performance reports include
metrics and dimensions
so let's first focus on metrics
here there are four types of metrics as
you can see in this image the metrics
include the total clicks or I must say
clicks Impressions average CTR and
average position
Impressions provides the data on how
many times your websites appears in the
search results
as you can see here the graph shows the
number of times this website has
appeared in the search results
the next metric we have is clicks
clicks provide the data on the total
number of times users clicked from the
search results and reached your website
the graph below shows the number of
times the users have clicked from search
results and they have arrived on any
page of my website so suppose if here is
a number 200 so we can definitely get an
idea
for very number of dates number of dates
provided on the x-axis which shows that
how many times the user has clicked and
arrived on the website and the number
various varies from between like 200 200
uh 250 300 and in between 250 to 300.
and the next metric we have is average
CTR average CTR or click-through rate is
the percentage of Impressions that
results in clicks
in the same manner the graph below shows
or the average CTR for various different
dates
the next metric we have is average
position the average position represents
the data about the average position of
the sites in the search results
it is possible that your website is
ranking today at number one position so
it may rank tomorrow at 3 some other day
at 4 some other day at 9 or 10 and again
it may rank to the one so this data
actually provides the detail about the
average position which your website
frequently ranks at so that is if it is
ranking at one two and three in between
one two and three positions so the
average position may be two
now understanding about the dimensions
dimensions are the data attribute that
defines who did something on your site
or from where
here is the list of dimensions on which
the dimension performance reports are
generated that is
countries Pages queries devices search
appearance and dates
the dimension country suggests the
country from which the search came as
you can see here from the left column
you can get the list of number of
countries from the right side you can
get the idea about the clicks impression
ctrn position that is all the metrics
related to that query uh from which the
search came from or from that location
or whatever the activity has happened
from that location next we have is the
dimensions Pages Pages show the pages
clicked by user or a page that is viewed
on a search so this this actually you
get the reports from the search consoled
in the form of the links where you get
the link which is the exact page that is
viewed on the search
if there exists duplicate pages on the
site then only one canonical page or
canonical link will be displayed by the
search engines out of the number of
duplicate pages so basically canonical
links are those links uh like if there
are suppose there is a one original page
and there are two three duplicate page
of the same page so what happens uh the
original page gains the canonical link
and uh this page has more value than the
duplicate pages
so whenever the search engine will crawl
your website or the duplicate pages may
be ignored and all its uh link juice or
link Equity or anything will be
completely taken for the original page
moving ahead to queries
queries provide the query string that
users search on the Google search
console
so Suppose there is a website it says
suppose uh let's talk about the simply
learn website so suppose a user may add
as Java course and simply learn websites
appears at second or third position so
this query so suppose user clicks on the
website and reaches the website this
query Java course on simply learn or
Java course will add in the search
console showing that the user has
reached to your website using this query
Java course and again all the list of
the queries appears towards the left and
all the matrixes for that query like
clicks impression CTR and its average
position is appeared towards the right
in the search console now talking about
the search appearance search appearance
helps in grouping the data as per the
search result type or by the feature so
you can get here the number of search
appearance and again the same metrics as
with respect back to the search
appearance criteria next let's move
towards the dates
groups of data as per the dates
according to the public time zones now
let's have a look over the Discover
performance report
now here you must be thinking about how
the search is different from discover
yes search and discover follow different
approaches users enter a query to find a
required information with search
whereas discover shows the content based
on what result will be best match for
your query as per the Google's automated
system
now coming to the Discover performance
report as per Google's guidelines
discover performance reports are visible
only if your website has a minimum
threshold of impressions in discover
now moving to another important
parameter of search console which is URL
inspection
URL inspection is an interesting tool in
the search console this tool allows you
to inspect whether the URL is indexable
or not
some main functions of this tool
includes
checking the current status of the URL
inspecting live URLs requesting indexing
for a URL
viewing Pages rendered version viewing
crawl Pages viewing tested Pages
Etc
in order to check the index status of
URL open the URL inspection tool
and add the complete URL for which we
need to know its indexing status
now to understand the results check the
present status if it shows that URL is
on Google as you can see in the screen
this means that URL qualifies Google's
criteria and is eligible to appear in
search results
if it shows URL is not on Google then
the URL does not qualify the Google's
criteria and is not eligible to appear
in search results
you can check more details like URL
Discovery crawl and indexing information
from the page availability tab
click on the crawl page to see the
information about the HTTP request and
response if you find that the link is
disabled just hover over the page to
check the reason
now coming to the live URL test
it is helpful to test the live URL and
check if it is capable of being indexed
it proves helpful when you update your
page and want to compare it with its
latest indexed version just to bring it
to your notice
a life test will only confirm whether
the Google crawler can access your page
for indexing but it doesn't assure that
your page will be included in the Google
index altogether with the help of index
coverage report one can find the list of
URLs which includes the URLs Google has
found on your website the URLs that have
been indexed and identify if any
indexing problem have occurred next we
move ahead to understand about the site
Maps
the site map is the file that contains
all the information of pages on your
website
this helps search engine crawlers to
crawl your website and understand your
website structure
and helps them to index the pages more
efficiently
more the crawler indexes your pages
higher the chances for the pages of your
website to appear in the search results
with the help of site maps you can
provide information about various
contents like Pages videos images
Etc as you can understand a sitemap
plays an important role in indexing
process
you must be curious to know how we can
create and submit a site map to search
engines
before we understand this process make
sure that all pages of your website are
linked in an appropriate manner with
each other thereby maintaining a healthy
site structure a site map can be created
in XML format RSS format or in text
format
it can be Auto generated or created
manually as well most commonly used
sitemap is XML
following is an example of an XML site
map
this is the simplest version of the
sitemap that we are representing here
you can submit a site map to the sitemap
reports in the search console
however site Maps can also be submitted
through robots.txt file let's understand
about
robots.txt file
so let's understand the robots.txt file
in short
robots.txt file notifies the web
Crawlers
about the URLs that they can access on
the website as there are lots of search
engines there exists different web
crawlers thus there is a possibility
that some web crawlers may not obey the
instructions from the robots.txt file it
is necessary to know how to use the
proper syntax as different crawlers
understand syntax differently
thus there are chances that some web
crawlers might fail to understand the
instructions from the robots.txt file
a page can be indexed even if it is
disallowed from the robots.txt file if
it is linked to other site
next let's know what enhancement reports
are
all the rich results status reports are
displayed under the enhancement tab
so let's know more about rich results
these type of results are known as Rich
results in serps so basically Rich
results can be any search results other
than the traditional Blue Links for
example image results carousels
Etc
you can check whether the pages from
your website support Rich results or not
using the rich result test tool provided
by Google Developers
now understanding the rich results
status report the enhancement tab
contains separate reports for Rich
result type
some rich result report types are listed
below that are breadcrumbs
education q a event FAQ fact check
guided recipe how to image license
job posting
learning video
review Snippets
Etc
Rich results status reports consist of
summary page and Details page
the summary page mainly consists of
Errors useful items found on your
website warnings
Etc The Details page consists of the
information about the issues when it was
detected item type when was the page
last crawled
Etc before we understand how to fix
error in search console it is important
to understand the status of each page as
reported by search console
each page has any of the following
status error warning excluded and valid
if the status of the page is valid it
means the page has successfully indexed
the status of the page appears to be
excluded
if one purposefully wants the page not
to be indexed
or a page is blocked by robots.txt file
for example setting the meta tag to no
index warnings majorly appears when the
page of your website is indexed but
there are some issues with the page
which needs your attention and have to
be resolved as soon as possible
if the page status is error then there
is a need to pay a detailed attention
over the issues in the page as these
issues prevent the page from getting
indexed
let's discuss about the errors in detail
and how we can fix them
some popular errors from the search
console are listed below
that is the redirect error server error
submitted URLs blocked by robots.txt URL
marked as no index submitted URL is a
soft pore not for not poor or page not
found error
so let's first know about the redirect
error some redirect error
that search console shows up are the
redirect chain that was too long
redirect true
redirect URL that exits maximum URL
length and bat or empty URL in the
redirect chain so all these error means
that the redirections are not working
properly and so there is a need to fix
them so suppose for example you have
added too many redirects from one page
to another
so in this scenario
search engine Bots find it a waste of
time to crawl again and again to the
same redirections and at that time the
search engine crawlers or search engine
boards ignore those URLs or redirections
so in such cases you need to fix those
redirection to a single URL
the next we have is server error
the server returns 5xx error when it
fails to fulfill a valid request this
error mainly conveys that something is
wrong with your website server all you
need to do is reach out to your hosting
services and inform them about the issue
and make sure it gets resolved as soon
as possible
the next one we have is submitted URL
blocked by robots.txt to resolve this
issue you need to remove the line of
code from the robot.txt file that
restricts Google from crawling the
respective page the next we have is URL
marked as no index
when a URL is marked as no index it
sends the signal to crawlers that this
page is not meant to be crawled or this
page is not meant to be indexed if you
want this page to be indexed check the
metadata and remove the no index
attribute
to allow the Crawlers to crawl the URL
now let's understand about the error
submitted URL is a soft 404 and 404 or
page not found error whenever a web page
load server returns a 200 signal showing
the success status code soft4 Note 4 is
a condition in which server returns 200
success status code and the page not
exist error simultaneously
this is considered to be a bad user
experience
this error can be solved simply by
redirecting this page to any relevant
URL
or the home page of the website
talking about 404 or page not bound
error this error mainly occurs
when you delete the page from your
website but the URL of the page still
exists in the site map
this error can be solved by simply
removing the URL or removing the four
not four URL from the site map or
redirecting the URL to a new page
this will help to avoid the further
errors in near future
we will have a detailed look at other
4xx errors in the upcoming videos
now that we are aware of the basics of
search console let's dive deeper to know
some stats regarding the search console
in the SEO industry
when you're thinking of adding a
business online your website should
fulfill all the technical SEO needs
which can be achieved by Google search
console thus there is a huge demand in
SEO industry for the candidates having
strong knowledge of Google search
console the average salary of an SEO
expert
with the Google search console skills in
US is 53 000 dollars
to seventy eight thousand dollars per
annum and that in India is 2 lakh 76 000
per annum
some biggies in the SEO industry looking
for this skill sets include Accenture
Amazon people group
Eton Etc
so let me know your dream company to
work as an SEO expert in the comment
section below
the search engines have put massive
resources into developing the visibility
of local and Regional businesses in the
search results
in addition the massive increase and
prevalence of smartphones over the past
few years have made location-based
searches and expected everyday
occurrence people expect to find results
based on where they are immediately
here's the basic idea behind local
now for a long time in the past search
engines wanted to be able to provide
results based on where you were in the
world in a very precise way
they were able to use this somewhat by
using the IP address and they could
approximate where you were but it wasn't
always that accurate what they really
wanted to know is where you exactly were
within feet or meters
now this technology has evolved
considerably and in a very short amount
of time using location technology like
GPS and Wi-Fi
in addition the prevalence of searching
on smartphones accounts for more than 60
percent of searches every day these
factors now enable search engines to
know your location and provide
incredibly accurate and thorough options
for your search
so what's at the core of this well it's
the acronym nap it stands for name
address and phone number
this is the most critical factor for any
business not just in local SEO but for
local it is critically important
all you need to do is on your website
specify one name for your business one
address and one phone number
and then when you put that into
different directories like Yelp or
Yellow Pages or whatever you may be
using
you need to make sure that you have
exactly letter four letter the same name
and the same address and the same phone
number unfortunately this gets
convoluted
because the search engine spiders index
and classify information
business information can be classified
separately all because of the slightest
variation in business name or address
making it look like a separate business
now a human would easily be able to
identify the difference and classify the
variations as a single business
search engines can't do that yet start
on your own website specify one name for
your business one address format and one
phone number and then use that same
identical name and format when you set
up your accounts at different websites
and directories like Yelp or yellow
pages
you need to make sure you have exactly
letter for letter the same name the same
address and the same phone number
unfortunately this can be difficult
there are a lot of different formats for
phone numbers certainly for addresses
and even for names
any inconsistency will cause problems
again a human might be able to figure
this out easily but using the examples a
search engine would consider this two
separate businesses at the same address
or because the address format is
different it may even be considered two
different businesses at two different
addresses do you see how that works
so search engines do not usually know
that they're the same business and this
causes all kinds of problems
so let's pretend that your address is
one two three Happy Street Suite 3.
there's a lot of different ways you
could write this you could spell out
sweet you could use just the
abbreviation for it and there's actually
two abbreviations for sweet
you could also use unit instead of sweet
but Suite numbers and abbreviations are
where people lose their consistency
even with Road Street Parkway or Avenue
you need to pick just one version spell
It And format it exactly the same and
use it consistently then find all the
instances of different variations you
have online and go fix them
the last part of this is directories
so directories for a while now has been
a bit of a bad word
it used to be a great way of doing SEO
until it got abused
in fact it got abused and overused and
abuse was that people would charge a lot
of money so that you could be listed in
a directory and now in modern days
directories are not like they used to be
and they're not that useful
getting links that way and doing link
building through directories is not
going to be greatly helpful however the
big exception to this is with local SEO
there are important iyps internet Yellow
Pages there are also things like Yelp or
Urban Spoon where people go and submit
their local businesses
real human beings pick up their phone
and they go to the Yelp app and look for
businesses and because real human beings
are using these unlike the directories
of the past this means that you want to
have your business there
so in some ways directories at least in
the local space have returned a great
example of this are local or even
National Business associations
Chambers of Commerce business
associations industry associations and
other directories can be good places now
after all that let's move on to some
other local signals
so the first most important signal is
This Acronym again an AP name address
and phone number the key here is that
consistency
the next thing is keywords and titles
this is extremely convenient because
it's something you should be doing for
SEO anyway
this is particular for title tags which
is something we've covered in the other
videos
the next one is domain Authority so if
you have an important domain an
important business Google is going to
use this as a signal when they're doing
a traditional local search
so when someone's on their mobile and
they're looking for a good restaurant if
you are an important restaurant in the
city you're going to be more popular in
both local search and traditional search
that's domain Authority the next one is
inbound link signals this again might
sound familiar the things that help you
for traditional SEO do the same for
local the first one is Anchor text
so this is one of the most important
if you're a great restaurant hopefully
you're going to have lots of bloggers
lots of magazines and local online
entities that are writing about you and
linking to you
they're naturally going to use your name
and the name of your business in the
review about you
these are the kinds of things that
Google is looking for because these are
what is effective online
the last one is reviews and citations
but in this context these have very
specific definitions
it's not just reviews in general like
the ones I've talked about it's reviews
on specific local directories or
business listings
and it's both the quality of them are
you getting five stars and the quantity
of them do you have a hundred reviews do
100 people care enough about your
business to review you now the next one
is a bit more complex as it does require
some programming on your website this is
called schema microdata or structured
data schema is an agreed upon
programming standard by search engines
browsers and device manufacturers that
directs the markup and display of
specific content
it's typically content that is
repetitive by nature and therefore if
it's displayed in a consistent manner
for all devices browsers and operating
systems to know the content then they
can display it properly you'll find it
in addresses contact cards dates
e-commerce products reviews people
places creative works and more
what we're most concerned with here is
the address and phone number by using
schema when you add your address or
phone number to your website it enables
the visitor to use the click to call
function on their phone when there's a
phone number on the website in addition
using the address schema can open up a
map when someone clicks on it to show
the location utilizing this schema
provides clear data to the search engine
that can be republished across a variety
of channels now specifically for
Google's business listings they give a
very wide range of content for
businesses to list so fill out as many
areas of the business listing as you can
business hours payment types accepted
phone numbers descriptions reviews from
Google and maybe even from your own
website you can link your social
profiles and any events or promotions
you have one of the biggest signals that
we've seen grow in importance are the
amount of pictures that you load into
your business listings in fact Google
provides a report as to how many times
the photos are viewed by Searchers many
times businesses that have many photos
will show up with more prominence than
those that have little or no photos so
take advantage of the listing
opportunities that Google provides
finally the same behavioral signals that
are used in search are also used in the
local search results and this is because
the search engines especially Google can
see how Searchers interact with your
local listing because it is in their
system the behavioral signals start with
how many people search for your business
this is directly related to your local
visibility and loyalty so don't forget
about your local offline marketing next
they measure how long someone views your
listing they count how many times the
phone number is clicked for someone to
call or when someone clicks to find
directions in addition there's a button
there for directions to be sent to a
searcher's phone if they're using a PC
or laptop all of these engagement
factors and buttons on a business
listing are counted as engagement and
task completion which increases the
behavioral signals for your business
as people save the listing check in or
even visit these all send important
behavioral signals of popularity and
loyalty which contributes to your
business's visibility and local search
before I tell you how to bring traffic
to your website let me tell you why this
is so important okay why do we want to
bring users to our website I mean it has
to be on equal ground as web development
and design is somebody who goes to your
site and then does something when they
get to your site so you have users and
when those users get to your site
they're generating page views and
traffic and you want to turn that
traffic into engagement okay so each
Page's traffic is configured
independently of all their pages so when
you go when somebody goes to your
website they look at a page that's a
page view and certain pages on your
website you want to turn that page view
into a conversion okay whether that be
you know looking at a video or
purchasing something so think of these
pages on your website as salespeople
they're trying to convert visitors who
come to your website but first we need
to get the visitors to your website so
when you give visitors to your website
again you can generate rate sales which
means revenue or you can increase brand
awareness or you can earn Revenue
through sponsored post and
advertisements so if you have for
example a lot of content on your website
you can turn that in to revenue by
hosting ads on your website so when
somebody clicks on that ad you're going
to earn a percentage of that click okay
what that click is worth so having a
website means a lot of good things for
you but first you got to get the traffic
there and so what we're going to do is
we're going to tell you how to drive
traffic to your website so there's lots
of different ways in which you can bring
traffic to your website well the first
is paid advertising so paying to
advertise your products services with
ads is one of the easiest ways to drive
traffic to your website so some of the
options available are search ads social
media ads or display ads so search ads
or ads that are displayed in the search
engine and results so when a user types
in a keyword query you want your ad to
show up based on that keyword query okay
so an example is digital marketing
course somebody types in digital
marketing course and simply learn is the
first app that shows up how do we know
it's an ad because you can see the word
add next to the domain so when somebody
clicks on that link simply learn is
going to pay Google so that's how search
advertising works okay the next is
social it's a social media marketing
involves increasing traffic or
engagement or brand awareness lots of
different strategies but you're instead
of doing this on search you're doing it
on a social media platform okay so for
example you can advertise on any
particular platform and the way you
advertise could be with an image it
could be with a video so in this case
you could see cobrio is doing a
sponsored ad here how to succeed with
Google flats and then another form of
advertising is display so display means
creating ads that are placed on specific
websites so with display unlike search
you have a choice in the ad format with
search you only have text ads but with
display you have text Edge image ads
rich media ads video ads so you have
lots of different options in which you
can advertise on other websites so the
idea here is to get your ad in front of
the Right audience when they could see
your display Banner your banner ad then
it's going to be more visual more
appealing generate some brand interest
and hopefully you can get somebody to
click on that ad and over to your
website so that's paid advertising again
through search through social through
display but you can also promote your
site on social media so once your
content is gone live you could take
advantage of different social media
platforms I mean it really depends on
what you're you're trying to promote
because what you're trying to promote
needs to align with the appropriate
social media platform so Facebook is
best suited for Industries like food and
Beverages and news and media and if
you're selling a product so you fall
into one of those categories and
Facebook could be the right platform for
you if you're involved in again beauty
or food and beverage or e-commerce then
you can also leverage Instagram which is
part of Facebook's ecosystem so if you
advertise on Facebook you can also
advertise on Instagram and or Instagram
so it doesn't have to be and Facebook
and Instagram it could be Facebook or
Instagram you also have LinkedIn as a
platform LinkedIn is great for B2B so if
you're trying to promote industry news
or or tips and best practices or job
postings then LinkedIn is the place for
you it's a B2B platform it's great for
targeting specific Industries targeting
specific job levels or job descriptions
okay so LinkedIn is great if you're into
B2B focusing on the business side of it
so you also have YouTube now YouTube is
part of Google's ecosystem YouTube is a
video platform okay so it's great if
you're trying to promote gaming or
entertainment or if you're a vlogger
okay so YouTube's a great way to promote
your site by getting your product out
there in the form of a video and then
you have Twitter Twitter to me
encompasses a lot of different
Industries Beauty and fitness news and
media entertainment okay you have
limited number of characters but a lot
of people are active on Twitter and it's
a great way to generate some awareness
and get some clicks over to your website
so these are just some of the most
popular social media platforms of course
there are plenty more out there the
third way in which you can drive traffic
to your site is guest plus blogging so
most of you already know what blogging's
all about well if you're blogging for
your own site you can jump on somebody
else's site and blog on their behalf so
having the opportunity to guess post on
another website can be very helpful
because one that other blog could have
lots of traffic and have a a well-known
brand so if you're blogging on another
blog it's going to build your brand
awareness and potentially increase
traffic to your blog or website so it
exposes to you to targeted traffic so if
you're going to guest blog guest blog on
a site that's very relevant to your
business or industry that way you're
targeting the Right audience okay you
can expand your personal Network so
getting yourself out there getting your
brand out there in front of a different
audience and then obviously for service
because it generates backlinks or serps
search engine ranking Pages means that
hey if you want to rank organically
you're going to have to generate some
backlinks so guest blogging isn't a way
to generate some back links to your site
and in effect that's going to help you
get your pages ranked higher because
Google is going to recognize the
relationship from one blog to your blog
and build up your relevancy so some
other benefits here to guest blogging is
you can grow your social media following
because you can then promote that on
social media that you're guest blogging
okay again you can improve your online
Authority okay because when you're guest
blogging and you have recognition on
that Guest block if it's a popular blog
then it's going to help your domain and
Page Authority for SEO and then the end
result is going to improve your backlink
score so the lot of benefits to guest
blogging to me at the end of the day
it's just about reaching out to your
audience using another platform to do
that in the form of a Blog and the
results of that is going to mean more
brand awareness for you and turning that
traffic from that other blog into
qualified leads so you can also in
interview industry thought leader so
that's another way an interesting way to
generate traffic to your site so
reaching out to thought leaders for
interviews okay could generate some
credibility for you and the other person
so it's reciprocal so it means that
you're active in the industry that
you're in and it allows you to engage
with other leaders in the industry and
the indirect net result of that could be
increased traffic because if you do the
interview and you record it or if it's
via video then you can obviously post it
on other platforms and that could in
turn Drive traffic to your website
obviously just like guest blogging it's
going to increase your reach so getting
yourself out there nobody knows who your
brand is and they know who the thought
leaders are and they say you're
interviewing the thought leaders then
that's going to put you in front of
these people and so it's going to
increase your reach another way to drive
traffic to your website is just to make
sure your website's response and what do
we mean by responsive well we mean does
it work on multiple devices specifically
MOBA so depending on the device your
website hides shows shrinks and larges
or moves content so that it conforms to
the browser that that person's looking
at on your web for your website so if
somebody's looking on mobile at your
website you want to make sure that your
website adjusts accordingly so you want
to be able to you know test to make sure
it's responsive and so as content range
based on importance okay does it work
across different browsers on different
devices and do the images text and
everything else align just like it does
on desktop so there are plenty of tools
out there on the web all you need to do
is just do a search for you know check
my website for responsiveness you know
so you you can use plenty of tools to
check to see if your website is
responsive towards multiple devices why
is that important because as some
somebody goes to your website Via Mobile
and your site doesn't align properly or
the content's all stretched out and
somebody has to maneuver their browser
just to see your website then chances
are they're not going to come back
chances are they're not going to convert
okay so you want to be able to revise
your device browser combinations you
want to make sure that everything works
accordingly you want to be able to test
those fonts make sure they look good and
then you also want to make sure that
people can navigate so if they're on
mobile are they going to navigate just
as easy as they can on desktop and if
you have any pop-ups you want to
probably make sure they're removed so
that way when somebody's looking at your
website they're not getting interfered
with on mobile and then of course you
want to make sure that these Pages load
okay so they load just as quick on
desktop as they should on mobile and
vice versa so this should not take a
long time to load so I'm moving on from
responsiveness on mobile to building a
brand community so brand community
refers to a group of people who identify
your brand and use your brand as a
platform to exchange ideas and
contribute content some advantages of
having a brand Community are promoting
brand evangelism and loyalty it can be a
source of feedback loyalty and ideas so
build a community build a brand
Community who you know identify with you
okay so continue to you know treat these
people as loyal customers okay maybe
give them a promotion uh to use
specifically just for them that they can
use on your website or talk directly to
them because you know that they're
followers they're repeat customers they
purchase for you multiple times so talk
to them differently as well you know who
these people are and that's what
building a brand is all about it's about
identifying your brand with other people
okay in an identify people who identify
with your brand and messaging and
talking to them as if they're part of
your own Community your own family so
you can use user generated content that
provides future marketing strategies so
the feedback you get from your own
Community could be in turn used to
promote or used in future marketing
strategies I.E advertising I.E post on
social okay it can also provide PR
opportunities so it's a chance for you
to you know put out press releases based
on the community that you built so any
brand regardless of who it is should be
able to identify with your audience
their target audience and that target
audience eventually going to become part
of a community these are group of people
who identify with you what you're trying
to sell what your cause is what your
mission statement is what your services
they identify with you so leverage them
and reciprocate identify them talk to
them separately give them the what they
deserve the respect and loyalty that
they deserve as well because they're
communicating and they're following you
as a brand so the next thing you could
do to drive traffic is Be Active in the
comments section so engage in relevant
and thought-provoking conversations on
other blogs and sites it doesn't
necessarily have to be another blog per
se it could be other sites like Reddit
or Cora or Mania sites that have a lot
of content that are broken out by
industry that allow you to engage in
conversation and allow you to either
upvote or share or respond okay so be
active because when you're active people
are going to see that hey you're a
leader in the industry you know what
you're talking about you have some some
brand Equity you have some thought and
some knowledge on the specific topic and
subjects so it just puts you in a better
light when you can respond and be active
on these different platforms okay let's
turn our attention to search engine
optimization also known as SEO or
organic search so in order to drive
traffic to your site you're going to
have to implement an SEO strategy why do
you want to implement an SEO strategy
because it can help you improve your
overall searchability and visibility on
search engines and obviously that comes
with advantages one of those advantages
is obviously more traffic to the site
search is still King in terms of volumes
of people using search on a daily basis
so you have a great opportunity to be
found it also builds trust and
credibility because still a majority of
the people who do a search click on an
organic search list in and so if you're
found organically and you're ranked
number one then chances are somebody's
going to click on your listing and it
provides increasing engagement and
traffic and so what that means is more
traffic more engagement and engagement
is something you define it could be
again a download of a document or the
clicking on the play button of a video
or or submitting a form or signing up
for a newsletter or calling these are
all forms of Engagement so the the
amount of traffic you drive from organic
search to your website is only going to
improve engagement okay so you can also
provide an improve user experience and
what do we mean by that well if you're
getting lots of traffic from organic
search you have a really good
opportunity to do a b testing and when
you do a b testing you can improve user
experience meaning you're showing one
variation against the other from people
coming from organic search and so this
is helpful in that you know if you're
running an A B test the variation has a
chance to improve or outperform the
original original and if it outperforms
the original you're improving user
experience and then it helps Target
quality traffic so SEO to me or all
search is the only medium in which
you're meeting somebody halfway you're
you're addressing what they're looking
for so somebody's looking for a pair of
red women's Nike shoes the 2019 model
and you have that particular product to
offer well you have a chance of showing
up via organic search somebody types in
you know women's red Nike shoes size
whatever at the year 2019 model then of
course they're gonna probably likely
click on your listing because you have
what they're looking for and and that
goes with any keyword any industry any
business any segment any type of product
you're selling so again you have a
chance to really be visible for what
people are looking for and so that's the
beauty of search engine optimization you
have a really good opportunity here to
meet people halfway to drive quality
traffic to get them to enjoy a good user
experience all the while generating
engagement and along with SEO we want to
be able to build backlinks so SEO is a
two-pronged approach meaning you have
two strategies in one on page and off
page and so off page involves
backlinking so backlinks are just links
that direct users from other websites to
your own website so with that inherently
it's going to drive traffic qualify
traffic to your website because if
somebody's on a relevant website that's
linking to yours and they click on that
link and go to your website it's likely
going to be qualified meaning they're
going to be relevant and so back linking
because it's an off-page strategy why
isn't an off-page SEO strategy because
if Google crawls that other site that
has a link to you then that's going to
give you credit because Google say hey
this site's getting some links from some
relevant sites we must think they're
relevant and therefore we're going to
trust the site so by Google trusting
your site it's going to improve your
organic ranking and with the organic
rankings being approved meaning it's
going to mean faster indexing so what
does that mean so you want to be indexed
by the search engines and so the quicker
Google can find your pages even if it's
on somebody else's site then that means
they're going to follow that link go to
that page on your site and take that
page back to their servers to be indexed
okay so the quicker you can get index
the quicker you can get found and then
it helps with referral traffic so again
we noticed that our efforts are on SEO
organic search but if you're getting
traffic from another website hey that
still counts that's referral traffic
okay so that's a side advantage to
having backlinks is good traffic from
other sites okay so those those are
inherently the some of the reasons to to
do backlinking okay never hurts I mean
there's brand awareness reasons to being
on other sites as well there's industry
leadership meaning if you you post
content on Reddit okay you're coming
across as an industry leader but yet
generating a backlink which helps with
SEO and referral traffic so there's a
lot of benefits to building backlinks
and the opposite of backlinks are
internal links so you want to do
internal linking and that just means
connecting one page on your site to
another and why is that beneficial
because it can help direct visitors to
other Pages they wouldn't normally
otherwise find via your navigation so if
you're active on a Blog don't be afraid
to include multiple internal links you
want to move people through your site
you want the flow of traffic to go from
one page to another to another and so
when you do internal linking just like
with backlinks it's going to improve the
indexing of your website Google's going
to follow those links and index those
pages and Google does give credit from
an SEO perspective from an internal
linking perspective so if one page is
linked to another and that page has
really good relevance in the eyes of
Google then the other page is probably
going to benefit from that the other
reason we want to do internal linking
again you want to move people from your
one page of your site to the other and
when you do that it's going to reduce
bounce rates so bounce rate is simply
the rate at which people land on a page
and then leave so if I have a hundred
people in on my home page and only one
person went to another page and the
other 99 left the site then that's a 99
bounce rate so by putting internal links
in place you're helping people move from
one page to the other and thus reducing
the bounce rate and that's what you want
you want to keep people on your site you
want to be greedy it also drives traffic
to older posts so again when we say
older post we're really referring to
blog posts so if you have a relevant
blog post and you're writing a new blog
post then link the two together if it's
relevant link it I don't you know
regardless of how old it is you know you
want to show Google that these older
blog posts just because they were
written a year ago doesn't mean they're
outdated and old-fashioned okay or
useless you want to keep them alive by
linking to them so to me that's a good
strategy for internal linking link to
older blog posts you know show people
you're an industry expert you've been
doing this for a while and then you have
lots of content to share okay so the
longer you can keep somebody on your
website the more likely it is they're
going to engage and convert and some
other inherent benefits improves
pagerank so what we mean by Page rank is
simply just a rank that Google gives
pages so the more internal linking you
have the better off you are and then it
helps spread link juice across websites
and what I mean by link juice again just
like backlinking it builds relevancy so
just keep all these inherent benefits in
mind to internal linking the end result
is keeping the flow of traffic on your
site and all these other benefits will
fall into place okay so another way in
which you can really hone in on traffic
to your website is long tail keywords
and long tail keywords to me are more
than just one or two keyword phrases
okay so there are usually three or
longer keywords in a phrase okay so long
tail keywords really nowadays account
for most web searches people really take
the time to even post questions as a
search query they likely somebody it's
unlikely somebody's going to go into
search and just type in the word shoes
they might type in red shoes but that's
unlikely what they're probably going to
type in is you know red Nike running
shoes 2019 or some variation of that
okay that's a long tail keyword and some
of the advantages of using long tail
keywords to be found for are less
competition so if you you're using broad
keywords like red shoes then who doesn't
want to be found for Red Shoes well you
don't necessarily you don't want to be
found for red shoes because it's too
broad you don't know what type of shoes
somebody's looking for you just know
they're looking for Red Shoes it could
be running shoes it could be work shoes
it could be you know boots it could be
slippers okay it's too bright so long
tail keywords help narrow it in and the
more narrow and focused a keyword is the
less competition is going to have and
when something's not competitive in the
form of a keyword then that means your
chances of ranking for that keyword are
going to be greater and the chance of
you ranking faster are going to be
greater and then of course if somebody's
looking for exactly what you have to
offer then you have a higher chance to
convert that person so if you have
exactly those 2019 red Nike women's
running shoes and somebody does a search
for that and that's a long tail keyword
and they click on your organic listing
if you have the right price then they're
probably going to convert so you have a
really good chance of converting
somebody using long tail keywords so my
point here is if you're looking for
keywords to use focus on longer tail
don't focus on one or two keyword
phrases what it also does is it brings
targeted traffic so even if somebody
doesn't convert hey they could be back
because it's exactly what they're
looking for and if you're focusing on
longer tail keywords like I just
mentioned stay away from the shorter
ones it's just easier to optimize your
page for SEO so remember SEO is a
two-pronged approach on page and off
page we talked about off page with
internal linking and backlinks on page
is all about making sure there's
keywords you choose are integrated in
with the page you want to be found for
and so if you're using a long tail
keyword it's just easy to work that
keyword in so it enables easier on-page
optimization okay let's switch away from
SEO to email marketing so let's focus on
email marketing as a form or method of
driving traffic to your website so email
marketing has been around a long time in
terms of digital marketing why because
it provides an effective way to convert
leads into sales why because you can
send personalized emails to a target
audience so when you send an email to
somebody on a regular basis you know who
that person is so what are you doing in
the email you're writing a specific
message to that person well email
marketing is the same thing except
you're just sending an email to a larger
group of people and when you send an
email to a larger group of people you're
still going to personalize the message
right you're not going to send a generic
email to 1 000 people okay nobody's
gonna do that so make sure your email is
targeted if it's targeted it could be
cost effective why because sending large
amounts of emails or let's just say an
email to a large amount of people or a
large group of people is going to be
cost effective it's not cost per click
you know it's not cost per open okay so
email usually depending on the the email
provider you're using really is a flat
fee so just really depends on how many
emails you're sending or how how many
people you're sending the email to as
well so but email generally tends to be
more cost effective than other forms of
marketing so look at the email content
provider you're using and just get a
sense of what they charge but if you
look at it and do a comparison email
generally is cheaper than say doing
pay-per-click because with pay-per-click
you're paying for each click okay so
that could be expensive depending on the
keywords so email marketing is also time
saving okay meaning it's a one-time
thing and done so once you send the
email it's just a matter of you know
watching and looking at the metrics and
learning what's going on so you don't
make the same mistakes again but it is
time conducive meaning you send out one
email and that's it with pay-per-click
you're constantly a measuring and
managing the campaigns and it provides
real-time marketing so when you do send
the email more than likely a majority of
the people on day one or the day you
send the email are going to be able to
view it open it click on some of the
links and convert so that's normally
what happens in email majority of the
people open it on day one and it kind of
tails off from there so think about it
as real time so when you send that email
and if you have a thousand people on
your email recipient list break it up
send the first 500 first with a
different subject line and then you can
see the data come in and if you don't
see the good results from the subject
line or the body of the email or you
know the page they're going to then make
adjustments before you send the other
email to the next 500. so that's a great
thing about emails you can break up the
email into two groups the first group
and then the second group with different
subject lines and you can probably send
them a little bit of time apart that way
you can learn learn from the first email
because with email you are generally
going to get results right away okay
within the first 24 hours so that's a
great thing about email okay so the
other thing about email it's less
intrusive so normally people who are
going to get the email are the ones who
sign up for the email so they're almost
expecting your email so when they get
your email again as long as you're not
sending an email on a daily basis
normally most companies send it monthly
or bi-weekly it's not going to be as
intrusive okay and then it also helps
build credibility increase visibility
and brand awareness meaning you're going
to build your brand in that email you're
going to put content in that email
that's going to show off your
credibility meaning you could put some
testimonials in the email you can put
some good affiliations you can put a
good article to an industry article you
just wrote so email is going to
inherently continue to build brand
awareness for you okay and it's an easy
way to track our Roi so if your
e-commerce it's pretty clear you send
the email somebody opens it clicks on it
checks out and purchases something it's
easily trackable because you could track
it right from that email so one thing I
want to say there is just if you do send
an email make sure you're tracking that
campaign and you want to be able to use
an analytics program like Google
analytics okay if you use Google
analytics you're going to be able to
track when you send the email who clicks
on it and who converts so you want to be
able to measure an Roi for these emails
and you can and that's the beauty of
email marketing okay let's move away
from email marketing to webinars so
webinars great method for Effective
social media promotion it's a great way
to bring traffic to your website so why
do we recommend webinars well because it
provides direct content contact within
your target group what I mean by contact
with your target group well you're going
to host a webinar and you're going to
invite this targeted group of people who
are interested in your product or
service so if you have a Facebook
Community you can do a Facebook live
event or you could do a YouTube or you
know you can even set up a webinar and
another platform but promote it on
social media and if you're pronouning
something on social media you're
probably promoting it to people who are
already following you or like you and so
that's what we mean by direct contact
with your target groups you're you're
going to be able to create a webinar and
talk directly to that group and that's
going to help build brand awareness and
credibility and the great thing about
webinars is you don't need some fancy
software I mean I'm talking to you on a
webinar right now and so webinars are
free all you need is a video camera and
a recorder that's all and that's all
built in with software so there's plenty
of software out there that allows you
just to do a webinar really quick and
easy there's lots of opportunities in
software so and a lot of them are very
costly effective so if you want to build
create a webinar you can do that by
spending very little money in webinars
again allow you to talk to your your
targeted group your community maybe
prospective clients it helps build
credibility and in effect Drive traffic
to your website and when somebody does
attend a webinar they're likely going to
be highly engaged because you're
inviting them they're going to opt into
the webinar and the great thing about
webinars is even if they don't attend
the webinar the day you have it it's
going to be recorded so they can always
go back and watch it so whoever watches
the webinar is going to be engaged
because it's going to be a topic they're
interested in and then users are likely
to become prospective customers so
having a webinar talking about something
inherently interesting to maybe a larger
group of people you can promote that on
social media and potentially get
prospective customers to sign up and
watch the webinar and if you do they're
going to be engaged and then take the
next step oh I like what this guy this
person has to say they seem to be
credible I like their personality I like
their brand I like their product I'm
gonna go check their web out their
website okay so webinars allow you to
kind of pull in more people as well as
just your community because you can
promote the webinar and you can promote
it in advance and you can leverage
social media for that okay so something
related to webinars incorporating video
content so videos have been proven to be
a really good way to attract new
visitors and it just it makes your
website very engaging when you have
videos on your website as well so if you
create video you have an opportunity to
post it on various video platforms like
YouTube or Vimeo okay there's plenty of
video platforms out there or just
embedded in a blog post or embed it in a
Facebook post or a tweet okay so you can
do a lot with video and having video on
your site is going to increase
engagement okay when you increase
engagement good things happen that's
going to lead to increased conversions
and sales or or Roi or just like we
mentioned the webinar can help build
trust with your audience so even that
webinar you could post on your website
so you want people to engage by watching
this video they watch the video they're
going to gain trust in you because
you're talking directly to that person
that user that audience that visitor to
your website and when you get Bell trust
it's going to increase engagement and
that's the beauty of video unlike text
or imagery videos really do engage with
the audience and so the more video you
could do the better off you are because
again you can leverage social to draw
attention to your brand and product and
service and then you can have that video
on your website to increase engagement
which in turn increases conversions and
sales and improves Roi so always they
think video there's plenty of video
software out there that you can leverage
and the great thing about video two is
hey most people are using mobile phones
these days smartphones and so video
works just as well on mobile as it does
on desktop so keep that in mind you know
video is going to be engaging regardless
of what device somebody uses and then of
course if they're watching the video on
Facebook or YouTube then it's chances
are they're going to share that
particular video which is going to bode
well for your brand and traffic okay so
video if somebody likes a video it's
very easy to share video especially from
a mobile phone so YouTube just makes it
so easy to share or like or subscribe to
a channel it just it becomes that much
easier things can go viral and chances
of them going viral with video are going
to be greater okay so other ways to
drive traffic to your website is submit
your content to content aggregators so
what's a Content aggregate Gator well
content aggregators like Reddit that
provides a great platform for you to
post your content so that's what a
Content aggregator is really a site like
Reddit or medium or quora where you
could post content to a large number of
people okay so with Reddit people are
either going to upvote it or download it
so the more upvotes you get are thumbs
up or likes or people who encourage that
content the more of a chance it has to
be found and so first thing out of the
gate if you do provide content to a
Content aggregator like Reddit make sure
it's good quality content that's
interesting and that should be a case
the case around across the board whether
it's a social post or blog post make
sure the content's unique professional
and interesting and then if you do say
put something on medium or you do put
something on quora and it is
professional and interesting and thought
provoking then people are going to react
to it and then that again could lead to
traffic but even if it does doesn't lead
to traffic it helps build brand
awareness so if you have content just
like videos leverage it put the content
out there okay and when you put content
out there it's only gonna especially if
it's good content put it's going to put
you in a good light so don't be afraid
to share your content on the likes of
Reddit or medium or core or some of
these other content aggregator websites
because good things are only going to
happen and again referral traffic SEO
brand awareness conversions so all these
are inherent benefits of just sharing
your content okay and then finally we
want to learn from analytics okay so
what do I mean learning from analytics
so there are plenty of analytics
platforms out there one of the most
popular is Google analytics so you want
to make sure you're tracking traffic on
your site with Google analytics so I
have to do is just go to Google
analytics via search sign up add the
analytics code to your website and voila
they're doing all the heavy lifting
they're going to to track traffic coming
your website and not only they're going
to track traffic but they're going to
tell you how that traffic engaged and so
the benefits of it Google analytics is
hey you could figure out where users are
coming from are they coming from that
email campaign that I sent out to a
thousand people are they coming from
YouTube based on that video I posted or
are they coming from Reddit based on the
content I just posted there or they come
in from organic search it is so Google
analytics can help us understand how
much traffic we're getting from organic
search so it'll help us measure our SEO
efforts and then with Google analytics
you could segment so we could segment by
mobile we can segment by desktop
returning user new user by campaign by
Page by Language by city by region I
mean there's so many ways in which to
segment your audience and segmenting
simply is breaking up the entire group
of people who come to your website into
different segments based on on what you
want to say so if you want to look at
you know females between the ages of 18
to 24 who come from mobile via organic
search that's a segment and you can look
at that information and analytics if
that's your target audience then you
could see how they're performing okay so
Anna there are a lot of benefits to
Google analytics definitely wants to
take advantage of segmenting in Google
analytics you could look at your
competition so there's a benchmarking
report the great thing about Google
analytics you can also look at content
and how your content is performing once
somebody lands on your website are they
what page are they spending time on what
page are they engaging on the most okay
what pages have the highest bounce rate
or the lowest time on page so you can
really determine what pages work best
and then of course the end result in
analyzing all this data is you want to
be able to fine-tune your website so
take advantage of the data that Google
analytics or or any other analytics
platform has given you by learning once
you learn what's going on with your
website you can make adjustments to your
website to improve user experience okay
so we went over a lot of different ways
to drive traffic okay you can
incorporate all this to your website
immediately
let's talk about that keyword research
for a website with shoes and it doesn't
really matter what particular product
you have if you need to rank number one
on Google it all starts with the
keywords as I mentioned before and so in
this example if you have a website where
you sell shoes for kids you're going to
want to be found for certain keywords so
the obvious keyword here would be shoes
for kids well every keyword that you
target has search volume associated with
it so that means when we talk about
search volume we're talking about how
many people on average type in that
keyword or related keyword on google.com
or Google search and there's always an
average number of searches associated
with every keyword and we call that
search volume how much search volume so
obviously if we're going to Target a
keyword we want to have as much volume
as possible however there's always going
to be competition for those keywords
meaning there's always going to be other
websites who want to rank number one on
Google for the same keywords and we call
that competition or difficulty so for
every keyword you're going to have
volume and you're going to have
competition or difficulty and the
difficulty ranges as well depending on
the tool you use and we'll get into that
in a minute but search volume is how
much on average people are typing in
that keyword or close variance of that
keyword and the difficulty is measured
in terms of how many other websites are
trying to rank for the same keyword and
so ideally when it comes to keyword
research we want to find that nice
balance we want high volume and we want
low competition but at the same time we
want to focus on keywords that are
highly relevant to our business so if
we're selling shoes for kids and shoes
for kids is highly relevant has high
volume in low competition then that's a
keyword we want to Target so we always
want to focus in on those three areas so
there's always a trade-off with keywords
so shoes for kids might have high volume
but also might have high competition or
difficulty if we look for another
keyword that's just as relevant for
example shoes for children it may still
have high search volume but the
competition or the difficulty may be
lower and if that's the case then that
may be a better keyword for us to Target
instead of something highly competitive
like shoes for kids we can focus on
another relevant keyword like shoes for
children with just as much volume and
lower competition and the reason why we
want lower competition is because we
want to be able to rank for that keyword
so the higher the competition the harder
it is for us to rank number one on
Google for that keyword and so the whole
idea be on keyword research is analyz
amazing and choosing the best keywords
so we want to identify a list of
keywords that are always relevant we
want to choose the keyword that your
competitors are ranking for and we want
to use third-party tools to choose
keywords to identify which keywords have
low competition and what keywords have
high search volume so one thing to take
into consideration when you're doing
keyword research is that the longer the
key word phrase or in other words long
tail keywords or keywords with three
keywords in the phrase or more you're
going to always have less competition
but there's always a trade-off with long
tail keywords meaning the longer the
keyword phrase there's going to be less
volume but the trade-off is less
competition and so what we want to do is
we want to brainstorm some ideas and
find those relevant keywords so let's
look at an example here so if we go to
Google ads so Google ads has a total
Keyword Planner and let's just say I
have a a website where I'm selling dried
figs and if I'm selling dried figs I
want people to buy these dried figs
however in order to attract them I want
to be able to show them that hey we have
a bunch of recipes and if I show you a
bunch of recipes where you can use dried
figs maybe you'll buy these dried figs
to use in these recipes and so we're
going to look for keywords related to
bread recipes because if we can optimize
for our recipes page for bread then that
will attract an audience who wants to
make bread and use dried figs with those
bread recipes so that's the example I'm
going to give here and so if I look at
the Keyword Planner and Google ads if I
just type in bread recipes what Google
is going to do is they're going to give
me an average monthly search volume so I
can see the average monthly search
volume here is 60 500. and so in order
to keep word research what I would
recommend is keep a spreadsheet and so
the idea behind the spreadsheet is to
document the volume and the competition
you're getting for certain keywords so
if I go into a spreadsheet here my theme
of keywords is bread recipes my keyword
is bread recipes and my volume therefore
is going to be sixty thousand five
hundred however if I go back into
Google's Keyword Planner Google's
telling me the competition is low so
that's great I want high volume I want
low competition but how low is low so we
want to be careful so if we're going to
put in numbers into a spreadsheet we
want to figure out what that competition
really is for the keyword bread recipes
so if I go to Google and just type in
bread recipes I'm going to be able to
see
771 billion results for the keyword
bread recipes now with 771 billion are
real competition maybe maybe not what we
want to do is put in a syntax and we
want to put in the syntax all in title
and then colon space and then our
keyword and the reason why we do that in
search is because we want to be able to
identify the true competitive number or
the true number of websites or trying to
rank for bread recipes and if we put in
the syntax all entitled colon and then
our keyword bread recipes we'll be able
to see that there are 998
000 results that's a lot lower than 771
billion so that means that 998
000 sites or listings have the keyword
bread recipes in the title tag and the
title tag is what shows up in the search
engine results and so if I look down and
scroll down here I can see bread recipes
on every one of these title tags so
title tag is an important element to
rank number one on Google and we'll talk
about that in a few minutes but if we
understand that there are 998 000
results with bread recipes in the title
tag then this tells us that those are
the websites who are trying to rank
number one on Google for that keyword
and therefore those are the websites we
need to jump over in order for our
website to rank number one on Google and
so therefore I'm going to put in 998
000 in my spreadsheet as the competitive
number and so now I could see for the
keyword bread recipes I have 60 500 and
if my competition is 998 000 then my Kei
or keyword Effectiveness index or in
other words the ratio of volume to
competition is six percent so that's
nothing more than volume divided by
competition so that tells me that my Kei
or my ratio which between volume
competition is six percent so remember
we want more volume than we want
competition so anytime you do a keyword
research you're going to find a number
of different relevant keywords so if I
go back into Google's Keyword Planner if
I typed in bread recipes you could see
that Google is going to give me a number
of different keywords related to bread
recipes let's just say I have another
keyword that I want to think about
optimizing for being ranked on Google
for and that's banana bread recipe very
similar keyword as bread recipes except
it's a little longer tail now if I type
in banana bread recipe and Google's
Keyword Planner now I can see the
average monthly search volume has
actually gone up it's 368
000. I can also see the competition is
low so those are good signs so now I can
see 368
000 I'm going to go ahead and put that
in my spreadsheet now I'm gonna go into
to Google I'm going to put in my syntax
all in title I'm going to put in banana
bread recipe I'm going to hit enter and
now I can see I have 233
000 results with the keyword banana
bread recipe in the title tag so if I
look at the title tags I can see banana
bread recipe banana bread recipe banana
bread recipe on all the listings in the
Google search results so that tells me I
have 233
000 results that I have to jump over in
order to rank number one on Google so
I'm going to put 233
000 in my spreadsheet now I can see my
Kei or my volume to competition ratio is
157 158 and so to me that's a lot better
number to work with or in other words
that's a lot better keyword because it's
just as relevant and it has a higher
ratio of volume to competition so
therefore banana bread recipe is going
to be a better keyword to optimize for
in order to rank number one on Google so
that's the whole idea behind keyword
research you want to brainstorm ideas
there are plenty of tools out there so
the tool I recommend is Google ads
Keyword Planner Google's going to give
you how much search volume they're going
to tell you the competition but then
you're going to go into Google search
you're going to use the syntax on title
to get a more accurate read on the
actual competitive number and so to find
out how keywords that your competitors
are ranking for you can use those
keyword tools that I mentioned another
tool that I use is Miles so Moz if you
go to moz.com they have a tool called
keyword Explorer so if we just type in
the keyword for example bread recipes
it's going to be able to tell us how
much volume and the difficulty so you
can use other tools at your disposal
figure out the volume and the difficulty
there are plenty of tools out there but
the one thing I would just make sure is
you use everything at your disposal so
you can use social media to find the
most shared article for a particular
topic or keyword like bread recipes you
can check other platforms that have a
lot of shared content like Reddit and
quora where you can ask people about
certain topics using keywords to figure
out how much competition or volume there
might be you could stay up to date on
industry news to get an idea of what
types of keywords are trending but when
it comes to keywords and keyword
research remember for every web page we
want to be able to pick two keywords we
want a primary and secondary keyword so
when we do keyword research and we enter
all our keywords into our spreadsheet we
want to be able to have a number of
different keywords in this case we're
focusing on the theme bread recipes we
want to have different keywords because
we want to be able to choose a primary
keyword and a secondary keyword because
we want to be able to focus on multiple
keywords for each page because we don't
want to put necessarily all our eggs in
one basket meaning we won't want to put
all our emphasis just on one keyword to
rank for we want multiple keywords to
try and rank for so the primary keyword
can Define the nature of our business
the secondary keyword could be just
highly relevant to our keyword at the
end of the day we want to choose
multiple keywords to try and rank on
Google for that page so for example we
have a Blog and we're using ice cream
recipes and we're blogging about ice
cream recipes we can have the primary
keyword that is about ice cream recipes
or homemade ice cream recipes we're
going to always want to find out what
the volume and the competition is our
sec secondary keyword could be built
around other similar keywords like
low-fat ice cream recipes or fat free
ice cream recipes or low-fat homemade
ice cream recipes those are
complementary keywords just like our
bread recipes and banana bread recipe so
one thing we want to do when we do
keyword research is we want to be able
to Target one keyword per content when
you can Target many we want to be able
to Target multiple keywords not
necessarily Target one keyword and so we
want to be able to Cluster keywords so
we don't want to Target just one we want
to Target multiple keywords per page and
when we talk about clustering if we go
back to our keyword research what we're
doing is we're clustering a bunch of
keywords under the theme bread recipes
and so by looking at the volume looking
at the competition looking at the Kei we
can choose different keywords for our
page and that's what we mean by
clustering we want to Cluster keywords
into a Content frame so why Target only
one keyword per content when we can
Target many because we don't want to put
all our eggs in one basket we don't want
to Target just one keyword we want to
Target many and so that means clustering
your keywords into a theme and choosing
multiple keywords for that particular
page and when we do that we have a
better opportunity to rank high on
Google Search and the whole idea behind
ranking high on Google Search is we can
get the volume so if we know we're
ranked number one on Google search for
bread recipes or banana bread recipe we
know we stand a chance of getting a
majority of the volume associated with
that keyword and if we can get the
volume and get the traffic then we can
get the conversions so let's move on to
high quality content and talk about the
impact content it has on your ability to
get your website ranked number one on
Google so let's just say you have
content on your website and the content
is ranking on you know page four of
Google and it's that blog with ice cream
recipes and if it's just content for the
sake of content it's not really
informative then it's not necessarily
going to get good engagement in the eyes
of Google you know they want to rank
content that's very informative it's
very fresh it's exciting to read it's
interesting it's going to have good
engagement so if it's a recipe or an
article about any topic if it's the
content is just non-informative then
you're not going to get good engagement
and when you don't get good engagement
if people don't stay on the site to
engage in the content and they just
leave the website after landing on the
page causing a bounce then the content
is just going to continue to fall down
on the rankings and we want to prevent
that we want to move up the rankings we
want to be number one on Google we don't
necessarily want to fall in the rankings
for our content so content is a key
driver and being able to rank number one
on Google so if the content is on page
nine what can we do well we want to be
able to you know take that content and
do something with it we feel like we did
write engaging content so let's go ahead
and share it on social media and to me
social media is a good platform to share
your content because on social media
platforms like Facebook for example
you're building a community on that
platform that Community is already
interested in your content so if you're
sharing an ice cream recipe especially
in the summertime and you're engaging
with your community on that platform
then the likelihood of that community on
that platform is going to increase
engagement increased engagement will
send social signals to the search engine
that says hey this content is good
quality likewise for any other platform
most social media platforms have
engagement metrics and those engagement
metrics pass signals is it good is it
not good do we like this content are we
giving it a thumbs up are we going to
want to follow it are we going to want
to share it and so if you share content
that you feel is engaging on social
platforms then it's going to be engaging
and it's likely going to cause an
increase in engagement for example a
decrease in balance and once you share
that quality content then the likelihood
of it moving up the rankings even as far
as number one on Google is going to be
greater so you always want to start out
writing good quality content so let's
talk about good quality content because
Google does take content seriously they
do take into account what other people
think of that content so high quality
content is an important factor so how to
create good content that's always the
question so let's talk about some best
practices here remember in the last
segment we talked about keyword research
so we want to perform good keyword
research why because we want to choose
keywords remember we're choosing
multiple keywords per page one keyword
could be related to our brand one
keyword could be related to the content
but another keyword could be related to
a user's intent like recipes if you
recall the example we use with bread
recipes maybe somebody's looking to type
in a keyword that says how do I make you
know a bread or how do I make a specific
type of bread or how do I make banana
bread or what's the best recipe for
banana bread they're question related
and we want to be able to answer those
questions so that's where choosing those
right keywords that's going to respond
to a user's intent so starts with
choosing the right keywords so remember
we talked about a number of different
tools when we talked about keyword
research so there's a research tool that
you can use called phrase.io and that
will help you do quick research on you
know keywords and Trends and whatnot so
if you know a better research tool that
you use for keyword research then drop
us a comment below I'd be interested in
getting your comments about keyword
research and what research tools are out
there so if you know something better
than phrase.io drop a comment below and
we'd be interested in getting your
perspective so keyword research is key
but creating content that fulfills users
requirements so answering those
questions it's a recipe we want to
answer that question if it's directions
we want to answer that question if they
don't know how to do something we want
to answer that question then that's the
whole idea behind content content is not
just a fill a page it's to really
fulfill users requirements that's when
you get good engage engagement so if
somebody's typing in something on Google
and they're looking for an answer your
content should answer that question but
we also want to make the content
readable so in other words you know
write for your audience don't impress
anybody with very high vocabulary type
words that somebody doesn't necessarily
know the meaning of don't use jargon
don't use a street language for example
use everyday common language that's just
easily digestible when your audience is
reading and then we want to keep that
content organized and so when we mean
organized we want to use headers and
subheaders you know break your content
into paragraphs keep the flow organized
if we can keep the flow organized then
it's going to be easier for somebody to
read and then it's okay to add resources
especially resources from credible sites
so if you can incorporate those
resources in there then it's just going
to add The credibility to your content
let the audience know that hey I I've
done my research on this topic and this
is what this person has to say about it
this person who seems to be credible
okay so it only adds value to your
content so these are all tips to
Remember When creating content and then
the one important tip here is we want to
use white hat techniques and when we say
white hat techniques that means you know
if we've chosen keywords that are going
to answer somebody's question we don't
want to stuff those keywords into the
content we want the content to be
naturally written so when we say opt for
wide hack techniques that's what we mean
write the content naturally keep it
organized keep it readable include
third-party sources and make sure it
answers a question so there are
different types of content so there's
content where you just write words to
install text based you could also use an
infographic infographic is simply just a
graphic that visualizes exactly what
you're trying to explain for example if
we want to write an article about how to
write good engaging content we don't
necessarily have to write all that out
as a text we can create an infographic
so for example here's an infographic on
20 effective ways to basically not bore
your readers but write engaging content
so you could see this is an infographic
it's all graphically laid out so
infographics tend to be easier to
understand because they're visual
they're easy for the end user to
comprehend because there's generally no
jargon it's usually images that are
portraying the points of what you're
trying to get across and so it tends to
break it up the monotony of just text
it's more visually appealing and it's
laid out and organized so you can see
this infographic has 20 different steps
or rules and they lay those out all here
in this infographic and the great thing
I like about infographics is you could
you could share them on social media you
can re-engage them as a post you can
save them from really any social
platform so infographics tend to tell a
better story and versus say just writing
text you can use video and images so you
don't necessarily have to lay it all out
in an infographic you can certainly
insert a video or an image into your
content especially if it's a blog post
if it's a blog post then sometimes video
and image is on its own tell the story
you don't necessarily need text to go
ahead and tell your story a video or an
image as they say tells a thousand words
and so images and videos are great to
use in a blog post so using different
forms of content you know you always
want to review your content when a user
dwells on your web page for a longer
time Google will tend to think okay this
person's engaged so we're going to rank
that favorable so if you're using
infographics videos and images then the
chances of somebody being more engaged
are going to increase versus just text
that's not well organized and written
out in a way that somebody doesn't
necessarily understand so be creative in
the types of content you use so longer
engaging content tends to bode well with
search engines so this is according to
HubSpot so the more word count you use
the more words you use the chances of
you ranking higher are going to be
better just take into account best
practices you want to maybe break up the
content with an image organize it make
it engaging use headers so it's not
necessarily just words it's the words
and how those words are written how
they're structured the types of keywords
you're using how you're engaging with
your audience there's a lot of factors
again there's best practices we just
went over but the key is you know if you
have longer more engaging content then
it's going to bode better for you on
search engines so a couple of steps to
create high quality content so you want
to begin with a comprehensive
introduction so always introduce your
content remember the content should be
relevant to the keywords so if you're
choosing keywords and your keyword
research think about answering that
question if somebody's typing in bread
recipes maybe they're looking for banana
bread recipes how to make the best
banana bread or how to make banana bread
using dried figs we want to be able to
align our content with that keyword
naturally you want to create a title
that's worthy that's click worthy so
remember if you're in Google search and
you're doing search for something simple
like bread recipes we want to make
something that's going to be you know
engaging for somebody to click on like
easy perfect yeast spread are easy
crusty French bread or something that's
going to be engaging you know the best
bread recipes or how to make the best
homemade bread you know something that's
going to draw somebody's attention to
the title of that blog post so we want
to include LSI keywords so what I mean
by LSI keywords in your content we mean
you know long tail keywords make it
natural headings and subheadings should
consist of keywords and variants so if
you're writing headers and subheaders
include the keyword in there and that
way the content always stays relevant to
the audience okay shorten your sentences
in paragraphs so don't write long
paragraphs remember we want to break
this up we want to make it easier for
the end user to read and we want to
always put internal links on our blog
post why because if we have internal
links then if we have a link from one
blog post to another blog post or say
our blog post to an internal page on our
website we want to make sure that it's
relevant content that way somebody's
reading something and you have an
internal link let's just say from a
bread recipes page to a banana bread
recipes page then they may find it
interesting click on that link and go to
the banana bread recipes page so it's
keeping somebody engaged on your website
so putting in internal linking will help
keep the end user engaged because you're
offering up links that's relevant to the
content you always want to break up that
content with images okay we want to use
alt tags meaning we want to pen the
image with text so that way if the image
doesn't load then at least the alt text
will load so we can incorporate call out
boxes and more importantly we want to
update our content regularly so we
always want to get the best recipe out
there if it's banana a bread or
different ways to Crepe banana bread or
always just coming up with ways to
update the content so we want to keep
our content our blog post fresh and then
we want to include a CTA call to action
if we include a call to action then
that's going to keep somebody engaged
and have them act on your content so
these are steps to creating high quality
content and so let's look at an example
here and this is a three-month-old post
on BuzzFeed and it's 21 pictures that
restore your faith in humanity so it has
a lot of likes a lot of tweaks and that
means it's engaged people are engaged
when reading that and so if we go and
look at it as an example we could see it
on a buzzfeed here 21 pictures that will
restore your faith in humanity so this
was written back in 2012. again a lot of
Engagement but if we look at it we can
see immediately that it's taking into
account third-party sources it's got
some content it's got images it's being
broken up by images we could see there's
call to actions on there in the form of
social so people can go ahead and go
ahead and share it if they like it okay
it includes videos includes images
third-party sources so it's a good post
because says listen you know it's
engaging content it's probably answering
somebody's question about humanity and
we could see clearly that look you know
there's a lot of different examples here
from a lot of different sources and we
could take action on this content so not
just video not just images but text as
well and so it's very engaging answers
questions takes into account the
different types of content available so
this is a good post in that regard so
contents updated regularly it's engaging
and it includes sources from high
Authority websites some do's and don'ts
on the content so take into account the
best practices I mentioned about
creating high quality content okay
answer those questions that the end user
wants to hear you know because that
likely is going to be their search and
so you want to be able to respond to the
end user that's part of creating high
quality content different types of
content I.E in the form of infographic
or videos or text or images you can add
images from public domain sites you can
be relatable and use examples to clarify
points just like the BuzzFeed article
simplify complex words don't use
sophisticated language talk to your
audience as if you they were standing
right in front of you and use bullet
points to exemplify your examples your
points so some Do's the don'ts obviously
don't lift content we don't want to lift
content from another website so that's
plagiarism so we want to have our own
unique content we also don't want to
take images from other websites and so
if you do happen to find an image that
works for your post and it's on somebody
else's website ideally that's not a good
situation but if you do happen to do
that then always give credit to the
website okay so if you took it from
xyz.com credit xyz.com for the image and
even put a link back but ideally you
don't want to take images from other
websites just as much as you don't want
to take copy you don't want to take
images use your own imagery and content
but if you don't have imagery then you
can always go to stock photography there
are plenty of websites out there where
you can sign up for a subscription like
Adobe stock images as an example you can
sign up for an account and in some cases
you can sign up for a free account and
use stock imagery okay don't give less
information to your audience give them
to your audience what they deserve which
is the information they're looking for
they're looking for the best banana
bread recipes give them the best banana
bread recipes incorporate your own
images break it up with titles give them
a good quality piece of content that
they're going to be able to engage with
and so if you put long paragraphs in
your content then it's going to be less
engaging so try to avoid those long
paragraph graphs remember shorten up the
paragraphs keep the language simple add
in images answer those questions use
third-party credible sources but write
it in your own words and you should be
on your way to creating good quality
content okay so now that we've talked
about high quality content in order to
get your pages ranked high on Google
search let's turn our attention to
optimizing on-page elements and discuss
some website level factors that are both
going to help you rank high on Google
search so let's just do an overview of
what we're talking about when we talk
about on-page elements and website level
factors so optimizing on page elements
include a number of different things but
primarily we're going to focus in on
meta tags also known as meta description
tags header tags also known as title
tags and URLs so those are just some of
the on-page elements we want to be able
able to optimize using relevant keywords
in order to rank on Google search we
also want to take a look at some website
factors that will affect our ranking on
Google search they include website
architecture having a secure website
having a site map and taking a look at
page speed so all of those are some of
the website factors we need to take into
account in order to rank high on Google
search so title tag and meta description
together are considered meta tags so
both play an important role in ranking
high on Google so we want to be able to
write unique title and descriptions for
each page on our website when I say
unique that means a title In The Meta
description need to be different for
every page on the website and so if
you're not quite sure what a title tag
in a meta description tag is if you go
to search and just type in any
particular our search query the title
tag is what's going to show up here and
bold and then the description is going
to show up below it below the URL and
that's going to describe the page so
both of these meta tags are important
because it describes what your page is
all about and that's what Google uses in
the search results pages so we want to
be able to pay attention to the length
of our meta tags so if we go back to our
search results Pages met title tags are
generally 60 65 characters meta
description tags are generally 160
characters so anything really longer
than that then what's going to happen is
the meta description tag or the title
tag will get trunk at it and so if we
look here for example we could see all
of the title tags here fit the 65
character limit but if you run over the
character count on meta description then
Google is going to truncate the copy so
you want to stay within your parameters
in order to avoid getting your content
truncated and so the other thing when
we're writing title meta description
tags we want to minimize keyword
repetition so if we're optimizing for
keyword we don't want to necessarily
just plug that keyword into the title
tag and meta description multiple times
we want to make sure our title tags and
meta descriptions are naturally written
so if somebody's typing for banana bread
recipe with dried figs you know we want
to have a nice title tag and a
description that is going to get
somebody to respond based on their need
and so we definitely want to avoid
keyword repetition but we want to be
able to use that keyword in the title
tag because if you remember from the
earlier segment when we did the all in
title syntax to find out exactly how
many competitors were using that
particular keyword well we obviously
want to use that keyword in the title
tag because again the title tag is an
important factor when it comes to search
engine results so we want to use the
keyword but we want to avoid stuffing or
using it repetitively in our title tag
and our meta description we want the
title tag and The Meta description to
describe the page sound natural but also
be engaging because the point is we want
people to click on our link and go to
our website from search engines so title
tags with numbers tend to result in
higher click-through rates this is
according to mods so for example if you
just put in a title tag that says learn
digital marketing well that may work but
if you put a number in there like five
easy ways to learn digital marketing
that might get somebody to click on your
link and go to your website so having
questions in your meta tags can also
increase your click-through rate for
example if you just put learn the
importance of first page rankings not
too bad but again generic but if you put
it into the formal question how to rank
number one on Google it's more action
oriented it's gonna get somebody to
resonate with the question that they
have and that may be their query how to
rank number one on Google and so these
techniques will help you get higher
click-through rates and so according to
backlinko title tag with a keyword can
improve site ranking so remember we want
to include that keyword in the title tag
even though we only have 65 characters
we want to include that keyword but we
want to avoid stuffing the keyword in
there we want to again make the title
tag action oriented maybe with the
number maybe as a question with the
keyword in there once naturally not easy
to do but that's the beauty of SEO if
you can follow these best practices and
write a good title tag then the chances
of you you improving in your search
results are going to be greater so
having only one H1 tag in your post is
going to be good so remember when
somebody clicks on a link so let's say
they do find a title tag engaging and
they click on this this link here and
they go to that website you know you
want to start out with having that
particular H1 Tech because the H1 tag
especially with the keyword in it is
going to signal to Google hey we're
organizing our page and because it's an
H1 tag it's important we're structuring
the page according to best practices so
having only one H1 tag in your post is
definitely helpful having multiple tags
H tags in your post help organize the
page a lot better so we want to add that
targeted keyword in that tag and your
pattern tag should be relevant to the
content so if we go back to our example
of the using Drive figs with banana
breads why well the title says
California fig banana bread and remember
the last segment when we're talking
about high quality content well look no
further than including a video into our
content so not only will this video help
keep the engagement high but it breaks
up the monotony of the page and it's
from a third-party source so it adds
credibility to the page so adding a
video based on the last segment of high
quality content definitely helps with
ranking high on Google search so
following hierarchical structure that
means putting those H tags in there H2
tags help break up the content and we
want to avoid repetition of H1 tags on
your different web pages of your site
meaning don't just put the same H1 tag
with the same keyword in it and keeping
it blase we want to make those H1 tags
exciting to read but also used
appropriately to break up the content so
remember all white hat techniques we
want to avoid hidden tags we want to
avoid stuffing keywords we want things
to be natural we don't want things to be
forced and your H1 tag should be 20 to
70 characters don't make long H1 tags if
we go back to our page example a short
sweet tag here California fig banana
bread it's relevant to the content it's
short sweet and breaks up the monotony
of the content and more importantly and
again any content you have on the page
should always answer the user's intent
remember people are using search to
answer questions find information our
content should be able to answer that
for them so according to John Moeller
senior webmaster Trends Analyst at
Google header tags would definitely help
Google for rankings in the search
results so we want to use header tags so
when it comes to URLs we want to use
hyphens and avoid avoid underscores so
if we look at this URL here this uses
hyphens fig and banana bread so it's all
broken up with hyphens that's the best
practice remember canonical URLs a
canonical URL signals to Google this is
the original content so we want to use
original content and if you have
multiple sources of content out there on
say different websites we want to use a
canonical tag to signal to Google this
is the original content please Index
this content and not doesn't hurt to use
a favicon URL meaning a small icon and
helps to break up the monotony and help
your URL stand out we can add targeted
keywords in the URL so again looking at
the URL here I can see we're using
targeted keyword as part of the URL
structure fig and banana bread and that
is the H1 tag is fake banana bread so
it's all consistent and it flows
naturally your URLs that are no longer
existing then we want to be able to set
up a redirect for those URLs meaning a
301 redirect is a server response for
Google that says Hey Google this page is
no longer available but it we
permanently redirected it to this page
which is now available so that's what a
301 redirect does it helps signal to
Google and all the other search engines
that if the page is no longer there
that's fine you're just going to go to
this page this is the page that's
permanently there now and another thing
we want to do here is if you have mobile
URLs you want to include those in the
site map and we're going to hit on that
in just a minute but all urls should be
mobile friendly as well as desktop
friendly meaning take into account this
best practices keep your URLs short use
hyphens put the keyword in that URL and
make it easy to understand want to avoid
capital letters in the URLs the URLs are
case sensitive so go lowercase you
should always go lowercase from the URL
readable URLs again the rule of thumb
here is if you understand what the URL
is then Google is going to understand
what the URL is so the shorter the URL
the easier it is to read the easier it
is to read the better chance you have to
rank high on Google search so according
to backlink to URLs that are shorter
definitely definitely help you rank so
we want to be able to shorten those URLs
keep them short and sweet don't make
them long and unreadable so those are
some on optimized ways or on-page
elements that help you optimize now we
want to look at some website level
factors that will help you optimize and
write client Google search so good site
structure provides better crawling for
search engine Bots and what do we mean
by that well we mean having your site
organized in a fashion that Google's
going to be able to find all the pages
so so what do we mean by that create a
logical hierarchy structure so if you're
selling shoes you know you're going to
have a home page break the structure up
into men's shoes women's shoes
Children's Shoes then under men's shoes
you can have it by brand it could be
Nike Puma Adidas on the women's side it
could be Nike Puma Adidas on the child
side it could be Nike Puma Adidas and so
you want to keep the structure flow in a
hierarchy so we want to balance the
amount of subcategories within each
category so the men's if it has Nike
Puma Adidas the women should have Nike
Puma Adidas and so you want to code your
site navigation and CSS or HTML meaning
we want to be able to use something that
Google is going to be able to index so
most sites are built in HTML and that's
what Google likes to index they like to
index something that they could take
back to their servers and then more
importantly build a comprehensive
structure for internal linking so
internal links mean that if you're on a
site you should have natural lengths
pointing to other pages on your website
so to keep the flow going we don't want
to have unnatural inbound things you
always want to have natural internal
links to keep the flow of the user going
from one page to the other so here I
could see as an example all the
ingredients in this recipe well this has
an internal link to another page on our
site and this happens to link to a page
where somebody can buy the ingredients
so it's a natural internal link so John
Doherty of Credo has claimed that one of
the biggest changes that he can make in
fixing the Credo website is architecture
so for example in Credo John Doherty has
increased the organic sessions by 74 in
Pages by per session by 41 just by
changing the site architecture so you'd
be surprised by changing the side
architecture what that will do to
engagement and so let's turn our
attention to secure versus nonsense
secure so what we mean by that is
securing your site we want to make it
sure that compliant with certain
protocols and so if we go back here we
can see that this particular site is
compliant it is secure https means it
has a secure license meaning the site is
secure so Google likes secure versus
non-secure so non-secure would be HTTP
so we want https as our protocol and
what that means is this enabling SSL
certificates and that means when you
enable an SSL certificate that means
your domain or your protocol is going to
be turned to https so Google prefers
sites that are secure versus non-secure
so if you use hsts as a protocol that
adds an extra layer of security over the
https and
hsts prevents cookie hijacking so adding
multiple layers of security always helps
in my opinion if you have an HTTP
website a non-secure website you should
look into buying an SSL certificate
getting your sites flipped over to https
because what's going to happen is your
url structure is going to change when
your url structure changes Google is
going to recognize that because they're
going to index your site and when they
index your site they're going to see
those secure URLs and that's going to
work favorably in your favor and help
you rank higher on Google search so
websites using secure or https have a
higher chance of ranking higher so https
is a ranking signal because Google
indexes those pages so let's also talk
about site Maps so sitemap is one of the
most important ways to improve your
website ranking why well because
sitemaps are a way to organize all your
URLs into one file so we're basically
going to prioritize all our web pages in
a site map so if you go to any
particular website and you type in
sitemap.xml you're likely going to see
all the pages on your website so usually
the site map is located in the root
directory so if I type in sitemap.xml
I'm going to be able to see all the
pages in my root directory and I can
also prioritize them I can also alert
Google as to how often they change and
every page is going to have a date stamp
associated with it so Google can
actually see how often it changes so
remember we want our content to be
updated frequently so content's not
updated frequently or it's not fresh
then Google's gonna see that size that
date stamp that last modification down
so we want to be able to make sure
content is updated frequently we want to
let Google know that we change it
frequently and we want to be able to
prioritize our Pages let Google know hey
these pages are important to us so all
that can be set up in a site map we want
to be able to add canonical versions of
URLs in the sitemap so we want to be
able to add all our original URLs in our
sitemap and so we always want to build
Dynamic URLs site maps for larger
websites and what I mean by Dynamic URLs
that means that if I look at this side
map and we're always adding content
let's just say in the form of a Blog
well guess what we want those pages to
be added to the sitemap as they're
published so as we add pages to the blog
or to the site then they should
automatically be added to the sitemap
and so in effect what's going to happen
is we're going to be able to see the
site map grow with more URLs when the
sitemap grows with more URLs then that
means then Google is going to index more
pages they're going to index more fresh
pages so they're going to be able to get
those pages that are just published
quicker so that's the whole idea idea
behind Dynamic site Maps is we want to
be able to capture all the URLs just as
they're published and we want to be able
to maintain our site maps and so I would
always recommend a dynamic site map but
you can always create your own sitemap
just by going to a tool called XML
sitemap so if I just type in XML
sitemaps
into Google search here I can see XML
sitemaps generator and I can be able if
I have a small website just create a
free and simple site map on my own when
XML sitemaps creates it or your platform
creates a dynamic sitemap either way the
sitemaps going to sit in the root
directory and then what we want to do in
turn is let Google know where that
sitemap is so in search console we want
to be able to submit the sitemap so
you're going to add the site map you're
going to let Google know where it is it
should be in the root directory and it
should be called sitemap.xml and when
you do that Google's going to be able to
take those URLs and index them so we
could see we submitted 528 URLs Google
index 521 so one thing about URLs here
is when we create a site map we're
putting all your URLs in there we do not
add no index URLs in your site map when
what that means is that any URL we don't
want Google to index we're just going to
exclude from the sitemap okay so we want
Google to take all the URLs we want
indexed and put them in the sitemap so
according to edgy using sitemaps for SEO
can increase your website's visibility
and help you get indexed why because
what you're in fact doing is taking all
your URLs that you want index you're
telling Google how often they're
modified you're telling Google which
ones are important and you're submitting
that to Google and so Google's going to
be able to take all these URLs quicker
index them quicker and when they're
index quicker you can get ranked quicker
and when you get ranked quicker you can
get traffic quicker so that's the whole
idea behind sitemaps so let's turn our
attention to page speed now so when the
last factors for our website besides
architecture making it secure and adding
site Maps is we want to take a look at
how quick our Pages load here are some
tips in order to optimize page speed
because ideally the quicker a page loads
the more engaged the user is going to be
if it takes a longer time for the page
to load all the elements of that page
then what's going to happen is the user
is going to get impatient maybe leave
the website all together or go to
another page and so we want to be able
to optimize images so any image that's
of large size in terms of megabytes we
want to be able to optimize that
compress the image so that's one way to
speed up page speed we want to use a
simple website design you know HTML with
CSS or cascading style sheets just a
simple design with simple a hierarchy
and website navigation structure so
nothing fancy nothing complex just a
simple website design with optimized
images we want to leverage browser
caching and we want to upgrade the
server response by meaning all your
files are sitting on the server so when
somebody goes to web page the server is
serving up all of those files the images
the text Etc and so we want the server
to respond as quick as possible so when
it comes to page speed we can look at
the factors affecting page speed and
Google analytics so if I go to Google
analytics and I go under behavior and I
go under site speed and I go to overview
I'm going to be able to see what my
average load time is for my site and
ideally we want our pages to load as
quick as possible so that means anything
under four seconds anything four seconds
or higher and it's likely the end user
is going to leave the page there's a
correlation BP between page load time
and bounce rate and so what Google
actually does is give you speed
suggestions so if we do have a page that
loads slow we can just go to speed
suggestions in Google analytics and we
go to speed suggestions then Google's
going to be able to tell us hey okay
this particular page load fast this
potato page loads slow and if it loaded
slow why is it loading slow so here we
could see the home page of the example
is loading on average of seven seconds
well if we look here they're going to
give us some suggestions so if I click
on this page speed suggestions it's
going to load a report and a tool called
page speed insights and basically what
it's then going to do after it's done
running is it's going to tell me all the
ways in which I can optimize my pages
not only for desktop but also for mobile
so here I can see for desktop or for
mobile I can look at some ways in which
I can optimize it to increase page speed
for example sizing my images properly
server response time reducing my server
response time avoiding multiple page
redirects so there's a lot of
opportunities that we can do to speed up
page load time and all that's found in
page speed insights and all that's found
within Google analytics so remember
optimizing code minimizing redirects
optimizing your images upgrading your
server response and all of those are
factors and so again you can go into
analytics page speed insights and you
can see exactly what Google is
recognizing as what's lowering or
slowing down your page load time so
Google takes site speed as one of the
most important ranking factors why
because they're going to rank Pages not
only with high quality content that are
relevant to the keyword queries but they
want those pages to have a good user
experience so if somebody clicks on the
page then the user should be able to see
that content fairly quickly and so
that's why it's such an important factor
so the quicker your pages load the
chances of you ranking higher are going
to be better so according to web
performance today Walmart as an example
experience to decline in conversions so
what they did was looked at their page
speed and when they looked at their page
speed you'd be surprised what that did
just increasing it from one to four
seconds or decreasing it basically
increased conversion so there's always
going to be a correlation between how
quick a page loads and how engaged the
user is because if it's users engaged
they're going to stay on the site and if
they stay on the site then their chances
of converting are going to be higher so
just even one to two seconds increase
and Page low is low time will make a
world of difference in terms of
Engagement and conversions let's turn
our attention to off-site engagement so
previously we talked about on-page
elements and website factors that are
fact our rankings for search results but
we also need to turn our attention away
from our website meaning what we do on
our website and turn our attention what
we can do for our website off our
website and onto other websites so
that's offside engagement and so let's
look get an example so that ice cream
recipes blog so we did everything we
possibly could we updated The Meta tags
the title tag The Meta description we
added H1 tags we've made sure the site
architecture was sound we submitted a
site map we we made sure the page load
was good and fast so we did all the
things we're supposed to do on our web
page but we're still not ranking well
what do we need to do well we need to
turn our attention away from our website
into other websites we call this off
side or off page SEO and we need to
basically generate links from high
quality sites back to our site so if
we've done everything we can on our own
website and we're still not ranking
where we want to be well then we need to
turn our attention to other websites and
so if we turn our attention other
websites and other websites that are
relevant other websites that are of
quality uh other websites that have high
domain Authority then we're going to see
an increase in rankings so it's just a
matter of getting quality links from
quality websites that are relevant
that's what's going to move the needle
on search after we've taken care of all
the on-page elements so more backlinks
from high domain Authority results in
higher rankings SEO is a combination
between what we do on our website
meaning optimizing the page and making
sure our website has good site
architecture and follows the best
practices in terms of site maps and Page
load then we need to turn our attention
to the backlinking to improve our domain
Authority so according to backlinko
analysis offsite engagement is one of
the most important elements for ranking
number one in Google so you can't just
focus your attention on updating the
title tag and making sure the pages load
fast you have have to turn your
attention as well to getting back
lengths from high quality sites that's
off-site engagement and so getting links
back links from multiple domains is
vital it's vital because they bring
referring traffic to your site they
bring credibility to your site but more
importantly Google is going to recognize
the relationship between these sites and
your website and if these sites that
have backlinks or links pointing to your
site and if they're of high quality then
we call that passing linkages so it's
going to bring quality to you in terms
of organic search so if we look at an
example if I do a search for banana
bread recipe they're 241 billion results
for banana bread recipe Why did this
particular page from Simply Recipes
ranked number one well we can turn our
attention to Moz and Maz has a report
called link Explorer and so Moz link
Explorer report helps us identify our
own page Authority our own domain
Authority and how many links we have
from other quality websites so if I put
that particular URL into link Explorer
and notice the URL here is short even
though it uses an underscore when it
should use a hyphen it's still ranked
number one and why because off page
elements help this page rank number one
why their page Authority out of 100 is
58 their domain Authority out of 100 is
82. and what does that mean well that
means that they have a lot of good links
from other domains of high quality they
have 824 linking domains to this one
domain they have 3600 inbound links and
they're ranking for a lot of different
keywords so if we scroll down we're
going to be able to see kind of a
breakout the quality of websites that
are linking to them so they have 19
domains with a domain authority of 91 to
100 linking to them they have 15 domains
between the range of 81 and 90. so what
does that tell me between 15 and 19
that's 34 particular domains that are
very high quality linking to them and so
we could see the breakout of the linking
domains we could see the top file links
to the site and we can see the page
Authority so the link Explorer report
gives us an overview of what pages are
linking to ours and it also gives us an
idea of what our own page Authority and
domain Authority are because domain
Authority and Page Authority both need
to be high in order for us to rank on
Google search in order for it to get
high we need links from high quality
sites so that's the whole idea behind
off-site engagement so some of the
offset engagements our influencer
marketing meaning is there somebody out
there on social who has a huge following
but not only do they have a huge volume
but are they relevant to our product for
example Usain Bolt who's a famous
Sprinter if we're selling shoes and
we're selling Nike shoes maybe Usain
Bolt can reference us on Twitter or
Facebook that's influencer marketing
getting people to influencing people to
buy our product we can engage with
audiences on multiple social media
platforms like Facebook and Twitter
meaning if we're running a promotion on
those running shoes then we can promote
that on Facebook okay we can promote
that on Twitter we can also bookmark our
webpage on popular bookmarking sites
like StumbleUpon we can also put our
content on discussion forums like Reddit
we can join High PR quality q a sites
excuse me and post answers to questions
related to our business is like
quora.com so we can engage in sharing
our content and answering questions so
there's lots of ways to get links to
your website if you have a blog post as
an example you can make sure that maybe
that content is shared on a similar blog
post so if you have an ice cream recipe
blog post well maybe you can look at a
dessert blog post and share your content
on that particular blog post and have a
back link pointing from that blog post
to yours as an example and you can
reciprocate so the whole idea of content
is sharing the content but at the same
time I've shared it you're producing
backlinks and backlinks help domain
Authority so not only did it help domain
Authority but they improve the search
rankings so in Google's eyes the higher
your domain Authority higher the page
Authority in Google's eyes that means
your page is important it's credible and
we're going to improve it in the search
engine rankings it increases brand
visibility if we have our content on a
highly engageable website a highly
popular website or blog it's not it's
going to lift our brand visibility if we
have Usain Bolt who's very famous
Sprinter do some influence in marketing
for us then that's going to increase our
brand visibility so anytime we can
associate with something that has some
influence or some clout or high domain
Authority then it's only going to
increase our brand awareness and
visibility so again it's going to
increase our domain Authority because of
the association of passing link juice
from one domain to another it's going to
then as a result increase referral
traffic because if we're on a high
quality website that gets a lot of
traffic then the chances of some of that
traffic going our site is going to be
great and again it improves The
credibility and Trust of our website and
that's what we want we want Google to
trust us and a way to build trust is by
by associating our website with other
websites of high equal or higher quality
so when we talk about off-site
engagement we want to do some guest
posts on relevant websites so if you
have that ice cream blog go to another
blog like the dessert blog and do a
guest post so not only that will that
improve your brand awareness but it'll
generate a backlink and maybe drive some
referral traffic you can participate in
forms and blog discussions like core.com
or Reddit get your content out there
start a discussion about a specific
topic to engage users build brand
awareness and generate that backlink you
can always you know put your your site
on a directory like Yelp for example or
Yahoo directory you could prefer
testimonial link building meaning if you
serve products or offer up a service
well somebody can provide a testimony on
their website or you can just earn back
links from relevant authoritative web
pages like we mentioned quora or
Wikipedia or there's plenty out there so
the idea is to associate yourself with
high quality websites but do it
naturally you don't want to force
anything so if you're selling a specific
service or you're selling a specific
product look for like mining services or
products that complement what you do and
that'll create the natural environment
natural ecosystem that will eventually
give you the benefits that you need to
rank higher in the search results pages
so we don't want to purchase any links
we don't want to cloak content we don't
want to just inject links on sites that
aren't relevant we don't want to just
have site-wide links all over the place
pointed to the same page and we
certainly don't want to be on low
quality websites or directories it's all
about quality not quantity with off-site
engagement so having an offside
engagement complements what you do on
your website for on-site to gather both
of the those efforts will get you higher
search engine results let's
measure your SEO performance so all that
hard work you've done with on-page SEO
coupled with all the work you've done
with off page SEO are eventually going
to net results and positive results and
we want to be able to measure that as
you're actually doing the work as you're
putting forth the effort on on page and
off page and so we want to be able to
measure that and so you want to be able
to understand what to measure and where
to measure it and so when we talk about
SEO we really want to hone in on three
high level core metrics and that's
ranking traffic and conversion so when
we talk about ranking traffic and
conversion we can break that down into
this list here what kind of traffic are
we getting from organic search what kind
of traffic are we getting from mobile
devices remember mobile is very
important because as we talked about
with on page SEO as we talked about with
local SEO a lot of searches start with
mobile devices we want to look at
keyword ranking remember keyword
research is the first step in the SEO
process even before we do any work with
on-page and off page you know we want to
look at the local visibility if we have
local SEO results we want to look at
engagement metrics so all that traffic
we're driving from organic search we
want to be able to measure how they're
performing and behaving on our website
we also want to measure some form of
progress on off-page SEO and that's in
the form of backlinks so all of these
are different metrics we can measure
using different tools so let's talk
about how to go about looking at these
metrics and where to go look at them and
measure them and so really monitoring
all this Behavior will help us
understand how we're performing how SEO
is performing and so really what we want
to do is start with Organic traffic and
so we can look at that on a
month-to-month basis we can look at it
from a geographic perspective we can
look at it in terms of how many new
visitors we're driving versus returning
and then again more importantly
conversion rate and so to me the best
place to start to look at that traffic
from organic search is Google analytics
and Google analytics is a free tool it's
simply there to measure website
performance so if you go into Google
analytics we can actually go in and we
can look at all sorts of data based on
website behavior and so if I'm in Google
analytics and I go under acquisition and
then I go under all traffic channels
over a given period of time let's just
say the last seven days for particular
website I can see what traffic is coming
from organic search and then I could see
the amount of new users that are coming
from organic search I can also see
engagement metrics bounce rate for
example so I want to be able to see if
somebody's typing in a query clicking on
our Link in the organic search results
and then coming to our website are they
actually engaging with their website or
are they leaving the website after only
visiting the page they landed on so
that's all in these are all important
metrics to measure and I can measure all
that right here in Google analytics if I
wanted to I can even take it a step
further and break that down by country
so if I type in country as a secondary
Dimension now I can see what country is
driving traffic from organic search so a
lot of your organic traffic information
is going to be centrally located in
Google analytics so we also talked about
Mobile Traffic a majority of searches
take place on mobile phones versus
desktop so Google basically is reporting
the nearly 60 percent of searches now
appear from mobile devices and so if we
go back to Google analytics we can also
look at a mobile report so if I go in
Google analytics under audience under
mobile overview I can see a breakdown of
the amount of traffic coming from
desktop versus tablet versus mobile and
so you'll find as time goes on that your
mobile device is likely going to drive a
majority of the traffic from organic
search and so you can compare device
information with channel so if I just
type in Channel and Google analytics as
a secondary Dimension and look at the
default Channel groupings versus device
category I could see that you know
mobile from organic search is driven
traffic over the last seven days this is
something you want to keep an eye on
because a lot of people tend to begin
their searches on mobile devices so
mobile ranking is different than desktop
ranking because with mobile ball ranking
it's based on a responsive website and
with that responsive website basically
response of being that the website's
going to adapt to the mobile device so
it's going to respond to the device that
somebody's on and so therefore the
metrics or the engagement metrics are
going to be different but if I look back
to Google analytics I can see again
bounce rate I can see pages per session
average session duration so if I look at
line three I could see all the different
engagement metrics compared to those
metrics from other devices and other
channels okay so you want to be able to
do a comparison because if behavior is
not up to par engagement is not the par
on mobile then you want to do something
about that so you want to hone in on
Mobile Traffic specifically from organic
search because the behavior is going to
be different you know people start their
searches on mobile the site's going to
be different and so therefore it's a
different experience altogether so make
sure you track the behavior and more
importantly make sure you track that
page speed so earlier we talked about
on-page SEO when we honed in on page
speed so this is a reminder if I'm back
in analytics and I go back under
Behavior then if I go to site speed then
if I go to overview I'll be able to see
the average page load time on my website
I can also look at specific page timings
and I should be able to see that by
device so if I type in device category
I'll just be able to see how each page
loads per device and so this allow me to
understand which pages are loading fast
which pages are not loading as fast and
address those pages accordingly to
improve engagement metrics so we want to
keep an eye on page speed as well as
overall user behavior from mobile
devices you can also use other tools
that are out there like agency analytics
their plan plenty of tools out there I
tend to use Google analytics because
primarily it's free and Google analytics
is a Google product so it works with
other Google platforms like Google
search console we want to keep an eye on
ranking so remember when we do our
keyword research we're choosing keywords
that have high relevancy high volume and
low competition so we want to be able to
track keywords that we choose that have
high relevancy high volume and low
competition and so the tool we use or at
least I recommend using is Moz so I
mentioned Moz earlier with on page and
off-page SEO so if we go into Moz and we
know what keywords we're trying to rank
for we can go ahead and add the Namaz
and what Moz does they actually track
where these keywords Rank and so if I go
into Mods and I click on rankings I'll
be able to see on a weekly basis or a
monthly basis how our key keywords are
ranking and for what page is the ranking
so for whatever keyword I choose to to
optimize for I want to make sure I put
those keywords in Moz because when I put
them in Moz Moz is going to on a weekly
basis tell me where these keywords Rank
and for what URL they're ranked for so
that way I can keep an eye on ranking
over time because in theory the higher
you rank the more traffic you're going
to get and so we want to be able to see
the trend in which keywords rank okay so
if I click on a particular keyword in
Moz it's going to give me over a period
of time where that keyword's ranked be
able to see Improvement in ranking for a
particular keyword the whole idea behind
SEO is to choose keywords that are
relevant optimize for those keywords so
that you can be ranked for those
keywords in order to get the traffic and
conversions so Moz is a good platform
that helps us monitor rankings for
particular keywords now if you don't
want to use Moz as an alternative you
can turn your attention to Google search
console and so remember we talked about
Google search console earlier when we
talked about sitemaps we also talked
about mobile usability with search
console we also talked about links to
your site with Google search console so
Google search console is a good tool to
help you understand how you're
performing with Organic search and so
there's one tool in particular which is
performance that helps us understand
what keyword queries people are actually
typing into Google search and so here I
could see the actual query and so with
this particular website valleyfig.com I
can see that dried fig recipes over the
course of the last three months had
5414 Impressions that means that one of
my pages either one or multiple Pages
appeared in Google search engine results
5414 times and over the course of those
5414 Impressions I received 1100 clicks
so Google search console is going to be
able to tell me not only you know how
many Impressions I received for a
particular keyword but they also going
to tell me how many clicks and if I
wanted to add more metrics to that I can
add them like the average ranking
position for keyword the click-through
rate so I can add multiple metrics to
this report to give me an understanding
of hey or any of my target keywords
being used or queried and if they are
where am I ranking and I am I showing up
and am I getting clicks so search
console serves as a good alternative if
not primary tool or platform for you to
measure how your organic search results
are showing so for local visibility this
metric is important for you know
maintaining local SEO so remember on the
local SEO we talked about Google my
business so if I go back to Google my
business I can go into my account and so
Google my business is going to be able
to show me some metrics so if I go into
Google my business and I click on
insights I'm going to be able to see a
number of different metrics over the
course of a month I can see exactly you
know what queries were used by how many
users and when I appeared so I'll be
able to see how many views I receive not
only on search results but on maps then
I can also see what actions people took
when they saw my results in maps or on
search did they visit my website did
they request directions did they call so
I can actually see engagement metrics
right in Google my business I could see
a Breakout by ZIP code I could see phone
calls by day of the week I could see how
many people even viewed my photos so
there's a lot of insights into local SEO
on Google my business so that gives you
an idea of how you're performing
organically on local search and remember
you want to be able to use Google my
business to hone in on your specific
audience so all these metrics help you
align with whether you're getting in
front of the Right audience and whether
that audience is actually behaving the
way you want them to meaning you know
are they actually contacting you are
they going to your website are they
calling you so local visibility and
understanding the metrics involved with
local SEO is very important so Google my
business is where you want to turn your
attention so overall engagement metrics
are important they play an important
role in determining rankings for example
we talk about bounce rate so bounce rate
is the rate at which people go from
organic search to your website and then
leave after a scene one page and not
going any further so if they land on a
page and then leave the website after
landing on that page it's considered a
bounce and so bounce or bounce rate is a
good indication of how people are
receiving our website or the content
that they're reading on our website
there are other metrics involved like
average session duration or pages per
visit all of these are engagement
metrics and let's not forget about page
speed so page speed is also a good
engagement metric all of these metrics
affect or determine rankings so we want
to be able to make sure that if we're in
Google analytics and we're looking at
engagement metrics that our metrics are
good because if somebody comes to our
website from organic search and there's
a high bounce rate then what does that
tell us that there's a disconnect
between what that person's querying and
then the content that they're reading
and so we want to be able to address
those engagement metrics so that we can
continue to not only drive quality
traffic but keep the traffic engaged and
then in turn drive up conversions last
metric we want to look at is backlinks
so content having more backlinks from
good domains will effectively improve
your SEO performance we talk about
backlinks with off-page SEO and remember
quality over quantity and so we can
measure backlinks going back into Moz we
can use moz's Link Explorer tool so
remember if I type in a domain Valley
fig I can get some metrics related
off-page SEO including my domain
Authority but more importantly I can see
what links are pointing to my site in
this case valleyfig.com so I can see
they're 575 link domains I can see
there's 7900 inbound links and so just
by clicking on that I can get an idea of
the types of websites that are linking
to my site and their domain Authority
and their spam score Google search
console so if you go back into search
console you can also just click on links
and we should be able to get an idea of
you know what website sites are linking
to our site and more importantly we want
to be able to see not only what sites
but what pages they're linked to
remember we want our backlinks pointing
to Interior Pages not necessarily the
home page so here I could see the top
link page for valleyfair.com it's slash
recipes so we want links pointing to our
interior page is not necessarily the
home page that's what's going to help
your performance your rankings for all
your pages not just your home page so
having quality back links pointing to
Interior Pages help boost the domain
Authority and the page Authority for
that particular page so again using Moz
link Explorer tool or using the links
report in search console are good
sources for you to identify backlinks so
when we look at these these reports we
want to look at the Domain authority of
these sites that are linking ours the
number of outbound links to the site or
specific pages on our site we want to be
able to look at the ratio of Link
distribution you know we want to be able
to look at how many follows and no
follows so most of this if not all of
these metrics are in Moz so if I go back
to Moz I can actually see you know which
ones pointing which ones are followed
the total quality of the link that's
pointing to our site again bam so Moz
link Explorer report tends to give us
all the information we need in order to
measure and get a sense of our backlinks
that help us with off-page SEO so there
are other tools out there there's hrefs
again search console there's other SEO
platforms out there that'll help you
measure backlinks let's get started with
keyword research so basically what we
want to do is Center our keywords just
like our website we want to Center our
keywords around or our content around
good keyword words so the videos on
YouTube are no different than the web
pages on our website so if we have
somebody who states YouTube is the
world's second most well well-known
engine well it is because it's right
behind Google it's not a search engine
per se it's a video platform but if it
was a search engine it'd probably be
second right behind Google so YouTube is
pretty popular majority people use
YouTube search every day to watch videos
on a number of different topics so they
can find these videos in Google but
because YouTube's so powerful and so
popular people go directly right into
YouTube for their searches and so the
whole idea behind YouTube being the
second most well-known search engine is
centered around keywords so if you have
the right keywords for your video then
the chances of you ranking higher
increases on YouTube so we're gonna
share with you a few easy ways to do
keyword research this is the the most
important step in getting your videos to
rank on YouTube just like for those of
you who watched any of the SEO videos we
produced at simply learn you know that
keyword research is so essential to
getting your web pages to rank on Google
well it's no different keyword research
and choosing the right keywords is just
as important for your videos as is for
your web pages so we're going to go into
a few things to do here to find the
right keywords so we have the search
suggestion you can look at your
competitors we have different tools we
can use some other factors involved in
Google itself so let's start talking
about some of these ways to really hone
in and do some good research on your
keywords to align them with your videos
the first thing is search suggest so
YouTube has a feature called
autocomplete so if you've done any
searches on Google it's very similar if
you're typing something in to YouTube
search then YouTube is going to suggest
other related popular keywords so let's
take a look at that if we go back to
YouTube for a second and I just type in
machine learning YouTube is going to
populate on the autocomplete in the
search bar some other popular keywords
that we can potentially use or in this
case if I Choose You Know machine
learning tutorial I'm going to see a
video about machine learning tutorial so
here you can see simply learns ranked
number one for machine learning tutorial
but there are other videos that show up
in my search result so we want to be
able to use the search suggestion box in
the search box field so when we're
typing in something new YouTube just
like on Google is going to give us those
suggestions so if we're focusing a video
on machine learning then you know we
have some ideas of some other keywords
that we could center around because
these are our popular keywords these are
key words that people are using to
search on YouTube so that's one
suggestion looking at competitors is
another suggestion so we could search
for keywords used by our competitors in
their video and title and description so
let me talk a little bit about that what
you want to do is you want to go to that
particular channel of your competitor so
when you go to your particular
competitors YouTube channel you want to
be able to click on the videos tab when
you click on the videos tab then you're
going to sort by most popular and then
what you could do is see a list of
videos and then when you look at a list
of videos you're going to choose a video
and then what you're going to do then is
take a look at the keywords used in the
title and description and then once you
do that you're going to have a list of
keywords that you can use yourself for
that video so for example let's go back
to YouTube so if I go to type in simply
learn here's our Channel page just by
clicking on simply learn I click on
videos ever wonder if there's so now I
can see all the videos ever wonder if
there's an easier way go back so here I
could see all the videos sort by most
popular once they do that then I can
choose a video this is the most popular
video right now for simply learn if I
click on that video it's automatically
going to start playing but what I could
do is simply just look at you know the
content description so just by clicking
show more I can see all the content that
align with this video that's one way to
do it is simply by looking at your
competitors now what you could also do
is look at the tags associated with the
particular video and so what you want to
do is you want to look at the HTML and
so that means looking at the page source
so just like web pages what YouTube does
is they look at meta tags so if you call
from SEO in order to get your pages to
rank you need to have a title tag and a
meta tag description so videos are no
different what we're doing for YouTube
is aligning certain keywords with the
video so if you take a look and do a
search for keywords by viewing the page
Source you're going to see all the
keywords associated with a particular
video so for example if I go back to
YouTube and I look at the page source of
a video Let's just say this video here
Facebook's ad tutorial I'm going to pull
up the page source and all I need to do
is control F and type in keywords and
now for that Facebook video I can see
all the keywords associated with the
video so you can see there's a lot of
different keywords we're aligning with
this video and so why do we want to do
that because we want you know our video
to show up for keywords that people may
type in and so if you use that YouTube
autocomplete it's going to give you
those ideas this most popular keywords
so if they're related align those
keywords with the video so here you can
see Facebook marketing Facebook ad
strategy Facebook ads for beginners so
forth and so on so there's a lot of
keywords we've aligned here with that
particular video you and again all you
need to do is look at the page source so
right clicking view page Source do a
control F for keywords and you'll be
able to see the keywords aligned so you
could do that for your competitors
videos as well so you can see what
keywords your competitors using for a
video that's most popular for their
Channel and is also ranking on YouTube
and on Google so using the autocomplete
gives you those keyword ideas looking at
your competitors videos also gives you
some other ideas for keywords that you
can align with a video that's relevant
that you want to rank for so let's look
at some other ideas here so you can
install plugins and there are plenty of
plugins available on the Chrome browser
that will help you see the video tags
associated with a particular video so a
couple of examples are vid IQ and
tubebuddy those are extensions that work
in Chrome and what they do is they give
you the exact tags that a particular
video is using so for example if I go
back here and I look at a video on
YouTube let's just say the machine
learning Basics video I have vid IQ
installed on my Chrome browser so just
by clicking on that vid IQ is going to
give me a lot of information about that
video you're just going to give me an
overview of their particular metrics
they're going to give me some other
information associated with Facebook
some engagement metrics really what I'm
interested in is those keywords so if I
scroll down a bit here I can see the
video tags associated with the machine
learning Basics video so vid IQ is
telling me is these keywords are
associated with this video and not only
does it show me what keywords are
associated I can also see where they
rank so for machine learning Basics this
particular video ranks number one if I
go down I could see what is machine
learning and how does it work I can see
it's rank number two here here I could
see machine learning algorithms it's
ranked number nine so I can get some
ideas of the types of keywords that are
being used as tags for that video
further down I can also see some Channel
tags but really this is the video tags
or the idea place I want to be able to
look to get an idea of the types of
keywords that are associated with the
video that are also ranking or not
ranking so that's another way for you to
really get an understanding of what
keywords to use of the particular video
so autocomplete you can look at the page
source of a competitors video or you can
use a Chrome extension in this case I'm
using vid IQ to give me some information
about the video tags for a particular
video so according to an industry study
using keywords and video tags will help
you rank well on YouTube so you have to
use keywords and video tags if you want
your video to rank there's been a lot of
studies YouTube is so pop popular and
videos are so prominent in today's world
where if you have videos and you're
going to upload them to YouTube then
associate the right keywords with those
videos so some important factors when we
look at keywords what we want to do is
look at search volume we want to look at
competition we want to look at relevancy
we want to look at the primary and
secondary keywords that we want to use
so well chosen keywords will help you
rank so we just gave you some ideas on
how to do some keyword research again
those ideas were really to use the
autocomplete on YouTube or Google
they're going to give you some popular
keywords you can look what your
competitors are doing by looking at the
page source and just looking at the
keywords that are aligned with that
video or you can use a third-party
extension in Chrome in my example I use
vid IQ that gave me the keywords
associated with that video so you have
ways to get the keywords so what we want
want to do is we want to make sure we
choose keywords with high search volume
they're going to drive more traffic to
your video however we want to balance it
out with keywords that have load
difficulty and are easier to rank for so
you don't want to choose something very
broad that's just going to be very
difficult to rank for and of course we
always want to go with relevancy so for
talking about machine learning Basics
then we want to choose keywords
associated with that and that's where
that autocomplete comes in handy because
what Google's going to do and YouTube's
going to do is give us keywords that are
very closely related to the video that
we're trying to optimize for and so we
have a number of different keywords at
our disposal that are relevant that we
can look to see if they have good volume
and low competition and so the whole
idea is we want to choose a keyword that
defines the nature of the content and
then what we want to do is support that
with secondary keywords so we want
keywords that are highly relevant to the
primary keyword so that's the way to go
about aligning your keywords you want
keywords that are high volume low
competition or relevant and you want to
choose that one keyword that is really
what the content's about and then those
secondary keywords that support the
primary so if you have a machine
learning video you can choose your
primary keyword as in this case the
machine learning Basics video so well
chosen keywords help you rank well on
YouTube just like the machine learning
Basics so if I go back to our video our
machine learning Basics video if I just
type in machine learning Basics I'll be
able to pull it up and so here it is if
I click on it I'm going to go to YouTube
and so here I can see this keyword we
know humans learn from is well aligned
because it's in the title it's in the
copy and it's a line is a keyword tagged
with the video so we know that that
keyword has good volume low competition
is relevant because that's what the
video is about the basics of machine
learning it's an introduction into
machine learning so instead of honing in
on just introduction I mean machine
learning primary keyword is machine
learning Basics and then we supported
that video with those secondary keywords
what is machine learning because
somebody who doesn't know machine
learning is probably going to type in
that keyword and then introduction to
machine learning is a good secondary
keyword because it's explaining the
basics of what machine learning is all
about so primary keyword machine
learning basic secondary keywords what
is machine learning an introduction to
machine learning so that's the whole
idea behind choosing keywords you want
that keyword that really is going to
define the content and then support that
with those secondary keywords so
remember when you're performing your
keyword research choose keywords for
your videos that Google shows on the
video results page so what I mean by
that is your video can get more views if
you rank on Google as well so the whole
idea is not necessarily to be found on
YouTube it's also to be found on Google
Google so if I go back to Google and I
just type in data science for beginners
and I type in videos then you could see
we're ranked number one so even if
you're not looking at the videos
clicking on the videos link on Google
search you can always just when you do a
search what Google's going to do is also
put in the videos here on par as part of
the search results so what they're going
to show you is the top videos that are
ranking for that particular keyword and
so we may not rank overall for data
science for beginners but we're ranked
number one in the videos category and so
somebody's looking for a video that's
important and you can see here that
these first two are ads so what Google
is doing is they're saying hey this is
so relevant this particular video for
the keyword query data science for
beginners that we're going to show it
above the organic listings even though
it's a video so the whole idea is to be
found on YouTube and Google because
you're increasing your visibility you're
increasing your chances of getting found
on both search platforms so according to
backlinko google Ranks videos with
keywords like how to tutorials so you
know a lot of the videos that you find
on YouTube are going to be instructional
based and so what Google's doing is
they're saying hey if somebody types in
how to or tutorial or an introduction to
anything that's going to signal to
Google that it's instructional it's
going to help you rank so when you
search for machine learning tutorial or
how to become a machine learning
engineer you're going to get results
related to that because if you look at
these examples we have machine learning
tutorial in our title or how to become a
machine learning engineer so keep that
in mind if you're creating a video and
it's educational in nature you know use
those key terms like how to and
tutorials in the video title because
that will help you rank so let's move
over now out to video title so we want
to use our Target keyword in the title
of the video and again we want to make
sure if it's educational to include that
keyword tutorial or how to so for every
video title YouTube has a limit of a
hundred characters so we really have to
pick and choose really wisely so if we
look at the video that we were focusing
on a couple of minutes ago so machine
learning Basics here we could see under
100 characters we have machine learning
Basics what is machine learning
introduction to machine learning and
then the brand name so that is the title
of this particular video so takes into
account the primary keyword the
secondary keywords and the title and it
also includes that really that key term
that really Google and YouTube like and
that's what is machine learning so it's
helping us Rank by having our keywords
in the title with that key phrase what
is okay so that's a good tidbit on
creating a good video title is to align
it with the right keywords your primary
and your secondary and so we want to use
those catchy words and numbers to gain
High click-through rates just like you
would on the title tag of your web page
we want to do the same with our video
title because the video titles what's
going to show up in search so if I go
back to you know search here we could
see you know data science tutorial data
science for beginners so we want to make
sure in this case you can see data signs
in five minutes so that was purposely
done so that hey I don't have time to
watch a video I only have a couple
minutes data science in five minutes
okay great I'm going to click on the
video and now I have an opportunity to
watch something and learn something
under five minutes so choosing the right
words in your video title is going to
help you get that click-through rate up
remember clicked array is clicks divided
by Impressions and an impression is how
many times your video shows up up and
the search results on YouTube or Google
so we want to keep our click-through
rate high and in order to do that we
want to be able to write some really
good title tags for our video so use
catchy words like a number or how to or
what is because that's going to resonate
with people when they're searching now
for the description what we want to do
is we want to use the target word at the
beginning of the description the title
and the tags itself so if I go back to
my video here machine learning Basics we
know it's in the video title and right
off the bat if I look at the description
of the video here I can see this machine
learning Basics video will help you
understand what is machine learning so
our primary keyword is in the first
sentence right in the introductory of
the description and so that's going to
bode well for optimizing our video the
description length is 5 000 characters
so we have a lot of characters to work
with so if I go back to my video I click
show more we have a lot of characters to
really describe what the video is about
okay there's no shortage no shortage of
including keywords into the content so
you have 5 000 characters go ahead and
see if you can work in naturally your
keywords but one of the key tips here is
just make sure that first sentence
starts out with that keyword that's a
good tip of course you always want to
make it sound natural as possible you
don't want to stuff it with keywords at
the same time work them in naturally
work in your keywords naturally and then
include hashtags in your description to
help the audience find your video is
easily so if I go back here you know we
want to be able to include hashtags so
hashtags it's like anything else you
would use on social media it just
signals to the end user hey this is what
the video is all about and if I go ahead
and type in that keyword then it's our
video has a better chance because it's a
line line with that hashtag and then
there's Target keywords and LSI keywords
latent semantic indexing keywords we
want to be able to use those keywords as
Target keywords with our video so if you
recall the example I gave a few minutes
ago we used the Facebook ads tutorial as
our example here I could see all the
target keywords associated with that
particular video so don't be afraid to
use those LSI related keywords meaning
keywords that are related to the content
use them as Target keywords with the
video so between your LSI keywords
Target keywords and then using our
primary and secondary keyword in the
title tag using our primary and
secondary keyword in the description and
then using hashtags in the description
the combination of all of that if we
chose the right keyword then we should
find that our video will eventually rank
on YouTube so just just doing these
small tidbits with our keywords really
help get our video to rank so at the end
of the day we want to be able to use the
tools available to Us YouTube Itself by
looking at our competitors those
extensions like vid IQ the autocomplete
to really find our good keywords and
then incorporating those keywords into
you know the title tag the description
as Target keywords hashtags we should
really be off and running with our video
on YouTube so at simply learn if I go to
YouTube and I just type in machine
learning you could see we're right here
is the first organic video on YouTube
for machine learning if I jump over to
Google and I type in machine learning
Basics you can see where number or
number one for machine learning Basics
under videos if I click on all we're
also ranked here as well under the video
section on organic search results
another example data science for
beginners we ranked number one for that
if I look at another keyword data
science interview questions okay we're
ranked number two for that so we're
ranking for a lot of videos and why are
we ranking for a lot of different
content and videos on Google Search and
on YouTube well we put a lot of work in
behind the scenes of creating the video
and that's what we want to show you so
part of that has a lot to do with you
know how our audience engages and sees
our video so for example we're looking
at a machine learning Basics video here
and we can see that it has over 221 000
subscribers for this video 234
000 views we've had over 2 000 people
like the video and we have had over 270
plus comment on the video so when we get
our videos to rank then we can see
there's a lot of Engagement and so
that's the whole idea is when you do a
video and you want to show up on YouTube
you want people to enjoy you want people
to share it you want people to like like
it you want people to comment on that
and that's part of the whole ecosystem
of YouTube It's you know we're going to
show you behind the scenes of what it
takes to get your videos to rank and
then we're going to show you some of the
metrics involved with some of these
videos to help you stay ranking so
without further Ado let's go into how to
get your videos to rank on YouTube so
we're going to talk about keyword
research for YouTube we're going to talk
about some ways to create high quality
videos to the importance of user
engagement just as I showed you with the
machine learning Basics video all the
shares all the commenting all the views
and subscriptions then we're going to
get into how to promote your content and
then we're going to just review a little
checklist for you and sum it all up so
let's get started with keyword research
so basically what we want to do is
Center our keywords just like our
website we want to Center our keywords
around or our content around good
keywords so the videos on YouTube are no
different than the web pages on our our
website so if we have somebody who
states YouTube is the world's second
most well well-known engine well it is
because it's right behind Google it's
not a search engine per se it's a video
platform but if it was a search engine
it'd probably be second right behind
Google so YouTube is pretty popular
majority people use YouTube search every
day to watch videos on a number of
different topics so they can find these
videos in Google but because YouTube's
so powerful and so popular people go
directly right into YouTube for their
searches and so the whole idea behind
YouTube being the second most well-known
search engine is centered around
keywords so if you have the right
keywords for your video then the chances
of you ranking higher increases on
YouTube so we're gonna share with you a
few easy ways to do keyword research
this is the most important step in
getting your videos to rank on YouTube
just like for those of you who watched
any of the SEO videos we produced it at
simply learn you know that keyword
research is so essential to getting your
web pages to rank on Google well it's no
different keyword research and choosing
the right keywords is just as important
for your videos as is for your web pages
so we're going to go into a few things
to do here to find the right keywords so
we have the search suggestion you can
look at your competitors we have
different tools we can use some other
factors involved in Google itself so
let's start talking about some of these
ways to really hone in and do some good
research on your keywords to align them
with your videos so first thing is
search suggest so YouTube has a feature
called autocomplete so if you've done
any searches on Google it's very similar
if you're typing something in to YouTube
search then YouTube is going to suggest
other related popular keywords so let's
take a look look at that if we go back
to YouTube for a second and I just type
in machine learning YouTube is going to
populate on the autocomplete in the
search bar some other popular keywords
that we can potentially use or in this
case if I Choose You Know machine
learning tutorial I'm going to see a
video about machine learning tutorial so
here you can see simply learns ranked
number one from a machine learning
tutorial but there are other videos that
show up in my search result so we want
to be able to use the search suggestion
box in the search box field so when
we're typing in something you know
YouTube just like on Google is going to
give us those suggestions so if we're
focusing a video on machine learning
then you know we have some ideas of some
other keywords that we could center
around because these are are popular
keywords these are key words that people
are using to search on YouTube so that's
one suggestion looking at competitors is
another suggestion so we could search
for key words used by our competitors in
their video and title and description so
let me talk a little bit about that what
you want to do is you want to go to that
particular channel of your competitor so
when you go to your particular
competitors YouTube channel you want to
be able to click on the videos tab when
you click on the videos tab then you're
going to sort by most popular and then
what you could do is see a list of
videos and then when you look at a list
of videos you're going to choose a video
and then what you're going to do then is
take a look at the keywords used in the
title description and then once you do
that you're going to have a list of
keywords that you can use yourself for
that video so for example let's go back
to YouTube so if I go to type in simply
learn here's our Channel page just by
clicking on simply learn I click on
videos ever wonder if there's so now I
can see all the videos I wonder if
there's an easier way go back so here I
can see all the videos sort by most
popular once they do that that then I
could choose a video this is the most
popular video right now for simply learn
if I click on that video it's
automatically going to start playing but
what I could do is simply just look at
you know the content description so just
by clicking show more I can see all the
content that align with this video
that's one way to do it is simply by
looking at your competitors now what you
could also do is look at the tags
associated with the particular video and
so what you want to do is you want to
look at the HTML and so that means
looking at the page source so just like
web pages what YouTube does is they look
at meta tags so if you call from SEO in
order to get your pages to rank you need
to have a title tag and a meta tag
description so videos are no different
what we're doing for YouTube is aligning
certain keywords with the video so if
you take a look and do a search for
keywords by viewing the page source
you're going to see all the keywords
associated with a particular video so
for example if I go back to YouTube and
I look at the page source of a video
Let's just say this video here
Facebook's ad tutorial I'm going to pull
up the page source and all I need to do
is control F and type in keywords and
now for that Facebook video I can see
all the keywords associated with the
video so you can see there's a lot of
different keywords we're aligning with
this video and so why do we want to do
that because we want you know our video
to show up for keywords that people may
type in and so if you use that YouTube
autocomplete it's going to give you
those ideas this most popular keywords
so if they're related align those
keywords with the video so here you can
see Facebook marketing Facebook ad
strategy Facebook ads for beginners so
forth and so on so there's a lot of
keywords we've aligned here with that
particular video and again all you need
to do is look at the page source so so
right clicking view page Source do a
control F for keywords and you'll be
able to see the keywords aligned so you
could do that for your competitors
videos as well so you can see what
keywords your competitors using for a
video that's most popular for their
Channel and is also ranking on YouTube
and on Google so using the autocomplete
gives you those keyword ideas looking at
your competitors videos also gives you
some other ideas for keywords that you
can align with a video that's relevant
that you want to rank for so let's look
at some other ideas here so you can
install plugins and there are plenty of
plugins available on the Chrome browser
that will help you see the video tags
associated with a particular video so a
couple of examples are vid IQ and
tubebuddy those are extensions that work
in Chrome and what they do is they give
you the exact tags that a particular
video is using so for example if I go
back here and I look at a video on
YouTube let's just say the machine
learning Basics video I have vid IQ
installed on my Chrome browser so just
by clicking on that vid IQ is going to
give me a lot of information about that
video you're just going to give me an
overview of their particular metrics
they're going to give me some other
information associated with Facebook
some engagement metrics really what I'm
interested in is those keywords so if I
scroll down a bit here I can see the
video tags associated with the machine
learning Basics video so vid IQ is
telling me is these keywords are
associated with this video and not only
does it show me what keywords are
associated I can also see where they
rank so for machine learning Basics this
particular video ranks number one if I
go down I could see what is machine
learning and how does it work I can see
it's rank number two here I could see
machine learning algorithms it's ranked
number nine so I can get some ideas of
the types of keywords that are being
used as tags for that video further down
I can also see some Channel tags but
really this is the video tags or the
idea place I want to be able to look to
get an idea of the types of keywords
that are associated with the video that
are also ranking or not ranking so
that's another way for you to really get
an understanding of what keywords to use
at the particular video so autocomplete
you can look at the page source of a
competitors video or you can use a
Chrome extension in this case I'm using
vid IQ to give me some information about
the video tags for a particular video so
according to an industry study using
keywords and video tags will help you
rank well on YouTube so you have to use
keywords and video tags if you want your
video to rank there's been a lot of
studies YouTube is so popular and videos
are so prominent in today's world where
if you have videos and you're going to
upload them to YouTube then associate
the right keywords with those videos so
some important factors when we look at
keywords what we want to do is look at
search volume we want to look at
competition we want to look at relevancy
we want to look at the primary and
secondary keywords that we want to use
so well chosen keywords will help you
rank so we just gave you some ideas on
how to do some keyword research again
those ideas were really to use the
autocomplete on YouTube or Google
they're going to give you some popular
keywords you can look what your
competitors are doing by looking at the
page source and just looking at the
keywords that are aligned with that
video or you can use a third-party
extension in Chrome in my example I use
vid IQ that gave me the keywords
associated with that video so you have
ways to get the keywords so what we want
to do is we want to make sure we choose
keywords with high search volume they're
going to drive more traffic to your
video however we want to balance it out
with keywords that have load difficulty
and are easier to rank for so you don't
want to choose something very broad
that's just going to be very difficult
to rank for and of course we always want
to go with relevancy so for talking
about machine learning Basics then we
want to choose keywords associated with
that and that's where that autocomplete
comes in handy because what Google's
going to do and YouTube's going to do is
give us keywords that are very closely
related to the video that we're trying
to optimize for and so we have a number
of different keywords that are disposal
that are relevant that we can look to
see if they have good volume and low
competition and so the whole idea is we
want to choose a keyword that defines
the nature of the content and then what
we want to do is support that with
secondary keywords so we want keywords
that are highly relevant to the primary
keyword so that's the way to go about
aligning your keywords you want keyword
words that are high volume low
competition or relevant and you want to
choose that one keyword that is really
what the content's about and then
there's secondary keywords that support
the primary so if you have a machine
learning video you can choose your
primary keyword as in this case the
machine learning Basics video so well
chosen keywords help you rank well on
YouTube just like the machine learning
Basics so if I go back to our video our
machine learning Basics video if I just
type in machine learning Basics I'll be
able to pull it up and so here it is if
I click on it I'm going to go to YouTube
and so here I can see this keyword we
know humans learn from is well aligned
because it's in the title it's in the
copy and it's a line is a keyword tagged
with the video so we know that that
keyword has good volume low competition
is relevant because that's what the
video is about the basics of machine
learning it's an introduction to machine
learning so instead of honing in on just
introduction and machine learning
primary keyword is machine learning
Basics and then we supported that video
with those secondary keywords what is
machine learning because somebody who
doesn't know machine learning is
probably going to type in that keyword
and then introduction to machine
learning is a good secondary keyword
because it's explaining the basics of
what machine learning is all about so
primary keyword machine learning basic
secondary keywords what is machine
learning and introduction to machine
learning so that's the whole idea behind
choosing keywords you want that keyword
that really is going to define the
content and then support that with those
secondary keywords so remember when
you're performing your keyword research
choose keywords for your videos that
Google shows on the video results page
so what I mean by that is your video can
get more views if you rank on Google as
well so the whole idea is not
necessarily to be found on YouTube it's
also to be found on Google so if I go
back to Google and I just type in data
science for beginners and I type in
videos then you could see we're ranked
number one so even if you're not looking
at the videos clicking on the videos
link on Google search you can always
just when you do a search what Google's
going to do is also put in the videos
here on par as part of the search
results so what they're going to show
you is the top videos that are ranking
for that particular keyword and so we
may not rank overall for data science
for beginners but we're ranked number
one in the videos category and so if
somebody's looking for a video that's
important and you can see here that
these first two are ads so what Google
is doing is they're saying hey this is
so relevant this particular video for
the keyword query data science for
beginners that we're going to show it
above the organic listings even though
it's a video so the whole idea is to be
found on YouTube and Google because
you're increasing your visibility you're
increasing your chances of getting found
on both search platforms so according to
backlinko google Ranks videos with
keywords like how to tutorials so you
know a lot of the videos that you find
on YouTube aren't going to be
instructional based and so what Google's
doing is they're saying hey if somebody
types in how to or tutorial or an
introduction to anything that's going to
signal to Google that it's instructional
it's going to help you rank so when you
search for machine learning tutorial or
how to become a machine learning
engineer you're going to get results
related to that because if you look at
these examples we have machine learning
tutorial in our title or how to become a
machine learning engineer so keep that
in mind if you're creating a video and
it's educational in nature you know use
those key terms like how to and
tutorials in the video title because
that will help you rank so let's move
over now to video title so we want to
use our Target keyword word in the title
of the video and again we want to make
sure if it's educational to include that
keyword tutorial or how to so for every
video title YouTube has a limit of 100
characters so we really have to pick and
choose really wisely so if we look at
the video that we were focusing on a
couple minutes ago so machine learning
Basics here we could see under 100
characters we have machine learning
Basics what is machine learning
introduction to machine learning and
then the brand name so that is the title
of this particular video so it takes
into account the primary keyword the
secondary keywords and the title and it
also includes that really the key term
that really Google and YouTube like and
that's what is machine learning so it's
helping us Rank by having our keywords
in the title with that key phrase what
is okay so that's a good tidbit on
creating a good video title is to lie
line it with the right keywords your
primary and your secondary and so we
want to use those catchy words and
numbers to gain High click-through rates
just like you would on the title tag of
your web page we want to do the same
with our video title because the video
titles what's going to show up in search
so if I go back to you know search here
we could see you know data science
tutorial data science for beginners so
we want to make sure in this case you
can see data science in five minutes so
that was purposely done so that hey I
don't have time to watch a video I only
have a couple minutes data science in
five minutes okay great I'm going to
click on the video and now I have an
opportunity to watch something and learn
something under five minutes so choosing
the right words in your video title is
going to help you get that click-through
rate up remember clicked array is clicks
divided by Impressions and an impression
is how many times your video shows up
and the search results on YouTube or
Google so we want to keep our or
click-through rate high and in order to
do that we want to be able to write some
really good title tags for our video so
use catchy words like a number or how to
or what is because that's going to
resonate with people when they're
searching now for the description what
we want to do is we want to use the
target word at the beginning of the
description the title and the tags
itself so if I go back to my video here
machine learning Basics we know it's in
the video title and right off the bat if
I look at the description of the video
here I can see this machine learning
Basics video will help you understand
what is machine learning so our primary
keyword is in the first sentence right
in the introductory of the description
and so that's going to bode well for
optimizing our video the description
length is 5 000 characters so we have a
lot of characters to work with so if I
go back to my video I click show more we
have a lot of characters to to really
describe what the video is about okay
there's no shortage no shortage of
including keywords into the content so
you have 5 000 characters go ahead and
see if you can work in naturally your
keywords but one of the key tips here is
just make sure that first sentence
starts out with that keyword that's a
good tip of course you always want to
make it sound natural as possible you
don't want to stuff it with keywords at
the same time work them in naturally
work in your keywords naturally and then
include hashtags in your description to
help the audience find your video is
easily so if I go back here you know we
want to be able to include hashtags so
hashtags it's like anything else you
would use on social media it just
signals to the end user hey this is what
the video is all about and if I go ahead
and type in that keyword then it's our
video has a better chance because it's a
line with that hashtag and then there's
Target keywords and LSi AI keywords
latent semantic indexing keywords we
want to be able to use those keywords as
Target keywords with our video so if you
recall the example I gave a few minutes
ago we used the Facebook ads tutorial as
our example here I could see all the
target keywords associated with that
particular video so don't be afraid to
use those LSI related keywords meaning
keywords that are related to the content
use them as Target keywords with the
video so between your LSI keywords
Target keywords and then using our
primary and secondary keyword in the
title tag using our primary and
secondary keyword in the description and
then using hashtags in the description
the combination of all of that if we
chose the right keyword then we should
find that our video will eventually rank
on YouTube so just doing these small
tidbits with our keywords really help
get our video to rank so at the end of
the day we want to be able to use the
tools available to Us YouTube Itself by
looking at our competitors those
extensions like vid IQ the autocomplete
to really find our good keywords and
then incorporating those keywords into
you know the title tag the description
as Target keywords hashtags we should
really be off and running with our video
on YouTube that's our turn our attention
to creating high quality videos and some
of the best practices around that so
along with everything we mentioned about
choosing the right keywords we always
need to keep in mind that the videos we
create need to be of high quality so the
content itself in addition to the
keywords is a primary factor in ranking
so in order to have keywords we need to
have content and in order to rank we
need to have you know good content so
let's talk a little bit about creating
content and what's involved with that
and what we really mean by high quality
videos so if you have a video content
that is not informative or irrelevant to
the topic it won't rank so that's just
common sense so you need to create
content that's aligned with the topic
obviously and then that way you have
keywords that are aligned with the
content so but if you have content it
really isn't aligned with the topic then
you're not going to rank no matter how
much you've optimized that video so just
keep that in mind so there's a couple of
things we want to look at here so high
quality content is determined by really
two metrics so if we're not sure about
how good our content is and how good of
high quality video we created we want to
look at audience retention and user
engagement so audience retention is
simply the percentage length of your
video that the audience has watched It's
the percentage your audience has watched
so focusing on audience retention is
important for people who want their
videos to rank high so if you want to
rank you need to optimize for the
keywords but got to keep in mind content
so content is related to audience
retention and user engagement so
audience retention percentage length
your video of your video that the
audience has watched and for example it
can be both absolute in minutes or
percentages so audience retention can be
the average view duration or percentage
of the audience that watched then we
have user engagement so yours engagement
of viewers who are engaged with your
content and so that means they're either
sharing it subscribing commenting or
liking so those are all forms of
Engagement so the percentage of users
who watched or how long they watched
versus engagement or in combination with
engagement are two factors for ranking
so let's talk about some tips for
creating high quality videos so we want
to publish longer videos and so so what
do we mean behind longer videos so
what's the reason for longer videos
let's just suppose we have two videos
one shorter in length and one longer in
length first video is 15 minutes long
the second video is seven minutes long
so on average if you viewers watch about
40 of both videos then video x which is
15 teams long will have more than twice
the watch time of the video that's seven
minutes long so remember duration we
want you know people to watch our videos
longer so if the video is longer in
length if it's 40 then it's gonna have a
longer audience engagement audience
retention so that's one of the reasons
you know from a metric standpoint so
even when viewers watch you know both
videos the time is going to differ so we
want to take into account longer videos
for primarily that region is because you
know it gives an end user an opportunity
to watch the video longer and then it's
going to help us rank our videos longer
so when we talk about watch time so if
one video has higher watch time than the
other watch time is just the number of
views times the average view duration so
another tip is we want to plan our video
script so we want to keep the content
organized my recognition is you know
create an outline first and once you
create an outline of how the video is
going to flow then start populating with
content and so to me that's how you can
keep the flow organized okay is really
with an outline starting out with it on
how there's no videos are no different
than say a presentation if you've done a
PowerPoint presentation you always want
to start out doing an outline and then
we want to upload a high resolution
videos high resolution we don't want to
create videos that you know are small
resolution like say you know 400 by 400
resolution or something you know
something really small we want to create
something a very high res so according
to back or link Oaks more than 50 of
videos on the first page of YouTube are
high definition so high definition
videos of higher quality are going to be
shown on the first page of YouTube more
often than not so high resolution videos
organizing the content publishing longer
videos are examples of of creating high
quality video we also want to make sure
that content is relevant to the title so
if we're talking about machine learning
Basics you know obviously the content is
going to be about you know intro to
machine learning or what is machine
learning and then the title should
reflect that content so aligning the
title sets the expectation for the end
user so when they see a title what is
machine learning then when they watch
the video they're expecting to learn
about machine learning and what it is so
if it meets expectations then the
chances are that person who's watching
the video is going to watch it longer
and that means it's going to fulfill the
viewers requirements and when you align
everything accordingly keywords titles
content then at the end of the day the
user is going to watch it and the more
they watch it the higher the engagement
the higher the engagement the better
chance you have to rank some other tips
that you could use to create high
quality videos so we want to be able to
you know use examples to clarify our
content so you don't be afraid to go
into another screen like I am if I want
to I'm talking about videos jump into
the machine learning Basics video which
I've done throughout this session I can
simply do that by keeping the user
engaged here this video is about machine
learning Basics well the titles online
with the video we made sure that we have
a nice description about what the video
is about and we're aligning the
expectations so not only that I'm
showing you example within the video
itself so we want to use examples
throughout your video to keep the user
engaged it will also help clarify what
you're trying to express in the video
itself so we want to make it visually
appealing so visually appealing means
imagery or examples in the video and
then when we talk about imagery you know
you want to use good images in your
video so use public domain sites that
are available able to like Shutterstock
or flat icon I mean there are plenty of
those sites out there so feel free to
use any one of those sites to use high
quality images in your video give more
information to your audience okay giving
maximum relevant information can help
gain more views and so when we talk
about more information again it goes
back to you know the examples you use
there's no should be no shortage of
examples here description use all 5 000
characters at your disposal imagery we
want to build up as much information as
you can in the video itself to keep the
end user the viewer engaged we also want
to create original content so always
create original content you could
certainly get ideas from YouTube if you
want to create a video about machine
learning see what else has already been
done do searches on YouTube itself but
you know when you're going to create a
video yeah you can create another video
about what is machine learning but just
make sure it has your own take on it
you're the subject matter expert when
creating the video create it with your
own original content have high audio
quality and video effects so just like
you see here on this video we have
effects in it and the audio is of high
quality meaning no background noise no
Distortion and we want to be able to
speak clearly in the video so you want
to speak clearly loudly concise just as
I'm trying to do now so that you can
understand what I'm trying to say or
what the viewer is trying to to
understand when they're watching the
video so watching and listening are two
of the components and you want to make
sure both of our high quality avoid
distractions we don't want to pause you
don't want to ramble on a particular
Point too long we want to keep users
engaged so you always want to move from
one point to the other intermix it with
examples those are ways to keep the
users engaged we want to include
transcripts or subtitles for your video
so transcripts is just more content
that's all line with the video and the
search engines will be able to pick up
that content and help your video rank so
to me that's a key component to creating
a good video is having the necessary
content that go along with the video
that outline I referenced earlier in
terms of organization you always want to
have a Content outline so what topics
are you going to cover in the video
that's why you need the outline to point
that out confirm that before you
actually start creating the video okay
focus on the initial 15 seconds so
that's key you know somebody's going to
click the play button of your video and
if you don't catch them in the first 15
seconds then they're likely going to
pause the video or just go ahead and
close it out altogether so you want to
be able to capture somebody's attention
right off the bat and even before they
click on that play button you want to
make sure again you're exceeding
expectations that title is aligned with
the content so in your first 15 seconds
it basically needs to be catchy but also
setting the X expectation of what the
user is expecting so in this example
here we want to pay close attention to
the first 15 seconds that's when viewers
are most likely to drop off so we can
look at audience retention and YouTube
so use the options above the graph to
view absolute audience retention or
relative audience retention so audience
retention is basically how many views a
video received and the percentage of the
total number of video views and that
includes every moment of the video as a
percentage so we'll show you an example
of what that looks like so here if we go
to the machine learning Basics video we
can look at the audience retention
report and this is since it's been
uploaded the lifetime audience retention
so here we can see a nice graph the
percentage of people who viewed it and
how long they viewed it so in percentage
so here for example I can see you know
43 44 watch the video for at least two
minutes here I can see 28.6 percent wash
it for six minutes plus so that's the
audience retention it gives us an idea
in terms of percentage how many people
or percentage of people watch the video
at what length so that's audience
retention so we want to keep that number
high at the very initial stage of the
video and we want to keep it high
throughout and that's why you always
want to create high quality content
using those examples using imagery
making it organized content not pausing
you know going from one point to the
other those are all best practices to
keep the viewer engaged and then we want
to add resources from well-known sites
so throughout this video we've used
backlinko there are other sources we've
used so if you have a source go ahead
and put it in your video to add
credibility and then we want to use
cards to your videos so this cards is
basically a feature that recommends
relevant videos to your audience so in
addition to machine learning Basics
there could be other videos about
machine learning that we can recommend
or use two can recommend to the audience
to set up end screens you want to make
sure that with end screens you can use
relevant videos to your audience towards
the end of your video so you can
recommend relevant videos towards the
end of your video you can also create
playlists so this is a feature that
keeps your audience engaged with
relevant content by Auto playing the
next video so if you enable this feature
it's going to go from one video to
another pattern interrupts keep the
audience engaged so basically it allows
for your audience to stay within one
video without having any interruptions
involved and so going back to the did
you know audience retention report helps
you analyze how well your videos are
engaging to the audience so what do we
mean by that well if I go back again to
my audience retention report how
engaging was it well I could see 42
percent 43 percent watched it on average
of 3 minutes and 21 seconds so to me
that's pretty good of course we always
want a hundred percent of the video the
video is seven minutes long if almost
half of our audience saw over half of
the video then I would say that's pretty
good people were engaged so audience
retention just is a good report to start
looking at to help you understand how
engaging is my video and if your video
is not engaging you know you can always
go back and edit it or fix it or tweak
it so remember the average view duration
for all videos and top performing videos
listed by all time we can look at that
information as well in addition we can
look at demographics so we can get an
overview of the age gender and location
and we can look at playback locations
report and what the playback locations
report does is it helps us determine the
platforms where our videos are being
streamed from within YouTube look at the
traffic sources where did the viewers
come from devices did they look on
mobile or tablet and so if there's any
doubts you know if you have any
questions please drop a comment below
but especially if you have any doubts on
the metrics so if we go back into
YouTube we can look at analytics and if
we're looking at analytics we can see
more and then this is going to show us
everything we need to see from device
type so if I click on more I can see my
playback location so this will show me
where the video is watched it was on a
watch page or a channel page I could see
the traffic sources I could see the
gender and age so if I click on the
viewer age report I can see the
percentage of views by age so I can get
a lot of information
about my video and how it's performed
who's watched it what they've done with
it where they come from all the
information they need to know okay so
it's all within YouTube analytics so
again if you have any questions about
that you know just drop a comment below
especially if you're new to YouTube you
may have some questions but just know
that every video you published to
YouTube high quality align with your
keywords you're going to be able to view
the metrics by looking at YouTube
analytics so let's talk about the
importance of user engagement so
engagement is as we mentioned important
because basically we can't rank without
engagement our videos won't rank unless
we have engagement so that's why it's
important so engagement is somebody
liking the video commenting sharing it
or subscribing each one of these is
important to ranking so yes you need to
line keywords yes you need to have high
quality content so when you do both of
those and you upload your video then
it's up to the viewer and so the hard
work that you put out for the video is
hopefully going to pay dividends with
engagement so you want people to do one
of these four okay so let's talk about
what that means so how do I get
engagement so we already talked about
creating engaging content so there are a
lot of tips to creating engaging content
and so according to wordstream if your
content is entertaining then over three
quarters of the users are going to share
it so that's part of keeping uh users
engaged is keeping it entertaining is
part of getting a high quality video so
remember on that high quality video when
we say entertaining the audio portion
has a lot to do with it examples has a
lot to do with it quality of the video
itself has a lot to do with it so a lot
of components so all those components on
a high quality video are going to lead
to engagement so parts of what you could
do in your videos is conduct a quiz so
meaning the quiz itself is a way to keep
people engaged in your video so that
also help you get some more comments so
according to backlinku video comments
help and rank in your video higher so
just as I mentioned the last segment
about YouTube analytics and all the
different different reports available on
YouTube hey if you have questions on
those just go ahead and add a comment so
that's a way to entice your users or
your viewers to add comments is if they
have questions because you know with
videos you're not going to be able to
cover every detail or every minute
detail about a particular topic you can
only cover in some cases the topic at a
high level so users are going to have
comments or questions naturally and so
the comment section is a good way to
remind viewers hey if you have a
question or comment go ahead and put in
the comment section because that will
lend to engagement as well so we want to
add sources from high quality websites
that'll help with engagement okay use
humor in your video we want to be able
to basically you know make it human
based we don't want to be robots so we
want to be able to sound like you know
we know what we're talking about but at
the same time talk to the viewer not
know necessarily at the viewer or
looking the other way and just going
through the motions so adding humor
adding personality never hurts at the
end of the day we are all human adding
that clear call to action at the end of
the video will also lead to engagement
so if we win the video with hey leave
your comments on this video or hey feel
free to share this video with colleagues
who are interested then that's a call to
action that's likely going to lead to
more engagement reply to your comments
as well so if you have comments we
always want to reply to them likely
those comments are going to be questions
because again as I mentioned even in
this video about how to rank your videos
on YouTube okay there's a lot of
information and a lot of information
sometimes doesn't get covered in its
entirety and so we want to make sure
that if we miss something because we're
only human that we're able to respond in
the form of an answer to a question that
somebody leaves in the comments section
so more comments also lead to higher
rankings because it's engagement so when
you're getting high engagement and your
video starts to rank well you know
you're going to start feeling really
good and what is that going to do look
at that feel good is going to lead to
confidence which in turn is going to
probably lead to more videos and that's
exactly what we do at simply learn I
mean we're in the education business but
we're in it to not only educate but
making sure that our videos are shown to
as many people as possible so that we
can educate as many people as possible
so it's all it's contagious so getting
ranked feels good and then once you get
ranked then you know you probably have
good engagement okay let's talk about
how to promote your content so once
you've done all the hard work getting
your video done high quality content
optimized with keywords and then publish
to YouTube we want to let everybody in
the world know about it right so we want
to promote it we've done all the work we
want to promote it now so is it
necessary to promote it I would say yes
because once your video is published
fish you want to reach out you want to
reach out to your audience not
necessarily on YouTube but on different
platforms so if you're active on
Facebook or Twitter that's an
opportunity for you to post or tweet
something about the new video so when we
say different platforms I am talking
about you know social media platforms so
it depends on what you're active on so
if you're active on Facebook yeah go
ahead and post some of you're active on
Twitter go ahead and tweet something it
could be you know on LinkedIn group if
you're part of a LinkedIn group about
you know machine learning then go ahead
and post something to that group to
promote the video so that's going to
help Drive traffic to the video and then
help with engagement so we want to
engage with our audience on those social
media sites so it really depends on what
you're active on so if you have a large
following on Twitter then go ahead and
you know share that YouTube video link
on Twitter with the Tweet that's going
to drive traffic from Twitter to YouTube
Remember you know you're going to be
able to see audience engagement or
retention by getting people to watch the
video so you're going to be able to see
right away by promoting the video and
driving traffic to the video how
engaging it is remember the more people
you have watched the video the more
engaging it becomes the better it's
going to rank so it's an ecosystem and
promoting your content is part of that
ecosystem so it all starts with social
media if you're active on whatever
platform that is go ahead and promote it
so you can also look at you know content
based social media sites or social media
content based platforms like Reddit or
Flickr for example so you can
participate in a forum discussion on
Reddit so in this example here it's
about machine learning so we want to be
able to post something about machine
learning with the link to our video so
we can also go to content-based sites
that are q a uh related like quora for
example Cora is a really good site where
you know if you go there post
information about machine learning or
the basics of machine learning with the
link back to the video it's going to
help because not only is it going to
drive traffic but it's going to signal
to Google hey you get a lot of traffic
coming from Cora this is going to bode
well for this video in terms of ranking
so here's an example you know if you
find a question that you can post on
core then you're going to get people to
click on your video and respond
accordingly on quora or you can act as
the person responding to a question
that's already there so somebody already
asked a question about what is machine
learning you can respond with your video
as the answer so you can just simply
embed your video URL as part of your
answer that'll help Drive traffic so you
can also create your own blog and embed
your video so in the case of machine
learning here we have an example machine
learning what is it and why it matters
so this goes nicely with the video so
here you can see the person the off
author of this blog went ahead and
embedded the relevant video in the blog
post so they play off one another nicely
you can also opt in for influencer
marketing meaning hey you can reach out
to somebody in this example here you
know Katie nuggets posted information
about machine learning so in this case
why choose machine learning as a career
well they got information and then what
do they do they went ahead and embedded
the video about machine learning Basics
and so working with you know influencers
in a particular category or topic will
help Drive traffic to the video you can
also create a YouTube playlist so
playlists tend to rank high in YouTube
searches so if you find yourself doing a
lot of videos we'll go ahead and you
know go to your channel and simply on
your channel you can go ahead and create
playlists so when you create playlists
basically what you're doing is you're
organizing the content into different
playlists no different than say the
music you have set up on your you know
your iPhone or iPad or or iPod whatever
it is you're using so you're just
creating different videos in a
particular category and it YouTube likes
it it's organized it's going to help you
get your videos found quicker and easier
on YouTube Itself by putting your videos
in a playlist so here you could see we
have entire playlist on machine learning
trending Technologies cloud computing
Big Data digital marketing project
management so a lot of different
playlists very organized if somebody
goes to the channel they're going to be
able to go to the playlist that's
interesting to them and see all the
videos there so it allows not only the
end user to find what they're looking
for but it's good for YouTube because
YouTube likes those playlists so we want
to engage our Audience by posting your
video link on a community page so you
could do that within YouTube and you can
prefer to link your YouTube channel in
your email so you can also do that so
for example if I go back to YouTube and
I'm looking at a YouTube video you know
I can always Click Share so here I'm
gonna get a particular URL that's
associated with the video and I can just
embed that so I can embed the whole
thing in my email I can embed it on a
web page or a blog post so just by
clicking share I can also immediately
share it onto the social media platforms
that we mentioned Facebook LinkedIn
Reddit okay Tumblr so there's a lot of
ways to embed the video not just not a
blog post or influencer blog post but in
our email and on social media as well so
here's an example of what we can do with
the YouTube discussion so we can also
bookmark the video on a popular
bookmarking site you know like stumbled
upon or read it or you know there's lots
of other ones out there so there's
plenty of sites that you'll be able to
go to and bookmark Mark that content so
that people can find it and you can
always opt for backlinks so that means
that hey if there's a blogger out there
that blogs about machine learning you
can always you know ask that blogger to
create a link back to the video and you
could reciprocate do the same thing so
that helps increase the authority of the
video so a lot of things you could do to
promote your video so let's do a quick
review on everything we talked about in
terms of ranking your video on YouTube
it all starts with the keywords so we
want to identify a list of keywords that
are relevant to the video so we can use
tools to choose our keywords but
remember we want to choose keywords that
have high volume and low competition and
so where can we go to choose those
keywords well we can use the
autocomplete on YouTube we can check out
our own competitors videos or you know
we could use vid IQ or tubebuddy or any
of these extensions in Chrome to help us
look at the keywords that are tagged
with a particular video so remember we
want to have a primary keyword that's
aligned with the content then we want to
choose LSI keywords as our secondary
keyword or keywords that are related to
the primary keyword so we want to create
high retention videos meaning that first
15 seconds of the most important but
throughout the video we want to use
examples we want to keep it interacting
by adding quizzes imagery good audio
good video quality so we want to focus
on the user experience and we also want
to optimize our video content what does
that mean well those keywords that we
chose we want to use them in the title
we want to use them in the description
we want to use them as hashtags we want
to use them and tag them with the video
themselves so we can add keywords to our
meta tag okay we don't want to overdo it
but we want to add a handful of keywords
that are associated with the video so we
want to be able to write I catchy video
titled and descriptions so remember use
some of those key phrases like a number
or a question like what is machine
learning so we want to use relevant meta
tags for the videos and we want to use
popular YouTube tags so we want to be
able to tag our videos appropriately to
watch the length of your meta tags so
there are links involved remember
keywords at the beginning of the title
Target keywords in the title description
and tags we want to use interesting
thumbnails to increase our click-through
rate ensure that thumbnails are relevant
meaning when I say thumbnails I mean the
actual title tag itself or The Meta
description we want to use hi-res videos
we want to create you know videos with
good high audio quality don't be afraid
to put in video effects like some
animation don't be afraid to use
examples and then you know obviously
look at the draft of the video before
you publish it so does your video follow
an outline is it organized so these are
all the things to take into account and
there's there's plenty more you can do
you know you remember once you create
and optimize that video you want to
promote it you want to make sure that
you're sharing it on social media you
create a complimentary blog you know
generate backlinks from say other blog
posts so there are lots of things you
can do to promote your video so before
you promote it you want to organize the
content create good quality content
align it with keywords once you publish
it you know keep organizing it by
creating those playlists and then reach
out on social reach out on different
communities related to the topic and all
those things combined will help you to
get your YouTube video ranked so again
some key takeaways here use the keyword
research Available to You on YouTube you
want to basically you know watch your
descriptions you want to be able to
align your keywords with your title and
meta tag description you want to be able
to promote your content on social media
on social bookmarking though and I can't
stress enough create a high quality
video first 15 seconds are important but
you're going to know if you have good
quality video because every video has
analytics associated with it so we want
to keep in mind the engagement so just
by looking at the video itself so here I
can see this blockchain in seven minutes
it was just posted just yesterday the
27th so basically already 42 likes 33
comments 378 views so these are all
engagement related metrics so you'll be
able to just look at the front of any
video and see how well it's performing
from an engagement standpoint so the
better the engagement the better you of
a chance you have to rank now when we're
talking about the trends there are
significant shifts happening in organic
search the first of which is machine
learning uh that is more artificial
intelligence analyzing search queries
and and developing new algorithms within
the machine learning to serve up results
determine intent which is the primary
goal of machine learning and to return
not only the results but the information
you need as well as predicting
information you might need in the near
future
the second is voice search more and more
voice assistance are becoming popular
through your smartphone through your
laptop through home assistance and
people are asking for information and so
it is completely happening at an
auditory level not in visual level and
so how that is happening and how that
affects SEO reporting is really going to
be a factor moving forward and then also
as I'm sure if you've been doing any
search engine optimization for any
length of time you are familiar with the
struggle uh that has happened ever since
Google decided to strip keyword data out
of any analytics reporting that took
away really the number one way that you
were able to measure the effectiveness
of gaining keywords in the search
engines
now to hit each one of these just to
explain them a little bit more so that
you know exactly what's happening and
what it looks like as it affects your
current level of SEO work as well as
reporting uh as an example of machine
learning uh if you go into Google
AdWords right now and you were to set up
a campaign looking at maybe like auto
body or Auto work or something like that
if you typed in a few keywords into
Google what's happening is Google is
only reporting one phrase that might
cover two or three or four phrases based
on
for example Auto Body being is it one
word or is it two words Google here is
providing it as two words so even if I
type in auto body as a single word this
is where the machine learning is coming
in realizing that these are the same
queries and so rather than treat them as
individual queries what is happening is
through machine learning is they are
trying to figure out what is the intent
of the search and then grouping the
intent into single categories or single
searches and then all the variations
would be included in that now if I do
keyword research at a third party such
as word tracker or something like that
now what I'm going to find are multiple
different ways that people search uh
they're going to put in locations
they're going to put in details they're
going to you know use one word two words
and so in a third party keyword research
format we're going to see a lot more
variations because those are tracking
what people are actually typing in what
Google is doing from the machine
learning standpoint is condensing
everything and trying to group it into
as I said similar forms of intent
now What's Happening Here It means that
phrases or words that are plurals
acronyms
typical variants uh
such as words that may mean the same
thing uh but then they're different
words so they're going to group them
together uh and then also as you saw
there words with spaces or without
spaces uh conjunction words as well as
hyphens and apostrophes a lot of these
are going to fall out of what you're
able to bid on also in the paid search
side and it will all go into a
particular group of words under a
primary heading so that's where voice
search is taking us is really a
condensing of the language into intent
what are people searching for and how do
we give that their in how do we give
their information back to them now
obviously this isn't perfect I've worked
with a number of clients where
they may offer a service and because of
that service Google is trying to then
associate them with another service uh
and it's not relevant and so because of
that machine learning sometimes uh what
we're seeing is a difficulty in trying
to get unique businesses new ideas or
something that just isn't a part of that
overall big picture uh they're trying to
force it into neat little boxes but as
we know business is not full of neat
little boxes uh it's messy it's fuzzy
it's it's all kinds of different types
of businesses suppliers industries that
are going to have some level of
uniqueness about them so hopefully this
can continue to improve uh but it does
at this point still need some human
intervention
the second aspect is voice search and
maybe some of you have uh maybe the
Google home or the Alexa Appliance in
your home and you've been playing around
with it and seeing what it can do uh but
also everyone's phone uh and then also
Cortana is on uh any Microsoft operating
system desktop and so being able to
search from your phone simply by a voice
command uh now this is affecting our
ability to report because this does not
show up uh as a search now if you're
using Google now and you are searching
on Google or a Google app it will show
up as a search referral however if
you're using Cortana if you're using uh
Siri it's going to use the
search engine of the operating system
and so in that case and I'm going to
address this a little bit later it shows
up as a direct visit rather than uh a
search initiated visit and so this is
affecting the reporting of SEO metrics
uh but at the same time it is also
changing the search landscape entirely
right now uh Amazon is probably Google's
biggest competitor for most searches
especially for electronics uh especially
for uh what you would consider things
for Home and Garden Amazon and right now
has taken about 40 percent of the market
share away from Google in terms of
electronics and Home Products because
people are going to Amazon first and
they're using Alexa to do this so how
voice search it really is going to be uh
a volatile industry to follow over the
next five years
and then as I mentioned before probably
the biggest frustration of anyone doing
search engine optimization or wanting to
measure the effectiveness of
optimization or where they stand in the
marketplace is the keyword not provided
now there's a number of reasons why
Google has gone about this the first
reason that they gave was for privacy
reasons that they wanted people's
searches to be private but at the same
time if you are doing paid search you
have full access to keywords and also if
you are advertising through Google you
can Target People based on their Search
terms so we know the Privacy thing uh
was really kind of a smoke screen I
think what's going on here is that this
was really the first step to getting
people away from thinking of individual
keywords or key phrases and focusing on
one or two phrases that there that would
describe their business by taking away
the vast majority of keywords that
you're going to see in your analytics it
will force you to look at other words it
will force you to think bigger picture
rather than those one or two words that
most people believe that's what my
business needs this is where I'm going
to focus my attention and in in so in
some ways this has been good by making
people forcing people to think Beyond a
single word or a single phrase about
their business and looking into the
bigger picture this also plays into the
machine learning because as I showed you
before machine learning is condensing
all of these keyword phrases trying to
determine intent and what better way to
really assist that than to start taking
away keyword data in the search engines
however when you take that away you have
then taken away the number one reporting
fact after uh of SEO and that is what
keywords am I ranking for what keywords
are bringing in not only visitors but
business and so by taking away the
number one factor we're forced to look
at a number of different methods that we
can use then to develop better campaign
metrics
now one of the first things about uh
metrics is the expectations whenever I
work with a company I want to know
specifically what are your expectations
for the campaign what are you trying to
get out of it what do you expect uh I'll
never forget I was Consulting with an
agency about how they are developing
their SEO campaigns and how they were
reporting them to their clients uh and I
went with them oops to one of their
client meetings and after some of the
agency people left
um I asked if I could talk with a client
for a bit after the meeting and because
the main reason was on this white board
in the corner of their office uh they
had visits this month and visits last
month
and the client asked me about the agency
um you know what I was doing for them
and what they what the agency was trying
to do and then they said that they had
concerns and the reason why they had
concerns is that the visits last month
uh were higher than the visits this
month and that over the past few months
the number of visits had been going down
and because of that they were having a
lack of confidence in their agency
now this was really kind of surprising
because this goes right to the heart of
client expectations
uh no when I had asked that client then
after that you know towards the end of
the conversation is how how is your
business how are leads how are your key
performance indicators how are the
conversions on the site
basically asking them how's business uh
and the response to that was well
business is great business has been
improving over the past few months
however the primary metrics they were
looking at was visits rather than the
business oriented metrics and so this is
where establishing expectations of what
campaign metrics we're going to follow
and what those campaign metrics mean to
a business this is a conversation that
must take place rather than just
reporting basic information the same
charts and graphs every month or every
quarter that really might not
communicate the information that
everyone needs and so a conversation
between agencies and clients about what
are the expectations of this SEO
campaign what do we want out of that and
what constitutes success that
conversation needs to take place and
then that will determine how the
campaign metrics are then developed and
presented and the discussion that will
happen around them
now one thing that I think has been uh
you know I would say both a struggle as
well as what needs to happen the the
first thing about SEO metrics is the
myth of the number one ranking once in a
while I'll still run into this where
someone will
hinge the entire success of a campaign
by seeing the number one ranking they
want a single word or a tooth word
phrase to rank number one in Google and
that is their only standard of success
unfortunately I you know anymore I will
not even work with that kind of a client
because it's an unrealistic expectation
and it also shows a complete ignorance
of how search works and what it the
power of what it can bring to your
business that this is much bigger than a
number one ranking and if that's all you
want then give me a budget we'll pay for
it uh but I would say for the most part
we've moved Beyond a number one ranking
uh and now what we have to educate
people on is that rankings are really a
personal metric that you the rankings
you see are probably going to be
slightly different than every body else
and I'm going to walk through why that
happens and so you can help educate
people within your own organization of
why ranking is a personal metric now
rather than a universal metric
and then of course as I had mentioned
before it's on the expectations
campaign metrics need to focus on the
business objectives not just on the
external factors of rankings and and
somewhat invisibility uh we want to look
at the visibility of a company but
ultimately what we need to look at is
how is your search campaign
delivering on your business objectives
because that's the point of it all is
what are we what are we trying to
accomplish and how is it being
accomplished
see it's when I see charts like this
that still make me a little queasy and
still make me roll my eyes this was done
uh about two years ago asking people
what are you measuring and unfortunately
there hasn't been much change since this
initial survey that the vast majority of
people are measuring the number of
visits to the website
uh and then they're measuring social
sharing time on site and less than half
are still measuring SEO rankings
um now that still boggles my mind
because that's what I'm going to walk
through here is why we can't measure SEO
rankings it is a completely undependable
metric
and so
what what really surprises me shocks me
is that 35 percent of people are
measuring subscriber growth and 27 a
little more than a fourth of businesses
surveyed here are measuring sales leads
this is what is so shocking and
surprising especially when we come to
campaign metrics and expectations of a
client and that is what are the business
objectives what is it that you want to
grow because the last column here sales
leads is what makes business grow that
is a direct contributor to revenue
and subscriber growth well that builds
my list and marketing to my list is a
direct contributor to revenue
and so as I said this is just so
mind-boggling because the two things
that directly contribute that have a
direct impact on Revenue are the least
measured in this survey the four things
that have an indirect impact uh meaning
that you can have is as I mentioned
before an incredible number of website
visits but absolutely no Revenue coming
in as a result of that
these are all key performance indicators
visits sharing time on site those are
key performance indicators they're not
business objectives and so part of the
expectations of developing campaign
metrics is understanding the difference
between a key performance indicator and
a business objective because it's easy
to get sidetracked especially with
search metrics especially with these
types of things of you know visits time
on site uh page views rankings but
they're all indirect which is why they
are under the key performance indicator
uh grouping whereas we want to look at
the business objectives of subscribers
sales leads downloads getting
information into people's hands engaging
with them and moving along the customer
Journey when we can develop metrics that
Focus on the experience of a prospect or
a customer then
tie that to our SEO performance now
we're developing how our Campaign Will
directly impact the business and the
customer
now I want to just go off to the side
for a little bit here and talk about
rankings and this is the whole concept
of rankings are personal not Universal
now you'll notice on this this is the
this is a a rankings report from 2008
and compared to 2006. I had to go back
really far to find this screenshot and
this is of uh if you were doing a search
for the keyword latest news this would
show you who ranked number one uh and
the change in the rankings over the past
two years and it also we're looking at
it in Google and MSN for some of you
this may look really familiar because
what this did is you put in the domains
that you were tracking the keywords and
you would get a report about who ranks
where for what keyword now this is back
in the day and even around 2008 uh we
were still seeing some or we were
starting to see fluctuations in rankings
based on where you are searching from as
well as some history coming in but we
weren't seeing it to the extent that we
see it today
you see now today your rankings that you
see are largely based on your search
history
it's based on past searches it's based
on content preferences uh what types of
content you tend to search on click on
or visit uh what business or industry
you tend to uh search on as well as any
behaviors such as your uh predilection
to click on ads paid ads display ads or
anything like that and so what's
happening here is this has been actually
going on for the past 10 years is that
more and more of your rankings are going
to be personalized to your unique
history and the words the sites that you
visit the words you use uh the types of
queries that you make all of this is
being developed in order to provide you
the most relevant personal results
ultimately it's also being done in order
to focus the paid search ads
specifically to you and your behavior
and the industry that you're in because
that's how the search engines monetize
so the better they understand you and
what you're looking for and again it all
comes down to intent if they can figure
out your intent and provide you results
that are relevant both paid and organic
then that's the goal that's what they're
trying to do and so simply based on your
history we're seeing that rankings are
going to vary from person to person and
maybe even from computer to computer to
smartphone depending upon how you use
them
the second thing is Regional results uh
if you search for specific things in one
region
it's going to show up differently in
other regions if I search for right now
if I go to Google and type in for
dealership I'm going to see the one
that's near me and I'm not going to see
one that's out in another state or
another region because based on the
localization that search engines are
providing it's going to look at that
query as a localized result and serve it
to me specifically So based on location
now sometimes we will see things brands
are more Global however if I'm looking
for something that is specific to my
region that can be based on my IP
address my country my city my state even
into a zip code uh local results
targeted results can be limited to a
small area to only show to people who
are within that area or searching in
that area
and so more and more based on
localization we're seeing that affect
the results and that has been highly
impactful especially over the past two
to three years as local search has just
gotten miles better uh in all of the
search engines and it's only going to
increase as well
uh but then also based on the different
types of media based on language based
on the type of search uh the intent of
search or what words you might use as
well as here we have the machine
learning come in what you'll notice here
is simply if I do a search for something
in Spanish as compared to English I get
different results I get a completely
different results page uh there's more
videos on the Spanish results uh from
the Spanish search then the English uh
also the makeup of the page is
completely different so the words you
use how you structure the query the
language those are all going to affect
the type of results that you see and
then also as you can see here is that
the organic results you know we're
seeing videos uh taking over results how
to's uh actual uh you know multiple
things happening in the search engine
and results page and so it's no longer
just a list of 10 links and running a
ranking report to see where you rank
because What's Happening Here is we're
seeing multiple videos being served
prior to even seeing any what you would
call a traditional link or traditional
website snippet here showing up in the
search engine results page so as you can
see all of these things are just
completely transforming
a individual's rankings and so if you
were to measure rankings what you're
measuring is unreality uh you're you're
measuring something that doesn't exist
uh and as I like to say it's a it's
extinct before it's even run because no
person will ever see a ranking report
they will see that reflected in their
results it's going to be personalized
and unique something also to throw into
the mix that even based on your device
you are going to see different results
primary reason is because if you're
using a smartphone it knows your
location and so you're going to have
location results mixed in also based on
contracts with different search
providers uh with different uh
you know licensing from Google licensing
from YouTube uh the results will be
different based on the phone you use
based on the provider that you have uh
and based on uh simply just being mobile
as opposed to desktop
so results are different based on the
device so hopefully if anyone uh was
hoping to run a simple ranking report as
an SEO campaign metric uh just this
little side light here has shown it's
really a non-starter anymore the
traditional ranking report is extinct
and we have to move beyond that so how
do we move beyond that because there's
also now that I just shared the the
difficulties of a traditional ranking
report we also have a couple other
obstacles thrown at us that are
specifically uh both from a search
engine standpoint and from a user
standpoint
the first obstacle that we're running
into is from a search engine standpoint
this is what Google is doing if I do a
search for top car reviews in 2017 at
the very top of the results
I get a snippet of information
uh pulled from Consumer Reports now
what's happening here and you may have
seen this as well if you type a question
or something like that that Google is
not only displaying websites but they're
displaying the answers and they're
pulling the content from these websites
now when they do that that does not show
up as a visit and it doesn't show up as
a ranking to Consumer Reports Consumer
Reports has no method of tracking this
visibility and it's incredible
visibility so at one point Google is
providing information to the searcher
but the owner of this result is having
its content displayed by Google without
any knowledge that it's happening unless
someone has gotten in in order to see
that
so
this is a significant amount of
visibility that right now goes
unreported because there's no way to
integrate this into any metric
calculation uh other than a visual
inspection to see what's happening with
this
we're going to see more and more of this
Google is presenting more and more
answers through the search engine
results page rather than just the
website
the main reason is Google has seen the
more they do this the more they deliver
the answer in the search engine results
page rather than having people click
through to go to a website
they find that people are more likely to
come back and use Google again
and what's happening here is that Google
essentially is eliminating The Click
through
they're trying to keep people on the
search engine results page as long as
possible think about some of the
searches you've done recently if you
search for weather information you
search for flight information if you
search for sports scores on Google uh
those types of things you're going to
get your answer in the search results
page you don't even have to click
anywhere else to get the information
it's right there
this is going to not only grow under
Google but this is really the big
question mark as to what is the whole
purpose of Google and what are they
doing and how does it benefit me as a
website being in these results when I
can't track this and when Google is
trying to keep people on their site on
their property as long as possible this
is the big question mark moving forward
for SEO metrics
the other side of this is from a
consumer standpoint and this is what we
call dark search dark search are
searches that originate from a
non-traditional search engine for
example if you do a search from your
computer for example Cortana or if you
do a search from your operating system
in uh in apple you can do a search uh
almost on the uh the desktop through the
spotlight search and it will bring up
search results
if you go through that uh it's using
basically the search engine capability
built into the operating system but it
doesn't get reported as a search engine
referral instead what's happening is
it's sending you to that site as a
direct traffic so anything that's from
an operating system a search that comes
through an app now if you're using the
Google app this is kind of a a kind of a
gray area
um but it does happen so you basically
have to install the Google Search app or
use something in the browser but if
you're in an app with a search function
and that app is not a search engine app
it will show up as direct traffic uh
your voice based searches that's using
the operating system uh now you can use
a voice based search in the Google
Search app and that will show up as a
search referral I know this might get a
little confusing uh but this also is you
know this is sort of the dark search of
what's going on uh and then also Amazon
like I said is stealing a lot of
business away from Google uh but there's
no way to really know
what your Amazon ranking is for a
specific product or query uh so in that
way you're kind of losing some of
whatever Amazon is taking we're also
losing some of that data
so those are some of the obstacles that
we're running into in terms of getting a
big picture of campaign metrics
so like I said
we need to start with a business goal
when we start developing campaign
metrics this is where the expectations
need to be very very clear uh and I kind
of like the acronym of clear here that
we need to clearly State what is the
business purpose what are we trying to
ultimately accomplish and how will
search help to accomplish that
based on that we create a set of goals
we lay out the goals of a campaign what
do we want people to do and then carry
that over into how does that accomplish
the purpose
we then explain how and define success
explain how success is accomplished as
people meet those goals how does that
fit into the customer Journey where is
that in the customer Journey how does it
move them from one stage to the next how
do we measure that and how do we Define
that as success then we align metrics to
that strategy we don't just start with
the metrics we start with the purpose
the goal defining success and then
aligning metrics as we have our strategy
and then the final stage is the ideal
customer experience how do we relate
that through these metrics how do we
explain that our customer has seen this
and then they did this or they looked
for this information and it was a
successful visit now what will they need
this is where we look at the overall
customer journey and how search is a
part of that Journey
now getting into some very specific
metrics that will assist this one of the
things that I like to look at and this
can be a part of the reporting if I'm
looking at just the cold hard facts of
of SEO campaign metrics one of the first
things I'm going to look at is that
audience overview and I'm going to look
specifically at my organic traffic now
one of the things I need to caution is
making sure and I'm I'm surprised I
still have to say this is comparing like
time frames you can compare year over
year if you're comparing the entire year
quarter to quarter example is I'm
looking at first quarter 2017 compared
to first quarter 2016. I want to compare
like time frames I am amazed at how many
businesses still look at month to month
to month to month and there is such a
drastic difference between month to
month you have to compare this quarter
to the same quarter last year this month
this year to let that you have to
compare the like time frames going month
to month is is a is chasing your tail
so from here I want to specifically just
look at my organic coverage at this
point what I'm looking at here is with
the audience overview I'm looking at my
total number of sessions this year
compared to last year and I can see that
it's higher uh and in some areas I've
seen some dips uh but then when I went
to go look at specifically in Google
this year or this first quarter compared
to first quarter last year where am I at
in terms of sessions new users bounce
rate conversion rate and transactions
that's what's going to help me as far as
getting the first step in my SEO metrics
the next is looking at total organic
visits this is anything that comes
through search now again this is part of
the conversation this is everything we
can track uh because there are things
that are completely outside of this uh
this might be a good time to say this I
was talking to an analytics provider a
couple of years ago and in comparing
different analytics systems and I asked
them what makes your analytics more
accurate than your competitors it was
very interesting because this is the
lead engineer and he sort of shushed me
this was on the trade show floor and he
says in analytics we don't talk about
accuracy
he says what I like to say is that our
analytics are less inaccurate than our
class than our competitors
and that is really the case when it
comes to analytics if you've ever
compared analytics from two different
systems and looking at the same metrics
they never agree
I'm always amazed at how many people try
to make their Google analytics line up
with their omniture analytics and it
will never happen or they'll look at
multiple different packages or they'll
tell me my agency is reporting these
numbers but these numbers are what I'm
seeing and they're using two different
systems that's because
Analytics it's tracking what it can
track and what is unclear an algorithm
tries to
organize it or an algorithm tries to
assign things that are unclear to
different areas so each analytics
program kind of has its own methodology
of organizing the information and
interpreting it based on that that's
where you come up with the we're less
inaccurate than our competitors so when
we're measuring organic coverage we're
measuring what we can based on this
system it may not agree with another
system don't try to make it agree
because it just simply won't
now here I'm looking at my total organic
search visits and I can see compared to
the the year prior this quarter is up 18
in visits I can look at total
conversions and I can see that it's up
30 percent uh and then also what I want
to do is look at landing pages and my
keyword Concepts now this is a sense
because the search engines don't provide
us any keyword data what we can do is
look at our landing pages and the amount
of visits those landing pages are
generating
then it doesn't take much to kind of
look at those landing pages and see what
what are they basically about what are
those keyword Concepts now you can go to
uh Google search console you can go to
Bing webmaster tools and you can see
which keywords uh are driving traffic to
your business through those webmaster
portals and you can get the concept of
what keywords uh are driving traffic now
one thing I do like about Bing webmaster
tools is that Bing webmaster tools will
not only show me which keywords I'm
ranking for and which ones are sending
traffic to my website but they will also
show me which Pages or the recipients of
those keywords so they are able to tie
together the keywords and the landing
pages and so I'll do that in bing uh on
also Google search console will do that
to an extent
but to some degree this is still a
manual process of looking at my landing
pages and comparing them to the keyword
Concepts as I said Google's trying to
push everything together into intent and
so evaluate your landing pages in terms
of intent what would someone be
searching on in order to get to this
page and utilize Google search console
and Bing webmaster tools maybe some of
your analytics in order to figure that
out
also what I like to look at are
comparative metrics
when I'm looking at the success of an
SEO campaign as tied to other types of
campaigns I also want to show the value
of search engine optimization and what
it's providing and so in looking at a
source medium I'm using Google analytics
here what I can do here is for this time
frame look at the overall numbers of
sessions generated through each Channel
as you can see there Google on its own
is about 67 percent of all visits Yahoo
is providing about
[Music]
1.28 percent of visits and then we can
see a little less than 20 percent are
direct visits so comparatively I can see
where my search engine optimization is
contributing in comparison to all the
other channels and I can get a sense
there into terms of I can run a revenue
report by Source where I can see where
my search is responsible for the
greatest amount of revenue for the
greatest amount of orders uh and also
when I look at uh when the interesting
thing here I can also do a value per
session breakdown and what this shows me
is uh the email campaigns those by far
have the highest value per session
visitors coming through the blog are
next in value per session and then we
can see our search visitors showing up
there as a significantly high value per
session
um
and one thing you might uh jump out to
you there is you can see that Bing has a
four pound 27 value per session compared
to Google with a one pound 77 that's
normal I over the past 15 years it has
been a really interesting phenomenon
that visitors from Bing or MSN have a
higher value even though I will get uh
just sheer numbers and higher revenue
from Google but they are higher value
visitor uh than Google visitors uh
that's just a phenomenon that we've just
observed for more than about 15 years
and really kind of interesting there uh
so from a metric standpoint I like doing
comparative metrics to see here's how
search compares to your other channels
here's what it's driving compared to
your other channels in terms of visitors
in terms of Engagement in terms of
Revenue and revenue per user
uh and again I I kind of mentioned this
associative metrics using Google search
console uh to see some of the keywords
that Google is driving uh Google my
business I'm going to show that uh as we
get into here before we wrap up Bing
webmaster tools as I said they will show
you the keywords as well as the
associated landing pages analytics uh
getting into analytics and looking at
your organic traffic I showed you a few
reports there uh but that is where
people need to live in order to
understand what's going on with their
search traffic and more and more
um alongside analytics I'm seeing a CRM
integration with analytics really
becoming a a different standard because
within the CRM integration I can then
look at the entire customer journey I
can track the initial touch point of a
consumer I can then see how that spreads
into different searches so maybe they'll
find me first from a paid ad but then
how does a subsequent organic searches
contribute to different touch points and
then maybe there is a retargeting touch
Point uh and so I really like what I'm
seeing with modern CRM systems and
tracking more of the customer journey
and how search is a part of it and that
really then gets to the point of looking
at that customer Journey that ideal
customer experience and it immediately
puts it in the context of the purpose of
the campaign uh and the goals of the
campaign focused around the user
experience
when I'm talking with a client laying
out expectations really my first
question is what makes you money because
that's what we want to track there's our
purpose we want to look at sales and
leads and so I want to look at this
prioritized outcomes this gets back to
what is the purpose of the overall
campaign
then we need to look at what are
performance goals now not all of these
goals
carry the same amount of weight what I
mean by that are inquiries support uh
people viewing videos online chat
subscribes downloads those are all a
different level of Engagement than a
typical like or retweet or a pin
um that's what I call you know it
these are much more active if someone
makes an inquiry that's a lead if they
contact support if they're viewing
videos about new cars that's a
performance goal that means I'm engaging
somebody and I'm answering their
questions uh we can look at people
subscribing and asking for more
information downloading brochures
downloading information this is where
we'll attach different value to
different actions because some actions
will contribute much more in terms of
value in the customer experience than
others and so we want to look at the
performance goals and establish a level
of value around them
and then explain clearly the difference
between a performance goal and a
performance indicator
performance indicators visibility visits
time on site Pages viewed bounce rate
these are all good performance
indicators but they are removed from a
direct impact on the business goals it's
an indirect factor in fact they can even
be misleading if that's what you're
using because you can see that business
goals are excelling while these numbers
might go down or they might go up and
business goals go down because it's what
are you doing with the information and
how are you focusing your efforts
I want to focus uh real quickly before I
wrap up here on uh Google my business
and this is something that uh Google has
done more and more of I'm using actually
a local landscaper that I've been
helping out simply because I love the
numbers that are showing up on this
um and it's really cool because you just
put your business in and then you set
the service area so it can be a zip code
it can be a radius uh and then you can
view the insights this is just on the
left side is the login panel and it will
show you how many searches your business
has shown up for in the past month as we
can see here we're over we're almost at
about six and a half thousand searches
where
people searched for uh their business we
we can see about 8.3
000 views of their local listing and
about uh 16
000 actions uh so we can see here this
now this probably right here is probably
going to be I think the future of SEO
metrics the main reason is this is what
happens when you do a search for a local
business and the business box shows up
in the results and that business box as
a picture of the business a description
hours uh pictures
and phone number and what can happen
here just like with the information
where Google is showing all the
information and you don't even have to
click through it
this is tracking that type of visibility
this is showing you how many times
simply your business information showed
in the search results and so now from
here we can look specifically on uh what
customers how they viewed your business
and we can see how many times the
business showed up in Search and how
many times it showed up on maps in the
top graph in the lower graph and this is
where I think this is I I think this
where reporting is really going to be
moving is from that business box in the
search results
we're now showing in the past month how
many total actions people have taken and
that is how many people visited the
website from the the inbox information
box how many people requested directions
and how many people called from that
business listing and the far right graph
shows you how many people uh the dark
green so maybe a little over a fourth of
people were looking for the specific
business name
a little more than or a little less than
three quarters of people we're looking
for related keywords and because of that
saw the business information
so from a visibility metric standpoint
within Google search results I love what
Google my business is doing because it's
providing me a view of how many people
are seeing my listing without even
clicking on it but then because of the
interactions available through
smartphone searches local searches map
based searches I can track a lot of this
local activity and how people are then
integrating uh or engaging with my local
search results on google.com
uh so reporting has changed it will
continue to do so that is the only uh
that is the only hard and fast rule here
uh and so metrics need to focus on uh
emphasizing conversion rates optimizing
landing pages and it requires analytics
expertise much more than ever and
ultimately what we want to get to is a
measurement of the user experience like
I said that big picture of the user
experience did they find what they
wanted uh doing task-based user testing
where they have to find a specific bit
of information uh from the search to the
site and from that you can gather an
understanding of how quickly they're
able to find it how they can navigate
there both in a desktop and a mobile and
this gets to the the micro moment
assessment when people are searching for
things such as can I afford it uh show
me the new cars
where can I get Finance those types of
micro moment questions that people type
into the search box or speak into their
phone okay I'm going to start out with
how to set up a Google analytics account
and so we're going to talk about
everything that entails including
creating your Google analytics account
we're going to talk about setting up a
property in your account and what a
property is we're going to talk about
setting up a reporting view in your
property and we're going to talk about
installing the tracking code so those
are the series of steps we're going to
go through today in terms of setting up
a Google analytics account so let's get
right to it and so really the Bruin
prerequisite here when it comes to
setting up a Google analytics account is
to have a Google login and ID so when
you actually go to Google analytics you
need to be able to sign up or sign in
and so once you actually sign in then
you're gonna go walk through a series of
steps but really that's really all you
need to get the account going is a
Google ID and login so if you have a
Gmail account or an other email account
that you use for other Google products
then you're good to go that's all you
need to do so when you actually go to
sign up for Google analytics you're
going to be asked to set up a new
account and these are the series of
steps you're going to walk through or go
through to set up a new Google Analytics
account so you're going to choose an
account name and then you're going to
choose a property name okay so the
account name can be anything you want it
to be the name your company your name
whatever you want to name it the
property name is really the website name
so what website are we talking about so
here I'm going to set up a fictitious
website name for now it's called demo
simply learn so the URL for this website
demo simply learn is going to be
demo.simplylearn.com so that's the
property when we talk about properties
and analytics we're really talking about
what websites we want to measure and
then you're going to be asked to choose
an industry category and so for simply
learn we're in jobs and education but
you have a number of different
industries that you could choose from
it's as important go ahead and choose
the most relevant industry that your
particular business is associated with
okay and I'm going to talk about why
that's important here in a minute and
then you're going to choose your time
zone and the time zone is also important
because that's when the day starts in
analytics and the day ends based on that
time zone so the data that Google
analytics collects starts and ends with
that time zone so very important to
choose the time zone your business is
located in okay and then you have some
additional options here okay so you have
some settings and so the first setting
is to allow Google products and services
so if you opt into this then basically
what Google's going to do is share some
products and services with you via email
I would go ahead and opt into that
that's of course recommended by Google
it doesn't hurt to hear from Google on
related products and services that may
enhance your business the second is
benchmarking so benchmarking to me is
something you should opt into so going
back to that industry and category we
chose jobs and education so by opting
into benchmarking basically what
Google's going to do is share your data
that it collects on your website in this
case
demo.simplylearn.com it's going to share
that data anonymously with others in the
industry in this case jobs and education
and because you've opted in it's going
to do the same exact thing for you it's
going to share Anonymous data on other
websites in the same industry and the
benefit of that is we get to see what
other websites or how other websites are
performing compared to ours what's the
Benchmark in our industry and so the
benchmarking to me is important and I'm
gonna go over that in a few minutes when
we go over the different reports but to
me I would always opt into benchmarking
because this is the only report Google
provides in analytics about how others
in your industry is performing versus
your website okay so it's a way to
compare your website performance against
others in the same industry the other
options here technical support and
account specialist I would also
recommend you opt into those because
then it allows you to basically Google
allow Google access to your account and
they'll be able to help you if you occur
or run into any issues so these are the
options in setting up a Google analytics
account it's very simple very easy easy
to do you're just entering in a few
Fields note that we talking about a
website right now so I'm talking about
demo.simplylearn.com but just know that
if you want to track a mobile app Google
analytics will allow you to do that as
well you just choose the option mobile
app so we're tracking a website we want
to know how users behave when they get
to my website and that's what Google
analytics is going to allow us to
measure and look at we just need to do a
couple more steps in the process so once
we fill out these fields here we're
going to click get tracking ID now I'm
going to accept the terms of service I'm
going to accept another terms and
service in relation to data protection
I'm going to click accept once I accept
I'm going to be able to get some
tracking code the tracking ID is the ID
associated with your account and so this
number is going to be associated with
your account so your account I ID starts
with UA and it's going to be this number
here now the dash one is the property
you set up so in this case I set up
demo.simplylearn.com if I wanted to
track multiple websites under that same
account then I can certainly set up
multiple properties just know that every
property I set up in that account is
going to have a dash 1-2-3-4
Etc depending on how many properties I
set up so by default I set up one
property so my first property ID is dash
one if I set up a second property the
same account number it's just gonna have
a dash two and that's important because
that ID that account and property ID is
going to be associated with that
particular property or website so again
once you finish setting up the account
settings then you're going to be asked
to add some tracking code to your site
and that tracking code is going to be
related to the account and the property
so notice my tracking ID up here notice
the tracking ID and the snippet of code
now this snip and a code needs to go on
every page of your website that you want
to track and you don't have to put it on
every page but if you want to track
website behavior on every page or
website then it needs to go on every
page of your website so if you're using
a you know platform like Drupal or
Joomla or even more popular platform
like WordPress adding the tracking code
site-wide is as easy as maybe adding a
Google analytics plugin to Wordpress for
example and then just simply plug in in
the ID now there's an alternative to
adding the Google analytics tracking
code to your site and that's Google tag
manager so Google tag manager is the way
I would recommend going so if you're not
familiar with Google tag manager I would
recomme man watching the YouTube video
we have on Google tag manager you can
just go to YouTube Type in simply learn
Google tag manager and this will give
you a nice overview of you know what
Google tag manager is and how it works
but basically this is the way I would go
and I would recommend that in addition
having Google analytics you set up a
Google tag manager account and then that
way you can put the tracking code in
Google tag manager so if I go to Google
tag manager and I just go into an
account on tag manager I can just simply
put in the Google analytics ID right
into tag manager and so if I have it in
tag manager then tag manager is going to
be the place that holds the code and
fires page view when somebody comes to
my website so that way I don't have to
add the tracking code to my website if I
do it in tag manager so that's the
recommended method for me is to add the
Google analytics ID associate it with
tag manager if you can associate it with
tag manager then that's the easier route
to go versus putting code on your
website okay so again take a look at the
video we have on YouTube for Google tag
manager that's the route I would go now
once you do get the tracking code on
your website whether that be through
Google tag manager or through a plug-in
or you know just simply adding the
script to your site to pages on your
site then what's going to happen is
you're going to start collecting data so
that's ideally the way it works you need
to add this code to your website now if
you're not ready to do that and you
simply want to basically understand how
Google analytics works then I would
recommend getting access to Google
analytics demo account and so if you
just type in and search Google analytics
demo account basically okay what you're
going to do you're going to choose the
first listing there and you're going to
go to demo account so if you have a
Google analytics or Google login then
all you need to do is click on access
demo account and so what Google is going
to do is put this demo account into your
account and so it's going to look
something like this so if I click on
demo account here it's going to add to
my Google analytics account so I'm going
to have then access to the demo account
from Google in Google analytics so I
would recommend going this route here if
you're not familiar you're not sure what
you're getting yourself into so think of
the demo account as kind of a test drive
you're test driving Google analytics
before you even add any code to your
website so again all you need is a
Google account and if you have a Google
account and you add the demo account to
your Google analytics account you're
going to be able to see how analytics
works okay and so that's what I I would
also recommend so if you're not ready to
start adding code to your website then
what you can do is just simply add the
demo account and then once you add the
demo account you're free to peruse
around Google analytics to see the
different types reports it has to offer
now when you do actually set up a Google
analytics account you're going to have
some settings that you're going to want
to pay attention to so when you set up
the account you have the account name
and then you have a property so under
each property you have by default you're
going to have one View and so here you
can see this view here so if we look at
the account we set up we set up a demo
simply learn account property is demo
simply learn so that's associated with
the website we're going to track and
then again by default under each
property you're going to have a view and
so by default the name of the view is
going to be called all website data and
so in that view is where all your
Analytics data is going to be stored so
you can see my screen here there's a lot
of different settings you have you have
settings under the account you have
settings under the property and you have
settings under the view so we're going
to talk more about these settings and
future webinars for advanced Google
analytics users but for now know that
there's a bunch of settings that you
have that you can play around with when
it comes to Google analytics anything
from adding users to your Google
analytics account your Google analytics
property or view you can actually set up
goals you can set up filters you can set
up segments you can link up Google ads
you can you know set up remarketing list
there's a lot you can do in terms of the
settings as it relates to Google
analytics but so know those settings are
there they're located right down here
and this little sprocket icon that's the
admin icon so if you need to get to
these settings at any time time you
could simply just click on the sprocket
or the admin icon and then you'll be
prompted to choose any one of these
settings here that you want to edit or
alter so now let's take a look at some
Google analytics reports so once you've
actually set up your account you have a
number of different reports that you
have available to you in Google
analytics so we're going to take a look
at you know customized reports we're
going to look at real time audience
reports acquisition behavior and
conversion so these are all the
different reporting buckets if you will
that you have available to you in Google
analytics so if I'm in admin and I'm
looking at the Google demo account let's
start out by looking at real time so if
I click on the real time report and I
just click on overview so basically what
this is going to do is show me at this
point in time how many users I actually
have active on the website site okay so
that's why they call it real time
reporting because it allows you to see
the behavior of users who are currently
on your website and so this is the
overview report under real time and you
can see here I can see that 79 percent
of my users are coming from desktop 18
20 are coming from mobile and then
approximately three percent are coming
from tablet here I can see how they
actually came to the website so this is
the referring Source if they came from
say search or social I can see the
source there and I can see what pages
they're active on and then here I could
see what locations where they're located
and so if I want to see a breakdown of
everything in the overview I can
certainly do that if I go to locations
under real time I could see a majority
of my users are coming from the United
States okay where are they coming from
I'll just click on traffic sources and
here I could see the different source
sources and mediums medium is the means
in which the traffic was driven so if
it's Google it's either paid search or
organic search so I can see here it's
organic then I can actually see what
contents they're looking at on my
website so I could see currently I have
three active users on the home page two
active users on the Google's women's
white t page so forth and so on now most
importantly if you have a vent tracking
set up so if you're taking a look at our
Google tag manager webinar you know that
you could set up event tracking in
Google analytics to measure engagement
on your website whether that be a form
submission or somebody clicking on the
play button of a video so if I click on
events I'll be able to see what events
are firing so here I can see we have
event tracking set up and I can see how
many different events are firing on my
website in real time so here I can see
econ Commerce somebody clicking on the
quick view click some a couple of users
clicking on add to cart a couple of
users clicking on the promotion click
and as these events are fired you're
going to be able to see them highlighted
so if something gets fired it's going to
get highlighted and I could see that
these are the current events that I have
currently firing on the website and
that's what's currently fire now if I
want to look at the events that have
happened in the last 30 minutes I could
just click on this link here last 30
minutes and it's going to give me an
overview of the events that have
happened over the past 30 minutes okay
so that's event tracking and then more
importantly we can also look at what
conversions are happening in real time
just by clicking on conversions and so
now I can see I had one active user who
entered the checkout so that's goal
number four so in analytics you can have
up to 20 goals and so here I can see we
have goal number four has already had
one active user and so if I look at the
last 30 minutes I can see I still have
only one goal over the last 30 minutes
and that was somebody who entered the
checkout so that's real time reporting
in summary it just gives you an idea of
what's currently happening on your
website and so for me ideally if I'm
launching a campaign or let's just say
you do a new website redesign and you
want to see how users performing and
behaving then real time is a good option
for you so you could see how things are
happening in real time now let's jump
down to audience reporting so if I click
on audience this is just right
underneath real time I'm gonna see a
number of different reports available to
me under audience and so let's click on
the audience overview report so audience
reporting basically allows us to get a
sense of who is coming to our website
when I say who is coming to our web
website it doesn't necessarily have to
be a specific person in fact Google
doesn't allow personally identifiable
information in Google analytics personal
identifiable information such as a
specific name uh social security number
credit card information
Etc however we could still paint a nice
picture on who is coming to our website
meaning what country city or state did
they come from what language what device
do they get to our website from how old
were they okay were they male or female
or other what interest do they have what
browser do they use so we can paint a
nice picture based on all this
information that Google analytics is
providing us under audience so if I go
to audience overview here I can see I
have all these different options
available to me to get a basic
understanding of who is coming to our
website so for example I could see a
majority of the people coming to our
website speak English and are from the
United States okay in fact that
represents 61 of the users and so Google
analytics does a great job of giving me
an overall percentage so if I have a
hundred percent of the users I could see
61 percent of those users represented
English-speaking users from the United
States seven percent represented
English-speaking users from Great
Britain and so when it comes to
analytics we have users and users are
broken down into two categories they're
either returning or they're new so when
you add the Google analytics tracking
script to your website what's gonna
happen is if a user or when a user goes
to your website they're gonna get
cookied if it's the first time they've
been to your website what Google
analytics is going to do is store a
cookie in the browser so when that same
user comes back another day in the same
browser analytics is going to recognize
that that cookie is in the browser and
so then analytics is going to categorize
that user as a returning user okay so
that's how analytics is able to
differentiate new versus returning so if
that user doesn't have a cookie in the
browser then analytics is going to
recognize that store the cookie and then
count that user as a new user and so
when you're looking in analytics you're
going to be able to see a breakdown of
new versus returning so here I can see
over three quarters of my traffic over
the past week here I can see April 6
through April 12th three over three
quarters are new users to the website
here I could see about 23 24 are
returning users okay so I can get a good
breakdown of what type of users are
coming am I driving new traffic am I
driving traffic that's been to my
website before what language are they
speaking okay I can also paint a bigger
picture how old are they are they what
gender are they do they come from mobile
so let's take a look at some of these
different reports under audience and so
if I skip down now to demographics I can
click on overview and when that report
loads I can see now under demographics
overview I can see the breakout of age
ranges and so here I can see the
majority of the traffic coming to my
site again over the past week now if I
want to change this date range I could
simply do that I can change the date
range just by clicking on the date range
and then maybe going say the last 30
days and I can even compare it to the
previous period or the previous year I'm
going to choose the last 30 days I'm
going to click apply now I'm looking at
data over the last 30 days and again you
can change the date range to any range
you want you can only go back as far as
when you actually created the Google
analytics account you can't go prior to
that so here I'm looking at the last 30
days and I can see almost 47 percent of
my users were in their age range of 25
to 34. now when it comes to gender I can
say 66 percent represent males so I can
get a breakout of gender and age as well
as interest I can click on interest and
look at the overview there and see what
the interest is of the users who are
coming to my site based on in-market
segments or Affinity I can also choose
language and location so if I want to
know exactly where my users are located
when they're coming to my website I can
click on location and here I can get a
breakout 43 of the users of the last 30
days were from the United States more
importantly I can align my audience with
goals and we'll talk about goals here in
a minute but he here I can see if I have
an e-commerce website I can see of those
43 percent 0.29 of those converted or
purchased something and that equates to
94 transactions so I can get a good
sense of not only how many users are
coming from a specific country but are
those users converting if I click on
mobile and mobile to me is one of those
reports I tend to spend a bit of time on
because I want to know what devices
users are coming to my website and so
for my website here or this is the
Google demo website I can see mobile
represents approximately 27 of the
traffic so desktop still represents a
majority of the traffic so for you you
want to keep an eye on mobile because
mobile is definitely a majority of what
people use nowadays that's how people
start their day that's how they transact
Via mobile whether that's purchasing
something communicating or searching it
all starts with mobile so you want to
keep an eye on mobile and more
importantly you want to keep an eye on
Behavior so Google analytics is telling
me that yes I have approximately 27 of
my traffic of the last 30 days came from
mobile how are they interacting with my
website so if I look across this report
I'm going to be able to see different
metrics so if I'm measuring specific
metrics against my dimension in this
case the dimension is what we're
measuring and in this example we're
measuring mobile I can see that the
bounce rate is approximately 48 percent
and bounce rate means that if a user in
this case for mobile landed on a page
they left the site without going any
further so they consider it a bounce if
they don't go to another page if they
leave the site from the page they landed
on and they don't go any further that's
considered a bounce so bounce rate is
the percentage of people who come to the
site and leave the site without going
any further so in this case we have 48
bounce rate that's almost half of our
users who come from mobile leave the
website from the page they landed on so
is that good is that bad well it's open
to interpretation is definitely
subjective but you want to keep the
bounce rate as low as possible you want
to keep people on your site especially
if you have an e-commerce website you
want people who come to your website to
purchase and so here we can see 48
mobile and desktop it's a little bit
lower at 41 percent now if I look a
little bit further at engagement I can
see how many pages on average do mobile
users look at so versus desktop it's a
little bit lower you can see 3.86 on
desktop it's 4.5 now if I look a little
bit further in engagement I want to be
able to measure how long somebody from
mobile stays on the website if they're
bouncing at 48 but they're also looking
at 3.8 Pages 3.9 almost four pages per
session then that means in this report
analytics is telling me they're spending
about two minutes on the site and
interestingly enough I can see that
mobile of the last 30 days had more
transactions so 51 transactions versus
34 transactions from desktop and
interestingly enough the e-commerce
conversion rate is at 0.29 percent
that's higher than desktop at .07 it's
lower than tablet but it's higher than
desktop and mobile has the most
transactions and since they have the
most transactions they have the most
Revenue at 2 380. so yes the engagement
it isn't exactly as great as it is as
desktop but we can see that people are
still purchasing with their mobile
devices so it's something to keep an eye
on and mobile is something I definitely
look at in fact since it's such an
important report one thing you can do in
analytics is if you actually like a
report and you think you're going to
look at that report multiple times then
you can simply just go ahead and click
save at the top here so if I click save
I'm going to enter a name for this
report I'm just going to call it mobile
report and click OK and then what's
going to happen is it's going to be
located under save reports and save
reports is located under customization
customization is located above real time
okay so if I close that up you can see
audience real time customization if I
click on customization if I click on
Save reports I should be able to see my
save report here and I do so here I can
see a mobile report if I click on it I
can simply go to the report I was
looking at before I saved it so save
reports to me is a good feature and
analytics because it allows you to
quickly access a report that you've
saved in the past so let's take a look
at one more report under audience and
let's go to benchmarking so remember
when we were setting up our analytics
account we had the option to opt into
benchmarking and I recommended you do so
and so if you did I actually opt into
benchmarking then you're going to be
able to see how your site compares to
others in the same industry so if I
click on benchmarking and then click on
channels what I'm actually able to do
now is compare my website with others in
the same industry so if I go back to say
jobs in education and I choose education
all education as my industry vertical I
should be able to see website sites that
are in the same particular industry and
how I compare with those websites so I'm
choosing all countries I can narrow that
down if I wanted to I can just search
for the United States I can choose a
specific State and then I can choose a
particular site size so here I'm
choosing sites by daily session so these
are sites that have an average of 5 000
to almost 10 000 sessions a day and so
in this vertical education in the United
States sites that have five thousand to
9999 sessions per day that means that
they're approximately 310 web properties
contributing to this report okay based
on this criteria I chose now if my site
is similar meaning if I'm in the United
States if I'm in education and I'm
receiving 5 000 to 9 999 sessions per
day then I'm able to compare my site
against 310 other websites now Google's
sharing this data anonymously from the
other websites and they're doing the
same with your website to those
particular websites benchmarking reports
okay so it's a shared data anonymously
in particular Industries and verticals
and so now I'm looking at a channel
report so if I want to see how I compare
to others in my industry then I can go
ahead and see by channel for example in
my driving as much traffic as others in
my industry and you can see I'm not in
fact I'm 76 77 percent worse in terms of
the amount of traffic being driven from
organic search so anything in red is
going to show as a negative result a
negative comparison whereas something in
green is a positive comparison so if I
look at engagement I can see that I
might not be driving as much traffic but
I can see that the pages per session are
better than the site average or the
industry average I can see if I go over
again looking just at organic search I
can see the bounce rate is better than
the industry average so the channel
report under benchmarking allows you to
measure how you compare to others in
your industry and you could do so by
looking at location and devices so if
you opted into benchmarking when you set
up your account then you'll be able to
compare your website against others in
your industry in your country region and
based on the size of your website in
terms of how many visitors or sessions
you're getting per day so let's go from
audience to acquisition so if audience
is who is coming to your website
acquisition allows us to see how the
traffic was driven to your website so
how do these users get to our website
and so under acquisition if we click on
overview we'll be able to to see an
overview of how users whether they're
returning are new came to our website
and so what analytics does by default is
they have a number of default channels
and when we say channels we mean
analytics is grouping different channels
based on how users got to your website
meaning how did users get to our website
did they come via organic search meaning
do they type something into Google and
find you in the organic listing
analytics also groups users based on
whether they came to your site directly
meaning did they type in the URL
directly into the browser or did they
bookmark your website and come back via
the bookmark so they're grouping users
under direct they also group users under
referral meaning do they come from
another website they group users by
social do they come from a social media
platform like Twitter or Facebook if
you're running paid search search
meaning if you're running paid search on
say Google then do they come from Paid
search ads now if you're running display
ads on say Google's Network Google's
Display Network that's a default channel
so analytics for group users there so if
they don't recognize a channel then
they're going to group it as others so
by default Google analytics groups users
and how they came to your website via
these default channels and so I can see
how many users came to the site from
each Channel now if I want to drill down
on this report I can click on all
traffic and then if I click on all
traffic I can go to channels I can look
specifically at the channels report and
so now I can see organic search again
over the last 30 days is the number one
channel driving traffic and they
represent approximately again you can
see this number here in parentheses next
to the raw number of users I can see
that number is about 56 cents so 56
percent of my traffic over the last 30
days came from organic search and so
those are the number of users again as a
metric you're also going to have
sessions and you'll see sessions a lot
as a metric so users are broken down
between new and returning so every time
a new or returning user comes to the
website basically what they're doing is
initiating a session so you can have a
user who can come back multiple times
every time they come back to the website
it's a session so session is simply the
start of somebody coming to your website
and the session ends when they leave the
website and so just like we looked at
with the audience reports when it came
to mobile we can also look at engagement
by channel so just like mobile we looked
at bounce rate pages per session average
session duration we can do the same
thing here with our our Channel report
more importantly in addition to behavior
we can see conversions and since we're
running an e-commerce platform we could
see what the conversion rate is by
channel so organic search did drive the
most traffic and they did have the most
transactions over the last 30 days and
the conversion rate in this case is 0.17
okay so how Google determines the
conversion rate they basically take the
number of transactions and divide that
by sessions so that means that over the
last 30 days organic search drove 38 123
sessions and of those 38 000 123 64
actually turned into a transaction which
equates to 0.17 which also equates to 3
000 in Revenue so I'm able to determine
not only how users are getting to my
website by looking at the channel report
I can actually see if they're in
engaging and if they are converting and
notice when you look at a report in
analytics you can look at it by Channel
you'll also get a summary so here I can
see a summary or a total based on my
date range so I could see over the last
30 days I've had 54 000 users 49
000 of them were new okay that meant
that out of this for 54 000 users I had
70 000 sessions I could see my average
bounce rate was 43 percent the pages per
session were just over four and the
average session duration how long did
somebody stay on my website on average
about two minutes and 55 seconds the
average conversion rate was 0.14 and I
had a total of 97 transactions totaling
fifty five hundred dollars okay and
that's all over the last 30 days so any
report you look at in analytics is going
to have a summary and note that any
report you look at analytics is going to
allow you to save it so if it's a report
you think you're going to go back and
look at at a future date then you simply
just have to click on the save button
conversely if you don't want to save it
you can simply just export it so you can
export it as a PDF if I click on PDF
it's going to allow me to export that as
a PDF now you have other options
available to you as well you can do a
Google sheet you can export it as an
Excel or you can export it as a comment
delimited file so here you can see I can
save it as a PDF if I want to and if I
click OK it's going to save to my
desktop or location of my choosing and
then I can go back and look at it in
that format at a later time so that's
the export feature available to you in
analytics again if you you could save it
as well or you can export it okay some
other reports under acquisition if
you're running Google ads note that you
can to connect Google ads to analytics
and this is key because now I can see
how many people are coming from Google
ads to my website and are they
converting now this is important because
with Google ads I'm actually paying for
the click so you can see here I'm
running a report based on campaign data
so I could see what campaigns are
driving traffic how much I'm paying per
click and you can see on average I'm
paying 34 cents per click and then more
importantly I want to be able to see if
they're converting so you can see I've
spent 810 dollars over the last 30 days
and received 858 dollars in Revenue so
you want to make sure that you link up
your Google ads account to your Google
analytics account for this very reason
you want to be able to see how your
Google ads campaigns perform once the
users get to your website and so I want
to see if there engaging and I want to
see if they're converting so they're all
sorts of reports under Google ads so you
can look at it by keywords by search
queries by hour of the day if you're
running display campaigns you can look
at display targeting it says all sorts
of reports under Google ads you just
have to link it up and you link it up
under the admin now there are other
reports that you can look at so if I go
to campaigns I can look at all campaigns
so if you're running all sorts of
different types of campaigns whether
that be on Facebook whether it be email
whether that be you know other types of
advertising let's just say Twitter or
Instagram you're going to be able to see
those campaigns here and that's under
all campaigns and again you'll be able
to see the campaign name and you'll be
able to see metrics associated with
those campaigns and more importantly
you'll be able to see your e-commerce if
you're running e-commerce platform or if
you have goals set up so you'll be able
to look at how your campaigns are not
one not only driving traffic but two are
they converting let's go from
acquisition reporting to behavior so
Behavior reports are going to actually
show you how users behaved once they got
to your website once they landed on a
page on your website how did they behave
so when we looked at audience we got a
sense of who is coming with acquisition
we get a sense of how the traffic got to
our website did they come from organic
direct social Etc the behavior reports
allow us to actually measure how that
traffic behaved once they landed on a
page on our website and so if I go to
overview under Behavior now I'm looking
at this graph here it's showing me how
many pages I've had and a page view is
simply once a page is viewed it's
counted as a page view so if a user
comes to my site they're initiating a
session and if they look at a page then
that page is going to have a page view
okay so a user can look at a page
multiple times in a session and every
time they look at that page it's going
to count as a page view so here I can
see in this graph how many pages I've
had again over the last 30 days and if I
look further at my overview report I can
see the specific pages and how many
pages they've had and I can also look at
some other metrics okay the average
bounce rate the average time on page I
can look at the exit rate which means
how many people actually exited or the
percentage of people who exited from
that page so I can dig deeper into my
behavior reporting so if I click on site
content and I click on all pages then
I'm going to look at a report by Page
this is my Dimension this is what I'm
measuring my page and now I can see how
many page views each page had of the
last 30 days now note you also have
something called unique page views so
unique page use is equivalent to one per
session in other words if a user came to
my site and looked at the home page then
the home page is going to have one
unique page view and one page view now
if the user in that same session looks
at other Pages then every page that user
looks at it's going to have one unique
page view however if the user goes back
to another to the same page in the same
session then it's still going to be one
unique page view but in this case the
home page if they look at the home page
a second time then the home page is
going to have two page views if they
look at the home page five times in one
session then the home page is gonna have
five total page views and one unique
page view okay so that's why unique
pages is equivalent to one per session
where pages is an accumulation of how
many times the page was viewed in the
same session so in other words you're
always going to have more page views
than unique pages okay so this gives me
a sense of how my page is performed so
again I can look at total page views and
then engagement so ideally what you want
to do with a report like this is if a
user is not engaging on the page then
that should tell you something about the
page itself if they're not engaging if
the bounce rate's high if the time on
page is low if the exit percentage of
exit rate is high then you probably want
to do something with that page now these
are all pages but if I jump down to
landing pages my landing page report is
showing me how many people actually
landed on that page and so here I can
see under my landing page report I can
see the home page had thirty six
thousand 17 sessions in the last 30 days
that's how many people landed on the
home page so here I can see 71 percent
were news sessions meaning that I had a
lot of new users who landed on the home
page in fact 25
000 or 52 percent of the people who
landed on the home page were new I could
see the bounce rates about 42 percent
but of those who didn't bounce they went
on to look at about 4.5 pages per
session and spent about three minutes on
the site and the one thing I like about
the landing page report is I can also
see whether that particular page in this
case the home page did it help
contribute to a goal or conversion and
in this case I can see of those 36 000
sessions I had 22 transactions totaling
1200 in revenue and that's an e-commerce
conversion rate of 0.06 percent so the
home page over the last 30 days
contributed to 0.06 percent of the
revenue so this gives you an idea of
when somebody lands on your website and
they land on a page is that page helping
to move that person along meaning are
they not bouncing and is that page
helping to move people towards
converting and so that's what the
landing page in effect allows us to
measure is the engagement and in this
case we're measuring transactions okay
so analytics also gives us some other
reports under Behavior including site
speed so site speed to me is an
important report to look at just like
the mobile report to me site speed is
important because what Google analytics
does is they take a sampling of pages
and in this case you can see over the
last 30 days they sampled
2835 page views and of that sample they
came back and said the average page load
time is about four seconds now ideally
you want to keep it as quick as possible
I would say even under three seconds
okay now there are other factors
involved with page load time the browser
you're using the country that you're
actually browsing that page from might
know how to have the best infrastructure
you may not even be on the best internet
Network meaning you're on a cell network
or the Wi-Fi is not that great or you
can be on a page that just has a lot of
images or a lot of code that may slow it
down so there are other factors involved
and so what Google analytics does is
show you what those factors are so here
I can see by browser with the average
load time is if I want to look at
Country I could see what country is
contributing to the load time now the
great thing about the site speed report
is if I go to speed suggestions okay
what speed suggestions is going to do is
it's going to show me the page load Time
by Page and then it's actually going to
provide a link where I can actually
click on to get suggestions on
increasing the page load time so for
example I can look at this particular
page here this Google redesign shop by
brand slash YouTube page line number
five if I look at line number five I can
see the average load time of this page
is eight seconds almost nine seconds
okay that's an eternity to some people
now notice this link next to it so
Google's recommending seven total
suggestions so if I click on seven total
what it's actually going to do it's
going to open up a new window and it's
going to open up another Google report
called page speed insights and Page
speed insights is going to give me some
information about what I can do to
create correct correct the page load of
that particular page so look at the site
speed report it's important because
there is a correlation between site
speed or page load time and user
behavior of that page and there's also
correlation between page load time and a
page ranking organically on search so
page load time is very important it's so
important that I'm even going to save it
so I'm going to click save and click on
speed site speed suggestions as my name
and click OK and now that report is
going to be saved under customization
under save reports let's jump from
Behavior to conversions now conversion
reporting is arguably the most important
section in in Google analytics because
what the conversions reporting allows us
to do is see how people are converting
or if they're not converting on our
website and so in Google analytics we
have the opportunity to set up goals now
you have the opportunity to set up 20
goals in your Google analytics View and
so to set up a goal okay so you're going
to click on admin and Under The View
you're going to see goals and so if you
don't even have goals the first step is
to create goals and so you have four
different goal types in analytics so you
have pages per session so how many pages
per session is so if your goal is set to
say three or two if somebody actually
looked at two or three pages per session
it's going to count as a goal okay so if
I look here I could see I have pages per
session set at 10. so that means that if
a user came to the site looked at more
than 10 pages per session then it's
going to count as a goal another goal
type is destination so destination means
that if somebody actually went to a
specific page then it's going to count
as a goal and in this case I can see
here that the goal is set to this
particular page here and so when
somebody actually lands on that page
it's going to count as a goal now there
are two other goal ties we can look at
one is duration so just like pages
question in our previous example is
somebody looked at 10 pages per session
it's going to count as a goal with
duration it's based on time so in this
particular case if you set up a duration
goal and the duration is set to say one
minute and 30 seconds then that means if
a user comes to my website and they
spend at least one minute and 30 seconds
then it's going to count as a goal okay
and then the fourth type of goal in
Google analytics is an event based goal
so when you set up event tracking you
could turn that event into a goal so if
somebody clicks on say the submit button
of a form you can turn that event into a
goal so here you can see the category
equals contact form so you can always
verify if a goal works just by clicking
on verify this goal and in this case
this event is turned into a goal so
anytime somebody fires this event it's
gonna count as a goal so you have four
different goal types in Google analytics
you have pages per session destination
event and duration and so once you've
set up a goal then you can measure goals
under conversions so now if I look at
goals overview I can be able to see how
many total goal completions I've had so
if I want to look at it by goal I can
just choose the goal option here so if I
want to look at for example goal two
engaged users this was the pages per
session I can see that I had a
conversion rate of 10 meaning that I had
7 000 of all the users that came to the
website 7 000 goal completions meaning
7106 users looked at 10 pages or more on
my website and so that's how you want to
be able to measure whether users
wherever they're coming from whoever
they are whatever Pages they look at you
want to be able to look at the
conversion in reports to see if they're
actually converting based on the goals
you've set up whether that's pages per
session duration destination or event
goal conversion tracking reports can
help you measure who is actually
converting and the great thing about
Google analytics here is that I can
actually see by segments so the default
segment in a segment is just looking at
a specific user set so the default
segment is always all users however I
can choose a different segment so if I
want to choose instead of all users if I
want to choose Mobile Traffic I can
select Mobile Traffic hit apply so I'm
actually now looking at a subset of data
I'm looking at mobile traffic so if all
the mobile users have come to my site I
can see 1400 engaged or looked at 10
pages or more okay and that's a seven
percent conversion rate so the great
thing about Google analytics is you have
the opportunity to set up four different
goal types okay based on those goal
types you can go to goals overview and
look at the conversion rates of each
goal but you can also change the
segments of that particular goal to see
who exactly converted okay another
report I like under conversions is the
multi-channel funnel report so if I
click on multi-channel funnel basically
what this allows me to do is see how
different channels work together to
convert so remember the channel
reporting we looked at under acquisition
here I can see now how different
channels work together to drive the
conversion so if I look at three
channels direct organic and referral I
can see all three together drive two
percent of the conversions if I look at
direct and referral twelve and a half
percent if I look at direct and organic
12.24 so I can see how different
channels work to together and so if I
look at top conversion paths as an
example I can actually see what channels
how channels work together to drive the
conversion so in this example I can see
over the last 30 days that my top
channel grouping was direct times two
meaning that somebody came to the
website directly meaning they typed in
the URL in the browser or they
bookmarked it and came to the site okay
they came the first time but didn't
convert but then they came back a second
time via direct and then converted so
that combination is my top conversion
combination of the last 30 days my
second best conversion grouping is
organic search and direct meaning that a
user came to the website via organic
search first did not convert and then
came back via direct the second time and
converted so basically what analytics
does is give credit to the last refer
girl meaning if you came to the website
via referral or referring website and
converted then the referring website's
gonna get the credit for the conversion
but analytics does a good job of showing
you how different channels work together
so a channel may drive a lot of traffic
like organic search but that traffic may
not convert the first time around for a
number of different reasons whether it
could be brand recognition Price
shopping reading content whatever the
case analytics is able to measure if
that channel actually did contribute at
a later point and in this case we could
see organic search drove traffic that
didn't convert but that traffic came
back a second time via direct and did
convert so that's our second best
Channel grouping and so the
multi-channel funneling Report top
conversion pass to me is a good report
to look at so you can actually see not
only at channels work together but you
can see sources and mediums and
campaigns and how all that all those
different campaigns from different
sources work together to convert so
that's just a good report to look at
there are so many different reports
available in analytics there's so many
that we haven't even gotten to yet so my
advice if you look at the demo report
you can get a feel for each of these
reports under each section whether that
be audience acquisition Behavior or
conversions take a look at these reports
see what makes sense to you see what you
can use to improve your website
performance so if I go to Google
analytics and I log in okay what I want
to do is go down to admin click on admin
here and admin will take you to
basically a screen that looks like this
where you have an account column you
have your property column and then you
have review column now the view column
is where you're going to go to set up
goals okay so every view in every
property has up to 20 goals okay so by
default in analytics you're going to
have at least one view for your property
so if I have a property I'm gonna have
at least one view but if I happen to set
up multiple views like you see here then
I know for every view I set up I have 20
goals to work with so where are those
goals so Under The View I'm going to
click on goals and now I could see I
have 20 at my disposal now you can see
here by clicking on the recording column
I can see I have in this particular
property this particular view I have
five goals that are active so you can
use up to 20 but you don't have to have
20 active Okay you can have one active
two active my recommendation is least
have one goal again when you set up a
goal you're going to measure everything
in analytics against that goal okay so
in this case we have five particular
goals we're measuring so we have five
active out of 20 total so if I don't
know no longer want to use a goal I
could simply just turn it off if I want
to continue using it just turn it on
okay it's that simple you could turn on
and off goals so here I already have
five set up so if you want to set up a
new goal the one thing you need to know
in Google analytics is in order to set
up a new goal okay you need to have edit
access at least the view level I would
say at the property level so you want to
make sure whoever's in charge of Google
analytics for your organization or if
you're in charge okay you simply just
want to go to user management and user
management you want to make sure the
email address you're using to log into
Google analytics has at least edit
permissions so you're going to need edit
permissions to add new goals so I have
edit permissions I'm going to go to
goals and I want to set up a new goal
but before we jump in and set up a new
goal what is it that we want to achieve
that's really the question we want to
ask ourselves what is the goal of the
website well if it's somebody
downloading something okay are you
measuring that download via an event
okay are they filling out a form
submission before they download so if
they submit that form submission is that
the goal or do you have any Commerce
site is somebody purchasing something so
these are things you want to ask
yourself before you actually set up the
goal what is it that I'm trying to
measure now when you actually do go to
set up a goal you're going to click on
the red CTA button that says new goal so
analytics actually has some templates
set up for you okay you can see them
here okay if you're somebody's
registering online or creating an
account or reading review downloading
something sharing something you could
choose all of these options here what I
normally do is choose custom 99 of the
time I'm just going to choose custom it
doesn't really matter if you use the
template or not it's just a template is
basically some free pre-filled
configurations but my recommendation is
always just go with custom you want
total control over how to set up your
goal so we already have in mind what
type of goal we want to set up so for
example if somebody goes to fill out a
form submission and they go to a thank
you page after that well what's the URL
of that thank you page we want to be
able to track how many people go to that
page because we know if somebody does
type in or fill in a form submission and
goes to that page we know that they
filled out the form and so for example
if I go to continue I'm going to name my
goal first so I'm going to say thank you
page as an example notice analytics is
assigning an ID so notice this is goal
ID 15. that means that that's the next
available goal there are 20 goals
available in analytics and so what
analytics does is they group goals
together so one through five six through
ten eleven through fifteen sixteen
through twenty into goal sets so for
example goal 16 through 20 is part of
goal set for and why does Google
analytics combine these goals into
different goal sets well because it's
easier to measure and look at data by
goal sets so for example if I jump into
any report here if I go to all traffic
channels and I want to measure how many
goals by Channel I can look at it by
goal set so if I have goal set one
selected then I know any goal I have
active in there between goal ID one
through goal id5 I'm going to be able to
see those goals and goal set one and now
I'm going to be able to measure every
goal I have active and goal set one
against the channel so if I choose goal
set two whatever goals are active there
goal set three Etc notice I don't have
any goals 16 through 20 active that earn
goal set four therefore I don't have
that option available to me so back to
admin the bottom left navigation again
goals okay we want to measure somebody
going to the thank you page we have
added access we're going to choose
custom as our goal setup we're going to
type in a goal name I'm just going to
say thank you okay this is goal 15. now
this is the important part Google
analytics has four different goal types
destination duration pages per session
or screens percent session screens per
session is related to mobile because
Google analytics measures mobile app
activity and then you have an event so
we're going to cover all four of these
but for the sake of this simple example
I'm going to choose destination why
because if somebody goes to that thank
you page we're going to go ahead and put
in the thank you page as the goal the
goal URL so for example destination is
my choice I'm going to click continue
now this is where I'm gonna put the URL
so if my URL is just simply thank
you.html I can just go ahead and put
thank you.html or if it's just thank you
then I can just do thank you depends on
the website depends on the URI structure
so whatever that URL is that's what
you're going to put in and when you're
done you can verify it so what Google
analytics does is actually we'll verify
over the last seven days is if anybody's
actually gone to that particular page so
if we click verify we can see zero
percent conversion rate so that tells us
that if this is the correct URL then
we've had zero percent people go to that
page this is just an example however if
you didn't see a conversion then you
might want to make sure you check the
URL here that you put in and if you do
see a conversion rate then you know it's
working so Google analytics actually has
options so we're saying thank you is
equal to so the destination URL is equal
to thank you or thank you.html or thank
you dot ESP or whatever that thank you
page is okay you do have options so if
you have a long URL you could say it
begins with and you could say it begins
with say thank you so this is the logic
we're going to say hey if anybody goes
to a URL that begins with thank you then
count it as a goal or you could say
equals to so if anybody goes to a URL
that equals 2 thank you then count it as
a goal you have one more option Here
regular expression so Google analytics
understands the language of regular
Expressions so regular expressions are
just special characters used to
communicate with Google analytics in
order to hone in on exactly what you're
trying to track so we can always say you
know starts with or ends with so we can
you know use characters like the dollar
sign ends with or begins with so we can
always do that so you can use regular
Expressions as well if you're familiar
with regular Expressions if you're not
then you don't have to use them but
there are special characters where that
you can insert in that are used as
regular expression so if you're not
familiar with regular expression don't
choose that option you can choose the
other option of equals to or begins with
now now note that on all three of these
options I didn't put the domain so if my
domain is Amma Dash foundation.org and
then thank you I don't need to put the
domain because analytics are already
knows what domain we're tracking so you
don't have to put in the domain here
when you're entering in in this case the
Google URL so you can omit the domain so
when you put in that URL you know that
you have three options to work with and
then you always always want to verify
that goal URL you always want to verify
it because if you see zero percent
conversion and in this case of the last
seven days then that should tell you
something either your goal is not set up
correctly or you just don't have any
conversions either way you want to
double check that now when it comes to
the destination URL goal you do have an
option here for funnel so if I turn on
final then that means I have the ability
to track how people went through my
funnel so if I have a cart and I want to
be able to check how many people go in
and out of the cart then I have the
option of adding specific Pages as part
of the cart so we could say you know
step one which is basically cart we
could say step two is billing
information that could be slash billing
we could see step three is shipping
information slash shipping and then step
four could be you know confirm and that
could be slash confirmation so whatever
your url structure is for your cart and
it doesn't necessarily have to be a cart
basically all I'm doing is putting a
series of steps with URLs as each step
and why do I want to do that because I
can then track how many people go
through my funnel that I've created okay
so here I could see this is my funnel
that I've created for this particular
goal okay and the funnel is only
available for the destination URL so the
funnels available if you want to see
traffic through the goal okay and how
people go through the funnel and where
they drop off now you have an option
here to make the first step required so
if you make that first step required
then that means you're measuring the
funnel through the first step only now
if I turn that off then I'm measuring
the funnel through each step meaning
that I can measure people as they drop
in and out of the funnel where if it's
required the first step then I'm only
measuring traffic as it enters in the
top of the funnel so you have that
option available to you the funnel and
then for all goals you do have a value
so if somebody did actually convert Okay
Google analytics is going to count it as
a conversion and you can assign sign a
value so if you're not an e-commerce
website then you may want to think about
assigning value if you are an e-commerce
website then analytics has the ability
to track e-commerce revenue for your
website so you don't need to add a value
but in this case let's just say your
non-profit organization and you're
collecting donations
and on average over the past year every
donation that somebody contributed was
equal to five dollars well you can just
go ahead and put five dollars in there
as the value for that goal so that means
that if somebody did go to in this
example slash thank you and convert
analytics is going to count it as a goal
and then assign five dollar value
alongside that goal so if you're
non-ecommerce if you're say a non-profit
like this organization or your B2B and
you want to track some value then you
have that option there so with the
destination URL goal you have the option
of adding a funnel with all goal types
you have the option of adding a value
all goal types and we're going to go
through the rest of them you have the
option of verifying that goal so that's
the structure of setting up a goal
destination URL is just one goal type
we're going to talk about the other
three goal types because in Google
analytics there are four goal types
again destination is one of them with
destination as you do have the option
with all goal types is you have to be
able to choose your logic here so we're
going to cover that with the other three
but just know when you set up a
destination URL goal you have the option
of adding a funnel now when you actually
do set up a funnel what's going to
happen is analytics is going to measure
traffic as it goes to the final so where
do you look for that funnel information
well you want to get out of admin you
want to go to the left side navigation
you want to click on conversions then
goals then funnel visualization So based
on the funnel you set up you're going to
be able to see traffic as it goes
through the funnel so notice on this
particular funnel we don't have the
first step required why because I could
see traffic as it goes in and out of
each step of the funnel so let's go
through this funnel and see how people
react so here I can see the first step
is the store front page so over this
particular period of time I have 84
sessions enter the storefront page so
out of those 84 I can see 21 left the
storefront page 63 went on to the next
step in the funnel which is the cart
page I can then see 24 people went on to
the cart page directly and five exited
the site all together okay so that gave
me 87 total and from 87 I saw that 82
went on to the next page for the next
step what analytics does is they give
you a percentage so in the first step we
had 63 move on to the cart page out of
84 that's 75 percent so from the cart
page to the create your account page we
had 94 move on so we didn't have anybody
enter in the create your account page we
didn't have anybody leave to create your
account page so if 82 82 create your
account and then we have 82 move on to
the payment page so that's a hundred
percent okay we have one exit so we have
81 that proceeded to beyond the payment
page which was purchase so 81 of 82 is
and we started with 84. so that gave us
plus the 24 that we accumulated along
the way so that gave us a 75 funnel
conversion rate so 75 percent of the
people who entered in the funnel went on
to purchase okay so don't be confused
with the overall e-commerce conversion
rate so 75 is the funnel conversion rate
the overall conversion rate for this
particular goal is
18.45 over this particular period of
time why because that takes into account
all sessions that have won to the
website so 18 of all traffic went on to
convert but those that did go into the
final 75 converted so that's a look at
the funnel so if you set up a funnel
that's what it's going to look like you
have the option to measure everything
from step one and Beyond or measure as
traffic goes in and out of the funnel so
the purpose of this is we're going to be
able to see where traffic drops off how
effective our funnel Liz what pages we
need to address in that funnel okay so
that's the whole point of the funnel and
the funnel is available with the
destination URL goal so if I go back to
admin if I go back to goals Under The
View I can actually see what that funnel
looks like so here we chose regular
expression so this is what the URL is
okay you can see our funnel in each of
the steps we have set up notice we're
using regular Expressions here and then
if we verify this goal we could see over
the past seven days 19 conversion rate
so that tells me something's working in
this particular with this particular
goal because we do have a conversion
rate okay so that's the destination URL
goals let's now talk about the other
three types of goals so the next goal
type we're going to talk about is pages
per session so if you're not sure what
type of goal to set up for your web
website at the very least you should try
and set up either duration or Let It Go
or pages per session related goal so
let's talk about the pages per session
so basically what this goal is going to
allow us to measure is for example if we
set the goal to three pages per session
then we're going to be able to measure
if how many people went to the site and
looked at three pages per session so
let's take a look at that goal so if I
open up the goal here I can see three
pages per session is what we're naming
it so basically what we're asking
analytics to do is anything greater than
two pages which would be three and
Beyond count as a goal so if anybody
comes to the site looks at more than two
pages three pages or more then it's
going to count as a goal and so here we
can verify it so if we verified over the
last seven days we could see a 4.12
conversion rate and that tells me that
four percent of my traffic over the last
seven days looked at at least three
pages or more so you're probably asking
yourself well what number should I put
in for the actual variable so in this
case we see two well what you want to do
is you want to look at on average let's
just say year to day you want to make
sure you have statistical significance
so you want to look at a period of time
so if you go to analytics go to audience
okay and then if you go to overview and
if I change my date range to year to
date I could see on average right now I
have 1.21 pages per session so that's on
average
so we don't want to make our goal one
page we don't want to make our goal two
pages we want to make it three so we
want to be able to basically measure at
a higher rate okay why do we want to
measure at a higher rate because if 1.21
is the average then two pages per
session really isn't moving the needle
so what we really want to do is get
people to stay on the site longer look
at Pages more during their session so
look at more pages and so we want to be
able to see what segment of the audience
is looking at more pages what channels
driving traffic that's looking at more
pages what pages are contributing to
more pages per session so the whole idea
is you want to hone in on what your goal
is and see what's working and then see
what's not working so you can make
adjustments the whole idea be on Google
analytics is to improves website
performance and so if our average is 1.2
then if we change it to just 2 it may
not be good enough so in this case you
know we want to up the bar a little bit
so we're going to choose three now you
can choose four or five that's perfectly
fine just know if your average is 1.2 I
wouldn't choose one page per session as
my goal and I probably wouldn't choose
two so I'd set the bar a little bit
higher now the third goal type available
in Google analytics is also engagement
related and that's duration so just like
pages per session we can measure how
long somebody stays on the website and
we could set up a goal for that so in
this case I have a goal set for one
minute 30 seconds so my goal type is
duration so if I click continue then
basically I'm asking analytics in this
case anybody who stays more than one
minute and 30 seconds on the website
count it as a goal and so so before you
actually put in the number of hours
minutes and seconds you want to look at
that average so if you go back to
audience overview here I can see a
minute and seven so do we want a minute
and 30 maybe we could do that maybe we
can go with two minutes so again the
whole point is you want to set the bar a
little bit higher than what the average
is and so here I could see over the last
seven days if I verify this particular
goal I can see eight percent of my
traffic over the last seven days stayed
on the site at least one minute and 31
seconds okay they stay greater than one
minute and thirty and so the whole point
is you can hone in because this is a
goal I can go in this is goal okay this
is a goal here and so I could see that
this is gold 13. so now I can go to
acquisition as an example I can go to
channels as an example since this is I
go this is goal 13 so that would be in
goal set three so I can actually see
what channel is basically driving that
goal okay in other words what channel is
driving traffic that is staying on the
side at least one minute 30 seconds and
so that's the whole idea behind goals so
likewise for pages per session we can go
into channels and here I can see we have
a over this period of time year to date
pages per session we have three percent
conversion rate and here I could see for
example organic search has a 13
conversion rate here I could see social
media has a 10 so I could see that or
people coming from organic search are
staying on the site longer or they're
looking at more pages than any other
channel so just like duration or
destination or any goal you set up you
can measure that goal against any
Dimension just because his engagement
doesn't mean you can't you absolutely
can and so the whole point of Engagement
related goals is to figure out what's
driving traffic the site but what
traffic is engaging so you want to be
able to pinpoint that so you can improve
website performance now the fourth goal
type available in Google analytics is an
event so if you click on new goal
include custom click continue you have
the option to choose an event so an
event is something that you can measure
on your website that analytics can't
measure by default so if you want to
measure PDF downloads or clicks on
buttons or clicks on play buttons on a
video or click on a submit button or
click on an external link I mean you can
measure pretty much anything with an
event then you want to be able to turn
that event into a goal so let's quickly
summarize what an event is so again we
want to be able to measure a particular
event that happens on the website so in
order to do so we need to identify that
event so if I go to for example this
particular website here and I want to
measure how many times somebody clicks
on the Donate Now button well if I met I
can measure that as an event so when you
set up an event in analytics you have to
actually assign a category and an action
for that event so that's the first thing
you need to do when you identify an
event or let it go first you need to set
up the event in order to set up the
event you need to assign a category in
action okay so once you identify what
you want to track as an event on your
website you're actually going to go on a
tag manager or have your web Master go
on a tag manager and set up a tag and in
that tag they're going to assign that
particular category in action and so
here you can see we have this set up our
category is named donate now and our
action is click and that's what we want
to do we want to measure how many people
click on that donate Now button so
anytime somebody does that then the
category donate now is going to appear
in analytics with the action click so
when you actually do set up an event you
can go into analytics and you could test
that event so if I go to the website and
I click donate now Okay the reason why I
have this as an event is because I'm
taking to a third-party website to
handle the donations so here I can go
into analytics and now I can see a
category is being fired for header
donate with the action click so that's
my category and that's my action so that
category in action is what is firing
after somebody clicks on the Donate Now
button so if I want to turn this event
into a goal I can easily do that now
that I've set up the event now that I've
identified the category in action I want
to go back to admin and set up the event
with these parameters in place so just
turns out we already have the goal set
up so let's go through how this goal is
set up so first we chose custom we chose
event we gave it a name so has the best
practice when you actually set up a goal
as an event or turn an event into a goal
I would add the prefix event colon to it
and then that way when you're
identifying goals in your reporting you
know it's an event so I'm going to click
continue and now that I've actually have
set up the event already in Google tag
manager I giving it a category give it
an action okay see here you can see we
have a regular expression set up so
anything with the header donate or
donate is going to fire this goal so
over the last seven days I have a 0.81
conversion rate okay I could have easily
put in equals two and put in whatever
the action what or the category which is
donate now or I could have put action
equals click I could have done that as
well so let me show you another example
here so if I do this custom continue
events donate now here's my goal ID it's
going to be an event so all I need to do
is put in the category in action so
donate now and then click so that's all
I have to do and that's my goal so I can
verify it okay to see if anybody's fired
it and basically that's what I need to
do to turn that event into to a goal
okay so you need to set up for an event
first you need to identify the event set
it up and Google tag manager which is
another platform and once you've done
that then you have your category in
action once you have your category in
action you're again going to go into
analytics and then simply put in that
category in action into the appropriate
fields to set up your event related goal
now all events don't have to be turned
into a goal if you actually do set up an
event and you're not worthy of a goal
meaning it's not a kpi or a dozen align
with your business goals well don't fret
you can always just go to behavior okay
you can always go to events you can
always go to overview and measure your
events that way so here you can see all
of our events that are fired now we do
have this one turn into a goal so if
it's important for a business then we
want to make sure we we convert that
particular event into a goal okay if
it's not important for example
somebody's just clicking on a social
button then you don't necessarily have
to turn that event into a goal if you
don't want to know that it's sitting
here under events under Behavior so the
point I'm trying to make here if it's
important to your business and you're
already tracking it as an event via
Google tag manager then feel free to
turn it into a goal all you need is a
category all you need is that action and
so so one final note on that event
related goal just like any other goal
you can add a value okay so if I have an
event set up I can choose to add a value
here or in Google tag manager if I've
assigned a value to that event so if I
go back to the actual event and Google
tag manager you can see I have a value
set up for one dollar then I could just
go into analytics and say you know what
I already have the value added so go
ahead and use the value added in Google
tag manager okay so I'm going to choose
yes now if I choose no I have the option
to add the value here just like I would
with any other goal so just keep that in
mind you can add a value to any goal
type with an event related go you can
add the value right into the tag in
Google tag manager just as I've done
here so remember when you actually set
up your goals whether it's a destination
pages per session duration or an event
you can just go ahead and choose that
goal set that it's in and measure any
Dimension against that particular goal
so here I can see e newsletter sign ups
by Channel I can go into another goal
set here I can see contact form
submissions okay I can see what
particular channels driving contact form
submissions okay so just know that you
can align a goal against any Dimension
so if you have e-commerce you don't have
to set up for goal for that that's
separate but if you want to take a look
at your goals and analytics and on its
own you can just go to conversions goals
overview here I can actually get a good
sense of how my goals are performing
over a period of time so again if I
choose for example year to date now I
could see based on the goals I've set up
how many total goal completions value
which takes into account the value we've
added into these goals okay the total
conversion rate and here I can see it
broken down by the goal I actually have
set up and I can see it by Page or I
could see it by Source a medium so I
could see Google organic is driving the
most gold completions then Google CPC
direct and then I could see some others
in here as well out contributing to
goals now I do want to point your
attention to another report in Google
analytics that does take into account
goals and that's multi-channel funneling
so again under conversion goals
multi-channel funnels if I go to
assistant conversions I can actually see
what channel in this example is
assisting with the conversions I've set
up and so what do we mean by assistive
conversions well that means that if a
channel let's just say organic search
drove traffic to the website and that
traffic didn't convert when it arrived
at the website and left but it came back
a week later via another Channel let's
just say email and when they came back
via email they did convert during that
session well what analytics does is they
give an assist to organic search because
they help Drive the traffic to the
website so it's similar to the game of
basketball if I have the ball and I pass
it to my colleague and my colleagues the
one who scores because they had the ball
last well they get the credit for the
point I.E the conversion but I get an
assist and so analytics works the same
way they're always going to give credit
to the last click or direct conversion
but they will give credits to the
channel in this case that assisted with
the conversion so that's under a cystic
inversion and that's based on the goals
you have set up you can highlight any
particular goal here if I want to hone
in on say the Donate clicks only then
I'm going to be able to see what
contributed to that particular goal so
there's another report in here top
conversion pass that I think is
important so after you set up your goals
you can actually see what channels in
this particular example help to Drive
conversions again this is year to day so
I can see all the different combinations
of channels that work together
to contribute to a conversion so again I
can choose a specific goal or I can
choose all my goals so those two reports
are under multi-channel funneling
there's also another report that I think
is good that's time lag meaning how long
did it actually take somebody to convert
so here you can see most of our
conversions 265 year-to-date happen on
the day somebody arrived on the website
but I could see I did get some
conversions a day later two days later
Etc so you have time lag top conversion
pass assistant conversions they're all
under multi-channel funneling and
they're all available after you set up
at least one goal and so if you're not
sure what goal to set up okay don't fret
you can always at least set up an
engagement related goal so that's
available to you duration pages per
session you also have destination and
event tracking and they're all available
to you you have 20 available per view
now if you're not quite sure exactly
what type of goal to set up there is an
option available in analytics and that's
the gallery so you can always import a
goal from the gallery so in other words
we could take a look at what other
people have set up in terms of goals so
you just have to click on the button
import from gallery and it'll take you
to the gallery and you'll be able to see
what are the goals others have set up so
many of you out there have a website
similar to the one I'm looking at now
this is a non-profit that I work with
I'm a foundation and like this website
and probably like your website you
probably have some interactivity on
there that needs to be tracked for
example buttons if you have buttons like
this one that says donate or newsletter
sign up or there's a PDF download or a
video that needs to be you know tracked
based on the amount of people who click
on the play button so I mean all sorts
of inter activity on a website have you
ever wondered how to track that well
there is a way to track that because by
default Google analytics can't track
interactivity and engagement on your
website like you probably want to have
your website tracked so if you have
buttons and videos and things of that
nature that you want to have tracked but
you're going to need event tracking and
if you're in analytics and you're always
wandering around the data and you happen
to find yourself under events well if
you want events on your website and you
want data to populate under Behavior top
events you're going to need to set up
event tracking so event tracking is a
two-part process and we're going to talk
about that two-part process the first
part of that is to identify what you
want to track okay so if we go back to
our example website here I'm a
foundation again we noted there's a lot
to track here we gotta donate now Bob we
got a newsletter sign up we have some
social icons okay we got a donate Now
button here we got a play button here
got all sorts of interactivity you know
we got a button here that says you know
purchase tickets for an upcoming event I
can go throughout the website and find
different buttons and things to to track
let me just say this there's no shortage
of what you can track on your website
with event tracking so event tracking is
just basically in layman's terms
tracking engagement on your site because
Google analytics by default is only
going to track page view data meaning
how somebody got to your website what
page they looked at how long they stayed
on that page what page they left from
more or less their timing how long
somebody stays on the website and what
pages they look at so there's more to a
website than just how long somebody
stayed on a page and so in this example
we want to be able to track everything
here not just the donating album but
everything because once you get the hang
of event tracking then it's very easy to
set up okay so step one identify what
you want to track okay so there's a lot
we want to track we're just going to use
one example to start off with and that's
going to be this donate Now button okay
so this donate Now button we want to
track now we have a newsletter sign up
we have Facebook and and that's fine you
could track all that but for the sake of
going through a step-by-step process
today let's just focus on the Donate Now
button what's focus on the Donate Now
button then we'll come back and start
tracking these other things but this is
what we want to track to start out with
okay so step one identify what you want
to track now when it comes to tracking
events on a website you want to identify
find those events so we did that by
choosing this donate Now button now once
we identify what we want to track we
need to assign two parameters for that
event so with event tracking you have
three parameters but one is actually
optional so you have two mandate
mandatory parameters that you have to
assign to everything you want to track
on your website and that's the category
and then the action so event label or
label is the third parameter but again
that's optional okay so basically when
we identify an event on our website we
want to assign it a category and an
action okay so why do we want to assign
it a category in an action because when
we're in analytics under Behavior under
events top events we could see we have
different categories here and we have
different actions we have different
labels so if I click on any one of these
Dimensions I'm going to be able to see
sum of the parameters I've entered in
for previous events I'm tracking okay so
the whole idea is you want to be able to
group different events together into a
category and assign an action and assign
a label to it that's really what you're
doing you're just grouping and
identifying the events you're trying to
track and so in this case I have this
donate Now button sitting in the header
okay in fact I have a lot of things
sitting in the header so if I wanted to
and I want to track all these buttons I
can create a category called header and
then if I track all these buttons all
these buttons can sit in that same
category if I wanted to or I can create
a separate category for each of these
buttons it's up to you how you organize
your categories because basically all
you're doing is giving a name to what
you're trying to track and the name is
equivalent to a category so in this case
the Donate Now button is very important
I'm just going to call it category
header donate now I need to give an
action to each category and so in this
case I'm just going to say click because
that's what the action is doing it's
it's somebody's taking the action of
clicking now if it's a video and it's a
play button I can assign an action of
play it's up to you whatever you name
these parameters you just need to be
organized and methodical about what you
name it that's all and so in this case
header donate and then click okay and so
that's our category in action and so
that's clearly step two so step one
identify what you want to track step two
assign a category action and or label
but remember label is optional so if we
go back in analytics here I could see
some categories and if I click on action
I can see some actions that I've named
now step three so we've identified in
Step One what we want to track we've
assigned a category in action so step
three is going into Google tag manager
to set up the event okay so if you're
not familiar with Google tag manager
then you can easily just you know do a
Google search for Google tag manager and
basically you'll have all sorts of
information on it there's a good video
overview of tag manager here that you
can watch so tag manager basically is
what we want to use to set up event
track and now tag managers use for a lot
of different things but the main thing
we're doing here is setting up an event
for our website and so I'm logged in to
the same email address I'm using for
analytics okay so now I'm in tag manager
and I want to set up my event for this
donate Now button so what do I need to
do well for every event I want to set up
I need to set up a tag okay so if I go
to tags I can see I already have some
tags set up up and some of these are
events and so when you actually set up a
tag I recommend having a naming
convention so here you can see any event
we set up we start out by calling it GA
Dash event Dash whatever it is we're
trying to set up and so in this case we
want to set up a new tag for the Donate
Now button on our website so we're in
Google tag manager because tag manager
is what's going to fire that event so if
I click on new okay and I click on tag
configuration I'm going to choose Google
analytics and then I'm going to choose
event as my track type so we want the
data to show up in Google analytics and
we're tracking an event we're not
tracking a page view we're tracking an
event and so now remember in step two
you identified what you want to call
that category you identify what you want
to call that action and you have some
optional parameters like label so first
things first header donates the name of
our category story and our action is
click and if you want to add in a label
and a value so if you want to sign a
value you can if you want to add in a
label you can okay those are optional so
you just need to focus on category in
action and then the last setting here
that's probably worth mentioning is a
non-interaction hit okay so this is
automatically set to false and why is it
set to false because it's a
non-interaction no that's false we want
this event if somebody clicks on the
header donate to be an interaction so
for example if I land on this page here
and I click on that donate Now button
that I'm tracking as an event and I
actually leave the site because I have
my settings set to false I want that
click to be an interaction then
analytics is not going to count a bounce
if I change it to true so from false to
true then that means it is going to be
an
non-interaction if somebody lands on the
page and if somebody clicks on the
button so I don't want it to be a bounce
I want it to be an interaction so my
advice is leave it set to false we're
going to choose Google analytics as our
setting here this is our variable for
Google analytics so in other words that
variable is set to our analytics
property ID and more or less that's what
you need to do to set up the tag okay
you need to in step two identify the
category in action and or label and or
value now value can be anything you want
you're assigning a numerical value so if
you just assign one anytime that event
fires in analytics it's going to have a
value of one okay and so we have our
non-interaction set to fall so anytime
the event fires it's going to count as
an interaction and therefore not count
as a bounce if somebody landed on that
page so that's more or less all you need
to do to set up the tag and Google tag
manager now if somebody else is setting
up the tag for you then again you want
to revert to step two you want to be
able to give that person the appropriate
category action and or label and or
value why because you're the one that's
going to be going into Google analytics
and you're the one that's going to have
to go to behavior events top events and
look for the particular at category in
action and or label so you need to be
able to communicate that information to
whomever is setting up the tag now if
it's you great you already know what it
is because you're entering that
information into tag manager so in this
case I'm going to go ahead and choose a
variable for my label parameter and why
do I want to do that because in tag
manager I have something at my disposal
called variables and variables allow you
to see specifically things that are
being tracked so in this case I chose
page path okay so pagepath is a URL and
why did I choose pagepath as my variable
for the parameter label because if
somebody does click on the header donate
button and the header donate button on
our website is on every page so if I go
to the children's page I'm still going
to see that header donate button and so
for me I want to be able to see what
page somebody clicked on that hitter
donate button and so this allows me to
actually see in Google analytics what
page somebody clicked on the header
donate Now button and so now if I go
back to GTM Google tag manager I have a
category I have an action and I have a
label which is a variable okay so note
that in Google tag manager you have a
lot of different variables at your
disposal and variables are there to help
help you identify specifically what is
being tracked so take a look at all the
variables at your disposal and tag
manager in this example I'm using page
path so now once you set up your tag
pretty straightforward again tag types
Google analytics track type is event you
are assigning the category action and or
label and or value you're changing or
leaving the default in place for
non-interaction hit and then you're
choosing the variable for Google
analytics which is your property ID so
once you've done that you have a tag the
second part of setting up a tag is to
assign a trigger to that tag so tag
manager needs to be able to know when to
fire that event and so here I'm going to
look at a trigger I've already set up
for this particular event and so if I
click on it I'll be able to see that
what it is is a click on some links not
all links but some links I'm actually
saying Hey Google tag manager fire this
event when the click ID equals header
donate button now it just so happens
that if somebody did click on this
donate Now button they're gonna go to
another website in this case
networkforgood.com so in tag manager I
could have set the trigger to equal URL
equal instead of Click ID I could have
said URL equal
networkforgood.com so that could have
been my Logic for my trigger in this
case I decided to go with the click ID
and so in this case that button has an
ID associated with it called header
donate button so if you wanted to use
click ID for your event for your button
you could simply just go to the website
you can right click on that button and
click inspect element and so when I
actually inspect the element I can see
now the button here you can see it's
highlighted in the upper Pane and in the
lower pane I can see where it's linking
to it's linking to networkforgood.com
but here you can see if I hone in a
little and I could see ID equals header
Dash donate dash button so that's the
click ID notice there's also a class I
could have set the trigger to equal this
class or again I could have set the
trigger to equal the URL or the page
that this button is pointing to I could
have chosen any one of those but I
decided to go with the ID so this is the
ID I chose and that's the ID I have in
my trigger okay so that is what's going
to fire that event so if somebody clicks
on a button that equals header Dash
donate dash button it's going to to fire
that event which is going to equal
category header donate action click and
then the label is going to be page path
so now that we've set up our event we
want to test to see if it actually works
so there's two ways to go about testing
an event and the first way is through
Google analytics so if we go to Google
analytics and then we go to real time
okay we can go to events and here you
can see one is already fired so let's go
ahead and go to and test this and go to
the website so if I go here for example
and I click on amagar alumni okay so if
I click on that you can see I'm under
our family and if I click on that button
then go back to analytics and look at
real time I should be able to see this
event fire so if I click on it I'm going
to go to network for good now if I go
back to analytics here in real time
under real time under events per second
I can see that event firing category
equals header donate the action equals
click now if I click on the category
here I can see the label the label
remember was page path and here you can
see this event fired on the our family
page which was the page I was just on so
that's one way to test to see if your
event works and in this case analytics
recognize the event so it works it fired
and so therefore it's going to show up
under Behavior under events you can go
under overview or top events okay and
what am I going to look for in this case
I'm going to look for header donate okay
if I click on header donate as my
category I'm going to be able to see my
action and if I click on action I'll be
able to see my label in this case home
page and then later on when the data
propagates in analytics I'll be be able
to see under label the page that I
clicked on that header donate button
which is slash our family okay the
second way in which you can test to see
if an event fires is if you preview so
if I click on preview in tag manager
okay I'm going to go into preview mode
okay in preview mode allows you to see
in analytics and tag manager and on the
website what tags are firing so here I
could see I'm in preview mode now so I'm
going to go to the website and I'm going
to refresh and in my browser same
browser I'm using for tag manager I can
see the tags that are being fired on
this page already okay because I'm in
preview mode so here I could see
remarketing I could see page views I
could see Google optimize I could see
some tags that are already firing on
this page now if I click on this button
here by holding down my shift command
and then click on that button I'll be
able to see that the tag fired in
preview mode there's my event header
donate and I can see it fired so now I
can see it fired in the preview mode so
in addition to Google analytics in
preview mode I could see that that tag
is fired and I know that it's working so
there you have you have two ways to test
to see if the event fires again you have
real time and analytics okay so in real
time if you just go up to real time all
you need to do is go down to events go
to your website click on the button if
you see it firing in real time then you
know it works the second version or
second way to test your event is through
the preview mode okay if you see it
firing in preview mode then you know
it's also working okay so let's rehash
our steps first step is we want to be
able to identify what we want to track
okay so it could be this newsletter sign
up it could be click on a Facebook it
could be anything we want to be able to
track an image a click on a CTA button
whatever we want to track identify it
second step identify the category action
and label because that's what's going to
show up in Google analytics remember
label is optional variable or excuse me
value is optional third step go into tag
manager actually set up your tag and
your trigger so if you set up a tag and
it's an event name it GA Dash events
that way you can see in your list of
tags and tag manager what event tracking
you have already set up so when you set
up your tag you set up your trigger your
trigger is based on logic that can be a
URL it can be a click ID it can be a
class ID whatever you want to use to
fire that event and then once you do
that you you want to test it you could
test it in GTM or you could test it in
Google analytics if it doesn't fire you
want to tweak your trigger if it does
fire then great and then one thing I
would recommend is if you're setting up
various events for your website as a
best practice what I would recommend is
set up a spreadsheet and in that
spreadsheet you know you want to put a
note what's firing what are you doing to
fire it could be in this case someone
somebody clicks on the Donate Now button
in the header you want to put the tag
name in here the type okay then you want
to record your category action and label
and then the great thing about events is
you could turn those events into goals
and that's as simple as going back into
analytics okay so if I go into analytics
and I go to admin and I go to goals if
you set up a new goal okay all you need
to do is choose custom click continue
you're going to choose event as your
goal name and then from a naming
perspective in Google analytics for your
goal I would definitely put event first
and then click on header donate okay so
if I click now continue what is my
category it's equal to header donate my
action is click and so I can verify to
see if this is working and here I can
see in analytics that the goal would
have a 0.22 percent conversion rate so
that tells me that the goal is working
and I can turn this event into a goal
and when you turn something into a goal
in analytics then you can measure it
across all dimensions that's what I
would recommend if the event is equal to
a kpi or business goal or it's of
importance something you really want to
measure okay if it's just a click say on
a Facebook button I wouldn't recommend
setting that up as a goal okay so once
you've set up your event you're recorded
it in your spreadsheet it's firing you
want to be able to then go back into
Behavior back into events okay you can
go to top events okay so top events tell
you by category as a default what events
are firing or what category is firing
the most okay so if I choose my date
range here I can just go to here to date
so here I can see my enter donate button
fortunately for me has the most total
events now notice in analytics you also
see unique events and so the difference
between unique events and total events
is that unique events are equivalent to
one per session where total events means
that somebody can come to your website
initiate a session and click on that
button multiple times in the same
session so if I go to the alma
Foundation website okay I can click on
that donate Now button three or four or
five different times in the same session
so what analytics is going to do is
actually in that session count it once
but accumulate the number of clicks as a
total event for that session so you're
always going to have more total events
than unique events because in some cases
users May click on the button more than
once in the same session and so here I
can see total events unique events and
if I added a value to that event I
should be able to see it here so if I
added a dollar as an example to this
particular event because it had 164
unique events I should be able to see
164 as my value but since I see Zero
that means that I did not assign value
and so average value basically is just
giving me how much average I have per
event so it's taking into account the
number of or the value the total value 2
divided by the total number of unique
Pages or sessions and so because I don't
have value I'm not going to have average
value but here you can see because value
is optional here I can at least see how
many events or how many clicks I receive
for a particular button again it could
be a video if I clicked on this video as
an example I can see how many people
actually started it I could see the
unique and the total events and if I
click on label if I have a label
assigned then I'll be able to see what
page triggered that event so if we go
back again to our header donate button
back to category if we click on label as
our primary Dimension here we can see
the home page had the most unique events
been followed by the children's page the
contact form Etc so what you can do in
analytics you can also look at the pages
that have driven events so here I could
see the home page has accumulate related
the most total events followed by the
contact us so that's how you would look
at the data in Google analytics under
Behavior under events and then under top
events or overview is where you can
start analyzing your event tracking so
first you need to do identify it assign
a category action enter label set up
that tag and Trigger once you do that
once you test that it's working this is
where you're going to go to analyze the
data let's start out with why GTM so
let's just say your Sam and you have
your own e-commerce website you want to
understand how people are interacting
with your website well Sam today's world
of websites contain a lot of
interactivity everything from videos to
PDF downloads to commenting to form
submissions uh to all sorts of chat
functionality interactivity going on
throughout the website so there's just a
lot that you need to track outside of
just page views and so really what GTM
does is they help you track all these
things I just mentioned everything from
somebody clicking on the play button of
a PDF to somebody clicking on the submit
button of a form to somebody entering in
something on a chat function so that's
what GTM is so why GTM because it helps
us track all that interactivity so all
GTM is is really allows you to really
place a piece of java code which is just
script and this script that's added to a
web page to collect information so
that's really what a tag is it's just
some script that gets put on a web page
in order for you to collect information
like page views clicks Etc and they send
it to third-party tools okay so that's
what GTM does it basically allows you to
take all these tags that collect
information and you can use them in GTM
so if you want to for example collect
how many people you know enter a chat
functionality and start chatting well
you're going to take that script and
you're going to put it in GTM and GTM
will then allow you to start tracking
that information so that's really what
GTM is it just allows you to put tags
into a container or think of it as a toy
box you have all these toys and you want
to track well you can put all those
those toys or tags in a toy box or
container we're going to talk a little
bit more about that but before we get
into GTM let's just say you know you're
communicating with your developer and
there's a new user request on your web
page and you want to update the tag well
your developer considering it's probably
a small update your website is probably
gonna not hesitate Tate and is going to
go ahead and turn around and do it
normally and so normally what happens is
the developer is going to go to the
website and update the tag well what if
you have a few things that you want to
track all those things I mentioned
before from downloads to clicks to you
know somebody checking out to watching a
video well your Web Master your web
developer is going to go well hold on a
second now all these requests are going
to take time I need to put them into the
work queue so to speak well what happens
is when they go into work queue usually
it's going to take some time and in some
cases you as a marketer need to launch a
campaign and you want to get that
tracking added to the website in time
for the campaign launch so you want to
go ahead and quickly turn around the
tracking for that particular campaign
let's just say you're launching a
campaign and you're sending people to a
landing page that has a form submission
and you want to be able to track how
many people click on the submit button
of that form submission well if you need
to turn that around your developer's
like well I need to put that in a work
queue the timing isn't going to always
work out between you and your developer
is my point and so that's where GTM
comes in because there is a solution to
update your tags faster and that's
Google tag manager so when we say GTM
that's what GTM stands for Google tag
manager it's a place for you to add tags
quickly and easily so tags remember are
just Snippets of code that allow you to
track things on your website
interactively interactive actively and
basically when you have GTM you can
bypass the webmaster and do it quickly
and easily so that's what GTM is all
about so why GTM because we just
identified two benefits one you could
track all the interactivity on your
website and two you can bypass your web
developer or webmaster and so that's the
benefit of GTM so the benefit you get
those tags updated very quickly via
Google tag manager okay so that's what
tag manager is so what we're going to
talk about today is specifically what
tag manager is and what it does we're
going to list some of the benefits of
tag manager we're going to show you how
it works and then we're going to show
you how to get started with tag manager
tag manager if you're not familiar with
working with webmasters and dealing with
JavaScript and tags and all this jargon
is just new to you today okay well don't
fret sit back we're gonna take it slow
this is an introduction into Google tag
manager again let's start out with what
is tag manager so we've already
introduced it to some degree because we
already introduced as a tool where you
can put all your tags into a toolbox toy
box or container so to speak right and
we already already mentioned that hey
you can bypass your webmaster so you're
probably thinking well if I'm if you're
not familiar with tag manager how can I
bypass my webmaster well first about to
free tool and it's a Google tool hence
the name Google tag manager and it helps
you really that's the main point it's
deploy and track tags on your website
bypassing your webmaster so that's tag
manager and so examples of tags that can
be deployed via Google tag manager are
numerous these are just some examples
like Google analytics Facebook's pixel
tracking or Google ads There's No Limit
into the number of texts you can track
and tag manager there is no limit you
can add any number of tracking tags and
tag manager okay so some of the benefits
well again I we just listed two you can
put any tag into tag manager and track
that onto your website and we know you
can bypass your web developer or
webmaster and what it also does is it
also allows you to test and deploy your
JavaScript codes quicker so remember
these JavaScript codes or Snippets of
codes are are just there to track
certain things on your website whether
that be a page view or somebody clicking
on a play button or tracking somebody
who converts or even just goes to your
website so the biggest benefit is you
can take that snippety code let's just
say Facebook let's just say you're
growing Facebook marketing and you want
to put that Facebook pixel on your
website so that you could track people
who come from Facebook and convert well
you don't need to put that Facebook
pixel on your website you can go right
to tag manager and you can put that
snippet of code right in tag manager
really quickly and the other benefit
here is all tags are managed in one
place and that's that to me is really a
good benefit because when you start
adding tags on your website and you have
some tags and tag manager it just gets
very confusing so ideally all the
tracking codes you have on your website
needs to be in tag manager think about
that all the tracking so if you're doing
Bing or you're doing Facebook or you're
doing Twitter or you're doing LinkedIn
and you're doing Google you're doing all
this type of marketing on all these
different platforms you're going to have
tracking code for all these different
platforms and instead of putting all
that code on your website return gonna
slow down the load time of your web page
and website you want to put them all in
tag manager so they can be organized and
you know exactly what you're trying to
track and the other great benefit of tag
manager is there's a versioning control
so let's just say you have added tags to
your website via GTM for the last six
months well and let's just say you add
another tag yesterday if you added that
tag yesterday and something doesn't work
well you can just roll back to a
previous version It's that simple so you
have versioning and that's that's a good
thing when you have versioning you can
control what gets published and if
something doesn't work after it gets
published then you can roll back to a
previous version so it's a a peace of
mind so to speak just because you've
added code to your site there's no
guarantee it's going to work and so you
can always control what version you're
dealing with in tag manager and we'll
talk a little bit more about that so the
biggest benefit here to me with tag
manager is you have event tracking and
so we talked about some of the things
you could track on your website from
videos from play buttons to somebody
clicking on the stop on the video or
pausing it all the way to somebody again
chatting or let's just say somebody
clicking on that purchase button on your
website okay and you want to track all
these different things these different
interactivities and buttons well event
tracking is what you're going to use to
track all those buttons and to me this
is the biggest benefit of tag manager
and I'll show you some examples as we go
along and if we didn't mention it
already I'll mention it again it is free
tag manager is free there's no limit so
once you have tag manager going you can
add as many tracking codes as you want
there's no limit on the number of
tracking codes you can add to tag
manager okay so it's it's free and you
can use it to its fullest Advantage okay
so it's also high security meaning that
it has different levels of permissions
okay so you can have uh somebody just go
in and look at the different tags and
tracking codes you have in GTM or you
can ask somebody who is very familiar
with tag manager it can go in and add
the tracking code to tag manager and
then publish that tracking code when it
gets added so those are all the benefits
let's talk about how it works now
specifically how does tag Manager work
because you're like Rob okay again a lot
of jargon you know you you got tags and
JavaScript and and versioning and
Publishing and all this other stuff well
I know I'm throwing a lot at you at once
but just bear with me here okay so let's
start talking about how it actually
works so you have a website okay
whatever that domain is you have a
website and there's chances are on your
website you have some form of
interactivity whether that be a video
whether that be a Blog whether it be a
form submission you have a website with
some interactivity and let's just say
you're even thinking about getting ready
to launch some type of campaign on maybe
Google or Facebook and you want to drive
traffic to your website fair enough
you're joining the millions of other
websites that are out there that have
interactivity that also Drive traffic to
the website so incomes Google tag
manager and so tag manager is important
because again we know we want to track
people coming from that Facebook
campaign or that Google campaign and
interacting with our site so if you are
running Facebook and you are running
Google analytics well guess what you
want to put that tracking code in tag
manager so Google analytics being a
Google product works very nicely with
tag manager Facebook has its own
tracking code but you still want to be
able to track people who come from the
Facebook campaign to your website so
you're gonna get that tracking code from
Facebook and put it in tag manager
that's generally how it works so so pair
information from your website is shared
with another data source through tag
manager so think about that if I add
Facebook tracking code to tag manager or
let's just say a Google analytics
tracking code to tag manager tag manager
is the one that's pushing out and doing
all the heavy lifting they're the ones
that are controlling what code gets
fired and what code doesn't so if you're
putting the code in tag manager tag
managers controlling the code think
about it that way and let's show you an
example of what that looks like so here
I am I'm in tag manager I just went to
tag
manager.google.com and here I can see a
list of tags so in our conversation
we're talking about tracking Facebook
and we're talking about tracking Google
analytics well Google analytics is easy
because it's a Google product so here if
I look at all the different tracking
code I have on my website through tag
manager let's just take a look at Google
analytics so if you're going to use Tag
manager you might as well put the Google
and analytics code in here so here I can
see I have Google analytics as a tag in
tag manager now for Facebook if I'm
running a Facebook campaign well I can
take that pixel tracking and put it in
GTM as well and here I could see
Facebook pixel that is that code is
added to GTM I just basically took what
Facebook gave me and put it in a Google
tag manager so you can see I can add
Facebook and Google analytics and again
I can't stress it enough any tracking
code from any platform I can add to
Google tag manager in order to track the
behavior from those sources so let's
take a little bit deeper dive into how
tag manager works so I just showed you
an example of how you could take
Facebook and Google analytics code and
put it in the tag manager but if you're
not familiar with tag manager then how
do I do that well let's talk about the
structure and how tag manager works so
when you have a tag man your account you
have a container remember I mentioned
Toy Box earlier you have a bunch of toys
if they're they're code and you're
tracking different bits of code from
different platforms like Facebook think
of those as toys and you have a toy box
okay well that's what this code is and
that's what a container is the code is
the code and that's going to go into the
toy box or container and so the way tag
manager works is you have tags triggers
and variables so if I take my Facebook
tracking code and put it into a
container I need to set up a tag and a
trigger okay so let's take a look at
what that is so first if I go back to
tag manager I'm going to have an account
and if I have an account I'm going to
have a container so here I'm just going
to click on an account with a container
and a container is nothing more than
what website you're adding the tracking
code to okay that's all the container is
we're just letting tag manager know this
is the website we're adding all this
code too so you have tags triggers and
variables that's the structure of tag
manager so tags are just what it says
tags what are we trying to quote unquote
tag well if it's Google analytics that's
easy here I could see I have Google
analytics added so if I click on Google
analytics here's my tag and if I take a
little bit of a deeper dive there since
Google analytics is a Google product it
integrates already with tag managers
it's pretty easy I can just choose
Google analytics then I'm going to check
page view and that's my tag now every
tag needs a trigger okay so I need to
tell tag manager how or when to fire the
Google analytics tracking code so in
this case I'm going to tell tag manager
to fire on all pages so if I get
somebody a visitor to my website
analytics is firing on all pages so
whatever change that visitor lands on
Google analytics is gonna fire so that's
really what it comes down to is I have a
tag and I need to tell tag manager when
to trigger that tag that's really what
the structure of tag manager is it's
tags triggers and variables and
variables we're going to talk about here
in a couple minutes but do you have a
piece of code you're going to go ahead
and put that into tag manager you're
going to tag it and then you're going to
fire that trigger so let's take a look
at another example here if I go back
here you can see Facebook well here's my
Facebook pixel okay that's my tag so
when is it gonna fire well it's gonna
fire on a specific domain or subdomain
that's basically what we're doing we're
trying to tell GTM when to fire that
particular tag so those are the three
main components a tag okay which is
going to contain the JavaScript code
that you get from say Facebook the
trigger so you're going to go into tag
manager and tell tag manager want to
fire that code that's the trigger and
then you have variables and so variables
are basically just additional
information that tag manager may need
for your tag and Trigger to work so
that's what a variable is it's there to
get the tag and Trigger to fire so
variables are divided into built-in and
user-defined variables so common used
variables include say page path or page
URL or hostname or click class again
they're there and these examples I just
gave you are there to get your tag and
Trigger to work think about it that way
they're just that's a component and if I
go into tag manager here and here on the
left side I can see variables so
remember I have built-in and user
defined so built-in means that tag
manager already built these for me so in
case I need to get my trigger here to
work with my tag I can use a variable so
those are built in and then I have user
defined so these are what I Define these
are what I created and again the
variables are there to get the tag and
Trigger to work okay so that's the job
of the variable the job of the tag is to
host that JavaScript code okay in the
case of Facebook or analytics that's
where we're putting our code so here if
I click on AdWords remarketing again
it's a Google product so I don't really
need to even deal with code I'm just
going to select Google AdWords for
marketing okay so you can see GTM
integrates nicely with some of the other
Google products but let's just say you
have a Facebook pixel tracking code
you're going to choose custom and you're
going to put the code here so that's
part of the tag and then the trigger
again is there to get the tag to fire so
you're telling GTM when to fire the tag
and the variable is there to help you
make sure that that trigger and that tag
work together so that's how all three
kind of work together you need the tag
to put the code you need the trigger to
tell GTM when to fire the tag and code
and the variables there to help you
define when that tag and Trigger should
work or how it should work so again
review tags are they're just small codes
of JavaScript are tracking pixels on
your website and so tags are allowed to
manage events like scroll track and
remarketing clicks downloads files play
buttons you name it even clicks on
external links for example let's just
say you have a click uh or a Facebook uh
icon on your site and when somebody
clicks on it they go to Facebook you
want to maybe track that you're going to
create a tag okay the trigger is there
because you need to tell GTM when to
fire that tag so it's a certain
condition whether it's you know fire the
tag if the URL equals facebook.com or
some other condition so the tag cannot
be created until the creation of the
corresponding trigger so tags and
triggers go together you can't just
create a tag and not have a trigger
otherwise your tag will never fire and
then the variable is there again it
stores the information when defining a
trigger or transferring data to tag so a
variable has a variety of data okay so
you pick and choose the variable you
want to use with that trigger okay so
you're making sure that by defining a
variable you're making sure that you're
telling GTM how that trigger should be
fired so let's take a look at another
example here of how all three play
together if I'm in this account I'm in
this container if I look down here I can
see Google optimize that's another
Google product so what I'm doing here is
I just chose Google optimize as my tag
it's already integrated so what does
that mean I don't even need to deal with
any code I'm just going to select
optimize well we have the tag Google
optimize but we need to tell GTM how to
fire that and so here we're going to
tell GTM to fire it on all pages so
that's basically a very simple example
because we're firing it on all pages so
if I want to look at something specific
again Facebook here's my tag here's my
code what's my trigger well my trigger
is it's going to fire on specific Pages
how do I know that well if I look at the
trigger here I could see the trigger is
a page view but I'm telling it to fire
on this particular hostname so the tag
and Trigger go hand in hand
so how to get started with tag manager
so first things first you have to create
that account so you're going to go to
tagmanager.google.com or you can do a
search for Google tag manager and you're
going to create your account and then
when you create your account what's
going to happen is you're going to set
up a container and when you set up a
container you have choices so you could
set it up for your website for an app on
iOS or maybe Android or you can even set
it up for amp except an accelerated
mobile page so most people by default
are probably going to set up tag manager
for their website and so when you do
that when you actually select website
what's gonna happen is you're going to
get some Google tag manager code in
return and so the whole idea here is
you're going to do a swap what's your
doing is basically you're saying Okay
Google I'm going to take this Google tag
manager code and I'm going to put it on
my website I'm going to put it on every
page in my website so notice tag manager
has two scripts one goes in the head as
high as possible the other goes into the
body tag as high as possible and so what
you're doing is you're making a deal
you're putting this tag manager code on
your website and in return every code
you deal with whether that be Facebook
or analytics or optimize or remarketing
or whatever it is is gonna go in GTM
okay it's going to go into the Container
you created so you need the tag manager
code on your website in order for tag
manager to work okay so when you add
this code to your website then you're
free to start adding all sorts of tags
to your container but if you don't have
this tracking code on your website then
none of the tags you add to your
container are gonna work so that's the
idea yeah behind the container and then
one thing I wanted to mention on the
account is it's a Google account so when
you create your account then make sure
it's the same account you use with say
Google analytics or some other Google
product that's a good best practice is
always use the same email address when
you set up your account so that it
integrates nicely across all the
different platforms meaning you can go
from say Google analytics right to
Google tag manager in one browser
without having to log out or log in okay
so when you create the account you're
going to create your container if you
choose web then you're going to be asked
to place code on your website and when
you place that code on your website then
you are free to start using tag manager
and that means you're free to start
adding tags so if you want to know more
information about installing Google tag
manager then what I would recommend is
visit the quick start guide website of
GTM so again if you're curious as to
where that code code is located in
Google tag manager well when you create
an account and you create a container
that container is going to have a
specific ID so if I click on that
specific ID here's where I can get my
code okay so again when I'm logged in to
tag manager I'm going to click on
workspace but in the top navigation I'm
going to see my unique GTM ID if I click
on that that's where my code is going to
be located and so again your code needs
to go in the header and there's another
script that needs to go in the body and
if you're not sure how to add the code
to your website well you can always
click on the quick start guide here okay
and that'll take you to a quick start
guide page a reference page related to
Google tag manager so let's talk about
creating a tag so once you get tag
manager installed I'm sure you're
excited to get going and create that
first tag so let's talk about how to
create a tag and tag manager so when
you're in tag manager all you need to do
is basically you're looking at all your
tags if you click on tag in the left
side navigation you'll see all your tags
and there's a new button there so you
just click new and so basically what
you're going to do is you're going to
create your first tag and so what I
would recommend once you get tag manager
installed on your website I would
recommend setting the first tag up as
Google analytics so that will get you
going with tracking page views on your
website when some when somebody visits
your website okay so ideally that's what
you want to do you want to get Google
analytics as your first tag and tag
manager so what I'm going to do is
because analytics is a Google product
it's already integrated nicely with tag
manager so I'm just going to click on
Google analytics it's going to be a page
view that's what I'm tracking and now I
have to set up a variable and so what
it's going to do it's going to ask me to
set a select a variable and so what
you're going to do is you're going to
select new variable and what you're
going to do is you're actually going to
go and add your tracking ID here that's
going to be your variable so where do I
get my tracking ID and analytics well if
I'm in analytics I'm going to go to
admin and then under property settings
I'm going to see my tracking ID and all
you need to do then is go to tag manager
and paste copy first you get a copy over
that tracking ID then you're going to
get a tag manager and paste it and then
that's going to create a variable for
you and then when you create that
variable you're going to see it in the
drop down here so I've already created
it and basically that's your tag with a
variable then what are you going to do
you're going to set up a trigger so see
I have some triggers already set up
you're going to see a default trigger
already set up for you and that's going
to be all pages so ideally what you want
to do is you want to select all pages in
order for analytics to fire on all pages
so that's what we're doing we're setting
up a trigger we're basically telling tag
manager hey if I get a visitor to any
page on my website then I want you to
fire Google analytics so that's
basically in summary how to set up your
first tag and my recommendation is your
first tag should be Google analytics and
when you set up analytics you're going
to have to set up a variable for the
tracking ID and so you get the tracking
ID again from admin property settings
copy and paste that tracking ID over
save it you have your variable that
variable is going to be included in with
the tag then your trigger is going to be
all pages and there you go you have your
first tag you have your first variable
you have your first trigger so that's
basically what you want to do and once
you've added that tag once you've added
that trigger then the only thing you
need to do now is basically publish the
tag and so anytime you save a tag you're
going to go ahead and submit it so that
way it gets published so again what
you're going to do is let's take a step
back here you're going to choose new tag
you're going to choose analytics from
the drop down menu you're going to
choose page view then basically you're
going to add your tracking ID so you can
set up the variable and then basically
that's what you need to do okay you're
going to add that tracking ID and then
voila that's your tag with a variable
and then once you've done that then
you're going to click submit so when you
click submit you're basically saying Hey
I want this tag to go live now this tag
and Trigger and once you've done that
then analytics is ready to go and
anytime somebody goes to your website on
any page tag manager is going to fire
Google analytics so the great thing here
is you have something called Google tag
assistant and that's a an extension that
works with Pro and so when you've
actually add a tag manager to your site
or you have analytics running in tag
manager you can confirm if those tags
are firing properly so let's take a look
at how Google tag assistant works okay
so if you just do a search for Google
tag assistant you're going to see here
that it's basically just an extension
that works in Chrome and unfortunately
it only works in Chrome browser it
doesn't work in any other browser so go
ahead and install that extension into
Chrome and when you do that you're going
to see this nice icon here in your
browser and now if you go to any website
and I click on Google tag assistant and
I click on enable Okay so basically I'm
loading Google tag assistant and now
once I refresh the page I can see that
this particular site has Google tag
manager installed and not only does it
have tag manager installed I can see
that it's also has Google analytics
right running I have also Google
optimize running and I have Google ads
remarketing tag running and tag manager
so that's what tag assistant does it
allows you to see if one tag manager is
on the site and if it is great what
other tags are firing on this particular
site so tag assistance telling me I have
these particular tags firing on that
site and they're firing within tag
manager so tag assistant is a great way
to confirm if one tag manager is on the
site and two what other tags are firing
on the site now another way you could
confirm if tag manager is firing on the
site is you can go into preview mode so
even before you submit and publish your
tag and Trigger you can click on the
preview mode so if I click preview in
tag manager so basically that's going to
put me in preview mode and so what does
that mean well that means that now I'm
free to go to my website right and see
if those tags are firing and so let's
take a look at what that looks like so
if I go to the website and just click
refresh then what's going to happen is
tag manager is going to load in preview
mode just as you see here okay so that's
going to take a second couple seconds to
load up and now what can I see in
preview mode I could see that I have GTM
firing but I also have some other tags
found on this page remarketing I have
Google analytics I have Google optimize
I have some other tags firing as well
and so the preview mode shows me what
tags are firing on any given page and I
can also see what tags did not fire okay
so here I have a number of tags already
in GTM but they didn't fire on this
particular page so let's just say I
clicked on the Donate Now button I'm
still in preview mode so I'm going to be
able to see what tags fired now I could
see I have a couple attacks bags that
have fired on this particular page and
then I could see what tags did not fire
on this page okay so that's the preview
mode you can use the preview mode before
you even submit a tag and Trigger to see
if it fires and that's the great benefit
of tag manager so if you're not sure if
something's going to fire or not then
you can always go into preview mode um
and if you are sure it's gonna fire then
you can go ahead and submit it so you
can leave preview mode and just go ahead
and submit that particular tag and
Trigger so here I'm going to leave
preview mode and now once I'm done and
I'm sure the tag is going to fire and go
ahead and submit all my changes that
I've worked on in terms of setting up
tags and triggers so that's really GTM
in a nutshell so I have my tags okay my
tags are just Snippets of code that I'm
going to put in whether that be Facebook
or vet tracking or any other Google
product like optimize answer page view
then I have my triggers my triggers are
there to tell GTM when to fire that tag
and the variables are there to help
those tags and triggers work together so
remember that particular variable we set
up for Google analytics okay so here it
is right here because we want to tell
GTM what property to specifically fire
in Google analytics so that's why we set
up that variable but there are all sorts
of variables Google tag manager has
built in or variables already created
for you or you can specifically Define a
variable so variables are there to help
the tags and triggers work together so
when you set up a tag you set up a
trigger you use a variable you can
always go into preview mode preview it
by going to the website seeing if it
fires if it fires then voila you can go
ahead and click submit and that will
publish the tag and Trigger and you're
good to go that's pretty much how tag
manager works and again I can't stress
that there is an unlimited number of
tags you can add to tag manager there's
no limit so you got everything from
anything from Google to non-google to
event tracking okay to Facebook to
anything that you want to track you want
to be able to put into tag manager and
again there's versioning that's one of
the great benefits of tag manager so if
I want to go back to an older version I
can simply do that so here you can see
I'm on version 32. that's how tag
manager works and I can't stress that
you know tag manager is there to help
you track interactivity on the site
because if you have a site that's
interactive that has a video that has a
download button let's just say you know
you have all sorts of newsletter
sign-ons Facebook YouTube buttons on
your website just like this website does
and you won't be able to track how many
people click on that particular button
well you're going to need tag manager
and when you have tag manager you're
going to be able to track all of these
button clicks and interactivity on your
website with that tag manager it's going
to be hard to do that so that's an
introduction to tag manager Google
analytics is a web analytics service
offered by Google
it was launched back in 2005.
it tracks and Reports website traffic
from the information through Wikipedia
Google analytics is the most used web
analytics Service as per the sources in
April 2022 Google analytics was used by
73 percent of the 10 000 most popular
website across the globe however as per
the reports from beltway.com
to crore 81 lakh 52
477 live websites use Google Analytics
so now this is the time to understand
what has been changed in Google
analytics over the years
if you are new to Google analytics it's
even better
before moving forward do subscribe to
Simply learn and hit the Bell icon to
never miss any updates from Simply learn
so what makes Google analytics so
important
Google analytics generates various types
of reports and helps to track bounce
rates identify the best content of your
website record user Behavior flow on
your site and many other metrics
thereby allowing you to understand and
build your business strategies
thereby growing your business
now that you have understood why Google
analytics is essential
let's check what we have for you in this
video
first we will understand what is Google
analytics for
then we will move forward with
identifying Google analytics version for
your website
next we will have a detailed look at
Universal analytics and Google analytics
score we will continue by understanding
success stories from Google analytics
for users and finally we will end this
session by understanding the future of
Google analytics port
so allow me to introduce the next
generation of Google Analytics Google
analytics score also known as ga4
initially Google analytics score was
known as app plus web Google analytics 4
is the latest analytics property with
several advantages over the old Google
analytics also known as universal
Analytics
understanding more clearly Google
analytics score can measure and keep
track of website traffic as well as app
usage
so now you can imagine that Google
analytics score is the One-Stop solution
for all your analytics needs if you are
still using Universal analytics we
recommend you to get familiar with
Google analytics score as well
as this is the new future of analytics
we will understand creating and setting
up Google analytics for account in
detail in the upcoming videos let's
first identify which Google analytics
property is associated with your website
in order to identify which Google
analytics property you have login to
your Google analytics account now go to
analytics account
and then open properties and apps here
you can see properties for your website
now
below the properties and apps several
properties are listed where
you can see different IDs if the ID
starts with UA and ends with a number
then you have a universal analytics
property
however if ID only has numbers
like here
then you have Google analytics for
property
we will learn how to switch the
universal analytics account to Google
analytics score in the upcoming videos
now that you have understood how to
identify Google analytics property let's
take a detailed look at the comparison
of universal analytics data and Google
analytics for data
the major difference between Universal
analytics and Google analytics Port is
the measurement model
Universal analytics uses sessions and
Page views as the measurement model
whereas Google analytics score uses
events and parameters as the measurement
model therefore any hit type from
Universal analytics property say a page
view user timing Etc are captured as
event in Google analytics for property
let's see the detail comparison of every
aspect of universal analytics and Google
analytics port
first we go with events
in analytics every measurable action for
example page load form completion
Scrolls app installs Etc is measured as
event and event has category label and
action in Universal Analytics
moreover it has its own head type
in case of Google analytics 4 there is
no categorization all the hit types from
Universal analytics are considered as
events
now let's find the comparison of
universal analytics and Google analytics
for in terms of page views
page views is a metric to find that
calculates total number of pages viewed
on your website
now let's get a better understanding of
page views
for instance when user lands on a web
page of your site the page loads this is
considered to be a page view now suppose
if user reloads the page
Google analytics tracks it as another
page view
if the user navigates to another page of
your website and returns to the same
page this adds another page view to your
site
now that you have understood page views
let's see how page views differs in
Universal analytics and Google analytics
port from Universal analytics page view
are translated to Google analytics for
property
as page view event
this page view event automatically gets
triggered in Google tag manager the next
metric we have is sessions session is a
Time duration for which user is active
on your website a universal analytics
session May consist of multiple page
views events e-commerce transactions
Etc
the session is considered to be ended if
the user has 30 minutes of inactivity or
any other event for which session end is
triggered
in Google analytics 4 session metrics
are tracked from session start event
which automatically gets triggered with
the basic interaction on your website
however the session duration depends on
the period between the first and the
last event now let's check our next
metric which is custom dimension
in Universal analytics custom Dimension
add the information to the collected
data
whereas in Google analytics 4
information is added through the event
parameters
moving ahead
the next metric we have is content
grouping
content grouping in Universal analytics
allows to group content into a logical
structure after which one can view and
compare metrics by the group name now
talking about Google analytics 4 it has
predefined event parameter for Content
group this parameter fills the data into
content group moving ahead the next
metric we have is client ID
client ID is a unique string generated
randomly and acts as a pseudonymous
identifier client ID identifies the
browser instance and then it gets stored
in the browser cookies
and therefore subsequent visits to the
same site are associated with that user
in both Universal analytics and Google
analytics for client ID serves the same
purpose that is the client ID is
responsible for providing the identifier
now let's move ahead with the next
metric
parameters
parameters are associated with Google
analytics Port Properties
understanding in detail about parameters
parameters are the chunk of information
that specifies the user action
for example parameters can be passed to
describe the value of the purchase next
we have is user property
user properties provide information like
preferred language a geographical
location of the users that interact with
your website or app now that we have
seen difference between Universal
analytics and Google analytics four
properties the question definitely
arises can Google analytics really bring
success to your business
well if you have a good understanding of
your audience and have extraordinary
strategies to work on the Google
analytics is your best companion
here are some success stories by Google
analytics for users we all know about
McDonald's the leading fast food
cooperation with huge number of outlets
across the globe recently a case study
has been shared by McDonald's Hong Kong
which suggests that the company has
experienced growth in conversions by 550
percent through the in-app orders and
what made them achieve such a great
growth
yes you guessed it right it's Google
analytics score
let's have a look on their success story
the major goal for the company was to
redesign the strategy to increase in-app
code orders predict the behavior of
in-app audiences and reach the right
customers with McDonald's mobile order
campaigns to achieve the goals McDonald
used a simple yet smart approach and
implemented Google analytics for
properties with the help of predictive
audiences in Google analytics for
properties they tried converting
audiences into customers
moreover with the help of Google ads
they were able to manage the campaigns
as a result of the smart efforts
McDonald was able to gain increase in
conversions by 550 percent for the users
who are likely to purchase in next seven
days
isn't it amazing moreover for the same
audience McDonald's had noticed a
visible decrease in cost per action by
63 percent
and an increase in Revenue by 560
percent
some other companies that have seen
growth in their business through Google
analytics score includes PepsiCo claro
shop
Etc
with the proven success of top brands in
the world let us know what the future of
Google analytic pole holds as per the
reports on buildver.com there are two
crore 81 lakh 52
477 live websites that are using Google
Analytics
out of which there are one crore 21 lakh
413 live websites from USA and 4 lakh 68
538 live websites from India who are
using Google analytics if you look in
detail we have a list of big names like
Bank of America
blogger.com
Cisco Netflix
Coursera
Flipkart
ICICI Bank
Tesla India
IRCTC myntra
Etc that are using Google analytics for
their growth however we are all well
aware of the success stories of all the
biggies on the list
thus Google analytics will continue to
be an important part of new business
strategies
so let's start with the keyword research
so with keyword research tools you can
do your job a lot more efficiently
finding the right relevant keywords I
mean that's really key to SEO is finding
keywords that are relevant to your
business product or service that you
want to rank for so you want to be able
to choose keywords with high search
volume and low competition so where do
you get those numbers you get those from
certain tools you also want to get
forecasts for certain targeted keywords
you want to be able to generate a list
of latent semantic indexing type
keywords keywords close to the keyword
you're trying to Target you want to be
able to select primary and secondary
keywords wisely so having a list of
keywords or certain data points will
help you do that and you want to be able
to identify the keywords that your
competitors are also ranking for so good
keyword research tool will help you do
all of those things so what are some of
the the tools out there well look no
further than some of the free ones that
Google offers like Google Trends so
Google Trends is a good tool that you
can lean on if so if we look at Google
Trends all you need to do is
trends.google.com you can type in a
keyword I can look at the volume or
interest of that keyword over time here
I'm looking at football versus American
football and I could see how it's
trending then I could see you know how
it Trends in specific regions of say the
United States as my market I can also
look at other related queries similar to
football or American football and so
Google Trends is a good tool helps you
look at the volume helps you look at
what specific regions helped you look at
other keywords you know if you want you
can simply just do a keyword search or
you can actually just see what's
trending just by looking at the latest
stories and insights so we could see
International women's day you know
started to pick up steam is picking up
more steam Etc so it's certain keywords
that tend to Trend well and you can pick
up on what those keywords are using
Google Trends now you could also use
another Google tool called Google
Keyword Planner the only difference is
this one's paid you need a Google ads
account so if we go into Google ads hey
you'll need to go to tools and you need
a Keyword Planner but when you're in
Keyword Planner you can find new
keywords so if I type in for example you
know online marketing and click get
started what the keyword tool is going
to do is give me the data that I need to
do appropriate keyword research it's
going to give me my keyword and similar
keywords it's going to give me the
average month and volume and the great
thing here is I can actually see the
trend for that keyword over time just by
clicking on this little bar graph so for
digital marketing I could see what the
trend is over time I could see what the
competition is I could see you know if
I'm going to bid on this keyword I could
see what the bidding range is so more
important I could see the volume and I
can see the competition here's my volume
for this keyword over the last 12 months
on average and here's my competition so
Google's Keyword Planner gives you the
necessary information you need to choose
relevant keywords wisely now there are
other tools out there that are paid that
help you look for Relevant keywords like
semrush or keyword finder that's a
freemium tool so there are plenty of
tools available to you you know another
tool I use that's not listed here is Moz
so if you just type a keyword let's just
type in the same keyword like online
marketing for example okay so what Moz
is going to do is going to give me some
volume it's going to give me some other
keyword suggestions okay it's going to
tell me how difficult that keyword is
and it's going to tell me who else is
ranking for that keyword so it gives me
again all the relative information I
need including competitive information
so you can use these two these keyword
tools moz's freemium summer paint summer
free there's plenty of tools out there
but these are the ones I would recommend
for keyword research now let's turn our
attention to technical SEO so so for
technical SEO you're going to need to
use some tools there's no getting around
that because you want to be able to
monitor how your website is performing I
mean is it loading slow for example does
it have a lot of uh issues with the
website in terms of server-side
rendering for example or server response
time what about four fours and redirects
so you want to be able to gather a lot
of the technical information that could
Aid or prohibit your site from ranking
so you want to be able to also you know
look at what the Bots are seeing and how
they're viewing your website so if
Google goes to crawl your site are they
experiencing you know a slow server
response time were they experiencing
Pages not found you also want to see if
you have a site map you know what's the
site map are these Bots crawling your
site or getting the pages from
assignment again you want to be able to
lean on some of these tools to help you
fix errors that you may encounter like
meta tags or four fours or canonicals so
you need a good tool to help you manage
all that and so I'm gonna go back to Maz
starting out so if we go back to Moz Moz
is a good tool it's an all-in-one it's a
great SEO platform so if I go to Moz and
I log into an account I can just go to
site crawl and so what Moz is gonna do
it's gonna give me a lot of information
about how Moz is bot is seeing my site
okay so if I go to the site crawl I can
look at all the particular critical uh
issues that I've experienced so I could
see four or four errors okay read a rex
related to that I could see Meta
descriptions missing meta descriptions
duplicate content so there's a lot of
different issues that Moz is detecting
for this particular site and the great
thing about Moz and this is why I use
Moz as my SEO platform I don't work for
mods I've just used them a long time is
if you do have issues then they give you
ways to fix it so how to fix it section
so if I see missing description here if
I just click on review and get a more
in-depth analysis as to what the issues
are here but I can also click on the why
and how to fix okay and they're going to
give you some information about how this
is impacting SEO and what you could do
to fix the issue they lay out the issues
pretty prominently here you can see for
all the metadata issues I have I have
you know 142 total metadata issues I
have 10 title tag two Longs I have 122
missing meta descriptions so they lay it
out nicely here up the top so you can
kind of get a sense of what to work on
and again they prioritize it based on
the severity of the issue and then they
break it down into several categories
for example I just looked at metadata
issues you can see if I click on content
issues I have some duplicate content
that Moz is recognizing or missing or
valid H tags so Mazda does a really
really great job playing all all the
issues out for you to recognize okay
there's another tool that I like to use
called screaming from frog it's a pay
tool so if we go look here great thing I
like about a screaming frog it will
crawl your sight and it will give you
some a list of issues just like Mazdas
of you know what it sees in your site is
experiencing four fours broken links are
there any redirects it's picking up
duplicate content site Maps you know
their JavaScript issues how is it see
the site architecture so it really does
take a deep look at everything that
could impact your website from ranking
okay there are other tools out there
like you know deep crawl or woo rank
they're both paid and so pay tools are
really great as well it just depends on
you know your pricing structure what
your budget is but really when it comes
to all these tools they all more or less
overlap and do the same thing you just
need to rely on one of them to make sure
that you're able to see what the issues
are now there's nothing wrong with using
two of them just as a second reference
point to see if both are picking up the
same issue and of course I like to use
search console I always like to lean on
Google search console because that is
the source so search console will also
you know give you some feedback on how
Google's bot is crawling your site so
that's under the crawl error section
here so you can also you know use search
console to upload a sitemap so that's a
key to SEO you want Google to be able to
find your web pages quickly so you can
simply just signify to Google where your
site map is located so the search
console does a lot more gives you some
HTML improvements gives you some
backlinking uh and then the process of
updating the search console user
interface so there's a new user
interface that you can use with Google
search console the great thing is it's
free and it has everything you need to
know about your website and how it's
affected by SEO organic search the only
thing you have to do with search console
is verify the site but once you verify
it has all the relevant information you
need so let's talk about backlink
monitoring and Analysis okay so this is
related to off-page SEO so you're going
to need a good tool to help you monitor
your website backlinks and backlinks are
simply just links from external sites
pointing to your site and you need to
keep an eye on what sites are linking to
yours are they spammy related sites are
they good at relevant sites or anything
in between so you need to really be able
to analyze what the good links are what
the bat links are pointing to your
website and you can also you know given
the tool also perform some competitor
analysis so you should be able to use a
tool to be able to compare how your
site's ranking against your competitor
okay you want to measure the ratio
referring domains to backlinks so how
many pure domains are linking to your
site so you want a tool that's going to
be able to tell you that you want to
identify and disavow Port back links
okay so you want to be able to to
recognize what sites are linking to
yours that's actually hurting you from
an SEO standpoint and you want to be
able to do something about that okay you
want to measure citation flow and Trust
flow you want to check the ratio of Link
distribution in terms of is it internal
or external or you know what kind of
sites are linking to my site are they
you know social related are they pure
content related and then you want to be
able to track the number of do follow
and no followings you know how many
links pointing to our site are actually
telling Google and other Bots not to
follow the link or how many are actually
allowing the Bots to follow that link if
a bot follows a link it's going to pass
what we call link juice so you're going
to get credit for the backlink if it's a
no follow you're not going to get credit
for the backlink and we want to be able
to measure that and so we want to have
tools that will help us do that so what
are some of those tools well hrefs is a
good tool it's a pain tool Majestic is a
freemium tool Moz again Moz is the tool
I use SCM rush and then again I gotta
mention Google search console so let's
take a look at some of these tools in
terms of backlink monitoring and
Analysis so let's start with Google
search console again it's free you just
have to verify your site and so if I go
to Google Search console I can look at
links and I can see what external links
I have pointing to my site okay so I
could see I have 17 000 in this example
pointing to the home page of this
particular site okay so if I click on
that I can see all the the top sites
pointing to my home page now from an
off-page SEO perspective do you want
every backlink or external link pointing
to your home page no so you want links
pointing to internal pages so you want
to be able to measure that so I could
see with the top linking sites are and I
can also see what the anchor text is so
do what I want my anchor text always to
be my brand name no I want it to be you
know keyword we're trying to Target
search console also gives you some
internal links okay what of top link
Pages for internal links so from an SEO
perspective you always want to have a
nice balance of internal linking so this
report helps you understand what pages
are getting links and are the links
evenly spread so this is Google search
console this is the links report this is
totally free this is provided by Google
all you have to do is verify your site
now if we go over to Moz we type in a
domain any domain so I just typed in
simple and learn okay Moz has some
metrics that are important to off-page
SEO including domain Authority so the
higher your domain Authority the better
off you are and so what helps a domain
Authority grow is how many quality links
are pointing to that domain and so here
we could see over
7500 linking domains to Simply learn so
what's important is we just don't want
any site we want quality relevant sites
pointed okay so we could see how many
total inbound links and then how many
ranking keywords we have okay so here is
going to give me kind of an idea of what
my domain Authority has been over time
they're going to tell me the top
followed links to this site so they can
tell me you know what are those links
pointing to my site and what's the page
authority of those sites okay here I can
get a nice graphical breakdown of the
linking domains by domain Authority so
you want pages with high domain
Authority pointing to your site so here
I can see 69 linking domains between 91
and 100 so that's really good we want
High relevant domains linking to our
site so just like search console I can
see the top anchor text being used okay
and I can see the top pages that have
you know good page Authority on the side
I could see following versus no follow
on internal and external links so this
is just the overview so Ma's really
really does break down for you you know
what those pages and linking domains are
so if I just click on linking domains
now I could get a detailed look for my
home page what domains are pointing to
our domain so I can see microsoft.com
has a domain authority of 100 YouTube 99
and so not only does Moz provide you
with the domains it also provides you
with their domain Authority score and
spam score so you want to keep an eye on
any particular site that has a high spam
score so having a site with a high spam
score and a low domain Authority will
hurt your domain and Page Authority for
that page so Mazda does a great job of
breaking it out and this is for any page
it doesn't necessarily have to be the
home page okay if I take a look look at
another example here Majestic so
Majestic again I can use a free version
of the tool they have their own metrics
citation flow trust flow so when they
say trust flow what's the link quality
all about okay citation flow what's the
link volume and they can get an idea of
how many external backlinks are pointing
to the site and what's the trend end on
that referring domains so Majestic does
a really good job again some of the same
metrics that we could see here except
they go into detail about languages as
well so this is majestic and you got
search console you got a lot of other
tools and then I'm going to just revert
back to Moz because you want to be able
to compare link profiles if you're in a
competitive space and you're doing
off-page SEO you know Moz will help you
compare how your site stands against
maybe another competitive side or
relevant site so just doing this
analysis I can compare my domain
Authority spam score how many total
links you know how many external file
links or external no follow links a
breakdown of linking domains so it does
a nice job of comparing one site versus
another that's going back to Moz and
that's what you want you want a good
tool that's going to help you do that I
mean there's other tools out there not
listed like bright Edge that will also
help you compare linking profile so at
the end of the day if you're doing
off-page SEO you want to get a sense of
what sites are linking to yours are they
quality sites are they spammy what
anchor text are they using are they no
follow are they do follow you know are
they top domains how do you compare
against your competitors I mean all
these metrics are related to off-page
SEO so you want a good tool that's going
to help you measure this okay so let's
talk about rank tracking so when we do
keyword research we're looking for
Relevant keywords we find our relevant
keywords we sign primary and secondary
keywords to Pages we optimize those
pages we do off-page SEO and we do an
all this work for SEO okay we want to be
able to measure the fruits of our labor
we want to be able to measure how we
perform for on and off page SEO for the
keywords we covet in the pages they're
related to and so that's where rank
tracking comes into play so we want to
be able to track our website's ranking
and not just our website all the pages
we've optimized we want to be able to
measure our click rates and Impressions
we want to be able to track the ranking
for both desktop and mobile for specific
locations and we want to identify top
performing gaining and losing keywords
so in other words we want to look at
Trends is a keyword ranking is it going
up and ranking is it going down and
ranking if it's going down in ranking
then you need to take action so you need
a tool a good tool for rank tracking so
we can look no further than again Google
search console it's free it's right from
the source so let's take a look at what
Google search console has to offer in
terms of rank tracking so if I go to
Google Search console and I put in a URL
what it's going to do is it's going to
give me and this is the search queries
report it's going to give me what
queries people have used to actually
type into google.com and it's going to
be able to tell me how many times my
pages show Pages showed up for that
query it could be more than one page so
that's an impression and if I did
receive an depression meaning did my
page show up in the organic listing then
did I get a click as a result and so in
this case if I got 68 Impressions and 10
clicks for keywords somebody typed in
that's a 14.7 percent click through rate
and so with search console we'll also do
is say hey look for that particular
keyword you appeared on average in
position 4.1 so it gives you really good
insight as to you know what people are
typing in and how you're being found for
those keywords it breaks it down by
Pages it breaks it down by country
breaks it down by device so I could see
you know mobile I've had
899 Impressions over the last three
months on mobile and I received 33
clicks as a result my average position
on mobile is 2.6 so search console does
a really good job again this is free
information uh providing you the actual
keywords somebody's using on Google
search as a query and how many
Impressions you're receiving for that
keyword how many clicks click click the
rate and then average position so in
theory the higher you are positioned on
Google the more clicks you're going to
receive so if I'm not positioned
properly for keyword let's say page two
then I'm probably not going to receive
as many clicks as I would like so that's
search console there are other tools out
there like hrefs again does a good job
of tracking AMZ tracker we look at
wincher so there's some good tools out
there I'm just going to show you another
one again I'm going to go back to Moz
for example so Moz has a tool called so
if I go back into the account so Moz has
a rankings tool that you can look at to
see where your keywords are ranking so
if you've already chosen keywords and
optimized Pages for those keywords then
you want to be able to load those
keywords into Moz and so Moz allows you
to do that and so what Moz does they do
a crawl once a week and they'll be able
to tell you where you rank for all your
keywords are we moving up in the
rankings are we moving down how many
keywords do we have ranked between
positions one and three eleven through
twenty four through ten twenty one
through fifty so we'll be able to see
where our keywords Rank and so it gives
you a breakdown here of nationally in
the United States where this keyword is
ranked and if it's moved up or down and
for what URL is it ranked for and so you
can label soak the keywords and and this
is what you want to look for in a good
tool you want to be able to organize
your keywords and label them so for all
our brand keywords we want to be able to
label them branded because ideally you
don't want to optimize for your brand
keywords so maybe we want to exclude our
brand keywords and look at our non-brain
keywords in terms of ranking and so you
can certainly add locations and look at
specific locations the whole idea
between a good ranking tool is to be
able to measure you know if a keyword is
trending up or down okay so I can simply
look at a particular keyword and I can
see the trend of that keyword and then
you know if a keyword is not ranking
then we want to wonder why it's not
ranking well is it difficult is it not
ranking because of its difficulty or can
we do a better job of optimizing for
that keyword and so Moz also has a page
optimization tool so if you're not
ranking for keyword you can flip over
the page optimization tool then put in
the keyword put in the URL and mods will
give you some idea as to what you can
further do to optimize the page okay so
that's Moz you know this is hrefs so you
can see ahrefs does the same thing they
provide you some visibility average
position how much traffic you know where
you're ranking in terms of positions one
through three four through ten eleven
through fifty and so you want to be able
to get a sense of where my track
keywords are trending are they trending
up are they trending down and the whole
idea again Beyond a ranking tool is if
you're trending down you want to be able
to address why it's trending down so you
want to start with on-page SEO can we do
a better job of optimizing in or off
page does that page need more backlinks
so that's why you need a backlink tool
to support your ranking and ahrefs does
offer up some competitor information as
well so you can see how your competitors
are performing so these are some good
examples of ranking tools that you could
take advantage of now there are also a
few important SEO tools that can be
helpful in different ways for example if
you're doing video so there are some
tools to help you measure how you're
performing via video for example vid IQ
so let's take a look at vid IQ so if I
load in say video in YouTube in this
example how to rank YouTube videos I
have a vid IQ extension loaded into my
browser in Chrome and so now I can get a
good eye sense of how many views the
duration the engagement rate the like
ratio how many people shared it on
Reddit but further I can look at how the
video is optimized so they're telling me
the title's too long here maybe shorten
it up but we have tags we have
descriptions we have cards we have end
screens it's been shared on Facebook it
hasn't been shared on Twitter okay it is
public we do have pinned comments and we
do have hearted comments and so this
gives me an idea of how we did in terms
of optimizing this particular video okay
so if we wanted to tweak it we could
tweak the title tag make it a little bit
shorter to help it rank better on
YouTube so you want to be able to use a
tool like this because if you have
videos then you want those videos to
rank and so you can certainly watch this
video on how to rank your YouTube videos
and in that video we do allude to vid IQ
so you want to be able to use a tool
like this because you know YouTube it is
a video portal but it's the second
largest search engine behind Google so
if you do have videos you want to be
able to rank for them and you want a
tool that's going to help you measure
and help you understand if you are
ranking if you're not ranking why are
you not ranking now for Content
optimization there are tools you can use
like SCS site checkup or site analyzer
are some good tools if you already have
Moz as an example just going back to Moz
as you already know I use mozz a lot so
they have a page optimization so you
could check the content and how you're
optimized your content so it's going to
give me some good feedback on you know
is your page title meta description are
they in line okay so it's going to give
you some good feedback on that you also
have again I have to allude to search
console you can always look at a
particular page in search console see if
it has any errors as well so is it
duplicated meta description is it a
duplicated title tag is it any Pages
missing title tags or meta descriptions
so when it comes to content you can look
at search console you can lean on Moz or
you can lean on some of these other paid
versions like site analyzer when it
comes to traffic and metrics look no
further than and Google analytics there
is a free version of Google analytics as
well as a paid version so if I go into
Google analytics it's going to tell me
all of my website Behavior okay who's
coming to my site how they got to my
site how they behaved once they went to
my site and are they achieving the goals
I set out for them to achieve via
conversions and so you want to look at
first in Google analytics how much
traffic you're getting so if I go to
Google analytics if I go to acquisition
all traffic channels I should be able to
see how much traffic organic search is
driving over a period of time so I can
see how many users how many sessions
then if I click on landing pages I can
see what landing page they went to so I
could see the home page over a
particular time I had over a thousand
sessions I can also see engagement from
organic search are they bouncing how
many pages are they looking at in this
session after they landed on a
particular page are they staying on the
site a long time what's the their
duration or are they achieving any goals
so analytics will provide me all that
information about how organic search as
a channel is performing the other thing
about Google analytics I like and that
goes back to the technical aspect of SEO
and that's site speed so if you go to
behavior and you go to site speed
overview you'll be able to see how my
pages are loading what's the average
load time so they'll break it down for
you by browser by country and by
specific page so if I look at page
timings I'll be able to see what page is
loading slow what page is loading quick
compared to site average and so the
great thing about analytics is if I have
a page that's loading slow compared to
site average they'll actually provide me
with some suggestions so if I go to site
speeds and speed suggestions what
they're going to do is they're going to
have a link in the report that's going
to allow me to click on it and I'm going
to be able to see what suggestions they
can provide so when this report loads
I'll be able to see what this speed
suggestions are for my pages so here I
could see the page I could see what the
average load time is of that page so for
example this particular page is loading
at six seconds ideally we want to have
you know three seconds or under maximum
so if I just click on this link here
they're giving me six page speed
suggestions so if I click on that I'm
gonna go to another Google tool called
page speed insights and then page speed
insights is going to run for both mobile
and desktop for this particular page and
then this page speed insights report is
going to give me feedback as to what I
need to do to speed up the load time of
that page so here you can see for
desktop and mobile they're going to give
me some suggestions and opportunities so
reduce the server response time properly
size images serve images in next-gen
formats so all these will shave off time
off my page load time and so that's
what's going to help me speed up the
page load and that's page being insights
you can get to from the speech
suggestions report and analytics so in
theory the higher page load time your
chances of ranking on Google organic
search diminished so Google wants pages
that have very low page load time that
load quickly so Google analytics is
great tool for Speed suggestions it's a
great tool for finding out what the
traffic is doing on your site how
they're engaging and are they achieving
goals now there are other tools out
there from an organic perspective like
keyword it that's a good keyword
research tool for Reddit so if you go to
keyword it you'll be able to see from a
Reddit perspective what keywords are
driving volume these are just the
results but you can put any keyword in
there and get the results of that
keyword
with tough competition to rank on the
search engines and app stores there is a
huge demand in industry for SEO experts
there are various types of roles in SEO
some popular ones are SEO associate SEO
analyst SEO executive SEO manager and
SEO expert
let's first talk about SEO Associates
SEO associate is responsible for
performing keyword research and
implementing SEO strategies to improve
organic ranking
the average base pay of an SEO associate
in U.S is between 1.59
000 to Dollar eighty thousand per annum
and in India is 2 lakh 28 000 rupees per
annum
next is SEO analyst SEO analyst is
responsible for keyword research
competitor analysis tracking organic
traffic and conversion rate the average
base pay of an SEO analyst in the US is
between dollar forty eight thousand to
Dollar 78 000 per annum and in India is
2 lakh 28 000 rupees per annum
understanding the responsibilities of
SEO executives
an SEO executive is responsible
for Gathering analytics reports
creating SEO friendly content and
implementing on-page and off-page
techniques
the average waste pay of an SEO
executive in U.S is dollar 39
382 per annual and in India is in
between 1 lakh 92 000 to 3 lakhs 62 000
rupees per annum
an SEO manager is responsible for
analyzing reports of the campaigns
developing content marketing strategies
managing a team of SEO experts fixing
technical SEO issues and more
the average base pay of SEO manager in
U.S is 1.72 652 per annum
and in India
is 8 lakh 79 000 rupees
moving towards the job responsibilities
of SEO expert SEO expert is responsible
for creating keywords and content
strategy link building strategies
competitor analysis and reports and
campaign the average base pay of an SEO
expert in U.S
is in between dollar fifty three
thousand to Dollar 78 000 per annum and
in India
is 2 lakh 76 000 rupees per annum
some companies hiring for significant
roles under SEO are Microsoft Disney
's
udemy and Deloitte there's questions for
you okay so the first question that you
might be asking interview is
differentiate between do follows and no
follows okay so if you take in or listen
to my SEO courses on YouTube for SEO we
we talked a lot about do follows and no
follows and and simply put I mean do
follows are just signals to the search
engines to follow the link so there's a
link on site a pointing to site B we're
gonna basically tell Google Bing and
some of these other search engines hey
go ahead and follow that link now I know
file is just the opposite so no follow
link doesn't allow the search engine
crawlers to follow it so if we have a
link on our site site a pointing to site
B we could put a nofollow tag in there
and what that's going to do it's going
to signal to the Crawlers hey don't
follow this link so in the end of the
Crawlers don't fall follow the link then
there's not going to be any link juice
passed and so Google is not going to
give you credit or give that site credit
for having a link pointing to it or
pointing to another site or from another
site and so it's all about linking so we
can control if there's links on our site
whether we want the Crawlers to
recognize those or not simply with no
follow tags so just a reminder link
juice is the reputation or Equity pass
from one website to another so if you
have a link on another website and that
website is of high quality meaning their
page Authority their domain Authority is
high they have a lot of content you know
they're not spammy they're really rich
and they're relevant then you may want
to make sure that the link pointing from
that site to your site is a no follow so
that way that Google can recognize the
link from that site to your site and
basically that reputation is going to be
passed on to you okay so that's a do
follow versus a nofollow and why would
we do a no follow well it just pens it
really depends a lot of social media
platforms like Facebook have no follows
if you have a lot of content you may not
want to be pushing out a lot of do
follows it could actually look bad from
an external linking standpoint and so a
lot of sites are really particular about
who they want to pass link choose onto
and give credit for the link so it's a
business decision at the end of the day
there's really no hard fast rule here
except from an SEO perspective if I have
a site and I have a lot of external
links pointing outward to other sites
I'm going to be particular about who I
allow the search engines to follow and
what links I allow not to follow okay so
here's an example of what they look like
so do follow is simply just the href
notice the nofollow has the the tag
appended to it the href tag with a
nofollow so if the search engine's
crawling your site and they say that no
foul there they're not going to follow
that link and vice versa if there's a
link on another site pointing to yours
and there's a no follow there you're not
going to get credit the search engines
aren't going to pick up that link okay
so question two what is 301 redirect and
how is it different from a 302 redirect
so 301 redirects tell users in the
search engine specifically that an
original page has been moved and this is
the keyword here permanently so
permanently moved we're going to explain
that in a minute so it's just moved from
one page to another and so if we don't
have a page anymore we have a new page
let's just say you built a new website
with new URLs you want to make sure the
old page is pointing to the new page
with a 301 redirect so for 301 redirect
is permanent then a 302 is temporary so
we want the search engines to recognize
that we have 301 permanent redirects in
place why because if we we have
temporary then it might alert Google to
not keep that page in its search engine
rankings because it's temporary so why
would Google want to keep a temporary
page or even a page that is pointing to
another page on a temporary basis so
they may remove both pages from its
index okay but if we have something
permanent in place Google may say okay
this page is permanently linking to
another page or redirecting to another
page therefore it's stable it's
permanent we're going to keep that new
page in the index and eventually remove
the old page so really something
permanent is more stable in the eyes of
the search engine something temporary
may not be as stable in the eyes of say
Google and if they don't see it as
stable then they may remove both pages
from the index okay so the idea is we
want to be found in Google search index
and we get it sometimes Pages go away
for a variety of reasons and if it does
go away just make sure you having a new
page for it and that new page is a 301
permanent redirect okay so question
three why are backlinks important in SEO
well we kind of hinted on that a bit
with the nofollow because if we have a
link from another website pointing to
ours and that link from that other
website is really relevant and and it
has a high page and domain Authority
then it's going to benefit us and so
backlinks are important because if we
have backlinks from quite quality sites
it's going to improve the credibility of
our site especially if it's a do follow
tag so the search engines are going to
recognize the relationship between the
site that has a link pointing to us okay
so it's just going to build our
credibility it's going to increase
increase our domain Authority and then
the net effect of that is if we're
credible and we have high domain
Authority then that's going to increase
the rankings of our pages and when the
pages increase in ranking then we're
going to get more of a Lion's Share of
the traffic for certain keywords that
our pages are found for and if our pages
are found in getting traffic then
because we have increased rankings we're
likely going to have increased traffic
and then it's just a snowball effect so
more traffic leads to more engagement
and conversions so the whole idea for
SEO is remember you have an on-page
strategy and an off-page strategy
building external links is part of an
off-page SEO strategy and we want to
make sure that you know we are relevant
in the form of a link or in the form of
content on other high quality sites
being on a high quality site only
benefits us because again increases
their domain Authority Google sees this
is more relevant therefore pages are
going to benefit by ranking higher and
therefore when we rank higher we get
more traffic so it's a snowball effect
so having bad links is important because
it snowballs all the way through to
conversions okay so what are the best
practices to rank your videos on YouTube
this is a great question really great
question given the importance of videos
especially with SEO because videos are
found YouTube in itself is a search
engine so if we have a video how are we
going to get it to rank on YouTube well
first things first you never want to put
a video out there and want it to rank if
it's not engaging or informative so make
sure you go ahead and follow the best
practices of having engaging and
informative content in your video now
once you have that video in place you
want to optimize it and then some of the
key factors for optimizing a video are
you want to choose a title that has high
search volume and low difficulty just as
you would keyword for example for web
page you want to choose a title with a
keyword in it that has high volume and
low difficulty IE low competition okay
so you want a nice ratio there and you
know what you want to choose a title
that's going to get people to watch the
video too so it's not all about just
choosing a title just for the sake of
high volume you also have to choose
something that's relevant that's going
to be catchy as well and then with that
title goes the description so you want a
description that's very relevant to your
title okay because most people aren't
going to click on a video just for the
sake of a title they're going to want to
probably get a sneak peek via the
description of what it is so again you
want to optimize that description but
make sure the description is is just as
snazzy as the title okay you also want
to use accurate and relevant video tags
just as you would on Twitter Facebook
tag these videos okay so make sure your
title tag length doesn't exceed 100
characters because it will get chopped
off so again that goes back to just
writing something really short and to
the point that's going to grab
somebody's attention Okay you also want
to upload a captivating thumbnail
something that's relevant then that's
gonna grab somebody's attention and then
again we set it similar to the video
tags we want to use relevant hashtags
again just as you would with Twitter and
Facebook go ahead and throw some
hashtags in there that people could see
because people search via hashtagging
and then this goes without saying you
did all the work created a really great
video it's engaging it's a formative you
optimized it feel free to promote your
video on other social media platforms
okay don't just stick with YouTube per
se so the benefit here is if you post it
on Facebook or LinkedIn or whatever
platform of your choice and it gets
engagement people click on the link go
to YouTube they're gonna like it and
then other people are gonna see that
engagement they're gonna see how many
people liked it or how many subscribers
you have so promote your videos to help
you with the ranking of the video on
YouTube so that does play into it so go
ahead and promote it so other people can
watch it like it comment Etc and then
that's going to engage other people to
want to do the same so what is mobile
first indexing this is a really
important and timely question mobile
first indexing means Google's just using
mobile friendly content for indexing and
ranking websites so in other words
Google for example has two Bots they
have the traditional desktop bot and
they have a smartphone bot and
eventually everybody that has a website
is going to be migrated over to the
smartphone bot and so with that
smartphone bot goes to your website and
starts crawling what do you think
they're looking for their smartphone bot
they're looking for mobile friendly
content if it's not mobile friendly
meaning the page isn't designed for a
smartphone browser or let's just say the
images are way too large or you have to
expand the text just to read it you know
a lot of these these issues that
somebody would have just simply trying
to read something on a web page on their
MO mobile device Google's not going to
grab that content so you want to make
sure it's mobile friendly so it gets
indexed and so if your website has a
responsive design Google will rank your
website based on its performance on
mobile devices okay so you want to make
sure that your website is mobile
friendly and if you're in an interview
and somebody asks you this question you
could even take it a step further and
say look I'm going to measure how
friendly my wall my website is for
mobile devices and Google search console
because Google search console has a
report that will show you what pages on
your website are not mobile friendly and
it's not a guarantee but I could tell
you if I'm Google and I'm crawling your
site with my smartphone Bob and that
page or one of my pages is not mobile
friendly I'm probably not going to index
it or rank it so you want to leverage
that report in Google search console to
see what pages are mobile friendly so
that's a little bonus for you to really
impress press the interviewer who asks
you this question because how are you
going to know if one of your pages is
mobile friendly or not if you don't look
at a report so keep an eye on Google
search consoles mobile usability report
okay number six list down the most
important local SEO ranking factors okay
so organic local ranking is just as
important as anything else in organic
search because if you have a local
business you want to use the likes of
say Google my business to show up when
somebody types in you know looking for a
florist or you're looking for a coffee
shop so what you want to do is you want
to create a web page for every product
and service okay you also want to opt
for your business listings on Google my
business and and there are plenty of
other local business directories out
there like Yelp for example or Bing even
has one so go ahead and also make sure
you have a business listing as well but
since Google in the United States has a
huge market share you want to start with
Google first you want to update your nap
citations on your website maintain
consistency of your nap okay so nap is
name address phone number so you want to
make sure that that's current and
consistent so if you have a number on
your website make sure it's the same
number on Google my business okay you
can embed a Google map on your website
it could certainly optimize The Meta
tags and content not only on your web
pages but within your Google my business
directory so you can add your business
to other local directories like I
mentioned Yelp and then also just as
important opt for reviews and ratings
okay so the more reviews The Hat you
have the better off you are okay so I
always say this with the with local
search three of the main factors in
showing up for local search on say
Google is obviously the keyword the
second is the price proximity of where
that person is and then third is the
reviews so you can't really control the
proximity but you can't control the
keyword and you can control the reviews
to some degree so work hard at getting
reviews for your business but at the
same time you can certainly work in some
keywords let's just say for your product
and service pages on your website but
also you can translate that over to
Google my business okay so working in
those keywords making sure your your
number your address your name they're
all consistent and and really just
spreading your the the business out on
other directors that's really all these
are really key factors for local SEO
okay so question number seven how to
avoid duplicate content getting
penalized for duplicate content so for
example if you have two different
versions of a web page you may result in
a duplicate content issue so it's just
SEO 101 you never want to have two two
or more pages with the same content so
what do we do well we can avoid this in
having Google penalize us by again
setting up a 301 redirect remember three
or ones are permanent we can also use
what they call canonical tag and a
canonical tag basically alerts the
search engines as to which page is the
original okay so if we have an original
page we want to point to that page with
a canonical tag and the third option is
opt for preferred domain and Google
search console okay so if you have
multiple no names make sure you set up a
primary one in search console so those
are ways to work around it of this three
I would always go with the canonical
tags because that's just a tag that's
going to sit on the page it's going to
alert Google as to what the original is
just in case they get their hands on the
duplicate so all the pages that have the
same content are going to have the same
canonical tag pointing to one page so
again three ones are permanent you could
simply just redirect one to the other if
you end up having duplication or you
could just tell the search engines hey
this is the original page or you can go
through search console okay number eight
what are the tactics to increase a web
page speed okay so what are some of the
tactics well when you build a site
especially for mobile you want to keep
it as simple as possible and what I mean
by simple as possible really I mean hey
use a simple website design don't get
overly creative if you will most
websites all websites have images you're
not going to be able to get around that
but just make sure you optimize your
images in other words don't have such a
large image size if you don't need
something very large don't have it okay
you want to improve server response time
and what do we mean by that well your
site's sitting on a server somewhere you
can own that server or you can be
renting it out from say Amazon web
services or let's just say GoDaddy as
your register they also have web hosting
well if you have it on say GoDaddy
server you may be sharing that server
with other businesses and at certain
times of the day other businesses may
get a lot of traffic and suck up a lot
of bandwidth what is that going to do
that's going to reduce the server
response time for your site and so you
want to make sure you have an idea of
you know what server your web page your
website is on and you want to be able to
have some control over that because if
your server response is slow that's
going to slow down everything else in
terms of loading in the browser and
that's not going to be good for SEO okay
optimize your code what do you mean by
optimally minifying when we see
mimifying we mean get rid of some of the
Redundant code if you have CSS you know
get rid of chop some of the get rid of
the JavaScript you're not using so
that's what we mean by optimizing code
reduce redirects okay ideally you just
want to have one redirect in place you
don't want to create a daisy chain so to
speak of redirecting and redirecting
after that that's Never Gonna bode well
and it's going to slow things down as
well enable browser caching so if you
enable browser caching basically if
somebody comes back to the page they've
been on say two days ago they're
probably going to see a cache version of
that page and then off for the content
delivery Network as well so these are
some of the ways to reduce page speed
now if you're curious about the page
speed of your website you can always go
to Google's page speed insights tool and
all you have to do is just Google page
speed insights or even just something
generic like Google page speed and
you're going to get this tool page speed
insights and all you need to do is just
plug in a URL when you plug in the URL
Google is going to analyze the URL for
both mobile and desktop and so here we
could see Google gives a score so we can
see the score from low ball and we can
see the score for desktop just by
clicking on desktop and so here I can
see some of the issues that the site may
be having in terms of page load time for
their desktop if I flip over to mobile
you know here I can see some other
issues for example they have a server
static assets with efficient cash policy
now if you're not sure what the heck
that means you can always just click on
it and you can see some specifics here
and where you can just always Google it
as well uh here you got to reduce the
impact of third-party code okay so
that's another thing uh reduce
JavaScript execution time so again going
back to a lot of some of the comments we
made about coding okay so sometimes too
much code or code not functioning as
well as it should we'll tend to slow
down the site okay so you can use page
bin insights you can always get a
glimpse of how pages are loading simply
by also going to for example Google
analytics under Behavior okay you can go
to site speed and if you click on
overview okay Google what go Google does
is they do a sampling of pages over time
and in this case based on 89 Page views
they have an average page load time and
so you can get a sense of how quick
specific Pages load or your site overall
simply by looking at the site speed
overview report in Google analytics to
get a sense of how quick your pages are
loading now there are certain factors
that do affect load time so obviously
the way the page is built with the code
the images Etc but also the browser each
browser loads differently okay so you
want to take a look at it by browser
also by country every country has a
different network you can be in the
United States and have worse network
service than you do say in you know
Ivory Coast in Africa okay so it really
depends on the network you're on so and
also the page every page is built
differently so you want to get a sense
of what pages are loading quicker and
which pages are not you can simply just
go to page timings and Google analytics
you get a sense of what pages do not
load fast and which ones do and maybe
hone in on the pages that aren't loading
fast and address those pages first okay
so you have two tools at your disposal
one Google analytics and one page speed
insights okay so let's look at question
number nine here so when should an
individual Target short tail and long
tail keywords okay so remember short
tail are usually one to two keywords
very Broad in nature long tail keywords
or maybe three four keywords in a query
or maybe an entire sentence those are
considered long tail keywords so usually
short tail keywords have higher volume
but also higher competition longer tail
keywords usually have lower uh volume
but also lower competition but the great
thing about long-term of keywords the
conversion rate will tend to be a little
bit higher than say a short tail because
it's less vague and more specific so you
can use short tail keywords if you're
trying to drive a lot of visitors
because those keywords are going to be
vague or Broad in nature long tail
keywords are used for targeted Pages
such as product pages and articles so if
you have a specific product with a long
name you can certainly optimize that
page for that product name again the
product name may have low volume but if
somebody types in exactly that product
name you show up the chance of you them
converting are going to be very high so
you don't have to always be that
specific at the product name but try and
be as specific as you possibly can in
order to get somebody to click on your
link in the search engine results and
get them over to your site to convert
okay so those are really the big
differences short tail very broad very
vague a lot of volume but also a lot of
competition but hey if you're ranking
for sure short tail keyword you're
probably going to get a lot of traffic
the conversion rates may not be as high
as something say long tail where hey
maybe you're just honed in on a few set
number of products and you're not care
you don't care a lot about the traffic
you just care about getting the relevant
traffic to your site to convert okay
number 10 what are they Port elements to
focus while developing a website so
we're talking in terms of SEO okay so if
somebody asks me this question in an
interview what am I going to focus on
while developing a website well the
answers are right here yes we talked
about mobile mobile is so important
because a lot of websites are going to
be indexed with Google smartphone bot so
mobile usability is very important so we
need to make sure our website is
responsive for mobile just some basic
practices when it comes to site
architecture navigation we want to have
a simple URL structure okay no overly
cumbersome the navigation should simply
be clean and neat okay if you have five
products okay maybe you have uh in your
navigation you have something called
products with all five listed or you
have all five products in the main
navigation the key is you just want to
make it clean and neat and easy for
somebody to find the the rule of thumb
is if it's good for the end user
probably gonna be good for Google but if
complicated for the end users probably
going to be complicated for Google you
always want to create a site map now
what is that sitemap a site map is
simply just a formatted file with two
that includes all your URLs and assets
your images and your videos they're
going to be sitting on your server as
well so you want Google or these these
Bots to be able to find your pages and
assets and by the way you want to take
it a step further and make sure you
upload that site map which is sitting in
the root directory meaning domain.com
sitemap.xml okay you want to take that
site map and make sure you input that
site map location in Google search
console that way Google search console
has a one-way ticket to grab the
elements in the sitemap another
important element to focus on while
developing a website is having a robot's
text file and all the robots text file
is it's like a lock I always say to a
house so if you lock a door in your
house nobody's going to be able to get
in that door so it's all a robots text
file is you're telling Google and these
other Bots that are coming across your
site what's locked and what's not locked
meaning what they have access to what
they don't have access to so you want to
be able to make sure you have a robot's
text file if you're trying to non-index
specific pages of your website because
if you tell Google don't crawl these
Pages or this directory they're not
going to get crawled if they don't get
crawled they're not going to get indexed
so robots text file is an important
element to focus on while you're
developing your website and while you're
developing your website it could be on a
you know in a directory just called new
web website so you probably want to have
new website as the directory in the
robots text file and just to let Google
know don't go into this directory
because it's my new website I'm not
ready to go live yet so you don't want
it indexed so there are a lot of reasons
to have robots text files that's the
main reason sitemap you want Google to
get these pages and assets quickly okay
you want to make sure that your site
architecture navigation is in order you
want to make sure your site is mobile
friendly and you also want to make sure
you have content on your website that's
the key because that's what's going to
keep people on the website and engaged
and when I say content I don't
necessarily just mean words I also mean
videos I also mean images you know
something interactive okay you want to
keep people engaged that's the key
behind it trust me if if an end user
finds your site engaging Google is
likely going to find your site engaging
okay so those are good brownie points to
bring up if somebody asks you this
question in an interview so just a quick
recap here it's important to have a
better site structure so the Bots can
easily access into next content okay
with a responsive design helps to make
your website mobile friendly and user
friendly would also increase the amount
of time a user spends on your website
which may improve your site's ranking
sitemap is simply just a file that helps
search engine Bots to understand the
structure of the website okay how many
pages are on your website and where they
located along with the videos and images
okay and then the robots text just
instructs the search engine Chrome
dollars to understand what pages should
not be indexed okay this is simply just
a text file and it's added to the root
directory again think like a door think
of a lock okay you can tell you can lock
whatever doors you want in your house
then give it that way I hope this course
was helpful for you and you like this
SEO full course share this with your
friend and the ones in need of this full
course feel free to post your questions
in the comment section below and our
experts will feel happy to answer you
and don't forget to subscribe to Simply
learn and hit the Bell icon to never
miss any updates from Simply learn keep
watching keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here